foreign
welcome to this full course video on
python for data science in this video we
will cover everything you need to know
to become a data scientist our
experienced instructors with good
industry experience will take you
through this course
first you will understand the basics of
data science in five minutes from an
animated video you will then learn the
important libraries in Python for data
science such as numpy pandas and
matplotlib you will get an idea about
the data science Concepts along with
mathematics statistics and linear
algebra we will then focus on some of
the essential data science algorithms
such as linear regression logistic
regressions decision trees and random
Forest K nearest neighbors and k-means
clustering
you will also learn about feature
selection cost functions and principal
component analysis
finally you will learn how to become a
data scientist in 2021 so let's begin
are you one of the many who dreams of
becoming a data scientist keep watching
this video if you're passionate about
data science because we will tell you
how does it really work under the hood
Emma is a data scientist let's see how a
day in a life goes while she's working
on data science project well it is very
important to understand the business
problem first in our meeting with the
clients Emma asks relevant questions
understands and defines objectives for
the problem that needs to be tackled she
is a curious Soul who asks a lot of eyes
one of the many traits of a good data
scientist now she gears up for data
acquisition to gather and scrape data
from multiple sources like web servers
logs databases apis and online
repositories oh it seems like finding
the right data takes both time and
effort after the data is gathered comes
data preparation this step involves data
cleaning and data transformation data
cleaning is the most time consuming
process as it involves handling many
complex scenarios here Mr deals with
inconsistent data types misspelled
attributes missing values duplicate
values and whatnot then in data
transformation she modifies the data
based on defined mapping rules in her
project ETL tools like talent and
Informatica are used to perform complex
Transformations that helps the team to
understand the data structure better
then understanding what you actually can
do with your data is very crucial for
that Emma does exploratory data analysis
with the help of Eda she defines and
refines the selection of feature
variables that will be used in the model
development but what if Mr skips this
step she might end up choosing the wrong
way tables which will produce an
inaccurate model thus exploratory data
analysis becomes the most important step
now she proceeds to the core activity of
a data science project which is data
model she repetitively applies diverse
machine learning techniques like k n
decision tree knife base to the data to
identify the model that best fits the
business requirements she trains the
models on the training data set and
tests them to select the best performing
model Emma prefers python for modeling
the data however it can also be done
using R and SAS well the trickiest part
is not yet over visualization and coming
Emma mean to communicate the business
findings in a simple and effective
manner to convince the stakeholders she
uses tools like Tableau power bi and
click view that can help her in creating
powerful reports and dashboards and then
finally she deploys and maintains the
model she tests the selected model in a
pre-production environment before
deploying it in the production
environment which is the best practice
right after successfully deploying it
she uses reports and dashboards to get
to real-time in analytics further she
also monitors and maintains the
Project's performance well that's how
Emma completes the data science project
we see the routine of a deal or fun has
a lot of interesting aspects and comes
with its own share of challenges now
let's see how data science is changing
the world data science techniques along
with genomic data provides a deeper
understanding of genetic issues in
reaction to particular drugs and
diseases logistic companies like DHL
FedEx have discovered the best routes to
ship the best suited time to deliver the
best to choose
thus leading to cost efficiency
with the latest signs it is possible to
not only with employee action but to
also understand any variables that in
the lower easily asked to enhance their
travel experience well if you're
wondering there are various roles
offered to a data scientist like data
analyst machine learning engineer deep
learning engineer data engineer and of
course data scientist the median beta
scientists can range from 95 000 to 165
000 so that was about the data science
ready to be a data scientist if yet
since today the world of data
needs you
bye
python is the most widely used
programming language
today when it comes
to solving data means tasks and travel
settings I'll have a patient and a bit
more research I was finally able to
narrow down my choice of top python
libraries for data science what are they
let's find out so let's talk about this
amazing Library tensorflow which is also
one of my favorites so tensorflow is a
library for high performance numerical
computations with around 35
000 GitHub comments and a Vibrant
Community of around 1500 contributors as
you used across various scientific
domains it's basically a framework where
we can Define and run computations which
involves tensors
and so as we can say are partially
defined computational objects again
flow is majorly used in deep learning
models and neural networks where we have
other libraries like torch and piano
also but tensorflow has hands down
better computational graphical
visualizations when compared to them
also tensorflow reduces the error
largely by 50 to 60 percent in neural
machine translations it's highly
parallel in a way where you can train
multiple neural networks and multiple
gpus for highly efficient and scalable
models this parallel Computing feature
of tensorflow is also called pipelining
also tens of the flow High advantage of
seamless performance as it's packed by
Google it has quicker updates frequent
new releases with the latest of features
now let's look at some applications
tensorflow is extensively used initi
Nations time series analysis and
forecasting and various other
applications involving video detection
so favorite thing about tensorflow that
it's already popular among the machine
learning community and most are open to
trying it and some of us are already
using it now let's look at an example of
a tensorflow model in this example we
will not dive deep into the explanation
of the model as it is beyond the scope
of this video so here we're using amnest
dataset which consists of images of
handwritten digits handwritten digits
can be easily recognized by building a
simple tensorflow model let's see how
when we visualize our data using
matplotlibrary the inputs will look
something like this then we create our
tensorflow model to create a basic
tensorflow model we need to initial and
start a session then after training the
model we can validate the data and then
predict the accuracy this model has
predicted 92 accuracy let's see which is
pretty well for this model so that's all
for tensorflow if you need to understand
this tutorial in detail then you can go
ahead and watch our deep learning
tutorial from Simply learn as shown in
the right corner interesting right let's
move on to the next library now let's
talk about a common yet a very powerful
python Library called numpy numpy is a
fundamental package for numerical
competition in Python it stands for
numerical python as the name suggests it
has around 18 000 comments on GitHub
with an active community of 700
contributors it's a general purpose
array processing package in a way that
it provides high performance
multi-dimensional objects called arrays
and tools for working with them also
numpy addresses the slowness problem
partly by providing these
multi-dimensional arrays that we talked
about and then functions and operators
that operate efficiently on these are
ways interesting right numbers of number
it's very easy to work with large arrays
and mattresses using numpy numpy fully
supports object oriented approach for
example coming back to ndre once again
it's a class possessing numerous methods
and attributes ndra provides for larger
and repeated computation patients numpy
offers vectorization it's more faster
and compact than traditional methods I
always wanted to get rid of loops and
vectorization of numpy clearly helps me
with that now let's talk about the
applications of numpy numpy along with
pandas is extensively used in data
analysis which forms the basis of data
science it helps in creating the
powerful n-dimensional array whenever we
talk about numpy the mention of the
array we cannot do it without the
mention of the powerful n-dimensional
array also number is extensively used in
machine learning when we are creating
machine learning models as in where it
forms the base of other libraries like
sci-fi scikit-learn
Etc when you start creating the machine
learning models in data science you will
realize that all the models will have
their bases numpy or pandas also when
number is used with sci-fi and
matplotlib it can be used as a
replacement of Matlab now let's look at
a simple simple example of an array in
numpad as you can see here there are
multiple array manipulation routines
like their basic examples where you can
copy the values from one array to
another we can give a new shape to an
array from maybe one dimensional to we
can make it as a two dimensional array
we can return a copy of the array
collapse into one dimension now let's
look at an example where this is Jupiter
notebook and we will just create a basic
array and for detailed explanation you
can watch our other videos which Targets
on these explanations of each libraries
so first of all whenever we are using
any library in Python we have to import
it so now this NP is the Alias which we
will be using let's create a simple
array
let's look what is the type of this
so this is an indiary type of array Also
let's look what's the shape of this
array
so this is a shape of the array now here
we saw that we can expand the shape of
the array
so this is where you can change the
shape of the array using all those
functions now let's create an array
using arrange functions if I give
arrange 12 it will give me a one day
array of 12 numbers like this now we can
reshape this array
to 3 comma 4 or we can write it here
itself
so this is how arrange function and the
reshape function works for numpy now
let's discuss the next Library which is
Sci Pi so this is another free and open
source python Library extensively used
in data science for high level
computations so this Library as the name
suggests stands for Scientific Python
and it has around 19 000 commits on
GitHub with an active community of 600
contributors it is extensively used for
scientific and Technical computations
also as it extends numpy it provides
many user-friendly and efficient
routines for scientific calculations now
let's discuss about some features of
sci-fi so sci-fi has a collection of
algorithms and functions which is built
on the numpy extension of python
secondly it has various high level
commands for data manipulation and
visualization also the ndmh function of
scipy is very useful in
multi-dimensional image processing and
it includes built-in functions for
solving differential equations linear
algebra and many more so that was about
the features of scipy now let's discuss
its applications so saipa is used in
multi-dimensional image operations it
has functions to read images from disk
into numpy arrays to write arrays to
discuss images resize images
Etc solving differential equations
Fourier transforms then optimization
algorithms linear algebra Etc let's look
at a simple example to learn what kind
of functions are there in cyber here I'm
importing the constants package of scipy
Library so in this package it has all
the constants
so here I'm just mentioning C or H or
any and this Library already knows what
it has to fetch like speed of light
Planck's constant Etc so this can be
used in further calculations data
analysis is an integral part of data
science data scientists spend most of
the day in data munching and then
cleaning the data also hence mention of
pandas is a must in data science
lifecycle yes pandas is the most popular
and widely used python library for data
science along with numpy and matplotlib
the name itself stands for python data
analysis with around 17 000 comets on
GitHub and an active community of 1200
contributors it is heavily used for data
analysis in cleaning as it provides fast
flexible data structures like data
frames series which are designed to work
with structured data very easily and
intuitively now let's talk about some
features of pandas so pandas offers this
eloquent syntax and Rich functionalities
like there are various methods in pandas
like Drop n a fill any which gives you
the freedom to deal with missing data
also Partners provides a powerful apply
function which lets you create your own
function and run it across a series of
data now forget about writing those four
Loops while using pandas also this
library's high level abstraction over
low level numpy which is written in pure
C then it also contains these high level
data structures and manipulation tools
which makes it very easy to work with
pandas like their data structures and
series now let's discuss the
applications of pandas so pandas is
extensively used in general data
wrangling and data cleaning then pandas
also Finds Its usage in ETL jobs for
data transformation and data storage as
it has excellent support for loading CSV
files into its data frame format then
pandas is used in a variety of academic
and Commercial domains including
statistics Finance Neuroscience
economics web analytics Etc then pandas
is also very useful in Time series
specific functionality like date range
generation moving window linear
regression date shifting Etc now let's
look at a very simple example of how to
create a data frame so data frame is a
very useful data structure in pandas and
it has very powerful functionalities so
here I'm only enlisting important
libraries in data science you can
explore more of our videos to learn
about these libraries in detail so let's
just go ahead and create data frame I'm
using Jupiter notebook again and in this
before using pandas here I'm importing
the pandas Library
let me go and run this so in data frame
we can import a file a CSV file Excel
files there are many functions doing
these things and we can also create our
own data and put it into Data frame so
here I am taking random data and putting
in a data frame also I'm creating an
index and then also giving the column
names so PD is the Alias we've given
pandas random data of 6x4 index which is
taking a range 6 numbers and column name
I'm giving as ABCD now let's go ahead
and look at it
so here it has created a data frame with
my column names ABCD my list has six
numbers 0 to 5 and a random data of six
by four so data frame is just another
table with rows and columns where you
can do various functions over it also I
can go ahead and describe this data
frame to see so it's giving me all these
functionalities where count and Main and
standard deviation
Etc okay so that was about pandas now
let's talk about next library and the
last one so matplotlib for me is the
most fun Library out of all of them why
because it has such powerful yet
beautiful visualizations we'll see in
the coming slides plot and mac.lib
suggest that it's a plotting library for
python it has around 26 000 comments on
GitHub and a very Vibrant Community of
700 contributors and because of such
graphs and plots that it produces it's
majorly used for data visualization and
also because it provides an
object-oriented API which can be used to
embed those plots into our applications
let's talk about the features of
matplotlib the pi plot module of
matplotlab provides Matlab like
interface so matplotlib is designed to
be as usable as Matlab with an advantage
of being free and open source also it
supports dozens of backends and output
types which means you can use it
regardless of which operating system
you're using or which output format you
wish pandas itself can be used as
wrappers around matplotlips API so as to
drive Mac broadly via cleaner and more
modern apis also when you start using
this Library you will realize that it
has a very little memory consumption and
a very good runtime Behavior now let's
talk about the applications of
matplotlib it's important to discover
the unknown relationship between the
variables in your data set so this
Library helps to visualize the
correlation analysis of variables also
in machine learning we can visualize 95
confidence interval of the model just to
communicate how well our model fits the
data then matpatliff Finds Its
application in outlier detection using
scatter plot Etc and to visualize the
distribution of data to gain instant
insights now let's make a very simple
plot to get a basic idea I've already
imported the libraries here so this
function matplotlib inline will help you
show the plots in the Jupiter notebook
this is also called a magic function I
won't be able to display my plots in the
jupyter notebook if I don't use this
function I am using this function in
numpy to fix random state for
reproducibility now I'll take my n as 30
and will assign random values to my
variables so this function is generating
30 random numbers here I am trying to
create a scatter plot so I want to
decide the area let's put this so just
multiplying 30 with random numbers to
the power 2 so that we get the area of
the plot which we will see in just a
minute so using the scatter function and
the Alias of Mac plot lip as PLT I've
created this if I don't use this then I
have very small circles as my scatter
plot it's colorful it's nice so that's
one very easy plot I suggest that you
Explore More of matplotlib and I'm sure
you will enjoy it let's create a
histogram so I'm using my the style is
GG plot and assigning some values to
these variables any random values
now we are assigning bars and colors and
Alignment to the plot and here we get
the graph so we can create different
type of visualizations and plots and
then work on them using matplotlib and
it's just that simple so that was about
the leading python libraries in the
field of data science but along with
these libraries data scientists are also
leveraging the power of some other
useful libraries for example like
tensorflow Keras is another popular
Library which is extensively used for
deep learning and neural network modules
kelas wraps both tensorflow and theano
back-ends so it is a good option if you
don't want to dive into details of
tensorflow then scikit-learn is a
machine learning library it provides
almost all the machine learning
algorithms that you need and it is
designed to interpolate with numpy and
sci-fi then we have C born which is
another library for data visualization
we can say that c bone is an enhancement
of matplotlib as it introduces
additional plot types so let's start
with what is number numpy is the core
library for scientific and numerical
Computing in Python it provides high
performance multi-dimensional array
object and tools for working with arrays
and I'll go a step further and say there
are so many other modules in Python
built on numpy so the fundamentals of
numpy are so important to latch onto for
the python so that you can understand
the other modules and what they're doing
numbers main object is a
multi-dimensional array it's a table of
elements usually numbers all of the same
type indexed by a tuple of position
integers in numpy dimensions are called
axes take a one-dimensional array or we
have remember dimensions are also called
axes you can say this is the first axis
0 1 2 3 4 5. and you can see down here
it has a shape of six why because
there's six different elements in it in
the one dimension array and they usually
denote that as six comma with an empty
node on there and then we have a two
dimensional array where you can see zero
one two three four five six seven and in
here we have two axes or two dimensions
and the shape is two four so if you were
looking at this as a matrix or another
mathematical functions you can see
there's all kinds of importance on shape
we're not going to cover shape today but
we will cover that in part two did you
know that numpy's array class is called
ND array for numpy data array now we're
going to take a detour here because
we're working in Python and two of my
favorite Tools in Python is the Jupiter
notebook and then I like to use that
sitting on top of anaconda and if you
flip over to jupiter.org that's jump e y
t e r dot org you can go in here you can
install it off of here if you don't want
to use the Anaconda notebook but this is
the Jupiter setup the documentation on
the Jupiter Jupiter opens up in your web
browser that's what makes it so nice is
this portable the files are saved on
your computer they do run an IPython or
iron Python and you can create all kinds
of different environments in there which
I'll show you in just a minute I myself
like to use Anaconda that's
www.anaconda.com if you install Anaconda
it will install the jupyter notebook
with the Anaconda separate and you can
install jupyter notebook and it'll run
completely separate from anaconda's
Jupiter notebook and you can see here
I've now opened up my anaconda Navigator
what I like about the Navigator this is
a fresh install on a new computer which
is always nice I can launch my jupyter
notebook from in here I can bring other
tools so the Anaconda does a lot more
and under environments I only have the
one environment and I can open up the
terminal specific to this environment
this one happens to have python 37 in it
the most current version as of this
tutorial and they open a terminal if
you're going to do your pip installs and
stuff like that for different modules
you can also create different
environments in here so maybe you need a
python36 python35 you can see we're
having a nice framework like Anaconda
really helps so you don't have to chat
track that on your own in the Jupiter
notebook in your different Jupiter
notebook setups we'll go ahead and
launch this Jupiter notebook and then
I've set my browser window for a deep
fault of chrome so it's going to open up
in Chrome and you can see here this
opens up a folder on my computer we have
a couple different options on here
remember I set the environment up as
python 3.7 you would install any
additional modules that aren't already
installed in your python on this and it
keeps them separate so you do have to
for each environment install the
separate modules so they match the
environment on there and in here we have
a couple things we can look up what's
running you have your different clusters
again this is I just installed this on a
new machine so I just have the one a
couple things in here that were run on
here recently and when we go on here is
we then have on the upper right new and
from the pull down menu you'll see
python3 and this will open up a new
window
and now we're in Jupiter python so this
is a python window and we'll just do a
print
and this of course is also hello world
and we'll run that and it prints out
hello world in the command line there's
a couple special things you have to know
we're not going to do today which is on
Graphics if you've never seen this
one of the things you can do is you can
also do a equals hello world and if you
just put the a in there now if you do a
bunch of these we have a equals hello
world b equals goodbye world and you put
a b a then return B it'll only run the
last one but you can see here if you put
the variable down here it will show you
what's in that variable
and that has to do with the Jupiter
notebook inline coding so that's not
basic python that's just Jupiter
notebook shorthand which you'll see in a
little bit so back to our numpy numpy
array versus python list python list
being the basic list in your python why
should we use numpy array when we have
python list well first it's fast the
numpy array has been optimized over
years and years by multiple programmers
and it's usually very quick compared to
the basic python list setup it's
convenient so it has a lot of
functionality in there that's not in the
basic python list and it also uses less
memory so it's optimized both for Speed
and memory use and let's go ahead and
jump into our Jupiter notebook since
we're coding best way to learn coding is
to code just like the best way to learn
how to write is right and the best way
to learn how to cook is cook so let's do
some coding here today and just like any
modules we have to import numpy we
almost always import it as in p that is
such a standard so you'll see that very
commonly we can just run that and now we
have access to our numpy module inside
our Python and then the most common
thing of course is to go and create a
number array
and in here we can send it a regular
list
and so we'll go ahead and send this a
regular array let's go one two three to
make it simple and then I'm just going
to type in a and we'll run this
as you can see down here the output is
an array of one two three and we could
also do
print just a reminder that this is an
inline command so that wouldn't work if
you're using a different editor you can
see that it's an array123 but we'll go
and leave it as a
kind of a nice feature so you can see
what you're doing really quick in the
jupyter notebook and just like all your
other standard arrays I can go a of 0
which is going to be a value of one of
course we do a of one you go all the way
through this
a of one has a value of 2 in it so
whether using the numpy array or the
basic python list that's going to be the
same that should all look pretty
familiar and be pretty straightforward
remember the first value is always zero
and when we set on there so let's take a
look why we're using numpy because we
went over the slide a little bit but
let's just take a look and see what that
actually looks like and what we want to
look at is the fact that it's fast
convenient and uses less memory so let's
take a glance at that in code and see
what that actually looks like when we're
writing it in Python and what the
differences are
and to do this I'm going to go ahead and
import a couple other modules we're
going to import the time module so we
can time it and we're going to import
the system module so that we can take a
look at how much memory it uses and
we'll go and just run those so those are
imported so we'll do b equals a range of
one yeah 1000 is fine
and so that's going to create a list of
one thousand zero to 999 remember it
starts at zero and it stops right at the
1000 without actually going to the 1000.
and let's go ahead and print
and we want system dot get size of
and we'll pick any integer because we
have you know zero to a thousand we'll
just throw one in there five it doesn't
matter because it's gonna whatever
integer we put in there is going to
generate the same value because we're
looking at the size of how how much
memory it stores an integer in and then
we want to have the link of the B that's
how many integers are in there
and if we go ahead and execute this and
run this at a line we'll see Oops I did
that wrong comma
if we multiply them together
we'll see it generates 28 000. so that's
the size we're looking at is 28 000. I
believe that's bytes that sounds about
right
so let's go ahead and create this in
numpy and we'll go with C equals NP and
this is a range
so that's the numpy command to do the
same thing that we were just doing in a
list
and we'll also use the same value on
there the 1000
. once we've created the C value of C
for NP dot a range let's go ahead and
print and we can do that by doing C dot
size
C dot item size
well that's very similar we did before
we did get the size of so the C size is
the size of the array and each item size
just reversed so it's the size of a
integer five item size is going to be
the integers and C size now let's just
take a look and see what that generates
and wow okay we got 4 000 versus 28 000.
that's a significant difference in
memory how much memory we're using with
the array and then let's go ahead and
take a look at uh speed let's do um oh
let's do size we trade this with lower
values and it would happen so fast that
the npra kept coming up with zero
because I just rounded it off so size
and let's create an L1
Bulls range of size
and we'll do an L2
I'll just set up to the same thing it's
also range
of size on there there we go
and then we can do on A1 equals
NP dot a range size
and then let's do an A 2 equals NP dot a
range we'll keep it the same size
and what we're going to do is we're
going to take these two different arrays
and we're going to perform some basic
functions on them
but let's go ahead actually just load
these up now we'll go ahead and run this
so those are all set in memory
except for the typo here
quickly fix that
there we go so these are now all loaded
in here and let's do a start equals
time dot time
so it's just going to look at my clock
time and see what time it is and it will
do result equals and let's do oh let's
say we got an array and we're going to
say
let's do some addition here X Plus y
for X comma y
in
and we'll zip it up here
two different arrays so here's our two
different arrays we're going to multiply
each of the individual things on here L1
L2
there we go so that should add up each
value so L1 plus L2 each value in each
array
and then we want to go ahead and print
and let's say python list took
and then we'll do
time
dot time
we'll just subtract the start out of
there so time whoops I messed up on some
of the quotation marks on there
okay there we go
time minus the start
and we'll convert that to seconds so
we'll go to this in milliseconds or
times 1000.
and let's hit the run on there this is
kind of fun because you also get a view
while we're doing this
of some ways to manipulate the script
and as you can see also my bad typing
there we go okay so we'll go ahead and
run this
and we can see here that the python list
took 34
actually I have to go back and look at
the conversion on there but you can see
it takes roughly 0.34 of a second and we
go ahead and print the result in here
too
let's do that
and we'll run that just so you can see
what the what kind of data we're looking
at
and we have the zero two four six eight
so it's just adding them together it
looks pretty straightforward on there
and if we scroll down to the bottom of
the answer again we see python list took
46 a little different time on there
depending on what um core because I have
this is on an eight core computer so it
just depends on what course running on
what else is pulling on the computer at
the time and let's go back up here and
do our start time paste that into here
and this time we're going to do a result
equals and this is really cool notice
how elegant this is so straightforward
this is for a lot of reason people
started using numpy is because I can add
the two arrays together by simply going
A1 Plus A2 makes a lot of sense both
looking at it and it's just very
convenient remember that slide we're
looking at fast convenient and less
memory so look how convenient that is
really easy to read real easy to see and
I don't know if we don't need to print
the result again so let's just go ahead
and print the time on here and we'll
borrow this from the top part
because I really am a lazy typer
and this isn't the python list this is
the numpy list or numpy array
and let's go ahead and see how that
comes out and we get 2.99
so let's take a look at these two
numbers 46 versus 2.99 so we'll just
round this up to three that's a huge
difference that's that's like more than
10 times faster that's like 15 times
roughly at a quick glance I'd have to go
do the math to look at it and it's going
to vary a little bit depending on what's
running in the background the computer
obviously so we've looked at this and if
we go back here we found out it's much
faster yes there's different going to be
different speeds depending on what
you're doing with the array very
convenient easy to read and it uses less
memory so that's the core of the numpy
that's why a lot of people base so many
other modules on numpy and why it's so
widely used so we did glance at a couple
operations when we were looking at speed
and size let's dive into a little bit
more into the basic operations
and these are always nice to see I mean
certainly you want to go get a cheat
sheet if you're using it for the first
time you know look things up Google is
your friend we did this we're the most
basic numpy dot array or NP dot array
and we'll go ahead and create an array
let's do pairs one comma two
and then let's do three comma four and
if we're gonna do that let's do five
comma six
there we go and if we go ahead and take
this and run this I can go ahead and do
our a down here so it's in line it'll
print that out you can see it makes a
nice array for us so we have a and if
you look at that we have three different
objects each with two values in them and
hopefully you're starting to think well
how many dimensions or indexes is that
and you'll see three by two so let's go
ahead and take a look and let's go how
about a dot in Dimensions speaking of
which we'll run that and we have two
dimensions for each object
we can do the item size so a DOT we saw
this earlier we looked up how many items
it was up here where we wanted to
multiply item size times the actual size
of the object so the memory is being
used versus the item size and we should
see four there
memory is compressed down that's always
a good thing
and then the shape the shape is so
important when you're working with data
science and you're moving it from one
format to another
so we have our shape we just talked
about that we have three by two three
rows by two objects in each one
generally I don't look too much at the
size but the dimensions I'm always
looking up this is nice you can automate
it so you might be converting something
you might need to know how many
dimensions are going into the next
machine learning package so that you can
automatically just have it send that
information over
so we looked at a shape let's go and
create a slightly different array NP dot
array let's go ahead and just do as our
original
set up here
and one of the features we can do which
is really important is we can do D type
equals in this case let's do NP
float 64. and so what we've done is
converting all of these into a float
when we type in a
and now instead of having one two three
four five six you see they're all float
values 1.0 there's no actual zero in
there just shows the one dot or the one
period two three period four period five
period six period
and this again data science I don't know
how many times I've had to convert
something from an integer to a float so
it's going to work correctly in the
model I'm using so very common features
to be aware of and to be able to get
around and use
and we'll also do let's just curiosity
item size
we'll go ahead and run that
and we see that it doubled in size so
it's not a huge increase well doubling
is always a big increase in computers
but it's not a huge increase compared to
what it would be if you're running this
in the python list format
and then we did the shape earlier
without having it set to the float 64.
let's go ahead and do a shape with it
set to 64. and it should be the same
three comma two so it all matches so
we've gone through and remember if you
really if this is all brand new to you
according to the Cambridge study at the
Cambridge University if you're learning
a brand new word in a foreign language
the average person has to repeat it 163
times before it's memorized
so a lot of this you build off of it so
hopefully you don't have to repeat it
163 times but we need to manage to
repeat at least twice here if not a
little bit more and let's go ahead and
take this we're going to go look at one
more setup on here and let me just take
this last statement here on the
converting our properties of our data
and instead of float 64
let's do complex let's just see what
that looks like and let's go ahead and
print that out and run it
and so we now have a complex data set up
and you'll see it's denoted by the one
dot plus 0 dot j
and if we flip over here and do a basic
search for numpy data types better to go
to the original web page but pull up a
bunch of these you can see there's a
whole list of different numpy data types
shorthand complex we have complex
complex 64 complex 128 complex number
represented by 264-bit floats real and
imaginary components
one option on there float 16 float 32
float shorthand for float 64 most
commonly used and of course all the
different ones that you can possibly put
into your numpy array so we covered a
basic addition up there we're comparing
how fast it runs but some very basic
components how to set up a numpy array
how many dimensions it has item size
data type item again we went to item
size and there's also the
shape probably one of the more used I
used a shape all the time very commonly
used
and then down here you can see where we
actually created a numpy complex data
type
so let's look at some other features in
numpy one of them is you could do numpy
Dot
zeros
and we're going to do three comma four
there we go and we'll go ahead and run
this and you can see if I do NP dot
zeros I create an array of zeros
this is really important I was building
my own neural network and I needed to
create an array where I initialized the
weights and I want them all to be the
same weight in this case I wanted them
to start off as zero for the particular
project I was working on and there's
other options that you can do p1s
and we'll do the same thing three comma
four we'll run that
and you can see I've created a an array
of numpy ones in this case it comes out
as a float array
and this is an interesting to note
because we have let's go back to our
Python and do L Range Five
and we'll print the L so there's our
list
and if I run that
doesn't create the range and tell after
the fact until you actually execute it
that's an upgrade in python python 27
actually created the array 0 1 2 3 4.
this one actually creates the script and
then once it's used it then actually
generates the array and if we do that in
numpy a Range remember that from before
and if we do a numpy a range 5
and let's do a
or we can just leave it as numpy that's
fine there we go just run that
you can see there we actually get an
array 0 1 2 3 4 for the value of the
numpy arrange a range five generates the
actual array
and for part one we're going to do just
one more section on basic setup
and we're going to concatenation
concatenation out an example
there we go we're gonna do strings let's
take a look at strings and what's going
on with there and let's do
oh let's see print
Let's do an NP character something new
here and we're going to add and then
here's our brackets for what we're going
to add
oh and let's say
um let's do
hello
comma High
and in the brackets on there let's
create another one
and this one's going to be
ABC and we'll do
x y z so we're just creating some
randomly making sum up on here and then
we'll go ahead and just print this
if we run that and come down here and of
course make sure all your brackets are
open and closed correctly and then you
can see in here when we concatenate the
example in numpy it takes the two
different arrays that we set up in there
and it combines the hello with the ABC
and the high with x y z
and if we can also do something like
print oh let's do NP character dot
multiply
so there's a lot of different functions
in here again you can look these up it's
probably good to look them all up and
see what they are but it's good to also
just see them in action let's do hello
space comma three
and we'll run this one
and run that without the error and
you'll see it does hello hello hello so
we multiplied it by three and we can
also let's just take this whole thing
here instead of retyping it
and we can do character Center so
instead of multiply this to Center
and over here keep our hello going
take the space out of there and let's do
Center at 20.
and fill character
equals we'll fill it with dashes
so if we run this
you can see it prints out the hello with
dashes on each side and we keep going um
with that we can also in addition to
doing the fill function we can play with
capitalize we can title we can do
lowercase we can do uppercase we can
split split line strip join these are
all the most common ones and let's go
ahead and just look at those and see
what those look like each one of them
so we're gonna do the hello world
all-time favorite of mine I would like
to say Hello Universe and you can see
here we do Capital H with the world but
so we want to capitalize so capitalize
is the first one in the array so we get
Hello World on there and we can also
take this and instead of capitalizing
another feature in here is title and
let's just change this to how are we
doing
how are you doing instead of we equal to
U and let's run that
and you can see here because we created
it as a title it capitalizes the first
letter in each word
and in this one we're going to do
character lower
two different examples here we have an
array we have Hello World all
capitalized and we have just hello and
you can see that one is an array and one
is just a string if we run that you get
a an array with Hello World lowercase
and hello lowercase and if we're going
to do it that way we can also do it the
opposite way there's also upper
and let's paste those in there and you
can see here we have character Dot Upper
opposite there python.data and we'll do
python is easy hopefully you're starting
to get the picture that most of the
Python and the scripting is very simple
is when you put the bigger picture
together and starts building these
puzzles and somebody asks you hey I need
the first letter capitalized unless it's
the title and then we have you start
realizing that this can get really
complicated so numpy just makes it
simple and we like that
and so in this case we did python data
it's all uppercase python is easy like
shouting in your messenger python is
easy and then if you're ever a
processing text and tokenizing it a lot
of times the first thing you do is we
just split the text and we're just going
to run this in P dot character.split are
you coming to the party if we do that it
returns an array of each of the
individual words are you coming to the
party splitting it by the spaces
and then if you're going to split it by
spaces we also need to know how to split
it by lines
and just like we have the basic split
command we also have split lines hello
and you'll see here the scoop in for our
new line and when we run that if you're
following the split part with the words
you should see hello how are you doing
the two different lines are now split
apart
and let's just review three more before
we wrap this up commonly used string
variable manipulations we have strip and
in this case we have Nina admin Anita
and we're going to strip a off of there
let's see what that looks like and then
you end up with nin dominate it
basically takes up all leading and
trailing letters in this case we're
looking for a more common would be a
space in there but it might also be
punctuation or anything like that that
you need to remove from your letters and
words and if we're going to strip and
clean data we also need to be able to
reformat it or join it together so you
see here we have a character joined
we'll go ahead and run this
and it has on the first one it splits
he's the letters up by the colon and the
second one by the dash and you can see
how this is really useful if you're
processing in this case a date we have
day month year year month date very
common things to have to always switch
around and manipulate depending on what
they're going into what you're working
with
and finally let's look at one last
character string we're going to do
replace if you're doing misinformation
this is good pulling news articles
replacing is and what in this case we're
just doing he is a good dancer and we're
going to place is with was
and you can see here he was a good
dancer hopefully that's not because he
had a bad fall he just was from like you
know 1920s and has gotten old
so there we go we've covered a lot of
the basics in numpy as far as creating
an array very important stuff here when
you're feeding it in how do we know the
shape of it the size of it what happens
we convert it from a regular integer
into a float value as far as how much
space it takes we saw that that doubled
it item size you have your in dimensions
and probably the most used is shape
we'll cover more on shape in part two so
make sure you join us on part two
because there's a lot of important
things on shaping in there and setting
them up we also saw that you can create
a zeros based array you can create one
with ones if we do a range you can see
how it is a lot easier to use to create
its own range or a range as it is in
numpy you saw how easy it was to add two
arrays we saw that earlier just plus
sign then we got into doing strings and
working with strings and how to
concatenate so if you have two different
arrays of strings you can bring them
together we also saw how you can fill so
you can add a nice headline dash dash
dash we saw about capitalize the first
letter we saw about turning it into a
title so all the first letters are
capitalized doing lowercase on all the
letters upper for all the letters just
lower and upper nice abbreviation we
also covered how to split the character
set how to strip it so if you want to
strip all the A's out from leading AI
A's and ending A's or spaces you can do
that very easily also how to join the
data sets so here's a character join
option for your strings and finally we
did the character replace pandas really
is a core python module you need for
doing data science and data processing
there's so many other modules that come
off of it there's actually sits kind of
on numpy so if you've already had our
numpy array hopefully you've already
gone through the numpy tutorial one and
two So today we're going to cover what
is pandas we'll discuss series we'll
discuss basic operations on series and
then we'll get into a data frame itself
basic operations on the data frame
file related operations on a data frame
visualization and then some practice
examples roll up our sleeves and get
some coding underneath there and let's
start with just some real general what
is pandas pandas is a tool for data
processing which helps in data analysis
it provides functions and methods to
officially manipulate large data sets
now this is a step down from say using
spark or Hadoop in Big Data so we're not
talking about Big Data here but we are
talking about pandas I mean there is
some connections there's like an
interface going on with that so there is
availability but you really should know
your pandas because if you're working in
Big Data you'll know there's data frames
well pandas is a data frame primarily it
has a couple different pieces we'll look
at here and if you've never worked with
data frames before a data frame is
basically like an Excel spreadsheet you
have rows and columns you can access
your data either by the row or the
column when you have an index in
different that kind of setup and we'll
dig more into that as we get deeper into
pandas but think of it as like a giant
Excel spreadsheet that's optimized to
run a larger data on your computer and
then I said it that it's a data frame so
the data structures in pandas are series
one-dimensional arrays and then we have
data frame two-dimensional array and it
really centers around the data frame the
series just happens to be part of that
data frame and here's a closer look at a
pandas series series is a
one-dimensional array with labels it can
contain any data type including integers
strings floats python objects and more
so it's very diverse if you remember
from numpy we studied they had to be all
uniform not in pandas and pandas we can
do a lot more and pen is actually kind
of sits on numpy so you really need to
know both of those if you haven't done
the numpy tutorials and you can see here
we have our index one two three four
five and then our data a b c d and e
very straightforward it's just two
columns and we have a nice index label
and a column label for the day and then
a data frame is a two-dimensional data
structure with labels we can use labels
to locate data and you can see here we
had if we go back one we had our index
one two three four five so in each one
of these series they would share the
same index over there the row index so
you have your row index DF dot index and
then you have a column index DF dot
columns and this would look like I said
this would be really familiar if you've
done any work with spreadsheets Excel so
it kind of resembles that this does make
it a lot easier to manipulate data and
add columns delete columns move them
around same thing with the rows so you
have a lot of control over all of this
now we're of course going to do this in
our Jupiter notebook you can use any of
your python editors but I highly suggest
if you haven't installed Jupiter and
haven't worked with it it is probably
one of the best ways for easily
displaying a project you're working on I
skip between a lot of different user
interfaces or Ides for editing my Python
and it's just simply jupiter.org j-u-p-y
ter.org and then I always let mine sit
on anaconda anaconda.com and just real
quick we'll open that up for you oops
offline mode don't show me that again
but you can see here that I have
different tools that I can actually
install in my anaconda including the
Jupiter notebook which comes by default
and then I have access to the
environments and again that's
anaconda.com named after the very large
one of the largest world's largest
snakes and then Jupiter notebook in this
case jupiter.org and when we're in our
I'm going to go in here to our Jupiter
notebook and we're going to go ahead and
just do new and a Python 3 and this will
open up a Python 3 Untitled folder so
diving right in let's go ahead and give
this a title pandas tutorial and we'll
go up to cell and we'll change the cell
type to mark down so it doesn't execute
it as actual code one of those wonderful
tools when you have jupyter notebooks
you can do demos with this and let's go
ahead and import pandas and usually
people just call it PD that's become
such a standard in the industry so we'll
go ahead and run that now we have our
pandas has been imported into our
jupyter notebook
and then oh we can go ahead and let me
do the Control Plus since it's Internet
Explorer I can enlarge it very easily so
you have a nice pretty view whoops too
big there we go and whenever you're
working with the new modules good to
check your version of the module in
pandas you just use the in this case PD
dot underscore underscore version
underscore underscore that's actually
pretty common in most of our python
modules there's different ways to look
up the version but that's one of the
more common ones and we'll go ahead and
run that we get
0.23.4 and if we go to the pandas site
we see
0.23.4 is the latest release and of
course a reminder that if you're going
to an environment you need to install it
so you'll need to do pip install pandas
if you're using the PIP installer we'll
go and close out of that
and the first thing we want to do is
we're going to work with series a lot of
the stuff you do in series you can then
do on the whole data set we need to do
what create one we need to manipulate it
take pieces of it so query query it
delete so you can delete different parts
of it so we want to do all those things
with the series and we'll start with the
series and then almost all the code in
fact all the code does transfer right
into
the actual data table so we go from a
series of a single list of one column
and then we'll take that and we'll
transfer that over to the whole table
and we'll start by creating let's put up
there we go creating a series from
list
and let's just call this ARR equals and
we'll do 0 1 2 3 4. if you remember from
our last one we could easily do R equals
range of five which would be zero to
four but we'll do R equals zero to four
and we'll call this S1 and we'll go PD
and series is capitalized this one
always throws me is which letters do you
capitalize on these modules they're
getting more and more uniform but you
got to watch that with python and we're
just going to go ahead and do ARR so
we're just going to take this python
list and we're going to turn it into a
series and then because we're in Jupiter
we don't have to put the print statement
we can just put S1 and it'll print out
this series for us and let's go ahead
and run that and take a look
and you'll see we have two rows of
numbers so the first one is the index
now it automatically creates the index
starting with zero unless you tell it to
do differently so we get zero index row
zero is zero one one two two three three
four four and because it's a series it
doesn't need a title for the column
there's only one column so why title it
and this also lets you know that it's a
data type of integer 64. so we print
this out this is our series our basic
series we've just created now let's do a
second series
PD and we'll use the same
data list and let's go ahead and do
order we'll give it an order equals oh
let's do it this way let's go index
equals order
and it helps if we actually give it an
order so we'll do order equals and let's
do one two three four five so instead of
starting with zero we're going to give
it an order starting with one we're
going to run that and we'll go ahead and
print it out down here S2
and we'll see that we now have an index
of one two three four five and that
represents zero one two three four in
the series and we're still data type
integer 64. and very common as you're
missing with numpy arrays is we can
import our number as NP remember that
from our numpy tutorials we can go ahead
and create a numpy out of random with
the random numbers of five and let's
just see what that end looks like so we
can see what our numpy looks like so we
have some nice random float values here
2.33 so on and that's from our last
tutorial the numpy tutorial one and two
and instead of calling it order let's
call it index and we're going to set our
index equal to a b c d and e I want to
show you that the index doesn't have to
be an integer so it can be something
very different here and then let's go
ahead and create our we'll just use S2
again and here's our NP for numpy
series capital s and n is our and P for
numpy
PD for pandas there we go switching my
anachronisms so we have pd.series of N
and we want to do our index equals our
index we just created
and then let's go ahead and see what
that looks like S2 is a printed and
let's run that and we can see here we
have a nice Series going on a b c d and
e for our indexes so instead of it being
0 1 2 3 or 4 we can make this index
whatever we want and you can see the
numbers here going down that we randomly
generated from the numpy array so we use
numpy to create our Panda Series right
here and so continuing on with creating
our Series this one I use so often we
create a series from a dictionary so we
have our dictionary in this case we went
ahead and did a of one B is 2 C of three
D4 EF5 so each one of those is a key and
then a value and then we're going to use
oh let's use S3 equals PD for pandas
series and then we want to go ahead and
just do D in here
print out S3 here and let's go ahead and
run this and you can see we got a is one
B is 2 C is three D is four e is 5. and
it's still of integer 64 Because the
actual data is one two three four five
and it's all integers 64 type 64. and
the last thing we want to do in the
creating section of our series is to go
ahead and modify the index because we're
going to start modifying all this data
so let's start with modifying the index
of the series and if you remember let's
do a print this time S1
I'll go ahead and run this and the
reason I did print is because it only
prints out the last variable so if I put
S1 up here and we're going to do another
variable back down lower it won't print
the first one just the last one and
we're going to go ahead and take S1
the index and we're just going to set it
equal to a new index and obviously the
number of objects in our index has to
equal the number of objects in our data
and then because it's a last variable we
can go ahead and just do an S1 and let's
run that and you can see how we went
from 0 to 0 0 1 2 3 4 as our index we've
now altered it to a b c d and e so this
would be much more readable or might be
representational of a larger database
you're working with
So Cool Tools we've covered creating
database based on my basic array python
array we've showed you how to reset the
index
that we showed you how to use a numpy
array so you can put a numpy array in
there it's all the same you know
pd.series numpy array and then we can
set the index on there and the same
thing with the dictionary so it's very
versatile how it pulls in data and you
can pull in data from different sources
and different setups and create a new
series very easily in the pandas and
then we looked on changing your index so
now we have a new index on here
and then we want to go ahead and do some
selection let's do some basic
slicing most common thing you'll
probably do on here and we'll just do S1
this notation should start to look
really familiar again this is going to
put an output so I'd usually it doesn't
change S1 this just selects it so we
might do a equals S1 and then print a
and you'll see that it just looks at the
first three zero one two and we can do
the same thing by not having the a in
there I'll go ahead and take that out
but it's just a reminder that it's not
actually changing S1 it's just viewing
S1 so simple slicing on here and we can
likewise do an append oops before we do
a pin let's just do a quick kind of fun
one we'll do two minus one and you'll
see it covers everything but the E of
course you can do minus 2 on this side
so one another way to select it is to go
how far from the end and likewise we can
do a 2 here a c d e to the end so it
starts at the second one and another way
we can do this is we can do a minus 2
over here and that looks at just the
last two in the slice so you can see how
easy it is to slice the data and of
course there's no reason to do this but
you could select all of them
if he wanted to view all of them on
there UPS 32 there's not 32 so it's just
going to show the first three there we
go and then we can also append so I can
take and oh let's create another series
and append one to it and if you remember
we had S3 there's our S3 and we have our
S1 I'm going to do S1
and let's go ahead and do let's call it
S4
equals S1
a pin S3 so we're just going to combine
those two into S4
and if we go ahead and print S4 on here
you'll now see that we have a b c d e a
b c d e zero one two three four one two
three four five because we started the
data at one so very easy to compend one
series to the next and if we're going to
append one series to the next we need to
go ahead and drop or delete one and drop
is a keyword for that and let's just do
e our index e and so if I run this
you'll see that it'll print it out and
ABCD there's no e and remember all these
changes if I type in S4 again you'll see
that S4 still has e in it so this change
does not affect the series unless you
tell it to so I'd have to do like x S4
equals S4 dot drop e and there's another
way to do that which we'll show you
later on let me just cut this one out
there we go all right so we've covered
all kinds of Cool Tools here we have a
pending we have slicing we did all the
creating stuff earlier as you can see
here on the setup how easy it is to
manipulate the series
so next what we want to get into is we
want to get into
operations that happen on the series so
let me go ahead and change this cell to
mark down there we go and we're so
series of operations what can we do with
the series and let's start by creating a
couple arrays we'll call it array one
and we'll do 0 through 7 and array two
six through six seven eight nine five I
don't let me through the five on the end
but let's go ahead and run those so
those load up into Jupiter and we'll do
this a little backwards we're going to
do S5 equals a panda series of array two
so I'm doing this in reverse and then
when we do S5 you'll see that we have
zero to four it automatically assign the
index
67895 for our series and let's go ahead
and do the same and we'll call this S6
and we'll set this equal to PD series
for our first array and if we do an S6
down here to print it out
we'll see something similar I got zero
through six zero one two three four five
seven for the data so those are two
series we just created series six five
and six
and one of the first things we can do is
we can add one series to the next so I
can do S5 dot add S6 and let's see what
that generates and just a quick thing if
you've never used pandas what do you
think is going to happen with the fact
that this only has five different values
in it and this one has seven values
so let's see what that does and we end
up with 6 8 10 12 9 and it goes oh I
can't add this there's nothing there so
it gives us a null return very different
than the numpy that would have given you
an error this instead tells you there's
no value here because we couldn't
generate one so we can easily add S5 dot
add S6 and likewise we can do S5 Dot
sub for subtract S6 and we'll run that
and on the add the subtract and you
guessed it we're going to do multiply
and divide next again you can see
there's the null values where it can't
subtract the two because there's no
values there to subtract we can also do
S5 multiply mul they're all three
letters on these that's one of the ways
to remember how they figured out the
code for this so remember these are all
three letters mole we'll go ahead and
run this and you can again you can see
how they're multiplied together and then
we can also do the S5 div three letters
again S6 and run that
and you'll see here this goes to
Infinity because we have zero in the
wrong position so it actually gives you
a whole different answer here that's
important to notice and then in the null
values because there's no data and it
can't actually produce an answer off of
null off of missing data and since we're
in data science let's do S6
median so let's look at the median data
which is simply median sorry for those
who are following the three letters
because median is not three letters and
you can see an S6 is 3.0 and let's do a
print here and we'll do median or
average S6
and let's print Max
S6 and just like median there's max
value and if we're going to have a max
value we should also have a minimum
value so let's pop in minimum
we'll go ahead and run this and you're
starting to see something that would be
generated like say an R where you're
starting to get your different
statistics we have a median value of
three max value of 7 and a minimum value
of zero and what it does when it hits
these null values if there is no values
in there because we could still do that
we could actually you know what let's go
up here and do
let's pick this one where we multiplied
let's go s seven equals
I'm going to print the S7 just so I keep
it nice and uniform so I still have my
S7 down there and run it and then I want
to take the S7
because S7 now has null values and an
Infinity value and let's see what
happens
this is going to be interesting so I
want to see what it does with infinity
and we end up with a median of six
maximum of 27 and minimum of zero which
is correct it drops those values so when
it gets to there and it doesn't know
what to do with them it just drops those
values and then it computes it on the
remaining data on there so that's
important to know when you're making
these computations you're looking at Min
and Max and median you're not going to
know that there's no values unless you
double check your data for the null
values that's a very important thing to
note on there so just a real quick
review on there we've done our created
our PD series and we've gone ahead and
done addition subtraction multiplication
division all those are three letters so
sub Min div add and then we looked at
median maximum and minimum so we're
going to go ahead and jump into the next
big topic which is to create a data
frame so now we're going to go from
series and we're going to create a
number of series and bundle them
together to make a data frame
there we go cell type markdown and run
that so we have a nice title on there
it's always good to have a good title
all right so our first data frame we'll
jump in with some stuff that looks a
little complicated we'll break it down
first I'm going to create some dates and
you know what let's just go ahead and do
this I want you to see what that looks
like what I'm creating here I've created
a series of dates PD date range and
we're going to use these for the index
okay so when you look at this you'll see
that it's just basically it comes out
kind of like a basic python list or
numpy array however you want to look at
it with our different dates going down
and we've generated six of them and it's
going to have whatever time it is right
now on your on the thing for the date
for the time that's that time stamp
right there and then you'll see we have
11 19 2008 11 20 11 19 and looking into
the future there so that's all this is
is generating a series of dates that
we're going to use as our index and this
is a pandas command so we have a date
range which is nice it's one of the
tools hidden in
can use and next we're going to use
numpy to go ahead and generate some
random numbers in this case we'll do the
np.random.random and six comma four you
can look at this as rows and columns as
we move it into the pandas and of course
you could reshape this if you had those
backwards on your data but we want the
six to match the rows and we have six
periods so our indexes should match
along with the rows on there and then
you know before we do the next one let's
go ahead and just print out our numpy
arrays and see what that looks like here
we have it one two three four by one two
three four five six four by six so it's
a nice little setup on there and since
working with data frames can be very
visual let's give our columns we have
four columns and we're going to give
them names A B C and D so now we have
columns on there also and then let's put
this all together in a data frame and we
can actually you know what let's do this
since I did it with everything else
let's go ahead and do columns and you
can see there's our columns on there
and we'll go ahead and do df1 equals
pandas Dot data frame and note that the
D and the f are capitalized series it
was just the S and I always highlight
this because you don't know how many
times these things get retyped when you
forget what's capitalized on there it's
a minor thing you'll pick it up right
away if you do a lot of it and the first
thing we want to do is we want to go
ahead and take our numpy array because
we're going to create our data frame off
of it's a numpy array and then we want
our index equal to our dates so there's
our index in there and then we also have
columns equals columns and then finally
let's see what that looks like now
remember we had all the different data
that just looked like a jumble of data
we have our column names and everything
else our numpy array kind of just a
jumble array over there four by six you
could sort of read it but look how nice
this looks I mean this is you come into
a board meeting you're working with your
shareholders
this is pretty readable this is you know
this is our date this is our a b c d
whatever it is maybe it's one of these
dates has your leads
closures lost leads total dollar made
you know whatever it is if it's in a
business maybe it's measurements on some
scientific equipment whether searching
material you know where this is like
high of the temperature low of the day
humidity of the day whatever it is so
you can see that we can really create a
nice clear chart and it looks just like
a spreadsheet you know we have our rows
and we have our columns and we have our
data in there now this one I use all the
time if we're going to create we can
create it like you saw here with our
numpy array very easy to do that and
reshape it you can also create it with a
dictionary array so here we have some
data and let me just go down a notch so
you can see all the data on there we
have an animal in this case cat cat
snake dog dog cat snake cat dog we have
the age so we have an array of Ages we
have the number of visits and the
priority was it a high priority yes no
and then we're going to take that we're
going to create some labels we have a b
c d e f g h i and what I want you to
notice on this is we have a title animal
and then we have basically a python list
and these lists they don't necessarily
have to be equal because we can have
non-data you know np.net numpy array
null value but we want to go ahead and
create labels that are equal to the
number in the list so a the first cat B
the second cat C the snake D the dog and
so on so we'll go ahead and create our
labels which we're going to use as an
index
and we'll call this DF let's do it this
way we'll call this df2
equals PD for pandas data frame and then
we have our data just like we did before
and we have our index equals
labels
and if we're going to go from there
let's go ahead and print it out so we
can see what that looks like df2 so
let's go ahead and run that and another
again you have a nice very clean chart
to look at we've gone from this mess of
data here to what looks like a very
organized spreadsheet very Visual and
easy to read animal age visits priority
and then a through J cats and all the
different animals so on and so on and
then when you do programming a lot of
times it's important to know what the
data types are so we can simply do df2
D types
and if we run that we can see that our
animal
is an object because it's just a string
but it comes in as an object age is a
float 64 integer 64 and then priority
again is just an object
and exploring this this one's very
popular let's go df2 head and if we
print that out the df2 head Returns the
first five and we can change this you
don't have to do five you might want to
just look at the top two maybe you want
to look at let's see now let's do six so
maybe we'll look at just the top six in
the database in your data frame and you
can actually this creates another data
frame so I could have a DF 3 equal to
df2 and this now takes the df2 and just
the first six values so so if we do df3
run get the same answer
and if we do it the head of the data we
can also do the tell it's the same thing
DFT you can look at the last we'll just
do the tell which by default does five
the last five and of course you can just
look at the last three of those real
quick just to see what's at the end of
the data and this is the tell I love
doing the tell of one because I'll have
like the index or something like that
and it will just show me the last
whatever the last entry was looking at
stock values and I might want to look at
just the last five days of the stock
values I can do that with the data frame
tail
and some other key things to look up are
the index so we can do df2 dot index
and I want you to notice that this isn't
a call function so if I put the brackets
on the end it'll give me an error
because index is not callable it's just
an object in there so we do do you have
two dot index there's also columns
so we can go ahead and Let's do let's
print this remember the first one is not
going to show unless I print it and then
df2 columns so now we can see we have
our indexes and we have our columns
listed here df2. columns animal age
visits priority it tells you what kind
of object it is or what kind of data
type it is and they're both object and
then finally df2 dot values and again
there's no brackets on the end of
df2.values because this is an actual
object it's not a callable function so
we'll go ahead and run that and it
creates this displays a nice array a
very easy way to convert this back to a
numpy array basically so before I go
into the next section let's just take a
quick look at what we covered so far
with the data frame we came up here we
created our data frame we did it from a
numpy array first setting the columns
and the index the index is setting it up
as the same as when we set up the series
so that should look very familiar so is
the whole format the numpy array the
index dates and the columns columns and
remember in our numpy array we're
looking at row comma column so six rows
four columns is how that reads in the
data frame
and we went ahead and also did that from
a dictionary in this case animal was the
column name with all the date data
underneath that column and then age with
that data visits that data priority that
data and then of course we added our
labels in there for our index so there's
no difference in there but it
automatically pulled the column names
important to know when you're dealing
with the data frame and importing a data
frame this way
and then we did looking up D type we
looked at head and tell looking at your
data really quick we also did index and
columns and values and note these don't
have the brackets on the end
so the next thing we want to do is go
ahead since we're dealing with data
science is we want to go and describe
the data so we have
def2.describe to do that and we're going
to manipulate it in just a minute but
let's just see what this generates
and you can see right here we have age
and visits so looking at our data from
up above let me just go all the way up
here animal age business priority
and it does a nice job generating your
age versus visits which has all the data
you have your account your means your
standard deviation your minimum value 25
or in this group 50 75 and your maximum
value so this would look familiar as a
data science setup with your describe
for a quick look at your data Frame data
so let's start manipulating this data
frame and moving stuff around and we'll
start with transposing and it is simply
capital T for transpose and when we run
that it flips The Columns and the
indexes so now the indexes are all
column names and the columns are all
indexes animal age visits priority so if
we had come in here with our data shaped
wrong up above where we had a four by
six we can quickly just swap it if we
had it backwards not a big deal and we
can also sort our data something that
you can't deal which is more difficult
to do with a lot of other packages and
the data frame is really easy to do take
our our data frame df2 and we're going
to sort underscore values y equals H and
so when we run this you'll see the
default is ascending so we have 0.5 to
2.53 and everything else is organized so
if you look at your indexes they've been
moved around because each index it moves
the whole row not just the one piece of
data is not being sorted so a very quick
way to sort by age are different data in
the data frame and in addition to
sorting it we can also slice the data
frame so I could do df2 and this should
look familiar from earlier we'll just do
one to three so we're going to pull out
oops it does help if I use the DF
instead of just D and we're going to
pull up just between one and three so we
have not zero which is a we have B which
is 2 or B which is one and C which is
two so one two and then it does not
include 3 which is the standard in
Python and we can even do something like
this we can combine them which is always
fun because remember this returns a data
frame so if I take df2 dot sort
values and we'll do by equals age this
is just kind of fun and then I'm going
to slice it there we go double check my
typing and run it and now you should see
fa because F A are now 1 and 2 on there
so you can very quickly create a whole
string on here which narrows it you know
that you can sort it then slice it and
do all kinds of fun things with your
data frame let's go back to the original
one run there we go and if we can slice
it by row we can also query the data
frame so we can do df2 and this is a
little different because I'm going to
create an array within an array and in
this case we're going to look at all
let's do age comma
visits so look at the different format
in here we have one to three which we've
done this by slicing by an integer value
and then on here I've done df2 H comma
visits in an array and when I run this
you can see that we get just these two
columns on here we get age and visits so
it's a quick way to select just two
columns or select number of columns
you're working with
and if you stop there we did the slicing
almost identical to slice is I location
which uses the integer location one
comma three there's a push in pandas to
move to this particular setup instead of
doing just a regular slice and that's
because this can be confusing when we
slice one to three and then we select
agent visits so there is a push to go
ahead and move to an eye location which
does the same thing you can see here BC
it's the same as up above there's also a
copy command so we can do df3 equals df2
copy we're just going to create a
straight copy of it and of course if we
do df3
that'll be the same as a df2 on there so
df3 equals df2 dot copy and then let's
do df3 dot is null so we're looking for
null values and this will return a nice
map and you'll see that everything is
false except when you go up here under
the cat or H they had a null there and
so if we go to have a couple up here
also underneath of let's see the dog
okay there's a bunch of nulls in here
there's D up here so let's look at D
down here and you'll see false true
there it is there's our null value so we
can create a quick chart of null values
you can use this to do other things we
can leverage that null value to maybe
take an average or something and fill
those null spaces with data and we can
also modify the location so here's our
df3 location
and notice this is location not I
location eye location has I for integer
location uses the in this case the
variables on the left and what we can do
on here and we're going to set this
equal to 1 5 and let's um I'll pick a
spot let's go back up here where we had
let's do F A just let's see where we're
looking at oh here we go let's do F and
age and up here f is set to age of 2.0
and we find out that that's incorrect
data so we go ahead and switch to df3
equal and then we're going to print out
our df3
and if we go to F and H it is now 1.5 so
we're just changing the value in the df3
and this is changing the actual data
frame remember a lot of our stuff we do
a slice and like it returns another data
frame this changes the actual data frame
and that value in the data frame
so we've covered uh location and I
location is null making a copy here's
our eye location which is equivalent of
a slice and also selecting columns so
now we want to dive just to take a
little detour here and let's look at
tdf3 means
and this is kind of nice because you can
do this you can either do this by as you
can select a single column here by the
way you can just add the column
selection right here like we did before
so we could have age
look up the mean that just creates a
series if I run that there's our age
but if I take that out instead of
selecting it we can do the whole setup
and it has age and visits so why doesn't
it have priority or animal well those
are not integers so it's really hard
they're non-numerical values so what is
the average I guess you could do a
histogram which probably we'll look at
that later on but the only two things we
can really look at is age and visits and
we have the average or the mean on the
age is 3.375 and the mean on visits is
1.9 and let's do df3
visits we'll go ahead and steal the
visits again
and remember all those different
functions we looked at for a series well
we can do those here we can do the sum
so if we run that we'll see that these
sum up to 19. we could also look up
minimum if you remember that from before
the minimum is 1 Max so all that
functionality is here I'll just go back
to summing it up and adding it all
together so real quick we've shown you
how to take the series operations and
put them into the data frame and then we
can actually this is interesting one we
can just do df3 sum run and you'll see
the different summations on there it
just combines them I like the way it
just combines the strings on there for
priority and animal we've looked at is
null we've also looked at copying along
with the different slices which we
talked about earlier so let's talk about
strings let's dive into the string setup
on there and let's go ahead and create a
string series string equals PD series
and we just put it right in there we
have ACD a a b a c a popped in a null
value cow and Al I don't know why they
picked Cal and Al in the background
someone must like those animals and of
course we can just do string if we run
that you'll see leave the r out we'll
get an error but if we put it in there
you'll see that we have a simple series
0 a 1C 2D and it automatically indexes
it zero to eight and then we can go
string dot lower so when we're talking
about our data frame in this case or our
data series string in this case we use
the string function Str and we're going
to make it lower and if we go ahead and
put the brackets on there and you'll see
that we've gone from capital a Capital C
so on to ABC and Baka CBA cow Al they
were all lowercase already and of course
if you want to go lower you can also do
upper and we'll go ahead and run that
and you can see we now have ACD AAA Baka
everything's capitalized except for the
null value which is still null all right
so we looked at a few basic string you
can see that string functions upper and
lower we're going to jump into a very
important topic I'm even going to give
it its own header on here because it's
such an important topic what do you do
with missing values Panda has some great
tools for that so we'll dive into those
we'll call we'll work with df4 and if
you remember the DF copy from above
we're just going to make a copy of df3
and let's just take a quick look at the
data we're working with oops df3 forgot
the three on there there we go so here
we have our cat snakes and dogs
hopefully not all in the same container
because that would be just probably mean
to all of them so we made a copy we're
going to be working with df4 and the
reason we made a copy is we want to go
ahead and fill the data and we just
simply do fill in a and then we're going
to give it the value we want to put in
there we'll give it the value 4. so I
can run in here and you'll see now that
df4 now has where the N A was is filled
with the value of 4 4 same thing down
here
a lot of times we'll compute the mean
first so I might do a mean page equals
df4 and then we want to go ahead and do
age
and dot mean
and then I'll do something like this df4
I only want to select the age and I want
to fill that
with the mean h and I run in there and
you'll see that our df4h now has the
means in there just a quick way of
showing you how you can combine these
let me go back to our original one there
we go and run that and keeping with good
practices df5 equals df3 dot copy
a little printer df5 which should be the
original one
and then on the df5 we can now drop our
missing data
I'm going to Simply drop in a and we're
going to use how equals any so I'm going
to drop any row that has missing data in
it and you'll see we had D here with
missing data and H and then let's go
ahead and see what df5 looks like when
we do that
there we go and there it is D is gone
and so is H so we create a new data
frame off of this missing those values
now if you have a lot of data dropping
values is a good way to take care of it
because you don't miss some data if you
have not a whole lot of data you're
working with like the iris data set or
something like that or something small
you want to start trying to find a way
to fill that data in so you don't lose
your computational power of the data you
got so just a quick look at processing
null values or missing values you can
fill them usually with the means some
people use medium or the mode there's
different ways you can fill it one way
is means and we can also just drop those
rows those are the two main things we do
with missing data
here we go uh we're going to cover next
this is I so love data frames for this
file operations it saved me so much time
because they have so many different
tools for bringing data in and saving
data so we're looking at the data frame
file operations it's really streamlined
I don't know how many times I'll go on
to different data downloads and they'll
have Panda download standard on there
just because it's so widely used so
let's start with the most common file is
a CSV so we have df3 to CSV or animal
and let me just show you the folders
going into right now I have some
Untitled a few things in here so we go
ahead and run this and this is now save
the animal to my hard drive and you can
now see the animal folder up here and if
I let's do edit with a notepad oh let's
open up with just a regular notepad
there we go or wordpad if I open that up
you can see it's comma separated our
titles they don't have an index on the
categories on the top in the index comma
then all the different data is separated
by commas
standard CSP file on there and if we're
going to send it to CSV and notice the
format is dot 2 underscore CSV and it's
just the name of the file we're sending
it to you can also put the complete path
by default it's going to go whatever the
active directory this program is running
on that's why those other folders are in
there so we have our df3 to CSV and then
if we're going to put it in there we
want to also get it back out and we'll
call this one DF underscore animal
equals PD read underscore CSV I always
have to remember is two underscore CSV
and read underscore CSV I always want to
do like a capital in there and not the
underscore we're going in here again
it's the active directory so if I now do
print out my DF animal
and let's just do the head we only want
to look at the first three lines so if I
go ahead and run this we'll see the
first three lines and they should match
up here what we saved to our CSV so very
easy to save and import from our CSV
files on here
and it turns out DF
3 also has a two Excel they actually
have a lot of different formats but you
know old school Excel was real popular
for so long still is we can go ahead and
save it as animal dot xlsx we're going
to call the sheet named sheet1 and then
I can also do DF we'll call it animal 2.
two and this one's going to come from
and the same format on here there we go
so we still have our animal xlsx the
sheet1 that's where it's coming from
index columns equals none so we're not
going to we're going to suppress the
indexing on the columns n a values and
it'll just assign that 0 1 up on your
indexes so if it says index columns
equals none that's what it does and then
we've added null values because there's
no values in here and we want to just
make sure that they're marked as n a and
we'll go ahead and just print out the
animal animal to there we go and let's
run that let's make this let's just do
the whole thing so we'll go ahead and
run that and it probably doesn't help
that I completely forgot the read so
animal 2 equals PD dot read
Excel there we go Excel so now we go
ahead and run it and what we expect is
happening here we have the same data
frame on here and if I flick back to my
folder you can now see that we have the
animal one of these is in Excel and one
of these is a CSV on here and so there's
our two file Types on there and they
have other formats these are just the
two most common ones used and I don't
know how many times I've had stuff from
Excel I need to pull out if you've ever
played with Excel it's a nightmare on
the back end because of the way they do
the indexing
so this just makes it quick and easy to
pull in an Excel spreadsheet so we
looked at two different ways to bring
data in and save it to files we've
looked at all kinds of different ways of
manipulating our data set and slicing it
and creating it for our data frame let's
get in there put your visualization
always a big thing at the end because
one it lets you check to see what you
did make sure it looks right and then
also if you're going to show somebody
else it makes it very clear what's going
on if they see something visual so this
is where a really important part of data
science is so let's go ahead and bring
in our tools we're going to do import
numpy as NP we want to make sure we have
our Amber sign matplot library in line
this just lets Jupiter know that we're
going to print it on this page if you're
using a different IDE you don't really
necessarily need that but this does help
it displays correctly in jupyter
Notebook and if you remember for earlier
we could create a we're going to call it
TS we're going to create a pandas which
are cute cuddly creatures versus a
pandem short for pandemonium no so we
have TS equals PD series and we're just
going to create a random setup of 50.
we'll do an index we'll set it equal to
the pandas date range today periods
equals 50 so the 50s should match and I
want you to notice something here I did
not import the matplot library why
because it's already in there pandas
already has its built-in connection and
interface with matplot Library so you
don't have to import it and we'll go
ahead and do TS equals
ts.cumulative sum we're going to do the
cumulative sum
it's a little reformatting there and
we'll go ahead and plot it and let's
take a look at what that looks like
so we have a nice graph here we have the
dates on the bottom we set this up so we
have a nice range between in this case
minus four to looks like about two maybe
or one minus four and one so what we've
done here we've plotted a basic series
just a single row of data and we've set
indexes on there but we can also do the
whole data frame on there and let's see
what that looks like so first let's go
ahead and create the data frame we have
here random number so we're going to do
50 by 4 and then we'll go ahead and
create columns a b X and Y just because
we can index is a ts.index on there so
we're going to use the same index as
before just to keep it nice and uniform
we've already generated the dates to go
with it and then we can do just like we
did with the series we can also do with
the data frame
DF equals DF cumulative sum so we're
going to sum the whole data frame and
then we'll do simply DF plot and this
puts that in and let's go ahead and run
this and look how easy and quick that
was to generate a nice graph with all
the different data on there so we have
our shared index we have the shared
columns and then we have the different
data from each one that we can easily
look at and compare so very quick way of
displaying data you can imagine if you
were working in oh I think I mentioned
stock earlier because they've been doing
some analysis of stock lately so you'd
have your date down here and then you
would have stock a Stock B stock X Y
whatever it is and you could put them
all on one chart and see how they what
they look like next to each other and
this isn't too far off from what some of
those graphs looks like and this is just
randomly generated so stock has a lot of
Randomness in it which is one of the
reasons I actually play with it for
doing some of my models on for testing
them out now there are a lot of features
in pandas so we're going to show you one
more thing on here there's some of the
things like I didn't go too deep we
looked at the top two for importing data
from a CSV and from an Excel spreadsheet
showed you how to quickly plot the data
there's more settings in there you can
do we're going to do one more thing down
here and this is kind of a fun one
change this to a markdown and run that
so how would you remove repeated data
using pandas
and this is where you have a data set
that comes in and maybe it's a feeding
from one location and instead of noting
that it's repeated the date like oh
let's go back to stocks that's a good
visual we have the stocks from the 23rd
and it adds another row and it's the
same row it's importing the 23rd again
and again so now you have that data
repeated three times and you need to go
back and figure out how to get rid of it
how do you track that down so let's
start by creating a quick database our
data frame not a database I keep saying
databases it's a data frame and we'll
just make this data frame has using our
dictionary going in this data frame only
has one data Series in it which is fine
so if we do DF to print it out you'll
see a one two two two two four five six
seven and so on and so how would you
remove that well there is a neat feature
in data frames called shift
along with another feature that lets us
select just certain date information and
we'll go with the location function put
that in Brackets remember that from
above location and then in the location
let me just spread this out a little bit
so it's really easy to read in fact I'm
going to go upscale on that since we're
doing some a little bit more complicated
here
what you can see on this on the location
is I have DFA dot shift so this is going
to shift up one by default you can
actually change this to two or three you
could even do a minus one and it shifts
the other way but it's going to shift up
by one by default that's going to say if
that does not equal DF of a then we want
that and if you look down here we had
one two two two two when we run this
Logic on here and we do the shift it now
gets rid of all the duplicates so we
went from 1 2 2 2 4 4 5 whatever it was
here it is one two two two four four
four five five five six six six two one
two four five six seven eight and you'll
see on the index it just deletes them
out of there so the index stays the same
obviously you don't want the dates to
change if you're working with an index
dated setup so it just deletes those
duplicates out of there
just a quick way to introduce you to one
the fact that you can add logic gates
into here and to the eye location allows
you to use shift so there's the shift
function and then the I location selects
that based on true or false
wow so we've actually covered a lot
today in pandas we've really covered
into the basics of selecting your
different series out of your column out
of your data frame how to index rows how
to slice how to plot hopefully you'll
take this beyond that and start
combining these different things and you
can create long strings and really
explore your data generate some nice
graphs if you're in jupyter Notebook
it's a great demo to show others and I
didn't know this about Jupiter notebook
you can do this in jupyter Notebook and
then you can download and I always I
never really look too closely at all the
downloads which you download as an HTML
and post it to your blog so it's got a
neat feature in there but any of this is
a really powerful tool all of this is
really powerful tools for doing your
data science today we're going to study
the matplot library and the python code
so what's in it for you what is matplot
Library types of plots plotting graphs
and sub graphs adding a graph inside a
graph graph parameters title label
Legend line graphs line types color and
transparency canvas grid and axes range
2D plots scatter step bar fill between
radar chart histogram Contour image 3D
surface image and then we'll hit a
practice example pie chart
so let's start with what is matplot
library matplot library is an open
source drawing Library which supports
Rich drawing types it is used to draw 2D
and 3D graphics and there are so many
packages in the matplot library we're
going to cover the basics and there are
so many packages that sit on top of the
matplot library that we can't even cover
them all today but we'll hit the main
one so that you have a good
understanding of what the matplot
library is and what the basics can do
you can understand your data easily by
visualizing it with the help of matplot
Library you can generate plots
histograms bar charts and many other
charts with just a few lines of code and
here we have some basic types of plots
you can see here that we'll go into we
have the bar chart the histogram boy I
use a lot of histograms in my stuff
scatter plot line chart pie chart and
area graph let's start plotting them and
to do this I'm going to be using Jupiter
notebook you can use any of your python
interfaces for programming or scripting
and running it of course we here really
like the Jupiter notebook for doing
basic a lot of basic stuff because it's
so visual and in our jupyter notebook
which opens up in this case I'm using
Google Chrome you can go up here to New
and we'll create a new Python 3 and set
that up if you're not familiar with
jupyter notebook we do have a tutorial
that covers some of the basics of that
you'll look at any of our tutorials I
usually cover a number of them showing
how to set up Jupiter and Anaconda I
myself use Jupiter through anaconda in
fact let's go ahead and open that up and
just take a look at what let's see what
that looks like you can see your
anaconda Navigator if you install it it
will automatically install the jupyter
notebook but it also installs a lot of
other things I know some people like the
QT console for doing python or spider
I've never used them I actually use
notepad plus plus as one of my editors
and then I use the jupyter notebook a
lot because it's so easy to have a
visual while I'm programming and even
simple script in Python I'll take it
from the Jupiter notebook and then do a
save as you can always go under file and
you can download as a Python program so
that will download it as an actual
python versus the IPython that this
saves it as so let's go ahead and dive
in and see we got going here and and
let's go ahead and put matplot Library
tutorial and I'm going to turn this cell
into a markdown so it doesn't actually
run it we can see it has a nice little
title there that's all Jupiter notebook
and then from matplot library let's
import
High Lab
back one and then let's go ahead and
just print
we'll go pylab and the version let's go
ahead and run this so we're going to
import our pylab module from the matplot
library and we find out that we're in
version
1.15.1 always important to note the
version you're in probably I was reading
an article that said the number one
thing that python programmers struggle
with is remembering what version they're
working in and making sure that they're
going from one platform to the other
with the same version and if we're going
to graph things I think we need some
data to graph so we're going to import
numpy as NP now if you're not familiar
with numpy definitely go back and check
out our numpy tutorial there's so many
different things you can do with it
dealing with reshaping the data and
creating the data we're just going to
use it to create some data for us and
there is a lot of ways to create data
but we're going to use the np.line space
so we're going to create a numpy array
and the way you read this is we're going
to create numbers between 0 and 10 and
we're going to create 25 of these
numbers so we're just going to divide
that equally up between 0 and 10. and if
we have x coordinates we should probably
have some Y coordinates and we'll do
something simple like x times X plus two
and let's just take a look we're going
to print X and print
y let me go ahead and run this and let's
see we got going on here so we have our
x coordinates which is 0 0.4.83
Etc and you can look at this as an X Y
plot so we have 0 we have two and we
have 0.416 we have 2.17 and just as a
quick reminder we're going to do print
in prax comma y dot reshape 25 comma two
and the reason I want to do this is I
want to show you something here a lot of
times a program returns X comma Y and
it's an array of X comma y x comma y x
comma Y and so when you're working with
the pi plot
you have to separate it out and reshape
it so if I start off with pairs like
this I can reshape them if I know
there's 25 pairs in there I can switch
the 2 and the 25 and this is kind of
goofy but we'll do it anyways reshape so
I'm going to reshape my 25 by 2 back to
2 by 25. and if I run that you'll see I
end up with the same output as the X Y
the two different arrays in here
and this is important that we want X and
we y separate again that's all numpy
stuff but it's important to understand
that this is a format that matplot
Library works with it works with an
array of x's and they should match your
array of y's so each one has 25
different entities in it and then for
our basic plotting of this data it only
takes one command to draw graph of this
data and so we use our from up here we
imported pylab we take our PI lab and
the keynet lender there is plot for
plotting aligned and then we want our x
coordinates and our Y coordinates and
we'll throw in R and the r simply means
red so we're going to draw the line in
red let me go and run that
you can actually switch this around if
you wanted to do different there's B for
blue we have a lot of fun yellow hard to
see yellow there we go but we'll go
ahead and stick with red run and when
you're doing presentations with these
try to be consistent you know if the
business and the shareholders send you a
spreadsheet and they have losses in red
you use red for losses in your graph
try to be consistent use green for
profit for money you don't have to
necessarily use green but it's whatever
they're using whatever the company is
using try to mirror that that way people
aren't going to be confused if you
switch your data around and every time
one graph has red for loss and one graph
has blue for loss it gets really
confusing so make sure you're consistent
in your graphs and your coloring and
something to know because we're going to
cover this in a minute this is your
canvas size so we have a canvas here and
what we're going to do next is we're
going to look at sub graphs okay so
let's take our PI lab and create a sub
plot
okay one of the things I also don't know
when we're working with the matplot
library I'm not sending when I do this
this is my drawing canvas the pi lab so
once I've imported the pylab I'm drawing
my images on there very important to
know and with the subplot we're going to
give it some different values and we're
going to represent by rows columns and
indexes and let's do one two one so it's
going to be the first row second column
and the index is like you can stack your
graphs and things like that we don't
worry too much about indexes but rows
and columns we want to go ahead and use
Row one and column two and if we're
going to have one object we should
probably have two but before we do that
we have to plot data onto the subplot so
the order is very important and we're
going to stick with our X comma Y and
let's do this we're going to add in a
third parameter here remember we did Red
we're going to add shorthand dash dash
for dashed lines so the this plots the
data into Row 1 column two and if we're
going to do that let's do another one
pilab dot subplot and if we're going to
do Row one let's do column two and index
two
and this time we're going to add G for
green and this denotes a style and if
we're going to set up our pylab subplot
here we go my lab we gotta go ahead and
plot that pi
lab plot
and instead of X Y we want y comma X
Oops I messed up this is in the wrong
spot there we go we'll move that down
here real quick because that goes in the
plot part so the subplot tells that the
row column and index and the pi plot
tells it what data in this case we
switch them and the color and then the
style shorthand and let's go ahead and
run that and you'll see it takes this
canvas splits it in two and now we have
two different graphs and we have the red
one with dashed lines and we have the
green one which is has little stars
going up and if we take this and let's
just um just for fun let's change this
and run that with an index of one it
puts them both on the same index it also
gives me a warning because it's a
strange way of doing two subplots
there's this depreciated there's another
way to do it but most people just ignore
that warning because it's not going to
go away anytime soon now that's using
the same setup what happens if we do
instead of
this let's change the column on here and
find out what happens
and if we do the column
I didn't really like that on the setup
it just disappears so let's keep our
column as 2 and let's change the row on
the second one to two and run that
and you'll see again it kind of squishes
everything together it can cause us some
issues so let's take the index so these
need a unique index and you can see here
where I made some changes I said row two
and look what happens when I change to
column two so I now have Row 2 column
two index two I squished it up here so
you could put another graph underneath
is what that does and there's all kinds
of different things you really have to
just play with these numbers until you
get a handle on them because
you know we get repeated 164 times
according to Cambridge University if
it's completely new to you and you can
see right here where we go three run
there we go but you can see it takes a
little bit sometimes to play with these
and get the numbers right I hope to hit
the wrong one that's why let's go three
there three there run
there we go now it's overlapping so I
have this doubled over here on the right
for now we'll just go ahead and leave
this with the where we have column and
row two and the two different indexes so
they appear nice and neatly side by side
and then as we just saw as we were
flashing through them we can put them on
top of each other
and let me just highlight that and copy
it down here
paste it down there and here we have one
two one and then we'll do one two one
also for this one and that puts the two
subplots directly on top of each other
it gives us that warning and you can see
we now have two different sets of data
graphed on top of each other and you can
also see how it did the indexes since
one of them is from 0 to 10 that's the
green one on the x axis and the other
one is from 0 to 10 on the y axis so it
took the greatest value of either one
and then used those as a shared value
so let's next look at operator
description and we'll go ahead and turn
this cell into a markdown and run that
so it looks nice so fig and remember I
talked about the canvas earlier I
briefly mentioned it we're going to look
a little bit more at the canvas later on
but that's what the figure is a fit
we're going to add axes so we're going
to initialize a subplot add the subplot
in rows and columns and all kinds of
different things with this that you can
do let's look at that code and see
exactly what's going on and I want you
to notice that there's fig which is the
actual canvas in the matplot library and
ax is commonly used to refer to the
subplots so we're creating subplots
you'll see ax equals PLT subplot
earlier we did the pi lab so let's go
ahead and import Pi plot from matplot
library and we're going to do it as PLT
you'll see that a lot that's really the
standard in the industry is to call it
PLT just like pandas's PD and numpy
array is NP certainly you can import it
as whatever you want but I would stick
to the standards and we're going to do
the same graph as we did above with the
pi lab but with the PLT so if it looks
familiar there's reason we're doing this
because we want to show you how the
figure part works and working with the
canvas goes but we're going to do the
same plot as we did before and we'll
call it fig and we're going to set that
equal to plot figure so there's our
figure or our canvas on there and let's
create a variable called axes and we're
going to set that equal to Fig dot add
axes
and in this we're going to control the
Left Right the width the height of the
canvas from zero to one and so we can go
ahead and I'm just going to put some
stuff in there I got 0.5
0.1.8.8 so when you're looking at this
this is a zero to one or you could say
50 percent 10 80 80 percent but it's a
control it's going to control your left
and your right along with the width and
the height so the width and the height
we're going to use 80 percent and we're
going to have like a little indent on
the left and the right and this would
look familiar from above xcs.plot X
comma Y and then let's give it a color
how about red since we're recreating the
same graph let's keep it uniform oops
and it helps if I use a ax i s instead
of axes I don't know where that came
from but this looks identical to the one
we had up above so here's our axis plot
X comma y of red same graph same setup
but this time we've added a variable
equal to the figure dot add axes so our
plot figures our canvas our axes is what
we're working in and then axis.plot X
comma Y and again we can draw Sub graphs
we put that down here
[Music]
just like we did before and a little
different notation here we're going to
have fig comma axes equal PLT Dot
subplots
and in here it's going to be the number
of rows we're going to do one row
in columns equals two so if you remember
before that's what we did we had one row
with two different graphs on it we're
going to do the same thing but know how
we did this here's our figure our canvas
and our axes we're going to create
actually two different axes we're going
to create Row one column two and so axes
is an array of information so we can
simply do
four well let's do X in axes
and this will now look familiar X Dot
Plot we're going to do X comma y we'll
go ahead and make it red keep everything
looking the same remember nice uniform
graphs everything looks the same and if
we go ahead and run this
you'll see we get two nice side by side
graphs so just as we had before the same
look the same setup
and just for fun let's change in columns
to three we'll run that and now you see
we'll have three on there and let's see
if we make it a little bit more
interesting we'll do in rows equals to
two and you can see down here we're
going to get in the tribute there
because it's trying to scrunch
everything together so it does have a
limit how much stuff we can put in one
small space that's important to know you
can fix that by changing the canvas size
which we'll look at in just a minute and
there's other ways to change it on here
but here we go we can do in rows two and
columns equals one you can see two nice
images right above each other we'll go
back to the original one row two columns
side by side left to right and we can
also draw a picture or graph inside
another graph
and that's kind of a fun thing to do
it's important to note that we can layer
our stuff on top of each other which
makes for a really nice presentation so
let's have a fig create another figure
so we're going to start over again with
our canvas we set that equal to
plt.figure
so there's our new canvas and let's do
axes we'll call it axes one and two axis
one equals fig dot add axes remember
this from earlier
and this here similar numbers we used
before saying how big this axis is this
figure in the axis is so this is going
to be the big
axes and let's do axes two equals
another figure at axes and then
0.2.5.4.3 and if we're going to do this
they need data on them so let's go ahead
and plot some data on our axes so axis1
Dot Plot and we'll make this simply X
comma y comma make it red and then let's
go axis true Dot Plot and let's reverse
them y comma X comma green there we go
doing what I told you not to do you
shouldn't be swapping axes around and
plotting your data in five different
directions because it's confusing let's
go ahead and run this and see what this
looks like and then let's talk a little
bit about this we talked about the
0.2.5.4.3 and let me just grab The
annotation for that that's left right
width and height so we have in here that
this is going to be left right so here's
our left is point one n 0.5 and we you
know what let's just play with this a
little bit what happens when I change
this to 0.1 it moves it way over to the
left so there's our 0.1 so we could make
this point four run that there we go so
you can see how you can move it around
the branches on here 0.2 0.5 is the left
so that's the right so see what happens
when we do point oh let's make this
point one and that actually is they had
it down a left right I thought this was
wrong it's actually how far from the
bottom let me switch that on here bottom
there we go so we had here on this we
can go ahead and put that back to 0.5
and run that and this is 0.3 let's make
this point three also and that is the
width and then course there's the height
we can make that really tiny actually
let's do 0.2 and let's run that and you
can see it changes the height on there
let me make it even smaller 0.2 by 0.2
and as you can see you can get stuck
playing with this to make it look just
right it could sometimes take a little
bit certainly once you have the settings
if you're doing a presentation you try
to keep it uniform unless it doesn't
make sense for the graph you're working
on try to keep the same color as the
same position and the same look and feel
and I mentioned earlier we can adjust
the canvas size so this is from earlier
I just copied it down below we're going
to re-plot the same data we've been
looking at and what we can do is we can
change the figure size to 16 by nine and
let me run that show you what that looks
like so it fills the whole screen and
then if you are normally when you're
working on the screen you don't worry
too much about this but we can set the
DPI to 300 run that
there it goes this is your dots per inch
and if you are doing an output of this
and you're printing a hard copy you want
the higher quality I would suggest
nothing under 300 if it's a professional
print you might get a little less than
that but whenever I'm doing professional
graphics and printing them out on
something 300 dots per inch is kind of
the minimal on there
you can go a lot higher too but keep in
mind the higher you get the more memory
it takes the more lag time and the more
resources you use so usually 300 is a
good solid number to use your dots per
inch and you can see it drill These are
nice it draws a nice large canvas here
which is 16 by nine and then the DPI is
300 on here it's a little higher quality
and just out of curiosity I wonder how
long it takes to draw something double
that size 600 and you can see here we're
at 600 DPI it's going to take a while
there it goes just because it's
utilizing a lot more graphics on there
and let me just go back to the 300 now
we'll actually do let's do a 100 you're
not going to see a difference on this
because it is web based Graphics are
pretty low and up here you saw I did
this with the plot figure this works the
same if I do figure axis subplot figure
size and then we'll go ahead and do axes
plot
X comma y comma we'll stick to red
let's go ahead and run this and you
should get almost the same thing here
here's our axes on the subplot on here
with the fixed size and the DPI let me
take this all out let me just
move all that real quick run it again
there we go now we're back to our
original figure and let's look at other
some of the other things you can do with
this
one of the things we do is we can set a
title for the axis so axis set title
you'll see right here since I put this
on the axis it's the main title for the
whole graph
and if you're going to have a title you
should also label so we can label our X
label and we can set our y label in this
case we're just going to call it X and Y
keep it nice and uniform and if we run
this you'll see that we've added a nice
X label and Y label whoops where did
they go and it turns out in this
environment that you have to put it
before the title so let me go ahead and
put it before the title and there's our
x y and we run that and of course we can
also do upper size a little bit so you
can see what's going on a little better
so here we have X label X if you come
down here you'll see our X label and our
y label we can of course change this to
X
label you can change this to y
and be whatever you want on here of
course and our title graph there we go
run so here we have our title graph our
y label and our X label all set up on
our nice little plot and then before we
move on to the next section let's do
more thing on here we have a thing
called The Legend and we're going
we're going to set our ax Legend label
one label two up here that's the format
for it but let's go down here and
actually use it I'm going to do two
different plots we have axis plot X by x
times x squared and X cubed and if I run
this you'll see it puts two nice graphs
on the setup on there but it's nice to
have a legend telling you what's going
on so for the legend we can actually do
axes since we have the two plots Legend
and on here we've created an array and
we have y equals x squared Y equals X
cubed you can actually put this as
whatever you want those are just strings
and then location two and let's go ahead
and run this and see what that looks
like and you can see it puts a nice
Legend on the upper left hand corner
location two we can do location three
and run it and it drops it down to the
bottom
one I can't remember where that's at
there we go upper right so each one of
these is a number that refers to the
different locations on the screen zero
kind of have to play with them or look
them up to remember where they're at but
they do work it just kind of moves
around depending on where you want your
Legend data on there so on this section
we cover the title of the graph the Y
labels and legends this is we're getting
into some starting to look really fancy
here so we now have something we can
actually put out you'll see the title of
the graph looks a little fuzzy so I
might in a web setup put the DPI up a
couple notches maybe put it at 200 100
might work fine just so you know
something to notice on here when you're
playing with these different things we
had our subplots DPI equals oh let's do
200 and see what that looks like so you
can see it now is a lot clearer it's
also larger so it's a nice little
feature you can throw in there with your
DPI dots per inch so the next section is
let's look at some graph features we're
going to look at line color transparency
size and a few more things on here and
oops I forgot the main title so we have
our figure and our axes equals our plot
and subplots and I'll go ahead and do a
DPI equals 150 so the graph comes out
nice and large and easy for you to see
and let's go ahead and do three plots on
here we'll do X by X plus one so it's
just going to be a straight line plot
X Plus X plus two
and axes Dot Plot
x x
plus three this looks like we're doing
nearest neighbor setup we're showing how
it uh located data and putting your
lines on there between the nearest
neighbors there we go so it draws a nice
little graph with three lines on it one
of the things we can do is we can
control the alpha on this oops and you
can actually see the when they did these
lines it automatically pulls in
different colors for your setup so some
automatic automatic things going on in
there and a lot of times we do that
comma R but we're going to do color
equals red another notation on here
let's go ahead and run this now we have
a bright red line down there and with
the matplot library you're not limited
to Red you can also use the one of many
different color references as you see
here with the pound sign
1155dd which just is just blue and we
could do the same thing with another
color on here which it turns out to be
green I can just as easily do this green
blue oops there we go blue and run that
and you'll see here we have red blue and
green and what I want to do is I want to
make this we're going to say What's
called the alpha on this and we're going
to set this equal to 0.5 so this is
halfway see-through when I run this and
it's almost going to look pink because
you can see through it and let's change
this just a little bit just to make this
kind of fun let's Square it there we go
run it so now we have this nice square
that comes up and you can see when it
crosses it because I plotted these two
lines after it and they have no Alpha
the red is behind those lines or in this
case pink because we did the alpha
halfway through so let's go ahead and do
this Alpha equals 0.5
and oh you know what instead of squaring
it let's take it to the 0.5 power
that'll be kind of interesting to see
what that does we'll just go to keep it
squared there we go and run that and
let's go back and look at this where it
crosses over and the first thing you see
right here is on the blue kind of light
blue now you can see how the two colors
add together you get almost a purple on
there so I can clearly see where the red
crosses the blue line and then the green
just blanks it over because I didn't do
any opaqueness no Alpha on there so this
is great if you have lots of data that
crosses over and you need to be able to
track those lines better and we'll go
ahead and do this 0.5 and we'll run that
oops I Did equals 0.5 let me go ahead
and run that and so you can see right
here now you can easily see the red line
how it crosses the green and the blue
down here and if we want to we can do
this as the default is one is solid so
we can change this all to 0.8 let me
just do that oops 58 there we go run up
semester hit a wrong button there let me
try that again I actually get rid of a
bracket and let's go ahead and run that
and we come down here and look at this
you can still see where it passes behind
them but the green dominates and the
blue dominates because we're now at 80
percent instead of 50 percent and you
can do less that's kind of fun although
at some point the lanes kind of fade
so 0.5 is usually the best setting on
there we have a nice pastel here at 0.3
and you can easily see where they cross
over and just like you can play with the
colors we can play with line width and
you know Let's do let's try DPI 100 and
see what that looks like on my screen
equals 100 and we'll go ahead and just
take our ax plot
let's do four of these lines just so you
can see how they look next to each other
click here there we go
and if I run this they should all appear
the same it automatically does different
colors on there so let's do color equals
blue
I forgot my quotation marks there we go
and we'll go ahead and just make these
all blue just for purposes of being nice
and uniform and then what I want to do
is I want to do the line width
line width equals
0.25 and this is copy paste that down
here
let's do equals one
about 1.5 and let's do one let's make
this equal to two let's see what that
looks like and we do that you can see it
goes from a very thin line at 0.5 a 1 or
1.5 and 2 which is twice the width of
the one
and if we're going to do different sizes
we had different colors we had our Alpha
scheme let's take this whole thing here
let's paste it down here and do another
one but instead of line width let's look
at Styles and something to note here you
can actually abbreviate this with LW so
line width can also be Point let's just
do everything point two and let's set up
a line style we'll do the first one
dashes so let me just paste that down
here so I'm not doing a lot of extra
typing there we go
this out so we have our dashed we can do
a dash dot let's do the dash dot here
and a colon here there we go and there's
a lot of different options we'll look at
a few more as we go down for different
ways of highlighting data but when you
look at this we have everything as a
line width of two and now we have a
straight line we have a dashed line or a
dot dash and a dot dot dot line
and then another thing we can add on
here is we're going to do here's our ax
plot and we did X plus two X plus four
so it goes right on the top and do color
black line with 1.5 so it's a smaller
line and we're going to take the line
and we're going to set dashes so look
I've changed some of the notation here
for my line and my X plot so I can set
my line comma equal to X plot and then I
can change the line settings this way
and when I run this let me run that on
here you'll see the 5 10 15 10 creates a
series of dashes that are buried in
length Link in this case they alternate
between a short Dash and a long Dash and
we can play with these numbers curiosity
always has me what happens when you play
with the numbers just to see what they
look like let's do this and let's paste
this down here I'll do two of these just
because they're kind of fun to play with
and let's change this from 10 to 3 and
we're going to change this one from 15
to to 4. and let's run that and you can
see the differences in the lines oops
very a little bit confusing on there
because I forgot to change the lines are
all on top of each other so let me
change that really quick here and let's
run that and now you can see here's our
original dashed line alternating when I
change these numbers on the second one
the very end value to 3 you can see now
we have the dashes of five let's see I'm
going to guess this is a dashes of five
skip ten dashes of 15 skip 3 and then it
goes back to the beginning dashes five
dashes skip 10 15 dashes skip three and
of course the last one we just switched
up a little bit it looks a lot more
uniform because I'm using two sets of
ten or if I did something like this and
changed it to 30 it really becomes
pronounced as far as the distances
between them and instead of four let's
go let's put 30 here also 30 by 30 there
we go really pronounced on that one and
let's look at one more important group
for plotting our data and in this we're
going to here's our plot we started with
with the X Plus One X plus two X plus
three and did it in Blue on this one's
three or four different blue lines
and this property we want to add the
actual plots so you can see where the
plots are on the graph and for that we
might have marker equals o and if we run
this you'll see it puts a DOT for each
of these and there's 25 dots because we
have 25 x values so we actually have
zero in each of the different values of
X Y are then plotted here with the dots
and we don't want to just limit
ourselves to dots
can also do plus sign that's another
option dots is most common I'll actually
like the dots the best if we do the plus
signings here puts a nice crosshairs or
plus sign on there and we can do a
marker there's a number of different
markers you can use
and I think this one was it s is just a
nice square and that's actually a good
one s for square o for period okay
that's just kind of weird so you can see
that probably on these markers another
one is uh number one so if we run that
you'll see we now have these little
hatch marks and let's take oh let's just
go with the o on this one
by the way this works with square really
nicely some of the stuff we're going to
do here on just a second let's do Marker
size equals two and change that to five
and run that and you can see here it
puts a nice little tiny dot versus uh
the size dot here and this is
interesting because it said two I
thought it would be bigger
but if you do 0.5 it gets even smaller
and let's just do 10 to see what that
looks like run that looks huge so marker
size a lot of these are dependent on the
DPI and the setups there's things that
switch around as far as the way the size
shows up you got to be a little careful
when you change one setting it can
change all the other markers all right
then let's take our Square on here
and we'll do we have marker size we also
have marker face we'll set that equal to
Red of course we're going to take change
the so it's up one notch we'll run that
whoops must have missed type something
on here and I did it's marker face color
equals red and so when I run that you
can now see I have the squares on there
with the marker face color of course we
can mix and match these come down here
we'll make this instead of this let's
make this plus seven and we'll make this
size 15
marker face color equals and we'll do
what green just because there we go run
very hard to actually see what's going
on there still 25 dots that kind of
overlap as you can see they print them
over each other and of course if we
really wanted to make it look horrible
we could just make that really huge
generally though you'd want something a
little bit smaller and cuter we'll just
try doing it this way there we go that's
too small to even see the face so four
you start to see the face on there
around four and maybe on eight eight
might be a good number for this there we
go eight again that all just depends on
what you're trying to show on display so
we've covered a lot of stuff here as far
as our lines we've covered opaque with
our Alpha setting on there give us some
nice pastels you can see how they
overlap and how they cross over we
covered the line width different size on
there different formats for the line
itself and these are all you can combine
all these so you can have our line width
equals two line style equals she can
bring this down here also to the markers
and then we added markers in just
entered a circle a plus sign the square
a little tick which uses a one then we
had a marker size and a marker color
face and we combined those you see we
get a nice different series of
representations we also briefly
mentioned color where you didn't have to
use like in here we used color black
someplace up here I'd have to find it we
use the actual number for the color as
opposed to I changed it to red and blue
so you get very precise on the color if
you have very specific color set that
you need to match your website or
whatever you're working on all of those
are tools in the matplot library so we
have one more piece to formatting the
graph so we want to show you and then we
have two big sections we're going to go
over the different graphs that they have
along with a challenge problem so let's
go in the last section we're going to
look at is limits we're going to limit
our data so this first parameter is
going to paste in there we're going to
create our subplots one two so one row
two columns we're going to do a figure
size a 10 comma five this would all look
familiar now since we've done a number
of them and we're going to go ahead and
plot and this is an interesting notation
you should notice here our axis zero so
one we've used instead of you can just
iterate through them but they're just an
array so it's an array of zero is still
the axes of the first axis out of two
and we're going to plot x x squared x x
cubed line width two so we're going to
go ahead and just plot two graphs right
on top of each other without doing
multiple plots on here and we'll set the
grid equal to true on here let's go
ahead and run that and you can see here
are two plots with the x value going
across and I'm going to do something
similar and by the ways you can just if
you look at it you can see the Grid on
there that's all that is easier to spot
the data going across we're going to
take the same data for axes one so we
have our plot of x x squared x and x
cubed line with two and this time we're
going to take our axes one and do y
limit that's actually set underscore y
limit this is the y axis so it's going
to be an array of two two values and
we'll do zero comma 60. I'm just making
these numbers up the guys in the back
actually made them up I'm just using
their numbers and we're going to set the
x limit
and let's set the x limit as if we get
our brackets there 2 comma 5. so it's
the same data going in and but we're
setting a limit on it let's go ahead and
run that and let's see what it comes out
of and here we have the Y limit 0 to 60.
so we're looking at just the lower part
of this curve here up to here and we
have the X limit two to five so that
starts right here at 2 and you can see
very different graphs this is kind of
nice because you could actually put one
of these on top of the other if you
wanted to draw Focus to one part of a
graph remember how we did that earlier
one inside the other but just a quick
note you can easily limit your graph and
re kind of reshape the way it looks
quite easily and we can also add that
grid down there if you want a grid
we'll run that and add the Grid in there
oops I guess you have to do the grid
beforehand
switch that there we go sometimes the
order on this is really important so you
may double check your order when you're
printing these things out it also helps
if I change it to one so in this case it
might not be the order I wonder if we'll
go back here as one there we go so it
doesn't matter the order and grid but
you can set the grid for easy viewing in
here nice setup on there but you can see
how we can limit the data so let's start
looking at some other 2D graphs and make
this cell a markdown so we run it as a
nice pretty title to it and let's go
ahead and create some data with an NP
array we'll do 0 to 5 on here there we
go and let's look at four common graphs
we'll put them side by side so we'll do
a figure our axes equals plot subplots
one four columns and then figure size
hopefully will fit nicely on here it
seems to do a pretty good on here and
I'll go and just run that since we're in
there run you'll see I have my four
blank plots on here
and we'll start with axes of zero the
set title
and we want this to be a scatter plot
a scatter plot just means it has a bunch
of dots on it so here's our axes of zero
dot scatter easy to remember scatter a
bunch of plots on there we'll do our n
we can do X or nope there
and let's go ahead and do axis set title
scatter up already did that we're just
going to do scatter
that's how you do it on there notice how
you create a scatter plot with simply
with the scattered control and we'll do
let's do the variable X X Plus let's
throw some Randomness in here use these
Scatter Plots are I have a lot of random
numbers connected to them that's why
they do them on there and so the bigger
the X gets the bigger the randomness so
0.25 times the randomness and what we
should end up down here is with the
scatter plot and you can see as you go
up it just kind of has some random
numbers and moves up and down the line
but plus just the points so if you
remember from back up here where we did
marker this is plotting basically just
the marker so it's a scatter plot
probably less used is a step plot so for
X is one we'll go ahead and do a step
plot so you can see what that looks like
and this time I'll use our n value
instead of X we generated that n value
up here and so for this we have n n
times 2 orn squared n times 2 N squared
line width equals two and if we run that
it creates a nice Step Up
let's see so we've got a scatter plot
we've got a step plot let's do a bar
plot
and we'll use the same formula in N
squared alignment centered because you
can have them left or right with 0.5 and
Alpha if you remember correctly that's
how opaque it is let's see what that
looks like on there so we have some nice
you can see here a nice bar plot it
should look very similar to the step
plot but color it in
and we can change the width let's see
what happens we do 0.9 run and if we
take width out completely
run that you can see it starts coming
together on there and we can change the
alpha we can take the alpha out too and
run that so now you have the solid
colors and if we take out the center and
run that everything you really can't see
the shift on here because that's
actually the default on this but these
are common settings for the bar graph
let me just put them back in there there
we go alignment center and Alpha now I
can't say I have used the step craft
very much there's certain other certain
I guess domains of expertise that
require a step graph but the scatter
plot and the bar graph very common
especially the bar graph and we'll look
at histograms here in just a minute so I
use histograms a lot especially in data
science but this is nice if you have
very concrete objects somebody how many
people are wearing yellow hats that kind
of thing but if we're going to do that
let's go ahead and do the last one which
I see a lot more in the Sciences
certainly using the data science but
more like for mapping I saw publication
on solar players and they're discussing
the energy and so filling in the graph
gives it a very different look so we're
going to do the fill between and it's
just like you think it'd be it's fill
between but with a underscore between
them and we'll do x and x squared and x
and x cubed and we'll do color green and
Alpha again in case you had other data
you want to plot on there you can see it
forms a nice squared coming up here and
also if you look at the bottom one is
your squared value the upper line is
your cubed value and then it fills in
everything in between
if you remember from calculus this would
be if you had like a car a motor and
efficiency they would talk about the
efficiency going up and the loss and
you're looking for the space or the area
between the two lines so it gives you a
nice visual of that now let's look at a
few more basic two-dimensionals so we
have our figure figure size on here
we're going to do a radar chart to be
honest I've never used a radar chart in
business or in data science I got to
find a reason to use one now so the
first line for doing a radar chart we
have to add axis into the figure and
with this this actually creates our well
let's let's run it so you can see what
it creates it creates a nice looks like
you're on a submarine and you're
tracking The Hunt for Red October or
something like that and it needs all of
these the polar is the fact that we're
doing polar coordinates 0 0.6.6 has to
do with the size if you take out any of
these things and run them you get just a
box if you take out the other half you
pretty much get nothing in there and if
you change these numbers and change them
a little bit you can see it gets bigger
they had 0.6 on here I'll go ahead and
leave it as one because that's just kind
of fun that's all about the size on here
the height and the width and then let's
create some data T equals NP line space
and this is 0 to 2 times NP times pi so
if you remember that is the distance
across and we're going to generate a
hundred points so this is just a thing
of data we're putting together let me
simply do an ax Dot Plot and in this
case let's do T comma T which would be a
diagonal line and a regular chart and
we'll give it a nice color equals blue
and line width equals three let's see
what that looks like and we can see here
a spiral coming out remember this would
be just a diagonal line on a regular
chart what happens if we take this and
instead of T times 0.5 there we go and
you can see it slightly Alters the way
it spirals out we could do T times two
spirals out a little quicker so it's
kind of just a fun like I said I've
never used a radar chart it's a column
but you can always think of radar under
submarine kind of looks like one of
those or on an airplane and none of this
would be complete if we didn't discuss
histograms oh my gosh do I use a
histogram so much and we'll use our
numpy that we have set as NP to generate
oh it looks like we have a hundred
thousand variables we're going to set
equal to n and of course we create our
figure and our axes from subplots one
two figure size 12 14. so we're going to
look at two different variations of the
histogram and we'll set a title default
histogram set our title there and then
this is simply hit
for histogram and we'll just go ahead
and put in our n in there and let me run
this and see what that looks like
and let's talk about what is going on
here so we generated an array here of
data 1000 random arrays it looks like
they're mostly between minus four and
four and then it adds up each one it
says I'm 0 you have 35
000 that are zero so that's what's most
common on here and we have 20 000 that
are somewhere in this range right here
between the minus two and well it looks
like one and minus two and somewhere
between zero and one there's thirty
thousand numbers so all this is saying
is this is how common these variables
are and this gives you this is a point
in so many directions when you're
looking at data science to go ahead and
run your histogram so you should always
have your histogram and you can always
put limits and all the other different
things on your rate just like you did on
the other graphs on there and then we're
going to do a cumulative detailed
histogram and all it is is a histogram
let me just do that
and we set cumulative equal to true
and bins equal 50. and I really want to
highlight the cumulative equals true is
important but we can now choose how many
bins we have in the first one it kind of
selected them for us in this case let me
go ahead and run this and you'll see it
has it prints the data out for us and
here's our whoops must have missed oh
there we go it doesn't help that I put
it over the old one there we go okay so
now you have your default histogram and
now we have a cumulative histogram and
we should have 50 steps in there and
let's just find out if that's true not
So Much by counting them I'm not going
to count them if you want to you can
count them let's just change it to 10
and see what happens and we see here we
have now 10 counts of that
set that for five
and run that
and then we have our five on there and
we go ahead and take the cumulative
equals true out just so you can see what
that looks like and let me run that on
here too
that looks just like it did before I
think there's what one two three four
five six seven eight they have eight
different bins on here is what the
default came out of
put that back in there run and so now it
should look almost identical and it does
and then we can put the cumulative back
in see what that looks like with the
cumulative
and run that
and we can see how that shifts
everything over and has a slightly
different look wait it shifts it all to
the right no it doesn't actually shift
it to the right it's cumulative so it's
a total of the different currencies and
so what that means is like if you
consider this like for the year of
rainfall we have like day one you had a
little bit of rain day two we have more
rain and so if you look at the number
this is a hundred thousand thirty five
thousand so it's a cumulative detail the
histogram the currents as it grows and
rainfall is a good one because that
would be a cumulative histogram of how
much rain occurred throughout the year
and we're going to look at two more
graphs we've already looked at a bunch
of them we looked at our radar graph
we've looked at scatter step bar fill in
basic plots we've looked at different
ways of showing the data and we can
increase the size of the line the look
the color the alpha setting
so let's look at contour maps let's put
that in there there we go draw a contour
map and before we draw a contour map we
need to go ahead and create data for it
and if you have Contours your data is
all going to have three different values
so let's go ahead and create the data
here we have our you'd import your
matplot library your numpy so we have
our numbers array and we'll import
matplot.cm and that's your color Maps so
you have all these different color maps
you can look at there's like hundreds of
color Maps so if you don't want to do
your own color you need to do your own
color map they're pretty diverse and of
course our PLT we're going to our PI
plot and to generate our different data
we're going to create a Delta 0.025 and
we'll start with X when we're going to
create an array between -3 and 3 and
Delta increments of 0.025
and we'll have our y we'll do something
similar and then we'll create our X Y
into a mesh grid again these are all
numpy commands so if you're not familiar
with these you'll want to go back and
review our numpy tutorial and we'll do
an exponential on here minus x squared
minus y squared for our Z1 we'll do a Z2
so we have two different areas and Z
equals z of one minus Z2 times 2. so
we've created a number of values here
and let me go ahead and run this and
let's plug that in so you can see where
those values are going so once we've set
these we're going to create our figure
and our X from our PLT subplots we're
going to create the variable Cs and this
is going to be our Contour so right here
CS is our Contour surface and we're
feeding it X Y and Z if you remember X Y
we created as our X and Y components
using our mesh grid and you know what
let's do this just because it's kind of
good to see this let's go ahead and
print X and let's print Y and I always
like to do this when I'm working with
something this either is really
complicated in this case is what we're
looking at or you don't understand yet
so we've created a mesh grid we have x y
and when we're done with this we end up
with here's our X
and this set of values in our y so those
are X and Y coordinates and then we've
also created Z based on our X and Y so
we have x capital x capital Y and
capital Z is our three components X and
Y being the coordinates well Z is going
to be our actual height since we're
doing a contour map so we created our
contour map from our X Y and Z
coordinates we want to go ahead and put
in a c label maybe we want to go ahead
and do an title on here
we'll put that in our set title and this
is a contour there we go contour map and
let's go ahead and run this and see what
that looks like and you'll see we
generated a nice little contour map
there's different settings you can play
with on this but you can picture this
being you're on a mountain climb and
here we have a line that's represents
zero maybe that's C Level and then
moving on up you have your Contours of
0.5 and then minus one and different
setups little Hills I guess if it's
minus that's like a pit so I guess
you're going down into a pit at minus
five and minus one but on the other side
you can see you're going up in levels so
here's a Mountaintop and here's like a
basin of some kind and in data science
this could represent a lot of things
this could also be representing two
different values and maybe profits and
loss I don't know if I'd ever really do
that as a contour map but I'm sure you
could be creative and find something fun
to do with a contour map and then we're
going to look at one last map which is
the 3D map and those are can be really
important as a final product because it
can show so much additional information
that you can't fit on two-dimensional
graphs
there we go draw a 3D image and so we're
going to import from our MPL toolkits
the implant 3D and the axis 3D we're
going to import axis 3D this is what's
going to let us work with the 3D image
and this should look familiar we're
going to create another figure just like
we did before figure size 14 by 6 that's
a good fit on the screen we'll go ahead
and run that so we have our figure and
let's go ahead and take our X and we're
going to set that equal to Fig dot add
subplot that should also be familiar
from earlier and we're going to work
with this sets the settings for the
projection we're going to use one two
one projection 3D and we'll see what
that looks like in just a minute and we
just created some three-dimensional data
here before where we had X Y and Z
capital X Y and Z so we're going to
reuse that data we're just going to use
that since this also this is also a
three-dimensional image so let's use
that for a three-dimensional graph and
we simply do ax plot underscore
surface and a capital x capital y
capital Z so there's our data coming in
and we're going to add some settings in
here we're going to do R stride 4 C
stride four and line width 0. I'll show
you what that is here in just a minute
let's go ahead and run that so we can
see our graph and of course it helps if
I don't add an extra comma in there and
you can see it generates this really
beautiful three-dimensional graph
so let's take a little bit time to
explore some of these numbers we have
going in here
we have the r stride 4 the C stride four
and the projection 3D projection 3D is
the important one because that's telling
us that this is a 3D graph here
so what are these first numbers one two
one let's just change one of these I'm
going to change this to five
and it's going to give me an error let's
change it to 1.
and oops that didn't work let's change
this middle one to three instead and
you're going to see how it starts
reshaping the size and how it fits on
the screen and we'll change the first
one to two and we'll run that one and
again it's changed the dimensions and
the size and how it fits on here play
with these numbers to get a nice look
and feel for it and part of it is the
Tilt and the angle
I'll do seven on this one
there we go you can see it really
shifted it there
but again that changes the size and
outfits on the canvas but we'll leave it
at the one
two and just so you get a good look at
what we're talking about here this is
column width and index from before
if we do one one one you can see that it
now spreads it out all the way across
uses the whole setup on there so this
has to do with the size and how big you
want it to be now there's one term that
we didn't cover in this yet but we've
used it throughout the whole setup
and I'm just going to type that down
here even though we're not going to go
into detail and that's the term heat map
you might see that is kind of starting
to lose ground as far as a common
reference but there sure are a lot of
people still talk about heat Maps what
is a heat map well it is simply a color
map that's all it is so if you ever see
the term heat map
that refers to the fact this is in
different colors representing different
heights
that one is in the heat map but you can
see up here we switched into let me go
back up here here we go this one has
different colors for the different
values a lot of times you'll use like
instead of X and Y you might do a heat
map
where you have a fourth value and the
fourth value represents the color and so
you'll see this 3D image into nice
colors represented by a heat map that's
all it is so if you see the term heat
map that only means we're plotting some
of the data in color to make it stand
out or to give it a fourth dimension in
this case
so we've covered a lot of things on
matplot and that brings us covered all
the basics so that brings us to practice
example and this is going to be the
challenge for you and let me go ahead
and change our cell cell type mark down
and run that so it looks pretty
practice example write a Python program
to create a pie chart of the popularity
of programming languages
okay excellent
and if you're going to have a challenge
we need some data and I'll just throw in
our import our matplot library at the
beginning you should do that
automatically and so for our data to
plot we're going to have our languages
we're going to have python we're going
to have Java PHP JavaScript c-sharp C
plus plus so those are six categories
and then we have our popularity oops
misspelling there popularity we'll give
the first one 22.2 percent Java 17.6 and
I don't know if these are real numbers
they pulled my guess is that they might
have just been made up because I don't
know if Python's really that much more
popular than the other ones maybe
specific to data science because
Python's very popular in data science
right now because it has so many options
the only other program that's highly
used and exclusively for data science is
R so Python's big and python also does a
lot more it's a full programming
language where R is primarily for data
science they didn't put R in here so we
have python we have Java we have our PHP
you can see the different values they've
given it or different percentages
and I did add these up does not add up
to 100 it adds up to 71 percent or
something like that
and then we're going to give colors and
we've chosen these guys in the back
brought in these colors I'm not sure
what these colors are we'll find out in
a minute so I'll be exciting but you can
see they're using the actual color
values you can pull off of a color wheel
or something like that it could have
just as easily done blue red green if
you're too lazy to pick the exact colors
and then let's go ahead and solve this
and see we got here we're going to do
something a little fancy just because we
can the first thing we're going to do is
we're going to use a variable called
explode and you'll notice that there's
six variables in here so that matches
our six different categories and the
first one we've done is 0.1 and then
zero zero zero zero zero point one when
we put this in here under the explode in
the plot it will actually push that
square out so it's a really cool feature
to highlight certain information on a
pie chart
and this is simply PLT dot pi and we're
plotting
popularity there we go and before we add
in all the really cool settings for this
let's go ahead and run it and you'll see
we generate a nice flat pie not too
exciting there and then we'll go ahead
and put in all the extras I talked about
explode or we can explode one of the
values out so here's our explode equals
explode labels as languages because we
want to know what the different colors
mean here's our colors equals colors our
Auto picture and this is standard print
format so that's a python setup on there
and that's just going to put the value
on the pi slice and then we're going to
add Shadow because it just looks cooler
with a shadow gives a little 3D look and
we'll do a start angle of 140. let's go
ahead and run this and take a look and
see what comes out of that
and look how that changes the whole
setup so here's our labels there's our
value we put on there there's our slice
that's pushed out there's our shadow a
3d effect and then we started at 140. we
could also rotate this let's just do
this angle 90.
and if we run it
you'll see the blue pie slices moved up
a little bit we could actually do
actually let's just take the whole
starting triangle out and run it'll
default to zero
this is what it looks like if it
defaulted to zero so depending on where
you want the highlighted slice to appear
usually you want that to appear on the
left because people read left to right
and so it draws a focus onto in this
case Python and how great python is I'm
a little biased we're teaching a Python
tutorial so it should be understandable
that we're looking at Python and one
last reference before we close you can
go over to the matplot library.pi plot
setup and if you go underneath there the
different functions on there you can
look this up on their website you'll see
a full list and this is why it's so
important to go through a tutorial like
this because this list is just so
massive I'm trying to figure out like
here's our bar plot there's a bar H you
can add barbs there's a box plot we
didn't cover C labels a totally
different kind of for your Contour plot
you can set up in there if you go down
here we have our figures we used on
there we showed you the basics how to do
the figure you'll see some closer
references on those there's a histogram
down here hist there's also the hist 2D
makes a 2d histogram plot H lines all of
this these are all the different
commands that are underneath of here and
you can see it's pretty extensive we've
covered all the basic ones so that you
know have a solid ground to look at
these different options so when you come
to these functions some of them are
going to look a little off or not off
will look unfamiliar but you'll still
have the availability to probably
understand most of this and have a basic
understanding of your matplot library
what does a data scientist do these are
some of the activities data acquisition
data preparation data mining data
modeling and then model maintenance we
will talk about each of these in a great
detail but at a very high level the
first step obviously is to get the raw
data which is known as data acquisition
it can be in all kinds of format and it
could be multiple sources but obviously
that raw data cannot be used as it is
for performing data mining activities or
data modeling activities so the data has
to be clamped and prepared for using in
the data models or in the data mining
activity so that is the data preparation
then we actually do the data mining
which can also include some exploratory
activities and then if we have to do
stuff like machine learning then you
need to build a machine learning model
and test the model get insights out of
it and then if the model is fine you
deploy it and then you need to maintain
the model because over a period of time
it is possible that you need to tweak
the model because of change in the
process or changing the data and so on
so that all comes under the model
maintenance so let's take deeper look at
each of these activities let's start
with data acquisition so the stage of
data acquisition basically the data
scientist will collect raw data from all
possible sources so this could be
typically an rdbms which is a relational
database or it can also be a non rdbms
or it could be flat files or
unstructured data and so on so we need
to bring all that data from different
sources if required we need to do some
kind of homogeneous formatting so that
it all fits into uh you know looks at
least format from a format perspective
it looks homogeneous so that may be
requiring some kind of transformation
very often this is loaded into what is
known as data warehouse so this can also
be sometimes referred to as ETL or
extract transform and load so a data
warehouse is like a common place where
data from different sources is brought
together so that people can perform data
science activities like reporting or
data mining or statistical analysis and
so on so data from various sources is
put in a centralized place which is
known as a data warehouse so that is
also known as ETL and in order to do
this there can be the data scientists
can take help of some ETL tools there
are some existing tools that a data
scientist can take help of like for
example data stage or Talent OR
Informatica these are pretty good tools
for performing this ETL activities and
getting the data the next stage now that
you have the raw data into a data
warehouse you still probably are not in
a position to straight away use this
data for performing the data mining
activities so that is where data
preparation comes into play and there
are multiple reasons for that one of
them could be the data is dirty there
are some missing values and so on and so
forth so a lot of time is actually spent
in this particular stage so a data
scientist spends a lot of time almost 60
to 70 percent of the time in this part
of the project or the process which is
data preparation so there are again
within this there can be multiple sub
activities starting from let's say data
cleaning you will probably have missing
values the data there is some columns
values are missing or the values are
incorrect there are null values and so
on and so forth so that is basically the
data cleaning part of it then you need
to perform certain Transformations like
for example normalizing the data and so
on right so you could probably have to
modify a categorical values into
numerical values and so on and so forth
so these are transformational activities
then we may have to handle outliers so
the data could be such that there are a
few values which are Way Beyond the
normal behavior of the data for whatever
reason either people have keyed in wrong
values or for some reason some of the
values are completely out of range so
those are known as outliers so there are
certain ways of handling these outliers
and detecting and handling these
outliers so this is a part of what is
known as exploratory analysis so you
quickly explore the data to find out are
there so and you can use visual tools
like plots and I identify what are the
outliers and see how we can get rid of
the outliers and so on then the next
part could be data Integrity data
Integrity is to validate for example if
there are some primary keys that all the
primary keys are populated there are
some foreign keys and at least most of
the foreign Keys should be populated and
otherwise when we are trying to query
the data you may get wrong values and so
on so that is the data Integrity part of
it and then we have what is known as
data reduction sometimes we may have
duplicate values we may have columns
that may be duplicated because they are
coming from different sources the same
values are there and so on so a lot of
this can be done using what is known as
data reduction and thereby you can
reduce the size of the data drastically
because very often because this could be
written in data which can be reminded so
let's take a look at what are the
various techniques that are used for
data cleaning so we need to ensure that
the data is valid and it is consistent
and uniform and accurate so these are
the various parameters that we need to
ensure as a part of the data cleaning
process now what are the techniques that
that are used for data cleaning or so we
will see what each of these are in this
particular case and so what is the data
set that we have we have data about a
bank and its customer details so let's
take an example and see how we go about
cleaning the data and in this particular
example we are assuming we are using
python so let's assume we loaded this
data which is the raw file.csv this is
how the customer data looks like and we
will see for example we take a closer
look at the geography column we will see
that there are quite a few blank spaces
so how do we go about when we have some
blank spaces or if it is a string value
then we put a empty string here or we
just use a space or empty string if
there are numerical values then we need
to come up with a strategy for example
we put the mean value so wherever it is
missing we find the mean for that
particular column so in this case let's
assume we have credit score and we see
that quite a few of these values are
missing so what do we do here we find
the mean for this column for all the
existing values and we found that the
mean is equal to 638.6 so we kind of
write a piece of code to replace
wherever there are blank values Nan is
basically like null and we just go ahead
and say fill it with the mean value so
this is the piece of code we are writing
to fill it so all the blanks or all the
null values get replaced with the mean
value now one of the reasons for doing
this is that very often if you have some
such situation many of your statistical
functions may not even work so that's
the reason you need to fill up these
values or either get rid of these
records or fill up these values with
something meaningful so this is one
mechanism which is basically using a
mean there are few others as we move
forward we can see what are the other
ways for example we can also say that
any missing value in a particular row if
even one column the value is missing you
just drop that particular row or delete
all rows where even a single column has
missing values so that is one way of
dealing now the problem here can be that
if a lot of data has let's say one or
two columns missing and we drop many
such rows then overall you may lose out
on let's say 60 of the data as some
value or the other missing sixty percent
of the rows then it may not be a good
idea to delete all the rows like in that
manner because then you're losing pretty
much 60 percent of your data Therefore
your analysis won't be accurate but if
it is only five or ten percent then this
will work underway is only to drop
values where or rather dropped rows
where all the columns are empty which
makes sense because that means that
record is of really no use because it
has no information in it so there can be
some situations like that so we can
provide a condition saying that drop the
records where all the columns are black
or not applicable we can also specify
some kind of a threshold let's say you
have 10 or 20 columns in a row you can
specify that maybe five columns are
blank or null then you drop that record
so again we need to take care that such
a condition such a situation the amount
of data that has been removed or
excluded is not large if it is like
maybe five percent maximum 10 percent
then it's okay but by doing this if you
are losing out on a large chunk of data
then it may not be a good idea you need
to come up with something better what
else we need to do next is the data
preparation part is done so now we get
into the data mining part so what
exactly we do in data mining primarily
we come up with ways to take meaningful
decisions so data mining will give us
insights into the data what is existing
there and then we can do additional
stuff like maybe machine learning and so
on to get perform Advanced analytics and
so on so one of the first steps we do is
what is known as data Discovery and
which is basically like exploratory
analysis so we can use tools like
Tableau for doing some of this so let's
just take a quick look at how we go
about that so Tableau is excellent data
mining or actually more of a reporting
or a bi tool and you can download a
trial version of Tableau at tableau.com
or there is also a tableau public which
is free and you can actually use an and
play around however if you want to use
it for Enterprise purpose then it is a
commercial software so you need to
purchase license and you can then run
some of the data mining activities say
your data source your data is in some
Excel sheet so you can select the source
as Microsoft Excel or any other format
and the data will be brought into the
Tableau environment and then it will
show you what is known as dimensions and
measures so dimensions are all the
descriptive columns so and Tableau is
intelligent enough to actually identify
these dimensions and measure so measures
are the numerical value so as you can
see here our customer ID gender
geography these are all Dimensions
non-numerical values whereas age balance
credit score and so on are numeric
values so they come under measures so
you got your data into Tableau and then
you want to let's say build a small
model and you want to let's say solve a
particular problem so what is the
problem problem statement all right
let's say we want to analyze why
customers are leaving the bank which is
known as exit and we want to analyze and
see what are some of the factors for
exiting the bank and we want to Let's
assume consider these three of them like
let's say gender credit card and
geography these as a criteria and
analyze if these are in any way
impacting or have some bearing on the
customer exiting or the customer exit
Behavior okay so let's use Tableau and
very quickly we will be able to find out
how these parameters are affecting all
right so let's see so this is our
customer data so from our Excel sheet we
have data set about let's say 10 000
rows and we want to find out what is the
criteria let's start with gender let's
say we want to first use gender as a
criteria so Tableau really offers an
easy drag and drop kind of a mechanical
so that makes it really really easy to
perform this kind of analysis so what we
need to do is exit it says whether the
customer has exited or not so it has a
value of 0 and 1 and then of course you
have gender and so on so we will take
these two and simply drag and drop okay
so exit it and then we will put gender
and if we drag and drop it to the
analysis side of tabloop all right so
here what we are doing is we are showing
male female as two different columns
here and zero for people who did not
exist and one for people who exited and
that is color coded so the blue color
means people who did not exist and this
yellow color means people who did exit
all right so now if we pull the data
here create like bar graphs this is how
it would look so what is yellow let's go
back so yellow is uh who exited and for
the mail only 16.45 percent have exited
and we can also to draw a reference line
that will help us or even provide
aliases so these are a lot of fancy
stuff that is provided by Tableau you
can create aliases and so that it looks
good rather than basic labels and you
can also add a reference line so you add
a reference line something like this
from here we can make out that on an
average female customers exit more than
the male customers right so that is what
we are seeing here on an average so we
have analyzed based on gender we do see
that there is some difference in the
male and female Behavior now let's take
the next criteria which is the credit
card so let's see if having a credit
card has any impact on the customer exit
Behavior so just like before we drag and
drop the credit card as credit card a
column if we drag and drop here and then
we will see that there is pretty much no
difference between people having credit
card and not having credit cards 20.81
percent of people who have no credit
card have exited and similarly 20.18
percent of people who have credit card
have also exited so the credit card is
not having much of an impact that's what
this piece of analysis shows last we
will basically go and check how the
geography is impacting so once again we
can drag and drop geography column onto
this side and if we see here there are
geographies like I think there are about
three geographies like France Germany
and Spain and we see that there is some
kind of uh impact with the geography as
well okay so what we derive from this is
that the credit card is really we can
ignore the credit card variable or
feature from our analysis because that
doesn't have any impact but gender and
geography we can keep and do further
analysis okay all right so what are some
of the advantages of data mining bit
more detail yield analysis can help us
in predicting the future Trends and it
also helps in identifying customer
Behavior patterns okay so you can take
informed decisions because the data is
telling you or providing you with some
insights and then you take a decision
based on that if there is any fraudulent
activity data mining will help in
quickly identifying such a fraud as well
and of course it will also help us in
identifying the right algorithm for
performing more Advanced Data Mining
activities like machine learning and so
on all right so the next activity now
that we have the data we have prepared
the data and performed some data mining
activity the next step is model building
let's take a look at model building so
what is a model building if we want to
perform a more detailed data mining
activity like maybe perform some machine
learning then you need to build a model
and how do you build a model first thing
is you need to select which each
algorithm you want to use to solve the
problem on hand and also what kind of
data that is available and so on and so
forth so you need to make a choice of
the algorithm and based on that you go
ahead and create a model train the model
and so on we look at data science
components there's the mathematics
statistics domain expertise data
engineering data visualization and
machine learning when we sum this up in
data science really this point
in all of this you want to focus on
first is domain expertise now when
you're taking your classes obviously you
want to go through the mathematics the
statistics the data engineering the data
visualization the machine learning and
learning all those tools
but it really in the job field the
domain expertise comes in
because if you're really good with
business and you go into business with
these tools then you're able to ask the
right questions and deal with it when we
talk about the tools in data science and
where they sit there is a data analysis
data analysis focuses more on statistics
and Mathematics where the data science
size
where the data science side focuses more
on the machine learning data
visualization
and then there's database management
which really focuses on the data
engineering part of it and how to manage
that data in the data flow
you see all these components come
together and then they form the data
science and we talk about Tools in data
science we have SAS we have Matlab we
have SQL you have your Apache spark your
R tab blue python right now in the
programming languages python is probably
the most widely used with r coming in a
close second
the reason for that is these are both
open source and anybody can use them we
look at SAS and tablu those are two
packages that are paid for which have a
lot of automation behind them so a lot
of the larger companies will pay for
those packages because they help work
out a lot of the the back end stuff
before you even need to use them
and of course we have Apache spark you
almost have to know Apache spark in the
growing data Lakes today that's your big
data how do you distribute this if
you're going to process it over a large
amount of data we look at data science
applications there's internet search
very common you enter your Google thing
and it uses a data science algorithms to
figure out what to return Voice
assistance analyzing The Voice coming in
and connecting it with whatever patterns
they need to activate so you can ask it
to turn your lights on in the living
room Healthcare biggest field growing
right now how do we analyze Health Data
from a smart watch and figure out how to
know when a disease is being spread
across the world Healthcare how do we
identify cancer versus non-cancer so we
know who to prioritize and get them in
for surgery where other people might not
need that immediate care and even
identifying problems somebody might have
with their health long before they even
happen what a neat thing to do instead
of waiting until you have a heart attack
to know months ahead of time that you're
having heart conditions Logistics how do
we get from point A to point B if you
ever look at some of the major
Distributors they pre-ship Things based
on what they guess people are going to
need this way you get your stuff right
in the mailbox the day after you order
it e-commerce
huge in there because you have to know
what kind of marketing we're going to
put out who are we selling to what's our
target audience robotics one of the
funner ones when you're coming up into
the future is how do we automate the
different
tasks we have from self-driving cars to
manufacturing lines to maybe even a
self-robotic chef in the kitchen so we
talk about solving problems with data
science we have to ask possible
questions and the desired algorithms and
these really are kind of an overview of
some of the terminology you'll want to
know in data science so we talk about
that how much or how many we're talking
about regression regression basically
means a number if you've ever seen stock
charts you see the guess at what the
next sales price is or buy price is
that's all on your regression side
is it ARB classification
is that a dog or a cat that my photo
took a picture of how is this organized
clustering this is where we take things
that look alike and put them together so
that we can then make predictions on it
how difference is this
just like you have clustering you have
the opposite anomaly detection how do we
find things that don't fit in we're the
outliers what are things we might need
to look at that aren't in our model
and what to do next reinforced learning
this is probably the newest Market is
how do we set something up whereas the
data comes in it learns from the new
data as to what the next action is going
to take
most of these are combined so when we
talk about regression classification
clustering anomaly detection reinforced
learning a lot of times when you put
your model together you might have
multiple parts of this we might look at
the clustering of data and then feed it
into a classification is this a bad loan
to make it the bank or is this a good
loan to give
and from there we might start looking at
when we start clustering these things as
good and bad and what kind of setup is
we then might run it through a
regression model to say hey what is the
amount dollar amount this person should
be allowed to take a loan out
and you can see that all of these start
coming in and then a lot of the models
reinforced learning
we talk about like bank loans and things
like that once a year
they have to rerun those algorithms and
so that's like a human run reinforced
learning uh now we're starting to
automate that so that as the data comes
in real time the models start updating
themselves they start figuring out a way
to solve new problems as they occur
and of course in robotics reinforced
learning is one of the biggest growing
Fields logarithms used in data science
linear regression
logistic regression when you're looking
at both of these think numbers we're
talking regression models and so linear
regression figures out the best line
through the data Maybe it's looking for
a curved line
logistic regression starts looking at
data on a Continuum so that
it goes to an exponential you have a
spot where it might be one or the other
and then you know what it is as it goes
to one side or the other
decision tree wonderful tool if you used
to call it a hack now it's becoming
mainstream to look at the back end what
made the decision so it's really easy to
trace back to how you arrived at the
decision decision trees are kind of nice
that way
nearest neighbors okay nearest neighbors
is your clustering K means clustering
hierarchical clustering so hierarchical
starts dividing them and builds a
hierarchy where the K means and the K
nearest neighbor look for things that
kind of connect each other how close are
they in data format
DB scan another form of clustering your
data principal component analysis so we
start breaking up and looking at the
different components in our data coming
in these are all algorithms used in data
science and there are more these are
kind of the mainline ones and each one
of these has many settings which you can
play with to build a better model to
predict your data and where you want it
to go let's go ahead and take a Hands-On
demo and just see what does this look
like
now I'm going to go ahead and use the
Anaconda Navigator and the which is your
Jupiter notebook which will then open up
in Google Chrome this is one of the Ides
or ways of editing python code I like
this one because it one protects my
computer and creates its own kind of
container and two it's got a really nice
visual demo for doing python certainly
you can use a number of other different
tools like pycharm there's another real
popular one you can actually access
pycharm code through the Anaconda
Navigator now and there's a lot of other
tools on there that each have their
benefit and we come into our jupyter
notebook go ahead and create a new
python I've already done that and we'll
start with a lot Logistics regression
model just so you can see what this
looks like in code we'll actually do two
of these
as we go through this and take a look
and see what that code looks like in
Python now the first thing we want to go
ahead and do is
load up all our parts modules that we
need in our python code
I'll go ahead and run that and you'll
see here I'm going to ignore warnings
because some of the stuff we're doing
we're just looking at it and as you go
from one version of python to one
version of whatever the site kit or in
this case the SC package you'll see some
warnings come up they're not really
important right now
um and then we're going to go ahead and
use the German Credit Data CSV
and so when I run this this is all
loaded up now let's go ahead and just
open up this CSV file so you can see
what that looks like
and here he is here's our German Credit
Data file we'll go ahead and just open
that up with uh let's do wordpad is fine
because it's a Word document
and when we open that up
you can see right here it's just a bunch
of comma separated values we have across
the top it actually has columns on here
so our first row is a bunch of columns
and then of course we look down here
oops I just move stuff around but that's
okay I'm not going to save it and you
can see the values al1 al4 whatever that
means or A14 I guess and then some sort
of numbers on here
and we'll take a closer look when we get
into the program
and looking at the data for right now
we've loaded that under credit DF
and at this point I want to just kind of
take a detour back to the life cycle of
data science so we can see how that fits
in there
and so we've already done our data
Discovery we have a little data prep but
the data is pretty clean it already
comes in preset on there we'll make do a
little data preparation in here we're
going to start looking at exploring the
data analysis and building a data model
and then interpreting the results so
really we're focusing on the last three
steps of this the data Discovery would
be asking start asking questions of what
do we want in there is this going to be
is this going to be a good loan a bad
loan what do we want to get out of this
data where are we going with it that
would be part of the data Discovery and
a lot of times that might be a meeting
you have with the management in the
office or whatever
and then data preparation is of course
cleaning the data up making sure you
know where the source came from all
those kind of fun things that go into
making sure you have good data coming in
we're going to cover mathematics for
machine learning so today's agenda is
going to cover data and its types then
we're going to dive into linear algebra
and its Concepts calculus statistics for
machine learning probability for machine
learning Hands-On demos
and of course throwing in there in the
middle is going to be your matrixes and
a few other things to go along with all
this
data in its types
notice the individual pieces of factual
information collected from various
sources it is stored process and later
used for analysis
and so we see here just a huge grouping
of information a lot of tech stuff money
dollar signs numbers and then you have
your performing analytics to drive
insights and hopefully you have a nice
share your shareholders gather it at the
meeting and you're able to explain it in
something they can understand
so we talk about data's types of data we
have in our types of data we have a
qualitative categorical
you think nominal or ordinal then you
have your quantitative or numerical
which is discrete or continuous
and let's look a little closer at those
data type vocabulary always people's
favorite is the vocabulary words okay
not mine
but let's dive into this what we mean by
nominal nominal they are used to label
various label our variables without
providing any measurable value
uh country gender race hair color Etc
it's something that you either mark true
or false this is a label it's on or off
either they have a red hat on or they do
not uh so a lot of times when you're
thinking nominal data labels uh think of
it as a true false kind of setup and we
look at ordinal this is categorical data
with a set order or a scale to it and
you can think of salary range as a great
one movie ratings Etc you see here the
celery rains if you have ten thousand to
twenty thousand number of employees
earning that rate is 150 20 000 to 30
000 100 and so forth some of the terms
you'll hear is bucket uh this is where
you have ten different buckets and you
want to separate it into something that
makes sense into those 10 buckets and so
we start talking about ordinal a lot of
times when you get down to the
breastbones again we're talking true
false so if you're a member of the 10 to
20K Reigns so so forth those would each
be either part of that group or you're
not but now we're talking about buckets
and we want to count how many people are
in that bucket
quantitative numerical data falls into
two classes discrete or continuous and
so data with a final set of values which
can be categorized class strength
questions answered correctly and runs
hit and Cricket a lot of times when you
see this you can think integer and a
very restricted integer I.E you can only
have 100 questions on a test so you can
it's very discreet I only have a hundred
different values that it can attain so
think usually you're talking about
integers but within a very small range
they don't have an open end or anything
like that
uh so discrete is very solid simple to
count set number continuous on the other
hand continuous data can take any
numerical value within a range so water
pressure weight of a person Etc usually
we start thinking about float values
where they can get phenomenally small in
their in what they're worth and there's
a whole series of values that falls
right between discrete and continuous
you can think of the stock market you
have dollar amounts it's still discrete
but it starts to get complicated enough
when you have like you know jump in the
stock market from
525.33 to
580.67 cents there's a lot of Point
values in there it'd still be called
discrete but you start looking at it as
almost continuous because it does have
such a variance in it now we talk about
no we did we went over nominal and
ordinal almost true false charts and we
looked at quantitative and numerical
data data which we'll start to get into
numbers discrete you can usually a lot
of times discrete will be put into it
could be put into true false but usually
it's not so we want to address this
stuff and the first thing we want to
look at is the very basic which is your
algebra so we're going to take a look at
linear algebra you can remember back
when your euclidean geometry we have a
line well let's go through this we have
a linear algebra as the domain of
mathematics concerning linear equations
and the representations in Vector spaces
and through matrixes I told you we're
going to talk about Matrix is
uh so a linear equation is simply
2x plus 4y minus 3z equals 10. very
linear 10x plus 12.4 y equals z and now
you can actually solve these two
equations by combining them and that's
we're talking about a linear equation
and the vectors we have a plus b equals
c now we're starting to look at a
direction and these values usually think
of an x y z plot so each one is a
direction and the actual distance of
like a triangle a b is C and then your
Matrix can describe all kinds of things
I find matrixes confuse a lot of people
not because they're particularly
difficult but because of the magnitude
and the different things are used for
and a matrix is a chart or a you know
think of a spreadsheet but you have your
rows and your columns and you'll see
here we have a times b equals c very
important to know your counts uh so
depending on how the math is being done
what you're using it for making sure you
have the same rows in the number of
columns or a single number there's all
kinds of things that play in that that
can make matrixes confusing but really
it has a lot more to do with what domain
you're working in are you adding in
multiple polynomials where you have like
uh a x squared plus b y plus you know
you start to see that it can be very
confusing versus a very straightforward
Matrix and let's just go a little deeper
into these because these are such
primary this is what we're here to talk
about is these different math
mathematical computations that come up
so we're looking at linear equations
let's dig deeper into that one an
equation having a maximum order of one
is called a linear equation
so it's linear because when you look at
this we have ax plus b equals c which is
a one variable
we have two variable ax plus b y equals
c a X plus b y plus z c z equals D and
so forth but all of these are to the
power of one you don't see x squared you
don't see X cubed so we're talking about
linear equations that's what we're
talking about in their addition if you
have already dived into say neural
networks you should recognize this ax
plus b y plus CZ
setup plus The Intercept which is
basically your your neural network each
node adding up all the different inputs
and we can drill down into that most
common formula is your y equals MX plus
c
so you have your y equals the M which is
your slope your X Value Plus C which is
your y-intercept it kind of labeled it
wrong here
threw me for a loop but the the C would
be your y-intercept so when you set x
equal to 0 y equals c and that's that's
your y-intercept right there
uh and that's they just had reversed
value of y when x equals zero equals the
y-intercept which is C and your slope
gradient line which is your M so get
your y equals two X plus three and
there's lots of easy ways to compute
this this way this is why we always
start with the most basic one when we're
solving one of these problems and then
of course the one of the most important
takeaways is the slope gradient of the
line so the slope is very important that
M value in this case we went ahead and
solved this
if you have y equals 2x plus 3 you can
see how it has a nice line graph here on
the right
so matrixes a matrix refers to a
rectangular representation of an array
of numbers arranged in columns and rows
so we're talking M rows by n columns
here a11 is denotes the element of the
first row in the First Column similarly
a 12 and it's really pronounced a11 in
this particular setup so it's a row one
column one a 12 is a of Row one column
two first row and second column and so
on
and there's a lot of ways to denote this
I've seen these as like a capital letter
a smaller case a for the top row or I
mean you can see where they can go all
kinds of different directions as far as
the value
you just take a moment to realize there
needs to be some designation as far as
what row it's in and what column it's in
and we have our basic operations we have
addition so when you think about
addition you have uh two matrixes of two
by two and you just add each individual
number in that Matrix and then when you
get to the bottom you have in this case
the solution is 12 10 plus 2 is 12 5
plus 3 is 8 and so on and the same thing
with subtraction
now again your counting matrixes you
want to check your dimensions of the
Matrix the shape you'll see shape come
up a lot in programming so we're talking
about Dimensions we're talking about the
shape if the two shapes are equal this
is what happens when you add them
together or subtract them
and we have multiplication when you look
at the multiplication you end up at the
very a slightly different setup going
now if we look at our last one where
we're like why this always gets to me
when we get to matrixes they don't
really say why you multiply matrixes
um you know my first thought is one
times two four times three but if you
look at this we get one times two plus
four times three one times three plus
four times five
uh six times two one times two plus four
times three
one times three plus four times five
uh six times two plus three times three
six times three plus three times five
and it gives us a nice little uh
fourteen twenty three twenty one and
thirty three over here which then can be
used and reduced down to a sample
formula as far as solving the variables
as you have enough inputs uh and then in
Matrix operations when you're dealing
with a lot of matrixes now keep in mind
multiplying matrixes is different than
finding the product of two matrixes okay
so we're talking about multiplication
we're talking about solving for
equations when you're finding the
product you are just finding one times
two keep that in mind because that does
come up I've had that come up a number
of times where I'm altering data and I
get confused so what I'm doing with it
uh transpose flipping the Matrix over
its diagonal comes up all the time where
you have you still have 12 but instead
of it being a 12 8 it's now 12 14 821
you're just flipping the columns in the
rows and then of course you can do an
inverse changing the signs of the values
across this main diagonal and you can
see here we have the inverse a to the
minus 1 and ends up with a set of 12 8
14 12 is now minus 22 minus 12. vectors
Vector just means we have
a value and a Direction
and we have down four numbers here on
our vector
in mathematics a one-dimensional matrix
is called a vector so if you have your X
plot and you have a single value that
value is along the x axis and it's a
single Dimension if you have two
Dimensions you can think about putting
them on a graph you might have X and you
might have y and each value denotes a
direction and then of course the actual
distance is going to be the hypothesis
of that triangle and you can do that
with three dimensionals X Y and Z and
you can do it all the way to nth
Dimensions so when they talk about the K
means for categorizing and how close
data is together they will compute that
based on the Pythagorean theorem so you
would take the square of each value add
them all together and find the square
root and that gives you a distance as
far as where that point is where that
Vector exists or the actual point value
and then you can compare that point
value to another one and it makes a very
easy comparison versus comparing 50 or
60 different numbers and that brings us
up to I Gene vectors and I Gene values
I Gene vectors the vectors that don't
change their span while transformation
and hygiene values the scalar values
that are associated to the vectors
conceptually you can think of the vector
as your picture you have a picture it's
two Dimensions X and Y
and so when you do those two dimensions
and those two values or whatever that
value is
that is that point but the values change
when you skew it and so if we take and
we have a vector a
and that's a set value uh B is your is
your you have a and b which is your I
Gene Vector 2 is the I Gene value so
we're altering all the values by two
that means we're maybe we're stretching
it out One Direction making it tall if
you're doing picture editing that's one
of the places this comes in but you can
see when you're transforming uh your
different information how you transform
it is then your hygiene value and you
can see here a vector after line Transit
transition we have 3A a a is the I Gene
Vector three is the iodine value so a
doesn't change that's whatever we
started with that's your original
picture and three is skewing in One
Direction and maybe a b is being skewed
in another Direction and so you have a
nice tilted picture because you've
altered it by those by the hygiene
values
so let's go ahead and pull up a demo on
linear algebra and to do this I'm going
to go through my trusted Anaconda into
my Jupiter notebook
and we'll create a new uh notebook
called linear algebra
since we are working in Python we're
going to use our numpy I always import
that as NP or numpy array probably the
most popular
module for doing matrixes and things in
given that this is part of a series I'm
not going to go too much into numpy we
are going to go ahead and create two
different variables a for a numpy array
10 15 and b 29
we'll go ahead and run this and you can
see there's our two arrays 10 15 29 and
I went and added a space there in
between
so it's easier to read
and since it's the last line we don't
have to put the print statement on it
unless you want we can simply but we can
simply do a plus b so when I run this we
have 10 15 29 and we get 30 24 which is
what you expect 10 plus 20 15 plus 9 you
could almost look at this addition as
being
um
just adding up the columns on here
coming down and if we wanted to do it a
different way we could also do a DOT t
plus b dot T remember that t flips them
and so if we do that we now get them we
now have 30 24 going the other way we
could also do something kind of fun
there's a lot of different ways to do
this
as far as a plus b I can also do a plus
b dot t
and you're going to see that that will
come out the same the 3024 whether I
transpose A and B or transpose them both
at the end
and likewise we can very easily subtract
two vectors I can go a minus B
and we run that and we get minus 10 6.
now remember this is the last line in
this particular section and so I don't
have to put the print around it
and just like we did before
we can transpose either the individual
or we can transpose the main setup and
then we get a minus 10 6 going the other
way
now we didn't mention this in our notes
but you can also do a scalar
multiplication
and just put down the scaler so you can
remember that
and what we're talking about here is I
have this array here U and if I go a
times U
H we'll take the value 2 we'll multiply
it by every value in here so 2 times 30
is 60 2 times 15
and just like we did before
this happens a lot because when you're
doing matrixes you do need to flip them
you get 60 30 coming this way
so in numpy uh we have what they call
Dot product
and uh with this this is in a
two-dimensional vectors it is the
equivalent of two matrix multiplication
remember we were talking about matrix
multiplication uh where it is the
well let's walk through it
we'll go ahead and start by defining two
numpy arrays we'll have uh 10 20 25 6 or
our U and our V and then we're going to
go ahead and do if we take
the values and if you remember correctly
an array like this would be 10 times 25
plus 20 times 6. we'll go ahead and
print that
there we go
and then we'll go ahead and do the NP
dot dot of U comma
V
and we'll find when we do this we go
ahead and run this
uh we're going to get
370. so this is a strain multiplication
where they use it to solve
linear algebra when you have multiple
numbers going across and so this could
be very complicated we could have a
whole string of different variables
going in here but for this we get a nice
value for our Dot multiplication
and we did addition earlier which was
just your basic addition and of course
the Matrix you can get very complicated
on these or in this case we'll go ahead
and do let's create two complex matrixes
this one is a matrix of
um you know 12 10 4 6 4 31. we'll just
print out a so you can see what that
looks like here's print a
we print a out you can see that we have
a
two by three layer Matrix for a
and we can also put together always kind
of fun when you're playing with print
values we can do something like this we
could go in here
there we go we could print a we have it
end with equals a run and this kind of
gives it a nice look here's your Matrix
that's all this is comma N means it just
tags it on the end that's all all that
is doing on there and then we can simply
add in what is a plus b and you should
already guess because this is the same
as what we did before there's no
difference we do a simple vector
addition we have 12 plus 2 is 14 10 plus
8 is 18 and so on
and just like we did The Matrix Edition
we can also do a minus B into our Matrix
subtraction
and we look at this we have what 12
minus 2 is 10 10 minus eight uh where
are we
oh there we go eight minus ah
confusing what I'm looking at I should
have reprinted out the original numbers
but we can see here 12 minus 2 is of
course 10 10 minus 8 is 2 4 minus 46 is
minus 42 and so forth so same as its
attraction as before we just call it
Matrix subtraction it's identical
now if you remember up here we had a
scalar addition we're adding just one
number
to a matrix you can also do scalar
multiplication and so simply if you have
a single value a and you have B which is
your array we can also do a times B
when we run that you can see here we
have 2 times 4 is 8 5 times 4 is 20 and
so forth you're just multiplying the 4
across each one of these values and this
is an interesting one that comes up a
little bit of a brain teaser is Matrix
and Vector multiplication
and so we're looking at this
we are let's do a regular arrays it
doesn't necessarily have to be a numpy
array we have a
which has our array of arrays and B
which is a single array and so we can
from here
do the DOT
a b
and this is going to return two values
and the verse value is that it's you
could say it's like uh we're doing the
this array B array
first with a and then with a second one
and so it splits it up so you have a
matrix of vector multiplication and you
can mix and match when you get into
really complicated uh back end stuff
this becomes more common because you're
now you've got layers upon layers of
data and so you you'll end up with a
matrix and a set of Bolt Vector Matrix
says do you want to multiply
now keep in mind that if you're doing
data science a lot of times you're not
looking at this this is what's going on
behind the scenes so if you're in the
side kit looking at SK learn where
you're doing linear regression models
this is some of the math that's hidden
behind the scenes that's going on
other times you might find yourself
having to do part of this and manipulate
the data around so it fits right and
then you go back in and you run it
through the sci kit and if we can do
um
up here we did a matrix and Vector
multiplication we can also do Matrix to
matrix multiplication and if we run this
or we have the two matrixes you can see
we have very complicated array that of
course comes out on there for our DOT
and just to reiterate it we have our
transposer Matrix which is your dot t
and so if we create a matrix a and we do
transpose it you can see how it flips it
from 5 10 15 20 25 30 to 5 15 25 10 20
30. uh rows and columns
and certainly with the math this comes
up a lot
um it also comes up a lot with X Y
plotting when you put into Pi plot you
have one format where they're looking at
Pairs and numbers and then they want L
of x's and all y's so you know the
transpose is an important tool both for
your math and for plotting and all kinds
of things
another tool that we didn't discuss uh
is your identity Matrix
and this one is more definition
uh the identity Matrix we have here one
where we just did uh two so it comes
down as one zero zero one one zero zero
zero one zero it creates a diagonal of
one and what that is is when you're
doing your identities you could be
comparing all your different features to
the different features and how they
correlate and of course when you have a
feature one compared to feature one to
itself it is always one where usually
it's between zero one depending on how
well correlates so when we're talking
about identity Matrix that's what we're
talking about right here is that you
create this preset Matrix and then you
might adjust these numbers depending on
what you're working with and what the
domain is and then another thing we can
do to kind of wrap this up we'll hit you
with the most complicated uh piece of
this puzzle here is an inverse a matrix
and let's just go ahead and put the um
that's a lengthy description
let's go and put the description this is
straight out of the uh the website for
numpy so given a square Matrix a here's
our Square Matrix a which is two one
zero zero one zero one two one keep in
mind three by three it's Square it's got
to be equal it's going to return the
Matrix a inverse satisfying dot a
um a inverse so here's our matrix
multiplication
um and then of course it equals the dot
uh yeah a inverse of a with an identity
shape of a DOT shape zero this is just
reshaping the identity
that's a little complicated there uh so
we're going to have our here's our array
we'll go ahead and run this and you can
see what we end up with is we end up
with an array 0.5 minus 0.5 and so forth
with our two one one going down two one
zero zero one zero one two one
um getting into a little deep on the
math understanding when you need this is
probably really is is what's really
important when you're doing data science
versus uh handwriting this out and
looking up the math and handwriting all
the pieces out you do need to know about
the linear algorithm inverse of a so if
it comes up you can easily pull it up or
at least remember where to look it up we
took a look at the algebra side of it
let's go ahead and take a look at the
calculus side of what's going on here
with the machine learning so calculus oh
my goodness and differential equations
you got to throw that in there because
that's all part of the bag of tricks
especially when you're doing large
neural networks but also comes up in
many other areas the good news is most
of it's already done for you in the back
end so when it comes up you really do
need to understand from the data science
not data analytics data analytics means
you're digging deep into actually
solving these math equations and a
neural network is just a giant
differential equation
so we talk about calculus we're going to
go ahead and understand it by talking
about cars versus time and speed
so it helps to calculate the spontaneous
rate of change
uh so suppose we plot a graph with a
speed of a car with respect to time so
as you can see here going down the
highway probably merged into the highway
from an on-ramp so I had to accelerate
so my speed went way up
stuck in traffic merged into the traffic
traffic opens up and I accelerate again
up to the speed limit and maybe Peter's
off up there so you can look at this as
as
the speed versus time I'm getting faster
and faster because I'm continually
accelerating and if I hit the brakes it
go the other way
so the rate of change of speed with
respect to time is nothing but
acceleration how fast are we
accelerating the acceleration is the
area between the start point of X and
the endpoint of Delta X
so we can calculate a simple if you had
X and Delta X we could put a line there
and that slope of the line is our
acceleration
now that's pretty easy when you're doing
linear algebra but I don't want to know
it just for that line in those two
points I want to know it across the
whole of what I'm working with that's
where we get into calculus so we talk
about the distance between X and Delta X
it has to be the smallest possible near
to zero in order to approximate the
acceleration
so the idea is that instead of I mean if
you ever did took a basic calculus class
they would draw bars down here and you
would divide this area up let's go back
up a screen you divide this area up of
this time period up into maybe 10
sections and you'd use that and you
could calculate the acceleration between
each one of those 10 sections kind of
thing and then we just keep making that
space smaller and smaller until Delta X
is almost
infinitesimally small
and so we get a function of a equals a
limit as H goes to zero of a function of
a plus h minus a function of a over H
and that is your Computing the slope of
the line
we're just Computing that slope under
smaller and smaller and smaller samples
and that's what calculus is calculus is
the integral you can see down here we
have our nice integral sign looks like a
giant s and that's what that means is
that we've taken this down to as small
as we can for that sampling
uh so we're talking about calculus we're
finding the area under the slope is the
main process in the integration similar
small intervals are made of the smallest
possible length of X Plus Delta X where
Delta X approaches almost an infantismy
small space
and then it helps to find the overall
acceleration by summing up all the links
together so we're summing up all the
accelerations from the beginning to the
end
and so here's our integral we sum of a
of x times D of x equals a plus c
that is our basic calculus here
so when we talk about multivariate
calculus
multivariate calculus deals with
functions that have multiple variables
and you can see here we start getting
into some very complicated equations
change in W over change of time equals
change of w over change of Z the
differential of Z to DX differential of
x to DT it gets pretty complicated and
it really translates into the
multivariate integration using double
integrals and so you have the the sum of
the sum of f of x or y of D of a equals
the sum from C to D and A to B of f of x
or y d x d y equals the sum of a to B
sum of C to D of f x or y d y d x
understanding the very specifics of
everything going on in here and actually
doing the math is use the calculus one
calculus 2 and differential equations uh
so you're talking about three full
length courses to dig into and solve
these math equations what we want to
take from here is we're talking about
calculus we're talking about summing of
all these different slopes and so we're
still solving a linear uh expression
we're still solving y equals m x plus b
but we're doing this for infinitesimally
small x's and then we want to sum them
up that's what this integral sign means
the sum of a of x d of x equals a plus c
and when you see these very complicated
uh multivariate differentiation using
the chain rule when we come in here and
we have the change of w to the change of
T equals a change of w DZ uh and so
forth that's what's going on here that's
what these means we're basically looking
for the area under the curve which
really comes to how is the change
changing the speed's going up how is
that changing and then you end up with a
multiple layer so if I have three layers
of neural networks how is a third layer
changing based on the second layer
changing which is based on the first
layer changing and you get the picture
here that now we have a very complicated
multivariate integration with integrals
the good news is we can solve this
mathematically and that's what we do
when you do neural networks and reverse
propagation so the nice thing is that
you don't have to solve this on paper
unless your data analysis and you're
working on the back end of integrating
these formulas and building the script
to actually build them so we talk about
applications of calculus it provides us
the tools to build an accurate
predictive model so it's really behind
the scenes we want to guess at what the
change or the change of the change is
that's a little goofy I I know I just
threw that out there's kind of a meta
term but if you can guess how things are
going to change then you can guess what
the new numbers are
multivariate calculus explains the
change in our Target variable in
relation to the rate of change in the
input variables
so there's our multiple variables going
in there if one variable is changing how
does it affect the other variable
and then in gradient descent calculus is
used to find the local and Global Maxima
and this is really big uh we're actually
going to have a whole gradient descent
because it is really I mean I talked
about neural networks and how you can
see how the different layers go in there
but gradient descent is one of the most
key things for trying to guess the best
answer to something
so let's take a look at the code behind
gradient descent and before we open up
the code let's just do real quick uh
gradient descent
let's say we have a curve like this and
most common
is that this is going to represent your
error oops
error there we go error uh hard to read
there and I want to make the error as
low as possible
and so when I'm looking at it is I want
to find this line here
which is the minimum value so we're
looking for the minimum
and it does that by sampling there
and then based on this it guesses it
might be someplace here and it goes hey
this is still going down it goes here
and then goes back over here and then
goes a little bit closer and it's just
playing a high low until it gets to that
spot that bottom spot
and so we want to minimize the error in
uh on the flip note you could also want
to be maximizing something you want to
get the best output of it that's simply
minus the value so if you're looking for
where the peak is this is the same as a
negative for where the valley is I'm
looking for that Valley that's all that
is and this is a way of finding it so
the cool thing is all the heavy
lifting's done I actually ended up
putting together one of these a while
back as uh when I didn't know about
sidekick and it was just starting boy
it's a long while back
and uh is playing high low how do you
play high low not get stuck in The
Valleys uh figure out these curves and
things like that while you do that in
the back end is all the calculus and
differential equations to calculate this
out
the good news is you don't have to do
those
uh so instead we're going to put
together the code and let's go ahead
and see what we can do with that
so uh guys in the back put together a
nice little piece of code here which is
kind of fun uh some things we're going
to note and this is this is really
important stuff because when you start
doing your data science and digging into
your machine learning models you're
going to find these things are stumbling
blocks the first one is current X where
do we start at keep in mind
your model that you're working with is
very generic so whatever you use to
minimize it the first question is where
do we start and we started at this
because the algorithm starts at x equals
three so we are arbitrarily picked five
learning rate is how many bars to skip
going one way or the other I'm in fact
I'm going to separate that a little bit
because these two are really important
if we're dealing with something like
this where we're talking about well
here's our here's the function we're
going to use our gradient of our
function 2 times X plus five keep it
simple so that's the function we're
going to work with so if I'm dealing
with increments of a thousand point one
is going to be a very long time and if
I'm dealing with increments of 0.001
0.1 is going to skip over my answer so I
won't get a very good answer and then we
look at Precision this tells us when to
stop the algorithm so again very
specific to what you're working on if
you're working with money
and you don't convert it into a float
value you might be dealing with 0.01
which is a penny that might be your
Precision you're working with
um and then of course the previous step
size Max iterations uh we want something
to cut out at a certain point usually
that's built into a lot of minimization
functions and then here's our actual
formula we're going to be working with
and then we come in we go while previous
step size is greater than precision and
itters is less than Max and Max itters
say that 10 times fast
um
we're just saying if it's uh if we're if
we're still greater than our Precision
level we still got to keep digging
deeper and then we also don't want to go
past a thou or whatever this is a
million or ten thousand uh running
that's actually pretty high I almost
never do Max iterations more than like
100 or 200 rare occasions you make up to
four or five hundred if it's depending
on the problem you're working with uh so
we have our previous equals our current
that way we can track time wise uh the
current now equals the current minus the
rate times the formula of our previous X
so now we've generated our new version
uh previous step size equals the
absolute current previous
so we're looking for the change in x
errors equals iterations plus one that's
so we know to stop if we get too far and
then we're just going to print the local
minimum occurs at axon here and if we go
ahead and run this
you can see right here it gets down to
this point and it says hey
um local minimum is minus
3.322 for this particular series we
created and this is created off of our
formula here Lambda x 2 times X Plus 5.
now when I'm running this stuff you'll
see this come up a lot
and with the sklearn kit and one of the
nice reasons of breaking this down the
way we did is I could go over those top
pieces those top pieces are everything
when you start looking at these
minimization tool kits and built-in code
and so from
um we'll just do it's actually Docs
Dot
scipy.org and we're looking at
the scikit there we go optimize minimize
you can only minimize one value
you have the function that's going in
this function can be very complicated so
we used a very simple function up here
it could be there's all kinds of things
that could be on there and there's a
number of methods to solve this as far
as how they shrink down and your X
naught there's your there's your start
value so your function your start value
there's all kinds of things that come in
here that you can look at which we're
not going to
optimization automatically creates
constraints bounds some of this it does
automatically but you really the big
thing I want to point out here is you
need to have a starting point you want
to start with something that you already
know is mostly the answer if you don't
then it's going to have a heck of a time
trying to calculate it out
or you can write your own little script
that does this and does a high low
guessing and tries to find the max value
that brings us to statistics what this
is kind of all about is figuring things
out a lot of vocabulary and statistics
ah so statistics well I guess it's all
relative it's definitely not an adult
class uh so a bunch of stuff going on
statistics statistics concerns with the
collection organization analysis
interpretation and presentation of data
that is a mouthful
um so we have from end to end where
where does it come from is it valid what
does it mean how do we organize it how
do we analyze it and then you got to
take those analysis and interpret it
into something that uh people can use
kind of reduce it to understandable and
nowadays you have to be able to present
it if you can't present it then no one
else is going to understand what the
heck you did
so we look at the terminologies uh there
is a lot of terminologies depending on
what domain you're working in so clearly
if you're working in a domain that deals
with
viruses and T cells and and how does you
know where does that come from you're
studying the different people then you
can have a population if you are working
with
um
mechanical gear you know a little bit
different if you're looking for the
wobbling statistics to know when to
replace a rotor on a machine or
something like that that can be a big
deal you know we have these huge fans
that turn
in our sewage processing systems and so
those fans they start to wobble and hum
and do different things that the sensors
pick up at one point do you replace them
instead of waiting for it to break in
which case it costs a lot of money
instead of replacing a bushing you're
replacing the whole fan unit
an interesting project that came up for
our city a while back
so population all objects are
measurements whose properties are being
observed so that's your population all
the objects it's easy to see it with
people because we have our population in
large but in the case of these sewer
fans we're talking about how the fan
units that's the population of fans that
we're working with
you have a parameter a matrix that is
used to represent a population or
characteristic
you have your sample a subset of the
population studied you don't want to do
them all because then you don't have a
if you come up with a conclusion for
everyone you don't have a way of testing
it so you take a sample sometimes you
don't have a choice you can only take a
sample of what's going on you can't
study the whole population and a
variable a metric of interest for each
person or object in a population
types of sampling we have probabilistic
approach selecting samples from a larger
population using a method based on the
theory of probability
and we'll go into a little bit more
deeper on these we have random
systematic stratified and then you have
non-probabilistic approach selecting
samples based on the subjective Judgment
of the researcher rather than random
selection has to do with convenience
trying to reach a quota or snowball
uh and they're very biased that's one of
the reasons you'll see this big stamp on
it says biased uh so you gotta be very
careful on that
so probabilistic sampling uh when we
talk about a random sampling we select
random size samples from each group or
category so we it's as random as you can
get uh we talk about systematic sampling
we're selecting random size samples from
each group or category with a fixed
periodic interval
uh so we kind of split it up this would
be like a Time setup or our different
categories and you might ask your
question what is a category or a group
uh if you look at I'm going to go back a
window let's say we're studying
economics of different of an area
we know pretty much that based on their
culture where they came from they might
need to be separated and so uh and when
I say separated I don't mean separated
from their their place where they live I
mean as far as the analysis we want to
look at the different groups and make
sure they're all represented
so if we had like an 80 uh of a group
that is uh say Hispanic and or Indian
and also in that same area we have 20 20
who are let's call our expatriates they
left America and they're nice and uh
your Caucasian group we might want to
sample a group that is representative of
both uh so we're talking about
stratified sampling and we're talking
about groups those are the groups we're
talking about and that brings us to
stratified sampling selecting
approximately equal size samples from
each group or category
uh this way we can actually separate the
categories and give us an insight into
the different cultures and how that
might affect them in that area
so you can see these are very very
different kind of depends on what you're
working with as far as your data and
what you're studying and so we can see
here just a little bit more we have
selecting 25 employees from a company of
250 employees randomly don't care
anything about them what groups are in
which office are in nothing
I'll be selecting one employee from
every 50 unique employees in a company
of 250 employees and then we have
selecting one employee from every branch
in the company office so we have all the
different branches there's our group or
our categories by the branch and the
category could depend on what you're
studying so it has a lot of variation on
there you see this kind of grouping and
categorizing is also used to generate a
lot of misinformation
so if you only study one group and you
say this is what it is then everybody
assumes that's what it is for everybody
and so you've got to be very careful of
that and it's very unethical thing to
kind of do
so types of Statistics uh we talk about
statistics we're going to talk about
descriptive and inferential statistics
there are so many different terms and
statistics to break it up uh so we so
we're talking about a particular
setup
so we're talking about descriptive and
inferential uh statistics the base of
the word describe is pretty solid you're
describing the data what does it look
like with inferential statistics we're
going to take that from the small
population to a large population so if
you're working with a drug company you
might look at the data and say these
people were helped by this drug they did
80 better as far as their health or 80
percent better survival rate than the
people
who did not have the drug so we can
infer that that drug will work in the
greater populace and will help people so
that's where you get your inferential so
we are predicting how it's going to
affect the greater population
so descriptive statistics it is used to
describe the basic features of data and
form the basis of quantitative analysis
of data
so we have a measure of central
Tendencies we have your mean median and
mode
and then we have a measure of spread
like your range your interquartile range
your variance and your standard
deviation
and we're going to look at all these a
little deeper here in a second but one
of them you can think of is
how the data difference
differences you know what's the max Min
range all that stuff is your spread and
anything that's just a single number is
usually your central Tendencies measure
of central tendencies
so we talk about the mean it is the
average of the set of values considered
what is the average outcome of whatever
is going on
and then your median separates the
higher half and the lower half of data
so where's the center point of all your
different data points so your mean might
have some a couple really big numbers
that skew it so that the average is much
higher than if you took those outliers
out where the median would by separating
the high from the low might give you a
much lower number you might look at and
say oh that's that's odd Y is the
average so much higher than the median
well it's because you have some outliers
or why is it so much lower
and then the mode is the most frequent
appearing value this is really
interesting if you're studying economics
and how people are doing you might find
that the most common
income like in the U.S was at 1.24 000 a
year
where the average was closer to 80 000
and it's like wow what a difference well
there's some people have a lot of money
and so that skews that way up so the
average person is not making that kind
of money and then you look at the median
income and you're like well the median
income is a little bit closer to the
average so it does create a very
interesting way of looking at the data
again these are all Central Tendencies
single numbers you can look at for the
whole spread of the data
and we look at the measure of central
Tendencies the mean is the average marks
of a student's in a classroom so here we
have the mean some of the marks of the
students total number of students and as
we talked about the median if we have 0
through 10 and we take half the numbers
and put them on one side of the line
half the numbers on the other side of
the line we end up with five in the
middle and then the mode what Mark was
scored by most of the students in a test
in a simple case where most people
scored like an 82 percent and got
certain problems wrong easy to figure
out not so easy when you have different
areas where like you have like the um oh
let's go back to economy a little bit
more difficult to calculate if you have
a large group of scores that makes
thirty thousand and a slightly bigger
group that makes twenty six thousand so
what do you put down for the mode
certainly there's a number of ways to
calculate that and there's actually a
different variations depending on what
you're doing so now we're looking at a
measure of spread uh range what's the
difference between the highest and the
lowest value first thing you want to
look at you know it's uh we had
everybody in the test scored between 60
and 100 so we got 100 or maybe 60 to 90
percent it was so hard that a lot of
people could not get a hundred percent
um you have your interquartile range
quartiles divide a rank ordered data set
into four equal parts
very common thing to do as part of all
the basic packages whether you're
working in uh data frames with pandas
whether you're working in Scala whether
you're working in R you'll see this come
up where they have range your Min your
Max and then it'll have your
interquartile range how does it look
like in each quarter of data variants
measures how far each number in the set
is from the mean and therefore from
every other number in the set
uh so you have like how much turbulence
is going on in this data
and then the standard deviation it is a
measure the variance or the dispersion
of a set of values from the mean
and you'll usually see if I'm doing a
graph I might have the value graphed and
then based on the the error I might grab
graph the standard deviation in the
error on the graph as a background so
you can see how far off it is so
standard deviation is used a lot
so measurement of spread marks of a
student out of 100 we have here from 50
to 63 or 50 to 90 so the range maximum
marks minimum marks we have 90 to 45 and
the spread of that is 45 90 minus 45 and
then we have the interquartile range
using the same marks over there you can
see here where the median is and then
there's the first quarter the second
quarter and the third quarter based on
splitting it apart by those values and
to understand the variance and standard
deviation we first need to find out the
mean so here's our you know calculating
the average there we end up at
approximately 66 for the average and
then we look at that in the variance
once we know the means we can do equals
the marks minus the mean squared Y is a
squared because one you want to make
sure it's you don't have like if you if
you're putting all this stuff together
you end up with an error as far as one's
negative one's positive one's a little
higher one's a little lower uh so you
always see the squared value and over
the total observations and so the
standard deviation equals the square
root of the variance which is
approximately 16. and if you were
looking at a predictable model you would
be looking at the deviation based on the
error how much error does it have uh
that's again really important to know if
your if your prediction is predicting
something what's the chance of it being
way off or just a little bit off
now that we've looked at the tools as
far as some of the basics for doing your
statistics and what we're talking about
let's go ahead and pull up a little demo
and show you what that looks like in
Python code so you can get some little
Hands-On here for that let's go back
into our Jupiter notebook in Python now
almost all of this you can do in numpy
last time we worked in numpy this time
we're going to go ahead and use pandas
and if you remember from pandas on here
this is basically a data frame rows
columns let's just go ahead and do a
print df.head
and run that
and you can see we have the name Jane
Michael William Rosie Hannah sat in
their salaries on here and of course
instead of having to do all those hand
calculations and add everything together
and divide by the total we can do
something very simple on this uh like
use the command mean in pandas and so if
I go ahead and do this print DF
pick our column salary because we want
to find the means of that calorie
we want to find the means of that column
uh and we go and print this out and you
can see that the average income on here
is 71
000.
uh and let's just go ahead and do this
we'll go ahead and put in means
and if we're going to do that we also
might want to find the median
and the median is very similar
except it actually is just median we're
used to means in average it's kind of
interesting that those are they use the
two different words
there can be in some computation slight
differences but for the most part the
means is the average uh and then the
median
whoops let's put a
medium here DF salary that way it
displays a little better we can see the
median is 54
000. so the halfway mark is
significantly below the average why
because we have somebody in here who
makes 189 000. darn you Rosie for
throwing off our numbers but that's
something you'd want to notice this is
this is the difference between these is
huge and so is what is the meaning
behind that when you're studying a
populist and looking at the different
data coming in and of course we also
want to find out hey what's the most
common
income that people make
in this little tiny sample and so we'll
go ahead and do the mode
and you can see here with the mode uh
it's at fifty thousand
so this is this is very telling that
most people are making fifty thousand
the middle point is at fifty four
thousand so half the people are making
more than that what that tells me is
that if the most common income is way is
below the median then there's a few
there's a you know there's a lot of high
salaries going up but there's some
really low salaries in there and so this
trend which is very common in statistic
and when you're in analyzing the economy
in different people's income is pretty
common and the bigger difference between
these is also very important when we're
studying statistics and when you hear
someone just say hey the average income
was you might start asking questions at
that point why aren't you talking about
the median income why aren't you talking
about the mode the most common income
what are you hiding and if you're doing
these analysis you should be looking at
these saying hey why are this
discrepancies why are these so different
and of course with any analysis it's
important to find out the minimum them
and the maximum so we'll go ahead it's
just simply
dot min
so pull up your minimum and then dot Max
pulls up the maximum pretty
straightforward on as far as
translating it and knowing what you're
you know put the your lowest value and
what your highest value is here which
you'll use to generate like a spread
later on and real quick on no mode note
that it puts mode zero like I said
there's a couple different ways you can
compute the mode
although the standard one's pretty good
we can of course do the range which is
your max minus your Min so now we have a
range of 149 000 between the upper end
and the lower end and you might want to
be looking up the individual values on
all of these but it turns out there is a
describe
feature in pandas
and so in pandas we can actually do DF
salary describe and if we do this you
can see we have that there's seven
setups here's our mean our standard
deviation which we didn't compute yet
which would just be a DOT STD and you
gotta be a little careful because when
it computes it it looks for axes and
things like that we have our minimum
value and here's our quartiles
our maximum value and then of course the
name salary uh so these are these are
the basic statistics you can pull them
up and like just describe this is a
dictionary so I could actually do
something like um
and here I could actually go uh count
and run and now it just prints the count
so because this is a dictionary you can
pull any one of these values out of here
it's kind of a quick and dirty way to
pull all the different information and
then split it up and depending on what
you need now if I just walked in and
gave you this information in a meeting
at some point you would just kind of
fall asleep that's what I would do
anyway
um so we want to go ahead and see about
graphing it here we'll go ahead and put
it into a histogram and plot that graph
on it
of the salaries and let's just go ahead
and put that in here so
we do our matplot inline remember that's
a Jupiter's notebook thing a lot of the
new version of the matplot library does
it automatically but just in case I
always put it in there import matplot
Library Pi plot is PLT that's my
plotting
and then we have our data frame uh I
guess I really don't need to respell the
data frame maybe we could just remind
ourselves what's in it so we'll go ahead
and just print
DF that way we still have it and then we
have our salary DF salary salary Dot
Plot history title salary distribution
color gray
uh plot axvline salary the mean value so
we're going to take the mean value
color violet line style Dash this is
just all making it pretty
uh what color dash line line width of
two that kind of thing and the median
and let's go ahead and run this just so
you can see what we're talking about
and so up here we are taking on our plot
so here's the data here's our our data
frame printed out so you can see it with
the salaries we'll look at the salary
distribution and just look at this the
way there the salary is distributed
um you have our in this case we did
Let's see we had red for the median
we have violet
for our average or mean and you can just
see how it really here's our outlier
here's our person who makes a lot of
money here's the average and here's a
median
um and so as you look at this you can
say wow based on the average it really
doesn't tell you much about what people
are really taking home all it does is
tell you how much money is in this you
know what the average salary is
so some of the things you want to take
away in addition to this is that it's
very easy to plot
um
an axv line these are these up and down
lines for your markers
and as you just display the data I mean
you can add all kinds of things to this
and get really complicated keeping it
simple is pretty straightforward I look
at this and I can see we have a major
outlier out here we can definitely do a
histogram and stuff like that but you
know pictures worth a thousand words
what you really want to make sure you
take away is that we can do a basic
describe which pulls all this
information out and we can print any of
the individual information from the
describe because this is a dictionary
and so if we want to go ahead and look
up
the mean value we can also do describe
mean so if you're doing a lot of
Statistics being able to
doesn't have the print on there so it's
only going to print the last one which
happens to be the mean you can very
easily reference any one of these and
then you can also if you're doing
something a little bit more complicated
and you don't need just the basics you
can come through and pull any one of the
individual
um
references from the from the pandas on
here so now we've had a chance to
describe our data let's get into
inferential statistics inferential
statistics allows you to make
predictions or inferences from data and
you can see here we have a nice little
picture movie ratings and
if we took this group of people and said
hey how many people like the movie
dislike it can't say and then you ask
just a random person who comes out of
the movie who hasn't been in the study
you can infer that 55 chance of saying
liked 35 chance of saying disliked or a
10 or 11 chance of can't say so that's
real basics of what we're talking about
is you're going to infer that the next
person is going to follow these
statistics
uh so let's look at Point estimation uh
it is a process of finding an
approximate value for a population's
parameter like mean or average from
random samples of the population let's
take an example of testing vaccines for
covid-19 vaccines and flu bugs all that
it's a pretty big thing of how do you
test these out and make sure they're
going to work on the populace
a group of people are chosen from the
population medical trials are performed
results are generalized for the whole
population so here's a protected there's
our small group up here where we've
selected them we run medical trials on
them and then the results work for the
population a nice diagram with the
arrows going back and forth in the very
scary covet virus in the middle of one
and let's take a look at the
applications of inferential statistics
very Central is what they call
hypotheses testing uh and the confidence
interval which go with that and then as
we get into
probability we get into our binomial
theorem our normal distribution in
central limit theorem
hypothesis testing hypothesis testing is
used to measure the plausibility of a
hypothesis assumption by using sample
data
now when we talk about theorems Theory
hypothesis keep in mind that if you are
in a philosophy class theory is the same
as hypothesis where theorem is a
scientific statement that is something
that has been proven although it is
always up for debate because in science
we always want to make sure things are
up to debate so a hypothesis is the same
as a philosophical class calling a
theory where theory in science is not
the same theory in science says this has
been well proven gravity is a theory so
if you want to debate the theory of
gravity try jumping up and down if you
want to have a theory about why the
economy is collapsing in your area that
is a philosophical debate very important
I've heard people mix those up and it is
a pet peeve of mine when we talk about
hypotheses testing the steps involved in
the hypotheses testing is first we
formulate a hypothesis we figure out the
right test to test our hypothesis we
execute the test and we make a decision
and so when you're talking about
hypothesis you're usually trying to
disprove it if you can't disprove it and
it works for all the facts then you
might call that a theorem at some point
so in a use case let's consider an
example we have four students we're
given a task to clean a room every day
sounds like working with my kids they
decided to distribute the job of
cleaning the room among themselves they
did so by making four chits which has
their names on it and the name that gets
picked up has to do the cleaning for
that day Rob took the opportunity to
make chits and wrote everyone's name on
it so here's our four people Nick Rob
imlia imlia and summer
now Rick Emilia and summer are asking us
to decide whether Rob has done some
Mischief in preparing the chits I.E
whether Rob has written his name on one
of the chit
for that we will find out the
probability of Rob getting the cleaning
job on first day second day third day
and so on till 12 days the probability
of Rob getting the job decreases every
day I.E his turn never comes up then
definitely he has done some Mischief
while making the chits so the
probability of Rob not doing work on day
one is three out of four there's a 0.75
chance that he didn't do work two days
three-fourths times three-fourths equals
0.56
three days you have three fourths three
fourths three-fourths which equals point
four two
uh when you get to day 12 it's 0.032
Which is less than 0.05 remember this
0.05 uh that comes up a lot when we're
talking about
um certain values when we're looking at
statistics Rob is cheating as he wasn't
chosen for 12 consecutive days that's a
very high probability when on day 12 he
still hasn't gotten the job cleaning the
room
so we come up to our important important
terminologies we have null hypothesis
a general statement that states that
there is no relationship between two
measured phenomenon or no association
among the groups
alternative hypothesis contrary to the
null hypothesis it states whenever
something is happening a new theory is
preferred instead of an old one and so
the two hypotheses go hand in hand uh so
your null this is always interesting in
in when talking about data science and
the math behind it it's about proving
that the things have no correlation null
hypothesis says these two have zero
relation to each other where the
alternative hypothesis says hey we found
a relation this is what it is we have
p-value the p-value is a probability of
finding the observed or more extreme
results when the null hypotheses of a
study question is true
and the T value it is simply the
calculated difference represented in
units of standard error the greater the
magnitude of T the greater the evidence
against the null hypothesis and you can
look at the T values being specific to
the test you're doing
where the p-value is derived from your T
value and you're looking for what is
called a five percent or the 0.05
showing that it has a high correlation
so digging in deeper let's assume that a
new drug is developed with the goal of
lowering the blood pressure more than
the existing drug and this is a good one
because the null value here isn't that
you don't have any drug then null value
here is it is better than existing drug
the new drug doesn't lower the blood
pressure more than the existing drug
now if we get that that says our null
hypothesis is correct there is no
correlation and the new drug is not
doing its job the alternative hypothesis
the new drug does significantly lower
the blood pressure more than an existing
drug uh yay we got a new drug out there
and that's our alternative hypothesis or
the H1 or ha
and we look at the p-value results from
the evidence like medical trials showing
positive results which will reject the
null hypothesis
and again they're looking for a 0.05 or
five percent and the T value comparing
all the positive test results and
finding means of different samples in
order to test hypothesis so this is
specific to the test how what percentage
of increase did they have
and this leads us to the confidence
intervals a confidence interval is a
range of values we are sure our true
values of observations lie in
let's say you asked a dog owner around
you and asked them how many cans of food
do you buy for your per year for your
dog
through calculations you got to know
that the on an average around 95 percent
of the people bought around 200 to 300
cans of food hence we can say that we
have a confidence interval of 2 300
where 95 percent of our values lie in
that data spread uh and this the graph
really helps a lot so you can start
seeing what you're looking at here where
you have the 95 percent you have your
peak in this case it's a normal
distribution so you have a nice bell
curve equal on both sides it's not
asymmetrical and 95 percent of all the
values lie within a very small range and
then you have your outliers the 2.5
percent going each way
so we touched upon hypothesis and we're
going to move into probability so you
have your hypothesis once you've
generated your hypothesis we want to
know the probability of something
occurring probability is a measure of
the likelihood of an event to occur any
event can be predicted with total
certainty and can only be predicted as a
likelihood of its occurrence so any
event cannot be predicted with total
search and T can only be predicted as a
likelihood of its occurrence score
prediction how good you're going to do
in whatever sport you're in weather
prediction stock prediction if you've
studied physics and Chaos Theory even
the location of the chair you're sitting
on has a probability that it might move
three feet over
granted that probability is one in like
uh I think we calculated as under one in
trillions upon trillions so it's
the better the probability the more
likely it's going to happen there are
some things that have such a low
probability that we don't see them so we
talk about random variable uh random
variable is a variable whose possible
values are numerical outcomes of a
random phenomena so we have the coin
toss how many heads will occur in the
series of 20 coin flips probably you
know the on average they're 10 but you
really can't know because it's very
random how many times a red ball is
picked from a bag of balls if there's
equal number of red balls and blue balls
and green balls in there how many times
the sum of digits on two dice results
are five each
um so you know there's how often are you
going to roll two fives on your pair of
Dives
so in a use case uh let's consider the
example of rolling two dice we have a
random variable outcome equals y you can
take values two three four five six
seven eight nine ten eleven twelve
so we have a random variable and a
combination of dice and instead of
looking at how many times both dice for
roll five let's go ahead and look at
total sum of five and you have in as far
as your random variables you can have a
one four equals five four one two three
three two
so four of those roles can be four if
you look at all the different options
you have four of those random roles can
be a five
and if we look at the total number
which happens to be 36 different options
uh you can see that we have four out of
36 chance every time you roll the dice
that you're going to roll a total of
five you're gonna have an outcome of
five
and uh we'll look a little deeper as to
what that means but you could think of
that at what point if someone never
rolls a five or they always roll a five
can you say hey that person's probably
cheating we'll look a little closer at
the math behind that but let's just
consider this is one of the cases is
rolling two dice and gambling
there's also a binomial distribution it
is the probability of getting success or
failure as an outcome in an experiment
or trial that is repeated multiple times
and the key is is by meaning two
binomial so passing or filling an exam
winning or losing a game and getting
either head or tails so if you ever see
binomial distribution it's based on a
true false kind of setup you win or lose
let's consider a use case and let's
consider the game of football between
two clubs Barcelona and Dortmund the
teams will have to play a total of four
matches and we have to find out the
chances of Barcelona winning the series
so we look at the total games and we're
looking at five different games or
matches let's say that the winning
chance for Barcelona is 75 percent or
0.75 that means that each game they have
a 75 chance that they're going to win
that game and losing chances are 25
percent or 0.25
clearly 0.75 plus 0.25 equals one so
that accounts for a hundred percent of
the game probability for getting K wins
in in matches is calculated
and we we're talking like so if you have
five games uh and you want to know if I
play
um how many wins in those five games
should I get what's the percentage on
those and the probability for getting K
wins and in matches is calculated by p x
equals k equals nck P to the k q to the
N minus K here p is a probability of
success and Q is the probability of
failure and so we can do total games of
n equals five where k equals zero one
two three four five P which is the
chance of winning is 0.75 Q the chance
of losing equals one minus P which
equals 1 minus 0.075 which equals 0.25
the probability that Barcelona will lose
all of the matches can then just plug in
the numbers and we end up with a point
zero zero zero nine seven six five six
two five so very small chance they're
going to lose all their matches
and we can plug in the value for two
matches probability of the Barcelona
will win at least two matches is 0.0878
and of course we can go on to the
probability of the Barcelona will win
three matches the 0.26 and of course
four matches and so on and it's always
nice to take this information
um and let's find the accumulated
discrete probabilities for each of the
outcomes where Barcelona has won three
or more matches x equals three x equals
four x equals five
and we end up with the p equals 0.264
plus 0.395 plus 237 which equals 0.89
in reality
the probability of Barcelona winning the
series is much higher than 0.75 and it's
always nice to uh put out a nice graph
so you can actually see the number of
wins to the probability and how that
pans out with our binomial case
continuing in our important terminology
location the location of the center of
the graph depends on the mean value and
this is some very important things so
much of the data we look at and when you
start looking at probabilities almost
always has a normalized look like the
graph in the middle
uh but you do have left skewed where the
data is skewed off to the left and you
have more stuff happening out to the
left and you have right skewed data and
so when this comes up and these
probabilities come up where they're
skewed it's really important to take a
closer look at that mostly you end up
with a normalized set of data but you
got to also be aware that sometimes it's
a skewed data
and then the height height of the slope
inversely depends upon the standard
deviation
so you can see down here the standard
deviation is really large it kind of
squishes it out and if the standard
deviation is small then most of your
data is going to hit right there in the
middle you can have a nice Peak and so
being aware of this that you might have
a probability that fits certain data but
it has a lot of outliers so you're if
you have a really high standard
deviation
if you're doing stock market analysis
this means your predictions are probably
not going to make you much money where
if you have a very small deviation you
might be right on Target and set to
become a millionaire which leads us to
the z-score z-score tells you how far
from the mean a data point is it is
measured in terms of standard deviations
from the mean around 68 percent of the
results are found between one standard
deviation around 95 percent of the
results are found between two standard
deviations and you read the symbols of
course they love to throw some Greek
letters in there we have mu minus two
Sigma mu is just a quick ways that kind
of funky you it just means the mean and
then the sigma is the standard deviation
and that's the o with a little arrow off
to the right or the little waggly Tail
Going Up deal with it with a line on it
so mu minus 2 Sigma is your 95 of the
results are found between two standard
deviations
Central limit theorem this goes back to
the skew if you remember we were looking
at the skew values on this previous
slide have left skewed normalized and
right skewed when we're talking about it
being skewed or not skewed the
distribution of the sample means will be
approximately normally distributed
evenly distributed not skewed if you
take large random samples from the
population with the mean mu and the
standard deviation Sigma with
replacement
and you can see here of course we have
our mu minus two Sigma on the spread
down here the mean the median and the
mode and so you're talking about very
large populations
these numbers should come together and
you shouldn't have a skewed value if you
do that's a flag that something's wrong
that's why this is so important to be
aware of what's going on with your data
where your samples are coming from and
the math behind it and if you're going
to do all this we got to jump into
conditional probability
the conditional probability of an event
a is a probability that the event will
occur given the knowledge that an event
to be has already occurred and you'll
see this as Bayes theorem b-a-y-e-s Bays
and this is red
I mean you have these funky looking
little p brackets a b this is the
probability of a being true while B is
already true
and you have the probability of B being
true when a is already true so P B of A
probability of a being true divided by
the probability of B being true
and we talk about Bayes theorem which
occurred back in the 1800s when he
discovered this this is such an
important formula and it's really it's
not if you actually do the math you
could just kind of do
um
um x y equals J K and then you divide
them out and you're going to see the
same math but it works with
probabilities which makes it really nice
and so if you have a set you might have
eight or nine different studies going on
in different areas different people have
done the studies they brought them
together
if we look at today's covid virus the
virus spread certainly the studies done
in China versus the studies the way
they're done in the U.S that data is
different in each of those studies but
if you can find a place where it
overlaps where they're studying the same
thing together you can then compute the
changes that you need to make in one
study to make them equal
and this is also true if you have a
study of one group and you want to find
out more about it so this formula is
very powerful and it really has to do
with the data collection part of the
math and data science and understanding
where your data is coming from and how
you're going to combine different
studies in different groups
and we're going to go into a use case
let's find out the chance of a person
getting lung disease due to smoking and
this is kind of interesting the way they
word this let's say that according to
medical report provided by the hospital
states that around 10 percent of all
patients they treated suffered lung
disease so we have kind of a generic
medical report they further found out by
a survey that 15 percent of the patients
that visit them smoke
so we have 10 percent that are lung
disease and um 15 of the patients smoke
and finally five percent of the people
continued smoke even when they had lung
disease uh not the brightest Choice
um but you know it is an addiction so it
can be really difficult to kick and so
we can look at the probability of a uh
prior probability of 10 people having
lung disease
and then probability B probability that
a patient smokes is 15 percent
uh and the probability of B if B then a
the probability of a patient smokes even
though they have lung disease is five
percent
and probability of a is B probability
that the patient will have lung disease
if they smoke and then when you put the
formulas together you get a nice
solution here you get the probability of
a of B probability that the patient will
have lung disease if they smoke
and you can just plug the numbers right
in and we get a 3.33 percent chance
there is a 3.33 chance that a person who
smokes will get a lung disease
so we're going to pull up a little
python code and always my favorite roll
up the sleeves keep in mind we're going
to be doing this um kind of like the
back end way
so that you can see what's going on and
then later on we're going to create
um we'll get into another demo which
shows you some of the tools are already
pre-built for this let's start by
creating a set so we're going to create
a set with curly braces
this means that our set has only unique
values so you have a list you have your
tuples which can never change and then
you have in this case the the set so
four seven you can't create a four seven
comma four it'll delete the four out so
it's only unique values and if you use
dictionaries
quick reminder this should look familiar
because it is a dictionary where you
have a value and that value is assigned
to or that key is assigned to a value
so you could have a key value set up as
a dictionary so it's like a dictionary
without the value it's just the keys and
they all have to be unique
and if we run this we have a set of four
seven
we can also take a list of regular setup
and I'm going to go ahead and just throw
in another number in here four
and run it and you can see here if I
take my list one two three four four and
I convert it to a set and here it is my
set from list equals set my list
the result is one two three four so it
just deletes that last four right out of
there
and with the sets you can also go in
there and print here is my set my set
three is in the set and then if you do
three in my set
that's going to be a logic function uh
and one in my set 6 is not in the set
and so forth if we run this
we get 3 is in the set true one is in
the set false because three five seven
is another one six is in the Set uh six
is not in the set so not in my set
you can also use this with a list we
could have just used three five seven
and it would have the same response on
there is three and usually you do if
three is in but three in my set is still
works on just a regular list
and we'll go ahead and do a little
iteration we're going to do kind of the
dice one remember
um uh one two three four five six and so
we're going to bring in that iteration
tool and import product as product
and see what that means in just a second
so we have our two dice we have dice a
and it's going to be a set of values we
can only have one value for each one
that's why they put it in a set and if
you remember from range it is up to
seven so this is going to be one two
three four five six it will not include
the seven and the same thing for our
dice B
and then we're going to do is we're
going to create a list
which is the product
of A and B so what's a plus b now if we
go ahead and run this it'll print that
out and you'll see in this case when
they say product because it's an
iteration tool
we're talking about creating a tuple of
the two so we've now created a tuple of
all possible outcomes of the dice where
dice a is one two three one to six and
dice B is one to six and you can see one
to one one to two one to three and so
forth you remember we had a slide on
this earlier where we talked about the
different all the different outcomes of
a dice
we can play around with this a little
bit we can do in dice equals two div
dice faces one two three four five six
uh another way of doing what we did
before and then we can create an event
space where we have a set which is the
product of the dice faces repeat equals
in dice and we're going to just run this
and you can see here it just again puts
it through all the different possible
variables we can have
and then if we wanted to take the same
set on here and print them all out like
we had before we can just go through
four outcome and event space outcome end
equals
so the event space is creating
uh sequence and as you can see here when
we print it out it Stacks them versus
going through and putting them in a nice
line
and we'll go ahead and do something
let's go print
since we have the End Printing with a
comma that just means it's just gonna
it's not going to hit the return going
down to the next line and we'll go ahead
and do the links
of our event space that'll be an
important variable we're going to want
to know in a minute
and of course if I get carried away with
my typing of length I will print it
twice and it'll give me an error so we
have 36 different possible variations
here
and we might want to calculate something
like
um what about the multiple of three what
if we want to have
the probability of the multiple of 3 in
our setup
and so we can put together the code for
the outcome and event space of X Y
equals outcome if X Plus y
remainder three so we're going to divide
by 3 and look at the remainder and it
equals zero
then it's a fable outcome and we're
going to pop that outcome on the end
there
and we'll turn it into a set so the
favor outcome equals a set not necessary
uh because we know it's not going to be
repeating itself but just in case we'll
go ahead and do that
and if we want to print out the outcome
we can go ahead and see what that looks
like and you can see here these are all
uh multiples of three one plus two is
three five plus four is nine which
divided by three is three and so forth
and just like we looked up the length uh
of the one before let's go ahead and
print
the length
of our F outcome
so we can see what that looks like
there we go
and of course I did forget to add the
print in the middle because We're
looping through and putting an end on
the on the setup on there so we're going
to put the print in there and if I run
this you can see
um
we end up with 12. so we have 36 total
options
we have 12 that are multiple that add up
to a multiple of three
and we can easily convert the
probability of this by simply taking the
length of our favorable outcome over the
length of the event space
and if we print it out let me put that
in there probability
last line so we just type it in we end
up with a 0.33333 Chance
and it's roughly a third
and we might want to make this look nice
so let's go ahead and put in another
line there the probability of getting
the sum which is a multiple of three is
0.333333
we can compute the same thing for five
dice
and if we do this for five dice and go
and run it you can see we just have a
huge amount of choices so just goes on
and on down here and we can look at the
length of the event space
and we have over
776 choices that's a lot of choices
and if we want to ask the question like
we did above uh what is the sum where
the sum is a multiple of five but not a
multiple of three
we can go through all of these different
options and then you can see here D1 D2
D3 D4 D5 equals the outcome and if you
add these all together and the
division by five does not have a
remainder of zero but the remainder is
also of a division by three is not equal
to zero so the multiple of five is equal
to zero but the multiple three is not we
can just append that on here and then we
can look at that uh favorable outcome
we'll go ahead and set that and we'll
just take a look at this what's our
length
of our favorable outcome
it's always good to see what we're
working with and so we have 904 out of
six and then of course we can just do a
simple division to get the probability
on here what's the probability that
we're going to roll a multiple of five
when you add them together
but not a multiple of three
and so we're just going to divide those
two numbers and you can see here we get
0.116255 or 11.62 percent
and so you can really have a nice visual
that this is not really complicated in
math right here on probabilities it's
just how many options do you have and
how many of those are you possibly going
to be able to come up with with the
solution you're looking for and this
leads us to a confusion Matrix
a confusion Matrix is a table which is
used to describe the performance of a
classification model on a set of test
data for which the True Values are known
and so you'll see on the left we have
the predicted and the actual and we have
a negative false negative positive true
positive and then we have false positive
and true negative and you can think of
this as your predicted model what does
that mean that means if you divided your
data and you used two-third of us to
create the model
you might then test it against an actual
case for the last third to see how well
it comes out how many times was it true
positive versus uh false positive we
gave a false positive response and you
can imagine in medical uh situations
this is a pretty big deal you don't want
to give a false positive so you might
adjust your model accordingly so you
don't have a false positive say with a
covet virus test it'd be better to have
a false negative when they go back and
get retested then to have 30 percent
false positives where then the test is
pretty much invalid
so in a use case like cancer prediction
let's consider an example where a cancer
prediction model is put to the test for
its accuracy and precision actual result
of a person's medical report is compared
with the prediction made by the machine
learning model
and so you can see here here's our
actual predicted whether they have
cancer or not you know cancer a big one
you don't want to have a false positive
I mean a false negative in other words
you don't want to have it tell you that
you don't have cancer when you do so
that would be something you'd really be
looking for in this particular domain
you don't want a false negative
uh and this is again you know you've
created a model you have hundreds of
people or thousands of pieces of data
that come in there's a real famous case
study where they have the imagery and
all the measurements they take and
there's about 36 different measurements
they take and then if you run the a
basic model you want to know just how
accurate is how many negative results do
you have that are either telling people
they have cancer that don't or telling
people that don't have cancer that they
do and then we can take these numbers
and we can feed them into our accuracy
our precision and our recall
uh so accuracy precision and recall
accuracy metric to measure how
accurately the results are predicted
and this is your total true where you
got the right results you add them
together the true positive the true
negative over all the results so what
percentage of them were accurate versus
what were wrong
we'll talk about Precision is a metric
to measure how many of the correctly
predicted cases are actually turned out
to be positive
uh so we have a Precision on true
positive again if you're talking about
like uh covid testing with the viruses
you really want this to be a high number
you want this true that to be the center
point where you might have the opposite
if you're dealing with cancer where you
want no false negatives
uh so this is your metric on here
Precision is your test positive uh true
positive plus uh false positive
and then your recall how many of the
actual positive cases we were able to
predict quickly with our model uh so
test positive is the test positive plus
the false negative on there let's look
at an X an example of a common use for
linear regression profit estimation of a
company if I was going to invest in a
company I would like to know how much
money I could expect to make so we'll
take a look at a venture capitalist firm
and try to understand which companies
they should invest in so we'll take the
idea that we need to decide the
companies to invest in we need to
predict the profit the company makes and
we're going to do it based on the
company's expenses and even just a
specific expense in this case we have
our company we have the different
expenses so we have our r d which is
your research and development we have
our marketing we might have the location
we might have what kind of
administrations going through based on
all this different information we would
like to calculate the profit now in
actuality there's usually about 23 to 27
different markers that they look at if
they're a heavy duty investor we're only
going to take a look at one basic one
we're going to come in and for
Simplicity let's consider a single
variable r d and find out which kind
companies to invest in based on that so
we take our r d and we're plotting The
Profit based on the r d expenditure how
much money they put into the research
and development and then we look at the
profit that goes with that we can
predict a line to estimate the profit so
we draw a line right through the data
when you look at that you can see how
much they invest in the r d is it good
marker as to how much profit they're
going to have we can also note that
companies spending more on R D make good
profit so let's invest in the ones that
spend a higher rate in their r d what's
in it for you first we'll have an
introduction to machine learning
followed by Machine learning algorithms
these will be specific to linear
regression and where it fits into the
larger model then we'll take a look at
applications of linear regression
understanding linear regression and
multiple linear regression finally we'll
roll up our sleeves and do a little
programming in use case profit
estimation of companies let's go ahead
and jump in let's start with our
introduction to machine learning along
with some machine learning algorithms
and where that fits in with linear
regression let's look at another example
of machine learning based on the amount
of rainfall how much would be the crop
yield so here we have our crops we have
our rainfall and we want to know how
much we're going to get from our crops
this year so we're going to introduce
two variables independent and dependent
the independent variable is a variable
whose value does not change by the
effect of other variables and is used to
manipulate the dependent variable it is
often denoted as X in our example
rainfall is the independent variable
this is a wonderful example because you
can easily see that we can't control the
rain but the rain does control the crop
so we talk about the independent
variable controlling the dependent
variable let's Define dependent variable
as a variable whose value change when
there is any manipulation the values of
the independent variables it is often
denoted as Y and you can see here our
crop yield is dependent variable and it
is dependent on the amount of rainfall
received now that we've taken a look at
a real life example let's go a little
bit into the theory and some definitions
on machine learning and see how that
fits together with linear regression
numeric Oracle values let's take our
data coming in and this is kind of
random data from any kind of project we
want to divide it up into numerical and
categorical so numerical is numbers age
salary height where categorical would be
a description the color a dog's breed
gender categoricals limited to very
specific items where numerical is a
range of information now that you've
seen the difference between numerical
and categorical data let's take a look
at some different machine learning
definitions when we look at a different
machine learning algorithms we can
divide them into three areas supervised
unsupervised reinforcement we're only
going to look at supervise today
unsupervised means we don't have the
answers we're just grouping things
reinforcement is where we give positive
and negative feedback to to our
algorithm to program it and it doesn't
have the information until after the
fact but today we're just looking at
supervised because that's where linear
regression fits in in supervised data we
have our data already there and our
answers for a group and then we use that
to program our model and come up with an
answer the two most common uses for that
is through the regression and
classification now we're doing linear
regression so we're just going to focus
on the regression side and in the
regression we have SIMPLE linear
regression we have multiple linear
regression and we have polynomial linear
regression now on these three simple
linear regression is the examples we've
looked at so far where we have a lot of
data and we draw a straight line through
it multiple linear regression means we
have multiple variables remember where
we had the rainfall and the crops we
might add additional variables in there
like how much food do we give our crops
when do we Harvest them those would be
additional information add into our
model and that's why it'd be multiple
linear regression and finally we have
polynomial me a linear regression that
is instead of drawing a line we can draw
a curved line through it now that you
see where regression model fits into the
machine learning algorithms and we're
specifically looking at linear
regression let's go ahead and take a
look at applications for linear
regression let's look at a few
applications of linear regression
economic growth used to determine the
economic growth of a country or a state
in the coming quarter can also be used
to predict the DDP of a country product
price can be used to predict what would
be the price of a product in the future
we can guess whether it's going to go up
or down or should I buy today housing
sales to estimate the number of houses a
builder would sell and what price in the
coming months score predictions Cricket
fever to predict the number of runs a
player would score in the coming matches
based on the previous performance I'm
sure you can figure out other
applications you could use linear
regression for so let's jump in and
let's understand linear regression and
dig into the theory understanding linear
regression linear regression is the
statistical model used to predict the
relationship between independent and
dependent variables by examining two
factors the first important one is which
variables in particular are significant
predictors of the outcome variable and
the second one that we need to look at
closely is how significant is the
regression line to make predictions with
the highest possible accuracy if it's
inaccurate we can't use it so it's very
important we find out the most accurate
line we can get since linear regression
is based on drawing a line through data
we're going to jump back and take a look
at some euclidean geometry the simplest
form of a simple linear regression
equation with one dependent and one
independent variable is represented by y
equals m times X plus C if you look at
our model here we plotted two points on
here X1 and y1 X2 and Y2 y being the
dependent variable variable remember
that from before and X being the
independent variable so y depends on
whatever X is m in this case is the
slope of the line where m equals the
difference in the Y2 minus y1 and X2
minus X1 and finally we have C which is
the coefficient of the line or where it
happens to cross the zero axes let's go
back and look at an example we used
earlier of linear regression we're going
to go back to plotting the amount of
crop yield based on the amount of
rainfall and here we have our rainfall
remember we cannot change rainfall and
we have our crop yield which is
dependent on the rainfall so we have our
independent and our dependent variables
we're going to take this and draw a line
through it as best we can through the
middle of the data and then we look at
that we put the red point on the y-axis
is the amount of crop yield you can
expect for the amount of rainfall
represented by the Green Dot so if we
have an idea what the rainfall is for
this year and what's going on that we
can guess how good our crops are going
to be and we've created a nice line
right through the middle to give us a
nice mathematical formula let's take a
look and see what the math looks like
behind this let's look at the intuition
behind the regression line now before we
dive into the math and the formulas that
go behind this and what's going on
behind the scenes
I want you to note that when we get into
the case study and we actually apply
some python script that this math you're
going to see here is already done
automatically for you you don't have to
have it memorized it is however good to
have an idea what's going on so if
people reference the different terms
you'll know what they're talking about
let's consider a sample data set with
five rows and find out how to draw the
regression line we're only going to do
five rows because if we did like the
rainfall with hundreds of points of data
that would be very hard to see what's
going on with the mathematics so we'll
go ahead and create our own two sets of
data and we have our independent
variable X and our dependent variable Y
and when X was one we got y equals 2
when X was 2 y was 4 and so on and so on
if we go ahead and plot this data on a
graph we can see how it forms a nice
line through the middle you can see
where it's kind of grouped going upwards
to the right the next thing we want to
know is what the means is of each of the
data coming in the X and the Y the means
doesn't mean anything other than the
average so we add up all the numbers and
divide by the total so one plus two plus
three plus four plus five over five
equals three and the same for y we get
four if we go ahead and plot the means
on the graph we'll see we get three
comma four which draws a nice line down
the middle a good estimate here we're
going to dig deeper into the math behind
the regression line now remember before
I said you don't have to have all these
formulas memorized or fully understand
them even though we're going to go into
a little more detail of how it works and
if you're not a math whiz and you don't
know if you've never seen the sigma
character before which looks a little
bit like an e that's opened up that just
means summation that's all that is so
when you see the sigma character it just
means we're adding everything in that
row and for computers this is great
because as a programmer you can easily
iterate through each of the X Y points
and create all all the information you
need so in the top half you can see
where we've broken that down into pieces
and as it goes through the first two
points it computes the squared value of
x the squared value of y and x times Y
and then it takes all of X and adds them
up all of Y adds them up all of x
squared adds them up and so on and so on
and you can see we have the sum of equal
to 15 the sum is equal to 20. all the
way up to x times Y where the sum equals
66. this all comes from our formula for
calculating a straight line where y
equals the slope times X plus the
coefficient C so we go down below and
we're going to compute more like the
averages of these and we'll explain
exactly what that is in just a minute
and where that information comes from is
called the square means error but we'll
go into that in detail in a few minutes
all you need to do is look at the
formula and see how we've gone about
Computing it line by line instead of
trying to you have a huge set of numbers
pushed into it and down here you'll see
where the slope m equals and then the
top part if you read through the
brackets you have the number of data
points times the sum of x times Y which
we computed one line at a time there and
that's just the 66 and take all that and
you subtract it from the sum of x times
the sum of Y and those have both been
computed so you have 15 times 20. and on
the bottom we have the number of lines
times the sum of x squared easily
computed as 86 for the sum minus I'll
take all that and subtract the sum of x
squared and we end up as we come across
with our formula you can plug in all
those numbers which is very easy to do
on the computer you don't have to do the
math on a piece of paper or calculator
and you'll get a slope of 0.6 and you'll
get your C coefficient if you continue
to follow through that formula you'll
see it comes out as equal to 2.2
continuing deeper into what's going
behind the scenes let's find out the
predicted values of Y for corresponding
values of X using the linear equation
where m equals 0.6 and C equals 2.2
we're going to take these values and
we're going to go ahead and plot them
we're going to predict them so y equals
0.6 times where x equals 1 plus 2.2
equals 2.8 and so on and so on and here
the Blue Points represent the actual y
values and the brown points represent
the predicted y values based on the
model we created the distance between
the actual and predicted values is known
as residuals or errors the best fit line
should have the least sum of squares of
these errors also known as e-square if
we put these into a nice chart we can
see X and you can see Y what the actual
values were and you can see why it
predicted you can easily see where we
take y minus y predicted and we get an
answer what is the difference between
those two and if we square that y minus
y prediction squared we can then sum
those squared values that's where we get
the 0.64 plus the 0.36 plus 1 all the
way down until we have a summation
equals 2.4 so the sum of squared errors
for this regression line is 2.4 we check
this error for each line and conclude
the best fit line having the least e
Square value in a nice graphical
representation we can see here where we
keep moving this line through the data
points to make sure the best fit line
has the least squared distance between
the data points and the regression line
now we only looked at the most commonly
used formula for minimizing the distance
there are lots of ways to minimize the
distance between the line and the data
points like sum of squared errors sum of
absolute errors root mean square error
Etc which you want to take away from
this is whatever formula is being used
you can easily using a computer
programming and iterating through the
data calculate the different parts of it
that way these complicated formulas you
see with the different summations and
absolute values are easily computed one
piece at a time up until this point
Point we've only been looking at two
values X and Y well in the real world
it's very rare that you only have two
values when you're figuring out a
solution so let's move on to the next
topic multiple linear regression let's
take a brief look at what happens when
you have multiple inputs so in multiple
linear regression we have well we'll
start with the simple linear regression
where we had y equals M plus X plus C
and we're trying to find the value of y
now with multiple linear regression we
have multiple variables coming in so
instead of having just X we have X1 X2
X3 and instead of having just one slope
each variable has its own slope attached
to it as you can see here we have M1 M2
M3 and we still just have the single
coefficient so when you're dealing with
multiple linear regression you basically
take your single linear regression and
you spread it out so you have y equals
M1 times X1 plus M2 times X2 so on all
the way to m to the nth x to the nth and
then you add your coefficient on there
implementation of linear regression now
we get into my favorite part let's
understand how multiple linear
regression works by implementing it in
Python if you remember before we were
looking at a company and just based on
its R and D trying to figure out its
profit we're going to start looking at
the expenditure of the company we're
going to go back to that we're going to
predict as profit but instead of
predicting it just on the r d we're
going to look at other factors like
Administration costs marketing costs and
so on and from there we're going to see
if we can figure out what the profit of
that company is going to be to start our
coding we're going to begin by importing
some basic like through what libraries
were importing first we're going to
import numpy as NP and then I want you
to skip one line and look at import
pandas as PD these are very common tools
that you need with most of your linear
regression the numpy which stands for
number python is usually denoted as NP
and you have to almost have that for
your sklearn toolbar so you always
import that right off the beginning
pandas although you don't have to have
it for your sklearn libraries it does
such a wonderful job of importing data
setting it up into a data frame so we
can manipulate it rather easily and it
has a lot of tools also in addition to
that so we usually like to use the
pandas when we can and I'll show you
what that looks like the other three
lines are for us to get a visual of this
data and take a look at it so we're
going to import
matplotlibrary.pipelot as PLT and then
Seaborn as SNS Seabourn works with the
matplot library so you have to always
import matplot library then Seaborn sits
on top of it and we'll take a look at
what that looks like you could use any
of your own plotting libraries you want
there's all kinds of ways to look at the
data these are just very common ones and
the Seabourn is so easy to use it just
looks beautiful it's a nice
representation that you can actually
take and show somebody and the final
line is the Amber signed matplot library
in line that is only because I'm doing
an inline IDE my interface in the
Anaconda Jupiter notebook requires I put
that in there or you're not going to see
the graph when it comes up let's go
ahead and run this it's not going to be
that interesting so we're just setting
up variables in fact it's not going to
do anything that we can see but it is
importing these different libraries in
setup the next step is load the data set
and extract independent and dependent
variables now here in this slide you'll
see companies equals pd.read CSV and it
has a long line there with the file at
the end one thousand companies.csv
you're going to have to change this to
fit whatever setup you have and the file
itself you can request just go down to
the commentary below this video and put
a note in there and simply learn we'll
try to get in contact with you and
Supply you with that file so you can try
this coding yourself so we're going to
add this code in here and we're going to
see that I have companies equals
pd.reader underscore CSV and I've
changed this path to match my computer C
colon slash simply learn slash 1000
underscore companies.csv e and then
below there we're going to set the x
equals to companies under the I location
and because this is companies as a PD
data set I can use this nice notation
that says take every row that's what the
colon the first colon is comma except
for the last column that's what the
second part is where we have a colon
minus one and we want the values set
into there so X is no longer a data set
a pandas data set but we can easily
extract the data from our pandas data
set with this notation and then y we're
going to set equal to the last row well
the question is going to be what are we
actually looking at so let's go ahead
and take a look at that and we're going
to look at the companies.head which
lists the first five rows of data and
I'll open up the file in just a second
so you can see where that's coming from
but let's look at the data in here as
far as the way the pandas sees it when I
hit run you'll see it breaks it out into
a nice setup this is what pandas one of
the things pandas is really good about
is it looks just like an Excel
spreadsheet you have your rows and
remember when we're programming we
always start with 0 row we don't start
with one so it shows the first five rows
zero one two three four and then it
shows your different columns R and D
spend Administration marketing spend
State profit it even notes that the top
are column names it was never told that
but pandas is able to recognize a lot of
things that they're not the same as the
data rows why don't we go ahead and open
this file up in a CSV so you can
actually see the raw data so here I've
opened it up as a text editor and you
can see at the top we have r d spend
comma Administration comma marketing
spin comma State comma profit carries
return I don't know about you but I'd go
crazy trying to read files like this
that's why we use the pandas you could
also open this up in an Excel and it
would separate it since it is a comma
separated variable file but we don't
want to look at this one we want to look
at something we can read rather easily
so let's flip back and take a look at
that top part the first five rows now as
nice as this format is where I can see
the data to me it doesn't mean a whole
lot maybe you're an expert in business
and Investments and you understand what
165 349 dollars and twenty cents
compared to the administration cost of
897.80 so on so on helps to create the
profit of 192 261 and 83 cents that
makes no pun intended so let's flip back
here and take a look at our next set of
code where we're going to graph it so we
can get a better understanding of our
data and what it means so at this point
we're going to use a single line of code
to get a lot of information so we can
see where we're going with this let's go
ahead and paste that into our notebook
and see what we got going and so we have
the visualization and again we're using
SNS which is pandas as you can see we
imported the matplot Library dot Pi plot
is PLT which then the Seaborn uses and
we imported the Seaborn as SNS and then
that final line of code helps us show
this in our inline coding without this
it wouldn't display you you could
display it to a file in other means and
that's the matplot library in line with
the Amber sign at the beginning so here
we come down to the single line of code
Seaborn is great because it actually
recognizes the panda data frame so I can
just take the companies dot core for
coordinates and I can put that right
into the Seaborn and when we run this we
get this beautiful plot and let's just
take a look at what this plot means if
you look at this plot on mine the colors
are probably a little bit more purplish
and blue than the original one we have
the columns and the rows we have R and D
spending we have a demonstration we have
marketing spending and profit and if you
cross index any two of these since we're
interested in profit if you cross index
profit with profit it's going to show up
if you look at the scale on the right
way up in the dark why because those are
the same data they have an exact
correspondence so R and D spending is
going to be the same as r d spending and
the same thing with Administration costs
so right down the middle you get this
dark row or dark diagonal row that shows
that this is the highest corresponding
data that's exactly the same and as it
becomes lighter there's less connections
between the data so we can see with
profit obviously profit is the same as
profit and next it has a very high
correlation with r d spending which we
looked at earlier and it has a slightly
less connection to marketing spending
and even less to how much money we put
into the administration so now that we
have a nice look at the data let's go
ahead and dig in and create some actual
useful linear regression models so that
we can predict values and have a better
profit now that we've taken a look at
the visualization of this data we're
going to move on to the next step
instead of just having a pretty picture
we need to generate some hard data some
hard values so let's see what that looks
like we're going to set up our linear
regression model in two steps the first
one is we need to prepare some of our
data so it fits correctly and let's go
ahead and paste this code into our
jupyter notebook and what we're bringing
in is we're going to bring in the
sklearn pre-processing where we're going
to import the label encoder and the one
hot encoder to use the label encoder
we're going to create a variable called
label encoder and set it equal to
capital L label capital E encoder this
creates a class so we can reuse for
transferring the labels back and forth
now about now you should ask what labels
are we talking about let's go take a
look at the data we processed before and
see what I'm talking about here if you
remember when we did the companies dot
head and we printed the top five rows of
data we have our columns going across we
have column 0 which is R and D spending
column one which is Administration
column two which is marketing spending
and column three is State and you'll see
under State we have New York California
Florida now to do a linear regression
model it doesn't know how to process New
York it knows how to process a number so
the first thing we're going to do is
we're going to change that New York
California and Florida and we're going
to change those to numbers that's what
this line of code does here x equals and
then it has the colon comma 3 in
Brackets the first part the colon comma
means that we're going to look at all
the different rows so we're going to
keep them all together but the only row
we're going to edit is the third row and
in there we're going to take the label
coder and we're going to fit and
transform the X also the third row so
we're going to take that third row we're
going to set it equal to a
transformation and that transformation
basically tells it that instead of
having a New York it has a zero or a one
or a two and then finally we need to do
a one hot encoder which equals one hot
in order categorical features equals
three and then we take the X and we go
ahead and do that equal to one hot
encoder fit transform X to array this
final transformation preps our data
Force so it's completely set the way we
need it is just a row of numbers even
though it's not in here let's go ahead
and print X and just take a look at what
this data is doing you'll see you have
an array of arrays and then each array
is a row of numbers and if I go ahead
and just do row zero you'll see I have a
nice organized row of numbers that the
computer now understands we'll go ahead
and take this out there because it
doesn't mean a whole lot to us it's just
a row of numbers
next on setting up our data we have
avoiding dummy variable trap this is
very important why because the computers
automatically transformed our header
into the setup and it's automatically
transformed all these different
variables so when we did the encoder the
encoder created two columns and what we
need to do is just have the one because
it has both the variable and the name
that's what this piece of code does here
let's go ahead and paste this in here
and we have x equals x colon comma one
colon all this is doing is removing that
one extra column we put in there when we
did our one hot encoder and our label
encoding let's go ahead and run that and
now we get to create our linear
regression model and let's see what that
looks like here and we're going to do
that in two steps the first step is
going to be in splitting the data now
whenever we create a predictive model of
data we always want to split it up so we
have a training set and we have a
testing set that's very important
otherwise we'd be very unethical without
testing it to see how good our fit is
and then we'll go ahead and create our
multiple linear regression model and
train it and set it up let's go ahead
and paste this next piece of code in
here and I'll go ahead and shrink it
down a size or two so it all fits on one
line so from the sklearn module
selection we're going to import train
test split and you'll see that we've
created four completely different
variables we have capital x train
capital X test smaller case y train
smaller case y test that is the standard
way that they usually reference these
when we're doing different models
usually see that a capital x and you see
the train and the test and the lowercase
Y what this is is X is our data going in
that's our RND spin our Administration
our marketing and then Y which we're
training is the answer that's the profit
because we want to know the profit of an
unknown entity so that's what we're
going to shoot for in this tutorial the
next part train test split we take X and
we take y we've already created those X
has the columns with the data in it and
Y has a column with profit in it and
then we're going to set the test size
equals 0.2 that basically means 20
percent so twenty percent of the rows
are going to be tested we're going to
put them off to the side so since we're
using a thousand lines of data that
means that 200 of those lines we're
going to hold off to the side to test
for later and then the random State
equals zero we're going to randomize
which ones it picks to hold off to the
side we'll go ahead and run this it's
not overly exciting so setting up our
variables but the next step is the next
step we actually create our linear
regression model now that we got to the
linear regression model we get that next
piece of the puzzle let's go ahead and
put that code in there and walk through
it so here we go we're going to paste it
in there and let's go ahead and since
this is a shorter line of code let's
zoom up there so we can get a good look
and we have from the sklearn dot linear
underscore model we're going to import
linear regression now I don't know if
you call from earlier when we were doing
all the math let's go ahead and flip
back there and take a look at that do
you remember this or we had this long
formula on the bottom and we were doing
all this summarization and then we also
looked at setting it up with the
different lines and then we also looked
all the way down to multiple linear
regression where we're adding all those
formulas together all of that is wrapped
up in this one section so what's going
on here is I'm going to create a
variable called regressor and the
regressor equals the linear regression
that's a linear regression model that
has all that math built in so we don't
have to have it all memorized or have to
compute it individually and then we do
the regressor.fit in this case we do X
train and Y train because we're using
the training data X being the data in
and Y being profit what we're looking at
and this does all that math for us so
within one click and one line we've
created the whole linear regression
model and we fit the data to the linear
regression model and you can see that
when I run the regressor it gives an
output linear regression it says copy x
equals True Fit intercept equals true in
jobs equal one normalize equals false
it's just giving you some general
information on what's going on with that
regressor model now that we've created
our linear regression model let's go
ahead and use it and if you remember we
kept a bunch of data aside so we're
going to do a y predict variable and
we're going to put in the X test and
let's see what that looks like scroll up
a little bit paste that in here
predicting the test set results so here
we have y predict equals regressor dot
predict X test going in and this gives
us y predict now because I'm in Jupiter
in line I can just put the variable up
there and when I hit the Run button
it'll print that array out I could have
just as easily done print y predict so
if you're in a different IDE that's not
an inline setup like the Jupiter
notebook you can do it this way print y
predict and you'll see that for the 200
different test variables we kept off to
the side it's going to produce 200
answers this is what it says the profit
are for those 200 predictions but let's
don't stop there let's keep going and
take a couple look we're going to take
just a short detail here and calculating
the coefficients and the intercepts this
gives us a quick flash at what's going
on behind the line we're going to take a
short detour here and we're going to be
calculating the coefficient and
intercepts so you can see what those
look like what's really nice about our
regressor we created is it already has a
coefficients for us and we can simply
just print regressor dot coefficient
underscore when I run this you'll see
our coefficients here and if we can do
the regressor coefficient we can also do
the regressor intercept and let's run
that and take a look at that this all
came from the multiple regression model
and we'll flip over so you can remember
where this is going into and where it's
coming from you can see the formula down
here where y equals M1 times X1 plus M2
times X2 and so on and so on plus C the
coefficient so these variables fit right
into this formula y equals slope one
times column one variable plus slope two
times column two variable all the way to
the m into the n and x to the N plus C
the coefficient or in this case you have
minus 8.89 to the power of two etc etc
times the First Column and the second
column and the third column and then our
intercept is the minus one zero three
zero zero nine point boy it gets kind of
complicated when you look at it this is
why we don't do this by hand anymore
this is why we have the computer to make
these calculations easy to understand
and calculate now I told you that was a
short detour and we're coming towards
the end of our script as you remember
from the beginning I said if we're going
to divide this information we have to
make sure it's a valid model that this
model works and understand how good it
works so calculating the r squared value
that's what we're going to use to
predict how good our prediction is and
let's take a look at what that looks
like in code and so we're going to use
this from
sklearn.metrix we're going to import R2
score that's the r squared value we're
looking at the error so in the R2 score
we take our y test versus our y predict
y test is the actual values we're
testing that was the one that was given
to us so we know are true the Y predict
of those 200 values is what we think it
was true and when we go ahead and run
this we see we get a
0.9352 that's the R2 score now it's not
exactly a straight percentage so it's
not saying it's 93 percent correct but
you do want that in the upper 90s oh and
higher shows that this is a very valid
prediction based on the R2 score and if
r squared value of 0.91 or 92 as we got
on our model could remember it does have
a random generation involved this proves
the model is a good model which means
success yay we successfully trained our
model with certain predictors and
estimated the profit of the companies
using linear regression what is logistic
regression let's say we have to build a
predictive model model or a machine
learning model to predict whether the
passengers of the Titanic ship have
survived or not the Shipwreck so how do
we do that so we use logistic regression
to build a model for this how do we use
logistic regression so we have the
information about the passengers their
ID whether they have survived or not
their class and name and so on and so
forth and we use this information where
we already know whether the person has
survived or not that is the labeled
information and we help the system to
train based on this information with
based on this labeled data this is known
as label data and during the process of
building the model we probably will
remove some of the non-essential
parameters or attributes here we only
take those attributes which are really
required to make these predictions and
once we train the model we run new data
through it whereby the model will
predict whether the passenger has
survived or not so let's see what we
will learn in this video we will talk
about what is supervised learning and we
will go into details about
classification which is one of the
techniques for supervised learning and
then we will further focus on logistic
regression is which is one of the
algorithms for performing classification
especially binary classification then we
will compare linear and logistic
regression and what are some of the
logistic regression applications and
finally we will end with a use case or a
demo of actual python code for doing
logistic regression in Jupiter number
all right so let's start with what is
supervised learning supervised learning
is one of the two main types of machine
learning methods here we use what is
known as labeled data to help the system
learn this is very similar to how we
human beings learn so let's say you want
to teach a child to recognize an apple
how do we do that we never tell the
child okay this is an apple has a
certain diameter on the top a certain
diameter at the bottom and this has a
certain RGB color no we just show an
apple to the child and tell the child
this is Apple and then next time when we
show an apple child immediately
recognizes yes this is an app supervised
learning works very similar on the
similar lines so where does logistic
regression fit into the overall machine
learning process machine learning is
divided into two types mainly two types
there is a third one called
reinforcement learning but we will not
talk about that right now so one is
supervised learning and the other is
unsupervised learning unsupervised
learning uses techniques like clustering
and Association and supervised learning
users techniques like classification and
regression now supervised learning is
used when you have labeled data you have
historical data then you use supervised
learning when you don't have labeled
data then you used unsupervised learning
it's it supervised learning there are
two types of techniques that are used
classification and regression based on
what is the kind of problem we have
solved let's say we want to take the
data and classify it it could be binary
classification like a zero or a one an
example of classification we have just
seen whether the passenger has survived
or not survived like a zero or one that
is known as binary classification
regression on the other hand is you need
to predict a value what is known as a
continuous value classification is for
discrete values regression is for
continuous values let's say you want to
predict a share price or you want to
predict the temperature that will be
there what will be the temperature
tomorrow that is where you use
regression whereas classification are
discrete values is will the customer buy
the product or will not buy the product
will you get a promotion or you will not
get a promotion I hope you're getting
the idea or it could be multi-class
classification as well let's say you
want to build an image classification
model so the image classification model
would take an image as an input and
classify into multiple classes whether
this image is of a cat or a dog or an
elephant or a tiger so there are
multiple classes so not necessarily
binary classification so that is known
as multi-class classification we are
going to focus on classification because
logistic regression is one of the
algorithms used for classification now
the name may be a little confusing in
fact whenever people come across
logistic regression it always causes
confusion because the name has
regression in it but we are actually
using this for performing classification
okay so yes it is logistic regression
but it is used for classification and in
case you are wondering is there
something similar for regression yes for
regression we have linear regression
keep that in mind so linear regression
is used for regression logistic
regression is used for classifications
so in this video we are going to focus
on supervised learning and within
supervised learning we are going to
focus on classification and then within
classification we are going to focus on
logistic regression algorithm so first
of all classification so what are the
various algorithms available for
performing classification the first one
is decision tree there are of course
multiple algorithms but here we will
talk about a few addition trees are
quite popular and very easy to
understand and therefore they use for
classification then we have K nearest
neighbors this is another algorithm for
performing classification and then there
is logistic regression and this is what
we are going to focus on in this video
and we are going to go into little bit
of details about logistic regression all
right what is logistic regression as I
mentioned earlier positive regression is
an algorithm for performing binary
classification so let's take an example
and see how this works let's say your
car has not been serviced for quite a
few years and now you want to find out
if it is going to break down in the near
future so this is like a classification
problem find out whether your car will
break down or not so how are we going to
perform this classification so here's
how it looks if we plot the information
along the X and Y axis X is the number
of years since the last service was
performed and why is the probability of
your car breaking down and let's say
this information was this data that was
collected from several car users it's
not just your car but several car users
so that is our labeled data so the data
has been collected and for for the
number of years and when the car broke
down and what was the probability and
that has been plotted along x and y axis
so this provides an idea or from this
graph we can find out whether your car
will break down or not we'll see how so
first of all the probability can go from
zero to one as you all aware probability
can be between 0 and 1. and as we can
imagine it is intuitive as well as the
number of years are on the Lower Side
maybe one year two years or three years
still after the service the chances of
your car breaking down are very limited
right so for example chances of your car
breaking down on the probability of your
car breaking down within two years of
your last service are 0.1 from 30.
similarly three years is maybe 0.3 and
so on but as the number of years
increases let's say if it was six or
seven years there is almost a certainty
that your car is going to break down
that is what this graph shows so this is
an example of a application of the
classification algorithm and we will see
in little details how exactly logistic
regression is applied here one more
thing needs to be added here is that the
different variables outcome is discrete
so if we are talking about whether the
car is going to break down or not so
that is a discrete value the why that we
are talking about the dependent variable
that we are talking about what we are
looking at is whether the car is going
to break down or not yes or no that is
what we are talking about so here the
outcome is discrete and not a continuous
way so this is how the logistic
regression curve looks let me explain a
little bit what exactly how exactly we
are going to
determine the class or the outcome
rather so for a logistic regression
curve a threshold has to be set saying
that because this is a probability
calculation remember this is a
probability calculation and the
probability itself will not be 0 or 1
but based on the probability we need to
decide what the outcome should be so
there has to be a threshold like for
example 0.5 can be the threshold let's
say in this case so any value of the
probability below 0.5 is considered to
be 0 and any value above 0.5 is
considered to be 1. so an output of
let's say 0.8 will mean that the car
will break down so that is considered as
an output of 1 and let's say an output
of 0.29 is considered as 0 which means
that the car will not break down so
that's the way logistic regression works
now let's do a quick comparison between
logistic regression and linear
regression because they both have the
term regression in them so it can cause
confusion so let's try to remove that
confusion so what is linear regression
linear regression is a process is once
again an algorithm for supervised
learning however here you are going to
find a continuous value you are going to
determine a continuous value it could be
the price of a real estate property it
could be your height how much height
you're going to get or it could be a
stock price these are all continuous
values these are not discrete compared
to a yes or no kind of a response that
we are looking for in logistic
regression so this is one example of a
linear regression let's say at the HR
team of a company tries to find out what
should be the salary hike of an employee
so they collect all the details of their
existing employees their ratings and
their salary hikes what has been given
and that is the labeled information that
is available and the system learns from
this it is straight and it learns from
this labeled information so that when a
new employee's information is fed based
on the rating it will determine what
should be dying so this is a linear
regression problem and a linear
regression example now salary is a
continuous value you can get five
thousand five thousand five hundred five
thousand six hundred it is not discrete
like a cat or a dog or an apple or a
banana these are discrete or a yes or a
no these are discrete values right so
this way you are trying to find
continuous values is where we use linear
regression so let's say just to extend
on this scenario we now want to find out
whether this employee is going to get a
promotion or not so we want to find out
that is the discrete problem right a yes
or no kind of a problem in this case we
actually cannot use linear regression
even though we may have labeled data so
this is the label So based on the
employee rating these are the ratings
and then some people got the promotion
and this is the ratings for which people
did not get promotion that is a no and
this is the rating for which people got
promotion we just plotted the data about
whether a person has got an employer's
got promotion or not yes no right so
there is nothing in between and what is
the employee's rating and ratings can be
continuous that is not an issue but the
output is discrete in this case whether
employee got promotion yes no okay so if
we try to plot that and we try to find a
straight line this is how it would look
and as you can see it doesn't look very
right because looks like there will be
lot of errors this root mean square
error if you remember for linear
regression would be very very high and
also the the values cannot go beyond
zero or Beyond one so the graph should
probably look somewhat like this clipped
at 0 and 1. but still this straight line
doesn't look right therefore instead of
using a linear equation we need to come
up with something different and
therefore the logistic regression model
looks somewhat like this so we calculate
the probability and if we plot that
probability not in the form of a
straight line but we need to use some
other equation we will see very soon
what that equation is then it is a
gradual process right so you see here
people with some of these ratings are
not getting any promotions and then
slowly uh at certain rating they get
promotion so that is a gradual process
and this is how the math behind logistic
regression looks so we are trying to
find the odds for a particular event
happening and this is the formula for
finding the odd so the probability of an
event happening divided by the
probability of the event not happening
so P if it is the probability of the
event happening probability of the
person getting a promotion and divided
by the probability of the person not
getting a promotion that is 1 minus p
this is how you measure the odds now the
values of the odds range from 0 to
Infinity so when this probability is 0
then the odds will the value of the odds
is equal to zero and when the
probability becomes 1 then the value of
the odds is 1 by 0 that will be Infinity
but the probability itself remains
between 0 and 1. now this is how an
equation of a straight line love so Y is
equal to beta0 plus beta 1 x where beta0
is the Y intercept and beta 1 is the
slope of the line if we take the odds
equation and take a log of both sides
then this would look somewhat like this
and the term logistic is actually
derived from the fact that we are doing
this we take a log of p x by 1 minus p x
this is an extension of the calculation
of odds that we have seen right and that
is equal to beta0 plus beta 1X which is
the equation of the straight line and
now from here if you want to find out
the value of p x we will see we can take
the exponential on both sides and then
if we solve that equation we will get
the equation of PX like this p x is
equal to 1 by 1 plus e to the power of
minus beta0 plus beta 1 x and recall
this is nothing but the equation of the
line which is equal to y y is equal to
Beta 0 plus beta 1 x so that this is the
equation also known as the sigmoid
function and this is the equation of the
logistic regression all right and if
this is plotted this is how the sigmoid
curve is obtained so let's compare
linear and logistic regression how they
are different from each other let's go
back so linear regression is solved or
used to solve regression problems and
logistic regression is used to solve
classification problems so both are
called regression but linear regression
is used for solving regression problems
where we predict continuous values
whereas logistic regression is used for
solving classification problems where we
have had to predict discrete values the
response variables in case of linear
regression are continuous in nature
whereas here they are categorical or
discrete in nature and linear regression
helps to estimate the dependent variable
when there is a change in the
independent variable whereas here in
case of logistic regression it helps to
calculate the probability or the
possibility of a particular event
happening and linear regression as the
name suggests is a straight line that's
why it's called or linear regression
whereas logistic regression is a sigmoid
function and the curve is the shape of
the curve is s it's an s-shaped curve
this is another example of application
of logistic regression in weather
prediction whether it's going to rain or
not drain now keep in mind both are used
in weather prediction if we want to find
the discrete values like whether it's
going to rain or not rain that is a
classification problem we use logistic
regression but if we want to determine
what is going to be the temperature
tomorrow then we use linear regression
so just keep in mind that in weather
prediction we actually use both but
these are some examples of logistic
regression so we want to find out
whether it's going to be rain or not it
is going to be sunny or not it is going
to snow or not these are all logistic
regression examples a few more examples
classification of objects this is a
again another example of logistic
regression now here of course one
distinction is that these are
multi-class classification so logistic
regression is not used in its original
form but it is used in a slightly
different form so we say whether it is a
dog or not a dog I hope you understand
so instead of saying is it a dog or a
cat or a elephant we convert this into
saying so because we need to keep it to
Binary classification so we say is it a
dog or not a dog is it a cat or not a
cat so that's the way logistic
regression can be used for classifying
objects otherwise there are other
techniques which can be used for
performing multi-class classification
Healthcare logistic regression is used
to find the survival rate of a patient
so they take multiple parameters like
drama score and age and so on and so
forth and it try to predict the rate of
survival all right now finally let's
take an example and see how we can apply
logistic regression to predict the
number that is shown in the image so
this is actually a live demo I will take
you into jupyter notebook and show the
code but before that let me take you
through a couple of slides to explain
what we are trying to do so let's say
you have an eight by eight image and
there the image has a number one two
three four and you need to train your
model to predict what this number is so
how do we do this so the first thing is
obviously in any machine learning
process you train your model so in this
case we are using logistic regression so
and then we provide a training set to
train the model and then we test how
accurate our model is with the test data
which means that like any machine
learning process we split our initial
data into two parts training set and
listen with the training set we train
our model and then with the test set we
test the model till we get good accuracy
and then we use it for for inference
right so that is typical methodology of
training testing and then deploying of
machine learning models so let's uh take
a look at the code and see what we are
doing so I'll not go line by line but
just take you through some of the blocks
so first thing we do is import all the
libraries and then we basically take a
look at the images and see what is the
total number of images we can display
using matplotlib some of the images or a
sample of these images and then we split
the data into training and test as I
mentioned earlier and we can do some
exploratory analysis and then we build
our model we train our model with a
training set and then we test it with
our test set and find out how accurate
our model is using the confusion Matrix
the heat map and use Heat plan for
visualizing this and I will show you in
the code what exactly is the confusion
Matrix and how it can be used for
finding the accuracy in our example we
go we get an accuracy of about 0.94
which is pretty good or 94 percent which
is pretty good all right so what is the
confusion Matrix this is an example of a
confusion Matrix and this is used for
identifying the accuracy of a
classification model or like a logistic
regression model so the most important
part in a confusion Matrix is that first
of all this as you can see this is a
matrix and the size of the Matrix
depends on how many outputs we are
expecting
right so the the most important part
here is that the model will be most
accurate when we have the maximum
numbers in its diagram like in this case
that's why it has almost 93 94 percent
because the diagonals should have the
maximum numbers and the others other
than diagnose the cells other than the
diagonal should have very few numbers so
here that's what is happening so there
is a 2 here there are there's a one here
but most of them are along the diagonal
this what does this mean this means that
the number that has been fed is zero and
the number that has been detected is
also zero so the predicted value and the
actual value are the same so along the
diagonals that is true which means that
let's let's take this diagonal right if
the maximum number is here that means
that like here in this case it is 34
which means that 34 of the images that
have been fed are rather actually there
are two misclassifications in there so
36 images have been fed which have
number four and out of which 34 have
been predicted correctly as number four
and one has been predicted as number
eight and another one has been predicted
as number nine so these are two
misclassifications okay so that is the
meaning of saying that the maximum
number should be in the diagonal so if
you have all of them so for an ideal
model which has let's say 100 accuracy
everything will be only in the diagonal
there will be no numbers other than zero
in all other cells so that is like a
hundred percent accurate model okay so
that's uh just of how to use this Matrix
how to use this confusion Matrix I know
the name uh is a little funny sounding
confusion Matrix but actually it is not
very confusing it's very straightforward
so you are just plotting what has been
predicted and what is the labeled
information or what is the actual data
that's also known as the ground truth
sometimes okay these are some fancy
terms that are used so predicted label
and the actual name that's all right
okay yeah so we are showing a little bit
more information here so 38 have been
predicted and here you will see that all
of them have been predicted correctly
there have been 38 zeros and
predicted value and the actual value is
exactly the same whereas in this case
right it has there are I think 37 plus 5
yeah 42 have been fed the images 42
images are of Digit 3 and the accuracy
is only 37 of them have been accurately
predicted three of them have been
predicted as number seven and two of
them have been predicted as number eight
and so on and so forth okay all right so
with that let's go into jupyter notebook
and see how the code looks so this is
the code in in Jupiter notebook for
logistic regression in this particular
demo what we are going to do is train
our model to recognize digits which are
the images which have digits from let's
say 0 to 5 or 0 to 9 and
um and then we will see how well it is
trained and whether it is able to
predict these numbers correctly or not
so let's get started so the first part
is as usual we are importing some
libraries that are required and then the
last line in this block is to load the
digits so let's go ahead and run this
code then here we will visualize the
shape of these digits so we can see here
if we take a look this is how the shape
is 1797 by 64. these are like 8 by 8
images so that's that's what is
reflected in this shape now from here
onwards we are basically once again
importing some of the libraries that are
required like numpy and matplot and we
will take a look at some of the sample
images that we have loaded so this one
for example creates a figure and then we
go ahead and take a few sample images to
see how they look so let me run this
code and so that it becomes easy to
understand so these are about five
images sample images that we are looking
at zero one two three four so this is
how the images this is how the data is
okay and based on this we will actually
train our logistic regression model and
then we will test it and see how well it
is able to recognize so the way it works
is the pixel information so as you can
see here this is an eight by eight pixel
kind of a image and the each pixel
whether it is activated are not
activated that is the information
available for each pixel now based on
the pattern of this activation and
non-activation of the various pixels
this will be identified as a zero for
example right similarly as you can see
so overall each of these numbers
actually has a different pattern of the
pixel activation and that's pretty much
that our model needs to learn for which
number what is the pattern of the
activation of the pixels right so that
is what we are going to train our model
okay so the first thing we need to do is
to split our data into training and test
data set right so whenever we perform
any training we split the data into
training and test so that the training
data set is used to train the system so
we pass this probably multiple times and
then we test it with the test data set
and the split is usually in the form of
the and there are various ways in which
you can split this data it is up to the
individual preferences in our case here
we are splitting in the form of 23 and
77 so when we say test size as 20.23
that means 23 percent of that entire
data is used for testing and the
remaining 77 percent is used for
training so there is a readily available
function which is uh called train test
split so we don't have to write any
special code for the splitting it will
automatically split the data based on
the proportion that we give here which
is test size so we just give the test
size automatically training size will be
determined and we pass the data that we
want to split and the the results will
be stored in X underscore train and Y
underscore train for the training data
set and what is X underscore train these
are these are the features right which
is like the independent variable and Y
underscore train is the label right so
in this case what happens is we have the
input value which is or the features
value which is in X underscore train and
since this is the labeled data for each
of them each of the observations we
already have the label information
saying whether this digit is a 0 or a
one or a 2 so that that's this is what
will be used for comparison to find out
whether the the system is able to
recognize it correctly or there is an
error for each observation it will
compare with this right so this is the
label so the same way X underscore train
y underscore train is for the training
data set X underscore test y underscore
test is for the test data set okay so
let me go ahead and execute this code as
well and then we can go and check
quickly what is the how many entries are
there and in each of this so X
underscore train the shape is
1383 by 64 and Y underscore train has
1383 because there is nothing like the
second part is not required here and
then X underscore test shape we see is
414 so actually there are 414
observations in test and 1383
observations in train so that's
basically what these four lines of code
are are saying okay then we import the
logistic regression library and which is
a part of scikit-learn so we we don't
have to implement the logistic
regression process itself we just call
these uh the function and let me go
ahead and execute that so that we have
the logistic regression Library imported
now we create an instance of logistic
regression right so logistic regr is a
is an instance of logistic regression
and then we use that for training our
model so let me first execute this code
so these two lines so the first line
basically creates an instance of
logistic regression model and then the
second line is where we are passing our
data the training data set right this is
our the the predictors and this is our
Target we are passing this data set to
train our model all right so once we do
this in this case the data is not large
but by and large and the training is
what takes usually a lot of time so we
spend in machine learning activities in
machine learning projects we spend a lot
of time for the training part of it okay
so here the data set is relatively small
so it was pretty quick so all right so
now our model has been trained using the
training data set and we want to see how
accurate this is so what we'll do is we
will test it out in probably faces so
let me first try out how well this is
working for one image okay I will just
try it out with one image my the first
entry in my test data set and see
whether it is uh correctly predicting or
not so and in order to test it so for
training purpose we use the fit method
there is a method called fit which is
for training the model and once the
training is done if you want to test for
a particular value new input you use the
predict method okay so let's run the
predict method and we pass this
particular image and we see that the
shape is or the prediction is four so
let's try a few more let me see for the
next 10 seems to be fine so let me just
go ahead and test the entire data set
okay that's basically what we will do so
now we want to find out how accurately
this has is performed so we use the
score method to find what is the
percentages of accuracy and we see here
that it has performed up to 94 percent
accurate okay so that's on this part now
what we can also do is we can
um also see this accuracy using what is
known as a confusion Matrix so let us go
ahead and try that as well so that we
can also visualize how well this model
has done so let me execute this piece of
code which will basically import some of
the libraries that are required and we
we basically create a confusion Matrix
an instance of confusion matrix by
running confusion Matrix and passing
these values so we have so this
confusion underscore Matrix method takes
two parameters one is the Y underscore
test and the other is the prediction so
what is the Y underscore test these are
the labeled values which we already know
for the test data set and predictions
are what the system has predicted for
the test data set okay so this is known
to us and this is what the system has
the model has generated so we kind of
create the confusion Matrix and we will
print it and this is how the confusion
Matrix looks as the name suggests it is
a matrix and the key point out here is
that the accuracy of the model is
determined by how many numbers are there
in the diagonal the more the numbers in
the diagonal the better the accuracy is
okay and first of all the total sum of
all the numbers in this whole Matrix is
equal to the number of observations in
the test data set that is the first
thing right so if you add up all these
numbers that will be equal to the number
of observations in the test data set and
then out of that the maximum number of
of them should be in the diagonal that
means the accuracy is pretty good if the
the numbers in the diagonal are less and
in all other places there are a lot of
numbers which means the accuracy is very
low the diagonal indicates a correct
prediction that so this means that the
actual value is same as the predicted
value here again actual value is same as
the predictive value and so on right so
the moment you see a number here that
means the actual value is something and
the predicted value is something else
right similarly here the actual value is
something and the predicted value is
something else so that is basically how
we read the confusion Matrix now how do
we find the accuracy you can actually
add up the total values in the diagonal
so it's like 38 plus 44 Plus 43 and so
on and divide that by the total number
of test observations that will give you
the percentage accuracy using a
confusion Matrix now let us visualize
this confusion Matrix tricks in a
slightly more sophisticated way using a
heat map so we will create a heat map
with some We'll add some colors as well
it's uh it's like a more visually
visually more appealing so that's the
whole idea so if we let me run this
piece of code and this is how the heat
map looks and as you can see here the
diagonals again are all the values are
here most of the values so which means
reasonably this seems to be reasonably
accurate and yeah basically the accuracy
score is 94 percent this is calculated
as I mentioned by adding all these
numbers divided by the total test value
so the total number of observations in
test data set okay so this is the
confusion Matrix for logistic regression
all right so now that we have seen the
confusion Matrix let's take a quick
sample and see how well the system has
classified and we will take a few
examples of the data so if we see here
we picked up randomly a few of them so
this is uh number four which is the
actual value and also the predicted
value both are four this is an image of
zero so the predicted value is also zero
actual value is of course zero then this
is the image of nine so this has also
been predicted correctly nine and actual
value is 9 and this is the image of one
and again this has been predicted
correctly as like the actual value okay
so this was a quick demo of logistic
regression how to use logistic
regression to identify images what is a
decision tree let's go through a very
simple example before we dig in D
decision tree is a tree shape diagram
used to determine a course of action
each branch of the tree represents a
possible decision or currents or
reaction let's start with a simple
question how to identify a random
vegetable from a shopping bag so we have
this group of vegetables in here and we
can start off by asking a simple
question is it red and if it's not then
it's going to be the purple fruit to the
left probably an eggplant if it's true
it's going to be one of the red fruits
is a diameter greater than two if false
is going to be a what looks to be a red
chili and if it's true it's going to be
a bell pepper from the capsicum family
so it's a cap to come problems that
decision tree can solve so let's look at
the two different categories the
decision tree can be used on it can be
used on the classification the true
false yes no and it can be used on
regression when we figure out what the
next value is in a series of numbers or
a group of data in classification the
classification tree will determine a set
of logical if-then conditions to
classify problems for example
discriminating between three types of
flowers based on certain features in
regression a regression tree is used
when the target variable is numerical or
continuous in nature we fit the
regression model to the Target variable
using each of the independent variables
each split is made based on the sum of
squared error
before we dig deeper into the mechanics
of the decision tree let's take a look
at the advantages of using a decision
tree and we'll also take a glimpse at
the disadvantages the first thing you'll
notice is that it's simple to understand
interpret and visualize it really shines
here because you can see exactly what's
going on in a decision tree little
effort is required for data preparation
so you don't have to do special scaling
there's a lot of things you don't have
to worry about when using a decision
tree it can handle both numerical and
categorical data as we discovered
earlier and non-linear parameters don't
affect its performance so even if the
data doesn't fit an easy curved graph
you can still use it to create an
effective decision or prediction
if we're going to look at the advantages
of a decision tree we also need to
understand the disadvantages of a
decision tree the first disadvantage is
overfitting overfitting occurs when the
algorithm captures noise in the data
that means you're solving for one
specific instance instead of a general
solution for all the data High variance
the model can get unstable due to small
variation in data low bias tree a highly
complicated decision tree tends to have
a low bias which makes it difficult for
the model to work with new data
decision tree important terms before we
dive in further we need to look at some
basic terms we need to have some
definitions to go with our decision tree
in the different parts we're going to
that has all that start with entropy
entropy is a measure of Randomness or
unpredictability in the data set for
example we have a group of animals in
this picture there's four different
kinds of animals and this data set is
considered to have a high entropy you
really can't pick out what kind of
animal it is based on looking at just
the four animals as a big clump of
entities so as we start splitting it
into subgroups we come up with our
second definition which is Information
Gain Information Gain it is a measure of
decrease in entropy after the data set
is split so in this case based on the
color yellow we've split one group of
animals on one side as true and those
who aren't yellow as false as we
continue down the yellow side we split
based on the height true or false equals
10 and on the other side height is less
than 10 true or false and as you see as
we split it the entropy continues to be
less and less and less and so our
Information Gain is simply the entropy
E1 from the top and how it's changed to
E2 in the bottom and we'll look at the
deeper math although you really don't
need to know a huge amount of math when
you actually do the programming in
Python because it'll do it for you but
we'll look on the actual math and how
they compute entropy finally we went
into the different parts of our tree and
they call the leaf node Leaf node
carries a classification or the decision
so it's a final end at the bottom the
decision node has two or more branches
this is where we're breaking the group
up into different parts and finally you
have the root node the topmost decision
node is known as the root node
how does a decision tree work wonder
what kind of animals I'll get in the
jungle today maybe you're the hunter
with a gun or if you're more into
photography you're a photographer with a
camera so let's look at this group of
animals and let's try to classify
different types of animals based on
their features using a decision tree so
the problem statement is to classify the
different types of animals based on
their features using a decision tree the
data set is looking quite messy and the
entropy is high in this case so let's
look at a training set or a training
data set and we're looking at color
we're looking at height and then we have
our different animals we have our
elephants our giraffes our monkeys and
our tigers and they're of different
colors and shapes let's see what that
looks like and how do we split the data
we have to frame the conditions that
split the data in such a way that the
Information Gain is the highest note
gain is the measure of decrease in
entropy after splitting so the formula
for entropy is the sum that's what this
symbol looks like that looks like kind
of like a the funky e of K where I
equals 1 to k k would represent the
number of animal the different animals
in there where value or P value of I
would be the percentage of that animal
times the log base 2 of the same the
percentage of that animal let's try to
calculate the entropy for the current
data set and take a look at what that
looks like and don't be afraid of the
math you don't really have to memorize
this math and just be aware that it's
there and this is what's going on in the
background and so we have three drafts
two tigers one monkey two elephants a
total of eight animals gather and if we
plug that into the formula we get an
entropy that equals three over eight so
we have three drafts a total of eight
times the log usually they use base two
on the log so log base 2 of 3 over 8
plus in this case this hits the
elephants two over eight two elephants
over a total of eight times log base two
two over eight plus one monkey over
total of eight log base two one over
eight and plus two 2 over 8 of the
Tigers log base 2 over 8. and if we plug
that into our computer or calculator I
obviously can't do logs in my head we
get an entropy equal to
0.571 the program will actually
calculate the entropy of the data set
similarly after every split to calculate
the gain now we're not going to go
through each set one at a time to see
what those numbers are we just want you
to be aware that this is a Formula or
the mathematics behind it gain can be
calculated by finding the difference of
the subsequent entropy values after a
split now we will try to choose a
condition that gives us the highest gain
we will do that by splitting the data
using each condition and checking that
the gain we get out of them the
condition that gives us the highest gain
will be used to make the first split can
you guess what that first split will be
just by looking at this image as a human
is probably pretty easy to split it
let's see if you're right if you guessed
the color yellow you're correct let's
say the condition that gives us the
maximum gain is yellow so we will split
the data based on the color yellow if
it's true that group of animals goes to
the left if it's false it goes to the
right the entropy after the splitting
has to decreased considerably however we
still need some splitting at both the
branches to attain an entropy value
equal to zero so we decide to split both
the nodes using height as the condition
since every Branch now contains single
label type we can say that entropy in
this case has reached the least value
and here you see we have the giraffes of
the Tigers the monkey and the elephants
all separate into their own groups this
tree can now predict all the classes of
animals present in the data set with the
hundred percent accuracy that was easy
use case loan repayment prediction let's
get into my favorite part and open up
some Python and see what the programming
code and the scripting looks like in
here we're going to want to do a
prediction and we start with this
individual here who's requesting to find
out how good his customers are going to
be whether they're going to be pay their
loan or not for this bank and from that
we want to generate a problem statement
to predict if a customer will repay loan
amount or not and then we're going to be
using the decision tree algorithm in
Python let's see what that looks like
and let's dive into the code in our
first few steps of implementation we're
going to start by importing the
necessary packages that we need from
Python and we're going to load up our
data and take a look at what the data
looks like so the first thing I need is
I need something to edit my Python and
run it in so let's flip on over and here
I'm using the Anaconda Jupiter notebook
now you can use any python IDE you like
to run it in but I find the jupyter
notebooks really nice for doing things
on the Fly and let's go ahead and just
paste that code in the beginning and
before we we start let's talk a little
bit about what we're bringing in and
then we're going to do a couple things
in here we have to make a couple changes
as we go through this first part of the
import the first thing we bring in is
numpy as NP that's very standard when
we're dealing with mathematics
especially with a very complicated
machine learning tools you almost always
see the numpy come in for your num your
number it's called number python it has
your mathematics in there in this case
we actually could take it out but
generally you'll need it for most of
your different things you work with and
then we're going to use pandas as PD
that's also a standard the pandas is a
data frame setup and you can liken this
to taking your basic data and storing it
in a way that looks like an Excel
spreadsheet so as we come back to this
when you see NP or PD those are very
standard uses you'll know that that's
the pandas and I'll show you a little
bit more when we explore the data in
just a minute then we're going to need
to split the data so I'm going to bring
in our train test and split and this is
coming from the sklearn package cross
validation and just a minute we're going
to change that and we'll go over that
too and then there's also the SK dot
tree import decision tree classifier
that's the actual tool we're using
remember I told you don't be afraid of
the mathematics it's going to be done
for you well the decision tree
classifier has all that mathematics in
there for you so you don't have to
figure it back out again and then we
have sklearn.metrix for accuracy score
we need to score our our setup that's
the whole reason we're splitting it
between the training and testing data
and finally we still need the sklearn
import tree and that's just the basic
tree function that's needed for the
decision tree classifier and finally
we're going to load our data down here
and I'm going to run this and we're
going to get two things on here one
we're going to get an error and two
we're going to get a warning let's see
what that looks like so the first thing
we had is we have an error why is this
error here well it's looking at this it
says I need to read a file and when this
was written the person who wrote it this
is their path where they stored the file
so let's go ahead and fix that
and I'm going to put in here my file
path I'm just going to call it full file
name and you'll see it's on my C drive
and it's very lengthy setup on here
where I stored the data2.csv file
don't worry too much about the full path
because on your computer it'll be
different the data.2 CSV file was
generated by simply learn
if you want a copy of that you can
comment down below and request it here
in the YouTube
and then if I'm going to give it a name
full file name
I'm going to go ahead and change it here
to full
file name so let's go ahead and run it
now and see what happens
and we get a warning
when you're coding understanding these
different warnings and these different
errors that come up is probably the
hardest lesson to learn
so let's just go ahead and take a look
at this and use this as a opportunity to
understand what's going on here if you
read the warning it says the cross
validation is depreciated so it's a
warning on it's being removed and it's
going to be moved in favor of the model
selection
so if we go up here we have
sklearn.cross validation and if you
research this and go to the sklearn site
you'll find out that you can actually
just swap it right in there with model
selection
and so when I come in here and I run it
again
that removes a warning what they've done
is they've had two different developers
develop it in two different branches
and then they decided to keep one of
those and eventually get rid of the
other one that's all that is and very
easy and quick to fix
before we go any further I went ahead
and opened up the data from this file
remember the the data file we just
loaded on here the data
underscore2.csv let's talk a little bit
more about that and see what that looks
like both as a text file because it's a
comma separated variable file and in a
spreadsheet this is what it looks like
as a basic text file you can see at the
top they've created a header and it's
got one two three four five columns and
each column has data in it and let me
flip this over because we're also going
to look at this in an actual spreadsheet
so you can see what that looks like and
here I've opened it up in the open
Office calc which is pretty much the
same as Excel and zoomed in and you can
see we've got our columns and our rows
of data a little easier to read in here
we have a result yes yes no we have
initial payment last payment credit
score house number if we scroll way down
we'll see that this occupies a thousand
and one lines of code or lines of data
with the first one being a column and
then 1000 lines of data
now as a programmer
if you're looking at a small amount of
data I usually start by pulling it up in
different sources I can see what I'm
working with
but in larger data you won't have that
option it'll just be too too large so
you need to either bring in a small
amount that you can look at it like
we're doing right now or we can start
looking at it through the python code so
let's go ahead and move on and take the
next couple steps to explore the data
using python let's go ahead and see what
it looks like in Python to print the
length and the shape of the data so
let's start by printing the length of
the database we can use a simple Lin
function from python
and when I run this you'll see that it's
a thousand long and that's what we
expected there's a thousand lines of
data in there if you subtract the column
head this is one of the nice things when
we did the balance data from the panda
read CSV you'll see that the header is
row zero so it automatically removes a
row
and then shows the data separate it does
a good job sorting the data out for us
and then we can use a different function
and let's take a look at that and again
we're going to utilize the tools in
panda
and since the balance underscore data
was loaded as a panda data frame
we can do a shape on it and let's go
ahead and run the shape and see what
that looks like
what's nice about this shape is not only
does it give me the length of the data
we have a thousand lines it also tells
me there's five columns so we were
looking at the data we had five columns
of data and then let's take one more
step to explore the data using Python
and now that we've taken a look at the
length and the shape let's go ahead and
use the pandas module for head another
beautiful thing in the data set that we
can utilize so let's put that on our
sheet here and we have print data set
and balanced data.head and this is a
hand as print statement of its own so it
has its own print feature in there and
then we went ahead and gave a label for
our print job here of data set just a
simple print statement
and when we run that
and let's just take a closer look at
that let me zoom in here
there we go
pandas does such a wonderful job of
making this a very clean
readable data set so you can look at the
data you can look at the column headers
you can have it when you put it as the
head it prints the first five lines of
the data and we always start with zero
so we have five lines we have zero one
two three four instead of one two three
four five
that's a standard scripting and
programming set as you want to start
with the zero position and that is what
the data head does it pulls the first
five rows of data puts in a nice format
that you can look at and view very
powerful tool to view the data so
instead of having to flip and open up an
Excel spreadsheet or open Office Cal or
trying to look at a word doc where it's
all scrunched together and hard to read
you can now get a nice open view of what
you're working with we're working with a
shape of a thousand long five wide so we
have five columns and we do the full
data head you can actually see what this
data looks like the initial payment last
payment credit scores house number so
let's take this now that we've explored
the data and let's start digging into
the decision tree so in our next step
we're going to train and build our data
tree and to do that we need to First
separate the data out we're going to
separate into two groups so that we have
something to actually train the data
with and then we have some data on the
site to test it to see how good our
model is remember with any of the
machine learning you always want to have
some kind of test set to weigh it
against so you know how good your model
is when you distribute it let's go ahead
and break this code down and look at it
in pieces
so first we have our X and Y
where did X and Y come from well X is
going to be our data and Y is going to
be the answer or the target you can look
at it source and Target
in this case we're using X and Y to
denote the data in and the data that
we're actually trying to guess what the
answer is going to be and so to separate
it we can simply put in x equals the
balance of the data.values the first
brackets
means that we're going to select all the
lines in the database so it's all the
data and the second one says we're only
going to look at columns one through
five remember always start with zero
zero is a yes or no and that's whether
the loan went default or not so we want
to start with one if we go back up here
that's the initial payment and it goes
all the way through the house number
well if we want to look at one through
five we can do the same thing for Y
which is the answers and we're going to
set that just equal to the zero row so
it's just the zero row and then it's all
rows going in there so now we've divided
this into two different data sets
one of them with the
data going in and one with the answers
next we need to split the data
and here you'll see that we have it
split into four different parts
the first one is your X training your X
test your y train your y test
simply put we have X going in where
we're going to train it and we have to
know the answer to train it with
and then we have X test where we're
going to test that data and we have to
know in the end what the Y was supposed
to be
and that's where this train test split
comes in that we loaded earlier in the
modules this does it all for us and you
can see they set the test size equal to
0.3 so that's roughly 30 percent will be
used in the test and then we use a
random state so it's completely random
which rows it takes out of there and
then finally we get to actually build
our decision tree and they've called it
here clf underscore entropy that's the
actual decision tree or decision tree
classifier and in here they've added a
couple variables which we'll explore in
just a minute and then finally we need
to fit the data to that so we take our
clf entropy that we created and we fit
the X train and since we know the
answers for X trade or the Y train we go
ahead and put those in and let's go
ahead and run this and what most of
these sklearn modules do is when you set
up the variable in this case when we set
the clf entropical decision tree
classifier it automatically prints out
what's in that decision tree there's a
lot of variables you can play Within
here and it's quite beyond the scope of
this tutorial able to go through all of
these and how they work but we're
working on entropy that's one of the
options we've added that it's completely
a random state of 100 so 100 percent and
we have a max depth of three now the max
depth if you remember above when we were
doing the different graphs of animals
means it's only going to go down three
layers before it stops and then we have
minimal samples of leaves is five so
it's going to have at least five leaves
at the end so I'll have at least three
splits I'll have no more than three
layers and at least five end leaves with
the final result at the bottom now that
we've created our decision tree
classifier not only created it but
trained it let's go ahead and apply it
and see what that looks like so let's go
ahead and make a prediction and see what
that looks like we're going to paste our
predict code in here
and before we run it let's just take a
quick look at what it's doing here we
have a variable y predict that we're
going to do
and we're going to use our variable clf
entropy that we created
and then you'll see dot predict and
that's very common in the SK learn
modules that they're different tools
have the predict when you're actually
running a prediction
in this case we're going to put our X
test data in here
now if you delivered this for use an
actual commercial use and distributed it
this would be the new loans you're
putting in here to guess
whether the person is going to be pay
them back or not in this case so we need
to test out the data and just see how
good our sample is how good of our tree
does at predicting the loan payments and
finally since Anaconda Jupiter notebook
works as a command line for python we
can simply put the why predict en to
print it I could just as easily have put
the print
and put brackets around y predict en to
print it out and we'll go ahead and do
that it doesn't matter which way you do
it
and you'll see right here that it runs a
prediction this is roughly 300 in here
remember it's 30 percent of a thousand
so you should have about 300 answers in
here
and this tells you which each one of
those lines of our test went in there
and this is what our y predict came out
so let's move on to the next step we're
going to take this data and try to
figure out just how good a model we have
so here we go since sklearn does all the
heavy lifting for you and all the math
we have a simple line of code to let us
know what the accuracy is and let's go
ahead and go through that and see what
that means and what that looks like
let's go ahead and paste this in and let
me zoom in a little bit
there we go
so you have a nice full picture
and we'll see here we're just going to
do a print accuracy is
and then we do the accuracy score
and this was something we imported
earlier if you remember at the very
beginning let me just scroll up there
real quick so you can see where that's
coming from
that's coming from here down here from
sklearn.metrix import accuracy score
and you could probably run a script make
your own script to do this very easily
how accurate is it how many out of 300
do we get right and so we put in our y
test that's the one we ran the predict
on and then we put in our y predict en
that's the answers we got and we're just
going to multiply that by a hundred
because this is just going to give us an
answer as a decimal and we want to see
it as a percentage and let's run that
and see what it looks like
and if you see here we got an accuracy
of 93.66667
so when we look at the number of loans
and we look at how good our model fit we
can tell people it has about a 93.6
fitting to it so just a quick recap on
that we now have accuracy set up on here
and so we have created a model that uses
a decision tree algorithm to predict
whether a customer will repay the loan
or not the accuracy of the model is
about 94.6 percent the bank can now use
this model to decide whether it should
approve the loan request from a
particular customer or not and so this
information is really powerful we may
not be able to as individuals understand
all these numbers because they have
thousands of numbers that come in but
you can see that this is a smart
decision for the bank to use a tool like
this to help them to predict how good
their profit is going to be off of the
loan balances and how many are going to
default or not today we're going to be
looking at random Forest one of the many
powerful tools in the machine learning
library before we dive into the topic
let's start by looking at a few of the
uses for random for us currently today
it's used in remote sensing for example
they're used in the etm devices if
you're a space buff that's the enhanced
thermatic mapper they use on satellites
which see far outside the human Spectrum
for looking at land masses and they
acquire images of the Earth's surface
the accuracy is higher and training time
is less than many other machine learning
tools out there also object detection
multi-class object detection is done
using random Forest algorithms a good
example is a traffic we try to sort out
the different cars buses and things and
it provides a better detection and
complicated environments they're very
complicated up there and then we have
another example connect and let's take a
little closer look at connect connect to
use a random Forest as part of the game
console and what it does is it tracks
the body movements and it recreates it
in the game and let's see what that
looks like we have a user who performs a
step in this case it looks like Elvis
Presley going there
that is then recorded So that connect
registers the movement and then it marks
the user based on accuracy and it looks
like we have prints going on this one
from Elvis Presley to Prince it's great
uh so Mark's user based on the accuracy
if we look at that a little closer we
have a training set to identify body
parts where are the hands where are the
feet what's going on with the body
that then goes into a random Forest
classifier that learns from it once
we've trained the classifier
and then identifies the body parts while
the person's dancing is able to
represent that in a computer format and
then based on that it scores the game
and how accurate you are as being Elvis
Presley or prince in your dancing let's
take an overview of what we're going to
cover today what's in it for you we're
going to start with is what is machine
learning we're not going to go into
detail on that we're going to
specifically look how the random Force
fits in the machine learning hierarchy
then we're going to look at some
applications of random Forest what is
classification which is its primary use
why use random Force what's the benefits
of it and how does it actually come
together what is random forest and then
we'll get into random forest and the
decision tree how all that's like the
final step in how it works and finally
we'll get some python code in there and
we'll use the case the iris flower
analysis now if you don't know what any
of these terms mean or where we're going
with this don't worry we're going to
cover all the basics and have you up and
running and even and having doing some
basic script in Python by the end let's
take a closer look at types of machine
learning specifically we're going to
look at where the decision tree fits in
with the different machine learning
packages out there we'll start with the
basic types of machine learning there's
supervised learning where you have lots
of data and you're able to train your
models there's unsupervised learning
where it has to look at the data and
then divide it based on its own
algorithms without having any training
and then there's reinforcement learning
where you get a plus or negative if you
have the answer correct this particular
tool belongs to the supervised learning
let's take a closer look at that what
that means in supervised learning
supervised learning falls into two
groups classification and regression
we'll talk about regression a little
later and how that differs this
particular format goes underneath
classification so we're looking at
supervised learning and classification
in the machine learning tools
classification is a kind of problem
wherein the outputs are categorical in
nature like yes or no true or false
false or zero or one in that particular
framework there's the k n n where the NN
stands for nearest neighbor Nave Bays
the decision tree which is part of the
random Forest that we're studying today
so why random Forest It's always
important to understand why we use this
tool over the other ones what are the
benefits here and so with the random
Forest the first one is there's no
overfitting if you use of multiple trees
reduce the risk of overfitting training
time is less overfitting means that we
have fit the data so close to what we
have as our sample that we pick up on
all the weird parts and instead of
predicting the overall data you're
predicting the weird stuff which you
don't want high accuracy runs
efficiently in large database for large
data it produces highly accurate
predictions in today's world of Big Data
this is really important and this is
probably where it really shines this is
where why random Forest really comes in
it estimates missing data data in
today's world is very messy so when you
have a random Forest it can maintain the
accuracy when a large proportion of the
data is missing what that means is if
you have data that comes in from five or
six different areas and maybe they took
one set of Statistics in one area and
they took a slightly different set of
Statistics in the other so they have
some of the same same shared data but
one is missing like the number of
children in the house if you're doing
something over demographics and the
other one is missing the size of the
house it will look at both of those
separately and build two different trees
and then it can do a very good job of
guessing which one fits better even
though it's missing that data let us dig
deep into the theory of exactly how it
works and let's look at what is random
forests random forests or random
decision Forest is a method that
operates by constructing multiple
decision trees the decision of the
majority of the trees is chosen by the
random Forest as the final decision and
let's uh we have some nice Graphics here
we have a decision tree and they
actually use a real tree to denote the
decision tree which I love and given a
random some kind of picture of a fruit
this decision tree decides that the
output is it's an apple and we have a
decision tree two where we have that
picture of the fruit goes in and this
one decides that it's a limit and the
decision three tree gets another image
and it decides it's an apple and then
this all goes together and what they
call the random forest and this random
Forest then looks at it and says okay I
got two votes for apple one vote for
lemon the majority is Apples so the
final decision is apples to understand
how the random Forest works we first
need to dig a little deeper and take a
look at the random forest and the actual
decision tree and how it builds that
decision tree and looking closer at how
the individual decision trees work we'll
go ahead and continue to use the fruit
example since we're talking about trees
and forests a decision tree is a tree
shaped diagrammed used to determine a
course of action each branch of the tree
represents a possible decision
occurrence or reaction so in here we
have a bowl of fruit and if you look at
that it looks like they switched from
lemons to oranges we have oranges
cherries and apples and the first
decision of the decision tree might be
is a diameter greater than or equal to
three and if it says false it knows that
they're cherries because everything else
is bigger than that so all the cherries
fall into that decision so we have all
that data we're training we can look at
that we know that that's what's going to
come up here's the color orange well
goes hmm orange or red well if it's true
then it comes out as the orange and if
it's false that leaves apples
so in this example it sorts out the
fruit in the bowl or the images of the
fruit a decision tree these are very
important terms to know because these
are very Central to understanding the
decision tree when working with them the
first is entropy everything on the
decision tree and how it makes this
decision is based on entropy entropy is
a measure of Randomness or
unpredictability in the data set then
they also have Information Gain
the leaf node the decision node and the
root node we'll cover these other four
terms as we go down the tree but let's
start with entropy so starting with
entropy we have here a high amount of
Randomness what that means is that
whatever is coming out of this decision
if it was going to guess based on this
data it wouldn't be able to tell you
whether it's a lemon or an apple it
would just say it's a fruit
so the first thing we want to do is we
want to split this apart and we take the
initial data set we're going to create a
data set one and a data set two we just
split it in two and if you look at these
new data sets after splitting them the
entropy of each of those sets is much
less so for the first one whatever comes
in there it's going to sort that data
and it's going to say okay if this data
goes this direction it's probably an
apple and if it goes into the other
direction it's probably a lemon so that
brings us up to Information Gain it is a
measure of decrease in the entropy after
the data set is split what that means in
here is that we've gone from one set
which has a very high entropy to two
lower sets of entropy and we've added in
the values of E1 for the first one and
E2 for the second two which are much
lower and so that information gain is
increased greatly in this example and so
you can find that the information grain
simply equals decision E1 minus E2 as
we're going down our list of definitions
we'll look at the leaf node and the leaf
node carries the classification or the
decision
so we look down here to the leaf node we
finally get to our set one or our set
two when it comes down there and it says
okay this object's gone into set one if
it's gone into set one it's going to be
split by some means and we'll either end
up with apples on the leaf node or a
lemon on the leaf node and on the right
it'll either be an apple or limits those
Leaf nodes are those final decisions or
classifications that's the definition of
leaf node in here if we're going to have
a final Leaf where we make the decision
we should have a name for the nodes
above it and they call those decision
nodes a decision node decision node has
two or more branches and you can see
here where we have the five apples and
one lemon and in the other case the five
lemons and one apple they have to make a
choice of which tree It Goes Down based
on some kind of measurement or
information given to the tree and that
brings us to our last definition the
root node the top most decision node is
known as the root node and this is where
you have all of your data and you have
your first decision it has to make or
the first split in information
so far we've looked at a very general
image with the fruit being split let's
look and see exactly what that means to
split the data and how do we make those
decisions on there let's go in there and
find out how does a decision tree work
so let's try to understand this and
let's use a simple example and we'll
stay with the fruit we have a bowl of
fruit and so let's create a problem
statement and the problem is we want to
classify the different types of fruits
in the bowl based on different features
the data set in the bowl is looking
quite messy and the entropy is high in
this case so if this bowl was our
decision maker it wouldn't know what
choice to make it has so many choices
which one do you pick Apple grapes or
lemons and so we look in here we're
going to start with a training set
so this is our data that we're training
our data with and we have a number of
options here we have the color and under
the color we have red yellow purple we
have a diameter three three one three
three one and we have a label Apple
lemon Grapes apple lemon grapes and how
do we split the data we have to frame
the conditions to split the data in such
a way that the Information Gain is the
highest it's very key to note that we're
looking for the best gain we don't want
to just start sorting out the smallest
piece in there we want to split it the
biggest way we can and so we measure
this decrease in entropy that's what
they call it entropy there's our entropy
after splitting and now we'll try to
choose a condition that gives us the
highest gain we will do that by
splitting the data using each condition
and checking the gain that we get out of
them the conditions that give us the
highest gain will be used to make the
first split so let's take a look at
these different conditions we have color
we have diameter and if we look
underneath that we have a couple
different values we have diameter equals
three color equals yellow red diameter
equals one and when we look at that
you'll see over here we have one two
three four threes that's a pretty hearty
selection so let's say the condition
gives us a maximum gain of three so we
have the most pieces fall into that
range so our first split from our
decision node is we split the data based
on the diameter is it greater than or
equal to three if it's not that's false
it goes into the great bolt and if it's
true it goes into a bowl fold of lemon
and apples the entropy after splitting
has decreased considerably so now we can
make two decisions if you look at
they're very much less chaos going on
there this node has already attained an
entropy value of zero as you can see
there's only one kind of label left for
this Branch so no further splitting is
required for this node however this node
on the right is still requires a split
to decrease the entropy further so we
split the right node further are based
on color if you look at this if I split
it on color that pretty much cuts it
right down the middle it's the only
thing we have left in our choices of
color and diameter too and if the color
is yellow it's going to go to the rifle
and if it's false it's going to go to
the left Bowl so the entropy in this
case is now zero so now we have three
moles with zero entropy there's only one
type of data in each one of those bowls
so we can predict a lemon with a hundred
percent accuracy and we can predict the
Apple also with 100 accuracy along with
our grapes up there so we've looked at
kind of a basic tree in our forest but
what we really want to know is how does
a random Forest work as a whole so to
begin our random Forest classifier let's
say we already have built three trees
and we're going to start with the first
tree that looks like this just like we
did in the example this tree looks at
the diameter if it's greater than or
equal to three it's true otherwise it's
false so one side goes to the smaller
diameter one side goes to larger
diameter and if the color is orange it's
going to go to the right true we're
using oranges now instead of lemons and
if it's red it's going to go to the left
false we build a second tree very
similar but split differently instead of
the first one being split by a diameter
this one when they created it if you
look at that first Bowl it has a lot of
red objects so it says is the color red
because that's going to bring our
entropy down the fastest and so of
course if it's true it goes to the left
if it's false it goes to the right and
then it looks at the shape false or true
and so on and so on and tree three is
the diameter equal to one and it came up
with this because there's a lot of
cherries in this bowl so that would be
the biggest split on there is is the
diameter equal to one that's going to
drop the entropy the quickest and as you
can see it splits it into true if it
goes false and they've added another
category does it grow in the summer and
if it's false it goes off to the left if
it's true it goes off to the right let's
go ahead and bring these three trees you
can see them all in one image so this
would be three completely different
trees categorizing a fruit and let's
take a fruit now let's try this and this
fruit if you look at it we've blackened
it out you can't see the color on it so
it's missing data remember one of the
things we talked about earlier is that a
random Forest works really good if
you're missing data if you're missing
pieces so this fruit has an image but
maybe as a person had a black and white
camera when they took the picture and
we're going to take a look at this and
it's going to have they put the color in
there so ignore the color down there but
the diameter equals three we find out it
grows in the summer equals yes and the
shape is a circle and if you go to the
right you can look at what one of the
decision trees did this is the third one
is the diameter greater than equal to
three is a color orange well it doesn't
really know on this one but if you look
at the value it say true and go to the
right tree two classifies it as cherries
is a color equal red is is the shape a
circle true it is a circle so this would
look at it and say oh that's a cherry
and then we go to the other classifier
and it says is the diameter equal one
well that's false does it grow in the
summer true so it goes down and looks at
as oranges so how does this random
Forest work the first one says it's an
orange the second one said it was a
cherry and the third one says it's an
orange
and you can guess that if you have two
oranges and one says it's a cherry when
you add that all together the majority
of the vote says orange so the answer is
it's classified as an orange even though
we didn't know the color and we're
missing data on it I don't know about
you but I'm getting tired of fruit so
let's switch and I did promise you we'd
start looking at a case example and get
into some python coding today we're
going to use the case the iris flower
analysis
oh this is the exciting part as we roll
up our sleeves and actually look at some
python coating before we start the
python coding we need to go ahead and
create a problem statement wonder what
species of Iris do these flowers belong
to let's try to predict the species of
the flowers using machine learning in
Python let's see how it can be done so
here we begin to go ahead and Implement
our python code and you'll find that the
first half of our implementation is all
about organizing and exploring the data
coming in let's go ahead and take this
first step which is loading the
different modules into Python and let's
go ahead and put that in our favorite
editor whatever your favorite editor is
in this case I'm going to be using the
Anaconda Jupiter notebook which is one
of my favorites certainly there's
notepad plus plus and eclipse and dozens
of others or just even using the python
terminal window any of those will work
just fine to go ahead and explore this
python coding so here we go let's go
ahead and flip over to our Jupiter note
book and I've already opened up a new
page for Python 3 code and I'm just
going to paste this right in there and
let's take a look and see what we're
bringing into our python the first thing
we're going to do is from the
sklearn.datasets import load Iris now
this isn't the actual data this is just
the module that allows us to bring in
the data the load Iris and the iris is
so popular it's been around since 1936
when Ronald Fisher published a paper on
it and they're measuring the different
parts of the flower and based on those
measurements predicting what kind of
flower it is and then if we're going to
do a random Forest classifier we need to
go ahead and import our random forest
classifier from the sklearn module so
sklearn dot Ensemble import random force
classifier and then we want to bring in
two more modules and these are probably
the most commonly used modules in Python
and data science with any of the other
modules that we bring in and one is
going to be pandas we're going to import
pandas as PD p is a common term used for
pandas and pandas is basically creates a
data format for us where when you create
a pandas data frame it looks like an
Excel spreadsheet and you'll see that in
a minute when we start digging deeper
into the code panda is just wonderful
because it plays nice with all the other
modules in there and then we have numpy
which is our numbers Python and the
numbers python allows us to do different
mathematical sets on here we'll see
right off the bat we're going to take
our NP and we're going to go ahead and
Seed the randomness with it with zero so
np.random.seed is seating that as zero
this code doesn't actually show anything
we're going to go ahead and run it
because I need to make sure I have all
those loaded and then let's take a look
at the next module on here the next six
slides including this one are all about
exploring the data remember I told you
half of this is about looking at the
data and getting it all set so let's go
ahead and take this code right here the
script and let's get that over into our
jupyter notebook and and here we go
we've gone ahead and run the Imports now
I'm going to paste the code down here
and let's take a look and see what's
going on the first thing we're doing is
we're actually loading the iris data and
if you remember up here we loaded the
module that tells it how to get the iris
data now we're actually assigning that
data to the variable Iris and then we're
going to go ahead and use the DF to
Define data frame
and that's going to equal PD and if you
remember that's pandas as PD so that's
our pandas
and Panda data frame and then we're
looking at Iris data and columns equals
Irish feature names
and we're going to do the DF head and
let's run this you can understand what's
going on here
the first thing you want to notice is
that our DF has created what looks like
an Excel spreadsheet and in this Excel
spreadsheet we have set the columns so
up on the top you can see the four
different columns and then we have the
data iris.data down below it's a little
confusing without knowing where this
data is coming from so let's look at the
bigger picture and I'm going to go print
I'm just going to change this for a
moment and we're going to print olivirus
and see what that looks like
so when I print all a virus I get this
long list of information and you can
scroll through here and see all the
different titles on there
what's important to notice is that first
off there's a brackets at the beginning
so this is a python dictionary
and in a python dictionary you'll have a
key or a label and this label pulls up
whatever information comes after it so
feature names which we actually used
over here under columns is equal to an
array of simple length simple width
petal length pedal width these are the
different names they have for the four
different columns and if you scroll down
far enough you'll also see data down
here oh goodness it came up right
towards the top and data is equal to the
different data we're looking at
now there's a lot of other things in
here like Target we're going to be
pulling that up in a minute and there's
also the names uh the target names which
is further down and we'll show you that
also in a minute let's go ahead and sit
that back
to the Head
and this is one of the neat features of
pandas and Panda data frames
is when you do df.head or the panda
dataframe dot head it'll print the first
five lines of the data set in there
along with the headers if you have them
in this case we have the column header
set to Iris features and in here you'll
see that we have 0 1 2 3 4 in Python
most arrays always start at zero so when
you look at the first five it's going to
be zero one two three four not one two
three four five so now we've got our IRS
data imported into a data frame let's
take a look at the next piece of code in
here and so in this section here of the
code we're going to take a look at the
Target and let's go ahead and get this
into our notebook this piece of code so
we can discuss it a little bit more in
detail so here we are in our jupyter
notebook I'm going to put the code in
here and before I run it I want to look
at a couple things going on so we have a
DF species and this is interesting
because right here you'll see where I
have DF species in Brackets which is the
key code for creating another column and
here we have iris.target now these are
both in the pandas setup on here so in
pandas we can do either one I could have
just as easily done Iris and then in
Brackets Target depending on what I'm
working on both are acceptable let's go
ahead and run this code and see how this
changes and what we've done is we've
added the target from the iris data set
as another column on the end
now what species is this is what we're
trying to predict so we have our data
which tells us the answer for all these
different pieces and then we've added a
column with the answer that way when we
do our final setup we'll have the
ability to program our neural network to
look for these this different data and
know what a setosa is or a Vera color
which we'll see in just a minute or
virginica those are the three that are
in there and now we're going to add one
more column I know we're organizing all
this data over and over again it's kind
of fun there's a lot of ways to organize
it what's nice about putting everything
onto one data frame is I can then do a
printout and it shows me exactly what
I'm looking at and I'll show you where
you where that's different where you can
alter that and do it slightly
differently but let's go ahead and put
this into our script up to that now and
here we go we're going to put that down
here
and we're going to run that
and let's talk a little bit about what
we're doing now we're exploring data and
one of the challenges is knowing how
good your model is did your model work
and to do this we need to split the data
and we split it into two different parts
they usually call it the training and
the testing and so in here we're going
to go ahead and put that in our database
so you can see it clearly and we've set
it DF remember you can put brackets this
is creating another column is train so
we're going to use part of it for
training and this equals NP remember
that stands for numpy DOT random.uniform
so we're generating a random number
between 0 and 1 and we're going to do it
for each of the rows that's where the
length DF comes from so each row gets a
generated number and if it's less than
0.75 it's true and if it's greater than
0.75 it's false this means we're going
to take 75 percent of the data roughly
because there's a Randomness involved
and we're going to use that to train it
and then the other 25 percent we're
going to hold off to the side and use
that to test it later on on so let's
flip back on over and see what the next
step is so now that we've labeled our
database for which is training and which
is testing let's go ahead and sort that
into two different variables train and
test and let's take this code and let's
bring it into our project and here we go
let's paste it on down here and before I
run this let's just take a quick look at
what's going on here is we have up above
we created remember there's our def dot
head which prints the first five rows
and we've added a column is train at the
end and so we're going to take that
we're going to create two variables
we're going to create two new data
frames one's called train one's called
test 75 percent in train 25 in test
and then to sort that out
we're going to do that by doing DF our
main original data frame with the iris
data in it and if DF is trained equals
true
that's going to go in the train and if
DF is trained equals false it goes in
the test and so when I run this
we're going to print out the number in
each one let's see what that looks like
and you'll see that it puts 118 in the
training module and it puts 32 in the
testing module which lets us know that
there was 150 lines of data in here so
if you went and looked at the original
data you could see that there's 150
lines and that's roughly 75 percent in
one and 25 percent for us to test our
model on afterward so let's jump back to
our code and see where this goes in the
next two steps
we want to do one more thing with our
data and let's make it readable to
humans I don't know about you but I hate
looking at zeros and ones so let's start
with the features and let's go ahead and
take those and make those readable to
humans and let's put that in our code
let's see here we go paste it in and
you'll see here we've done a couple very
basic things we know that the columns in
our data frame again this is a panda
thing the DF columns
and we know the first four of them 0 1 2
3 that'd be the first four are going to
be the features or the titles of those
columns and so when I run this
you'll see down here that it creates an
index sepa length sepa width petal
length and petal width and this should
be familiar because if you look up here
here's our column titles going across
and here's the first four
one thing I want you to notice here is
that when you're in a command line
whether it's Jupiter notebook or you're
running command line in the a terminal
window if you just put the name of it
it'll print it out this is the same as
doing print
features
and the shorthand is you just put
features in here if you're actually
writing a code
and saving the script and running it by
remote you really need to put the print
in there but for this when I run it
you'll see it gives me the same thing
but for this we want to go ahead and
we'll just leave it as features because
it doesn't really matter and this is one
of the fun thing about jupyter notebooks
is I'm just building the code as we go
and then we need to go ahead and create
the labels for the other part so let's
take a look and see what that for our
final step in prepping our data before
we actually start running the training
and the testing is we're going to go
ahead and convert the species on here
into something the computer understands
so let's put this code into our script
and see where that takes us
all right here we go we've set y equal
to PD dot factorize train species of
zero so let's break this down just a
little bit we have our pandas right here
PD factorize what is factorize doing I'm
going to come back to that in just a
second let's look at what train species
is and why we're looking at the group
zero on there
and let's go up here and here is our
species
remember this on we created this whole
column here for species
and then it has cytosis cytosis cytosis
cytosa and if you scroll down enough
you'd also see virginica and Vera color
we need to convert that into something
the computer understands zeros and ones
so the trained species of zero because
this is in the format of a of an array
of arrays so you have to have the zero
on the end and then species is just that
column factorize goes in there looks at
the fact that there's only three of them
so when I run this you'll see that y
generates an array that's equal to in
this case it's the training set and it's
zeros ones and twos representing the
three different kinds of flowers we have
so now we have something the computer
understands and we have a nice table
that we can read and understand and now
finally we get to actually start doing
the predicting so here we go we have two
lines of code oh my goodness that was a
lot of work to get to two lines of code
but there is a lot in these two lines of
code so let's take a look and see what's
going on here and put this into our full
script that we're running and let's
paste this in here and let's take a look
and see what this is we have we're
creating a variable clf and we're going
to set this equal to the random forest
classifier and we're passing two
variables in here and there's a lot of
variables you can play with as far as
these two are concerned they're very
standard in jobs all that does is to
prioritize it not something to really
worry about usually when you're doing
this on your own computer you do in jobs
equals two if you're working in a larger
or big data and you need to prioritize
it differently this is what that number
does is it changes your priorities and
how it's going to run across the system
and things like that and then the random
state is just how it starts zero is fine
for here
but let's go ahead and run this
we also have clf.fit train features
comma Y and before we run it let's talk
about this a little bit more clf dot fit
so we're fitting we're training it we
are actually creating our random Forest
classifier right here this is a code
that does everything and we're going to
take our training set remember we kept
our test off to the side and we're going
to take our training set with the
features and then we're going to go
ahead and put that in and here's our
Target the Y so the Y is 0 1 and 2 that
we just created and the features is the
actual data going in that we put into
the training set let's go ahead and run
that
and this is kind of an interesting thing
because it printed out the random Forest
classifier
and everything around it
and so when you're running this in your
terminal window or in a script like this
this automatically treats this like just
like when we were up here and I typed in
y and it printed out y instead of print
y
this does the same thing it treats this
as a variable and prints it out but if
you're actually running your code that
wouldn't be the case and what is printed
out is it shows us all the different
variables we can change and if we go
down here you can actually see in jobs
equals two you can see the random State
equals zero those are the two that we
sent in there you would really have to
dig deep to find out all these the
different meanings of all these
different settings on here some of them
are self-explanatory if you kind of
think about it a little bit like Max
features is auto so all the features
that we're putting in there is just
going to automatically take all four of
them whatever we send it it'll take some
of them might have so many features
because you're processing words there
might be like 1.4 million features in
there because you're doing legal
documents and that's how many different
words are in there at that point you
probably want to limit the maximum
features that you're going to process in
leaf nodes that's the end notes remember
we had the fruit and we're talking about
the leaf nodes like I said there's a lot
in this we're looking at a lot of stuff
here so you might have in this case
there's probably only think three leaf
nodes maybe four you might have
thousands of leaf nodes at which point
you do need to put a cap on that and say
okay you can only go so far and then
we're going to use all of our resources
on processing this and that really is
what most of these are about is limiting
the process and making sure we don't
overwhelm a system and there's some
other settings in here again we're not
going to go over all of them warm start
equals false alarm start is if you're
programming it one piece at a time
externally since we're not we're not
going to have like we're not going to
continually to train this particular
Learning Tree and again like I said
there's a lot of things in here that
you'll want to look up more detail from
the SK learn and if you're digging in
deep and running a major project on here
for today though all we need to do is
fit or train our features and our Target
y so now we have our training model
what's next if we're going to create a
model
we now need to test it remember we set
aside the test feature test group 25 of
the data so let's go ahead and take this
code and let's put it into our script
and see what that looks like okay here
we go
and we're going to run this
and it's going to come out with a bunch
of zeros ones and twos which represents
the three type of flowers the setosa the
virginica and the Versa color and what
we're putting into our predict is the
test features and I always kind of like
to know what it is I am looking at so
real quick we're going to do test
features and remember features is an
array
of simple length sepal width pedal
length pedal width so when we put it in
this way it actually loads all these
different columns that we loaded into
features so if we did just features let
me just do features in here seeing so
what features looks like this is just
playing with the with pandas data frames
you'll see that it's an index so when
you put an index in like this
into test features into test it then
takes those columns and creates a panda
data frames from those columns and in
this case
we're going to go ahead and put those
into our predict
so we're going to put each one of these
lines of data
the 5.0 3.4 1.5.2 and we're going to put
those in and we're going to predict what
our new Forest classifier is going to
come up with and this is what it
predicts it predicts zero zero zero one
two one one two two two and and again
this is the flower type setosa virginica
and Versa color so now that we've taken
our test features let's explore that
let's see exactly what that data means
to us so the first thing we can do with
our predicts is we can actually generate
a different prediction model when I say
different we're going to view it
differently it's not that the data
itself is different so let's take this
next piece of code and put it into our
script
so we're pasting it in here and you'll
see that we're doing uh predict and
we've added underscore proba for
probability so there's our clf DOT
predict probability so we're running it
just like we ran it up here but this
time with this we're going to get
slightly different result and we're only
going to look at the first 10.
so you'll see down here instead of
looking at all of them which was what 27
you'll see right down here that this
generates a much larger field on the
probability and let's take a look and
see what that looks like and what that
means
so when we do the predict underscore
praba for probability it generates three
numbers so we had three leaf nodes at
the end and if you remember from all the
theory we did this is the predictors the
first one is predicting a one for setosa
it predicts a zero for virginica and it
predicts a zero for Versa color and so
on and so on and so on and let's uh you
know what I'm going to change this just
a little bit let's look at 10
to 20 just because we can
and we start to get a little different
of data and you'll see right down here
it gets to this one this line right here
and this line has 0 0.5 0.5 and so if
we're going to vote and we have two
equal votes it's going to go with the
first one so it says uh satosha gets
zero votes virginica gets 0.5 votes
Versa color gets 0.5 votes but let's
just go with the virginica since these
two are equal and so on and so on down
the list you can see how they vary on
here so now we've looked at both how to
do a basic predict of the features and
we've looked at the predict probability
let's see what's next on here so now we
want to go ahead and start mapping names
for the plants we want to attach names
so that it makes a little more sense for
us and this we're going to do in these
next two steps we're going to start by
setting up our predictions and mapping
them to the name so let's see what that
looks like
and let's go ahead and paste that code
in here and run it and this goes along
with the next piece of code so we'll
skip through this quickly and then come
back to it a little bit so here's Iris
dot Target names
and if you remember correctly this was
the the names that we've been talking
about this whole time the Sentosa
virginica versus color and then we're
going to go ahead and do the prediction
again we've run we could have just hit a
variable equal to this instead of
re-running it each time but we'll go
ahead and run it again clf dot predict
test features remember that Returns the
zeros the ones in the twos and then
we're going to set that equal to
predictions so this time we're actually
putting it in a variable and when I run
this
it distributes it it comes out as an
array and the array is setosis cytosis
cytosis cytosis cytosa we're only
looking at the first five we could
actually do let's do the first 25 just
so we can see a little bit more on there
and you'll see that it starts mapping it
to all the different flower types the
Versa color and the virginica in there
and let's see how this goes with the
next one so let's take a look at the top
part of our species in here and we'll
take this code and put it in our script
and let's put that down here and paste
it there we go and we'll go ahead and
run it and let's talk about both these
sections of code here
and how they go together the first one
is our predictions and I went ahead and
did uh predictions through 25 let's just
do five
and so we have setosis cytosis cytosis
cytosis that's what we're predicting
from our test model
and then we come down here we look at
test species I remember I could have
just done
test.species.head and you'll see it says
cytosis cytosis cytosa and they match so
the first one is what our forest is
doing
and the second one is what the actual
data is now is we need to combine these
so that we can understand what that
means we need to know how good our
forest is how good it is at predicting
the features so that's where we come up
to the next step which is lots of fun
we're going to use a single line of code
to combine our predictions and our
actuals so we have a nice chart to look
at and let's go ahead and put that in
our script in our Jupiter notebook here
let's see let's go ahead and paste that
in and then I'm going to because I'm on
the Jupiter notebook I can do a control
minus you can see the whole line there
there we go resize it and let's take a
look and see what's going on here we're
going to create in pandas remember PD
stands for pandas and we're doing a
cross tab this function takes two sets
of data and creates a chart out of them
so when I run it you'll get a nice chart
down here and we have the predicted
species
so across the top you'll see the satosha
versus color virginica and the actual
species sistosa versicolor virginica and
so the way to read this chart and let's
go ahead and take a look on how to read
this chart here when you read this chart
you have setosa where they meet you have
versicolor where they meet and you have
virginica where they meet and they're
meeting where the actual and the
predicted agree so this is the number of
accurate predictions so in this case it
equals 30. if you had 13 plus 5 plus 12
you get 30. and then we notice here
where it says virginica but it was
supposed to be versacolor this is
inaccurate so now we have two two
inaccurate predictions and 30 accurate
predictions so I will say that the model
accuracy is 93 that's just 30 divided by
32 and if we multiply it by a hundred we
can say that it is 93 percent accurate
so we have a 93 accuracy with our model
I did want to add one more quick thing
in here on our scripting before we wrap
it up so let's flip back on over to my
script in here we're going to take this
line of code from up above I don't know
if you remember it but predicts equals
the iris dot Target underscore names so
we're going to map it to the names and
we're going to run the prediction and we
read it on test features but you know
we're not just testing it we want to
actually deploy it so at this point I
would go ahead and change this and this
is an array of arrays this is really
important when you're running these to
know that
so you need the double brackets and I
could actually create data maybe let's
let's just do two flowers so maybe I'm
processing more data coming in and we'll
put two flowers in here
and then I actually want to see what the
answer is so let's go ahead and type in
preds and print that out and when I run
this
you'll see that I've now predicted two
flowers so maybe I measured in my front
yard as versacolor and versacolor
not surprising since I put the same data
in for each one
this would be the actual end product
going out to be used on data that you
don't know the answer for
so that's going to conclude our
scripting part of this today we're going
to cover the K nearest neighbors that
referred to as k n n and KN is really a
fundamental place to start in the
machine learning it's a basis of a lot
of other things and just the logic
behind it is easy to understand and
Incorporated in other forms of machine
learning so today what's in it for you
why do we need k n n what is k n how do
we choose the factor k
when do we use k n n
how does k n algorithm work and then
we'll dive in to my favorite part the
use case predict whether a person will
have diabetes or not that is a very
common and popular used data set as far
as testing out models and learning how
to use the different models in machine
learning by now we all know machine
learning models make predictions by
learning from the past data available so
we have our input values our machine
learning model Builds on those inputs of
what we already know and then we use
that to create a predicted output is
that a dog a little kid looking over
there and watching the black cat cross
their path no dear you can differentiate
between a cat and a dog based on their
characteristics cats
cats have sharp claws uses to climb
smaller length of ears meows and purrs
doesn't love to play around dogs they
have dull claws bigger length of ears
barks loves to run around you usually
don't see a cat running around people
although I do have a cat that does that
where dogs do and we can look at these
we can say we can evaluate their
sharpness of the claws how sharp are
their claws and we can evaluate the
length of the ears and we can usually
sort out cats from dogs based on even
those two characteristics now tell me if
it is a cat or a dog an odd question
usually little kids no cats and dogs by
now unless you live in a place where
there's not many cats or dogs so if we
look at the sharpness of the claws the
length of the ears and we can see that
the cat has a smaller ears and sharper
claws than the other animals its
features are more like cats it must be a
cat sharp claws length of ears and goes
in the cat group because KNN is based on
feature similarity we can do
classification using kn n classifier so
we have our input value the picture of
the black cat it goes into our trained
model and it predicts that this is a cat
coming out so what is KNN what is the k
n algorithm K nearest neighbors is what
that stands for it's one of the simplest
supervised machine learning algorithms
mostly used for classification so we
want to know is this a dog or is not a
dog is it a cat or not a cat it
classifies a data point based on how his
neighbors are classified KNN stores all
available cases and classifies new cases
based on a similarity measure and here
we gone from cats and dogs right into
wine another favorite of mine k n stores
all available cases and classifies new
cases based on a similarity measure and
here you see we have a measurement of
sulfur dioxide versus the chloride level
and then the different wines they've
tested and where they fall on that graph
based on how much sulfur dioxide and how
much chloride K and K N is a perimeter
that refers to the number of nearest
neighbors to include in the majority of
the voting process and so if we add a
new glass of wine there red or white we
want to know what the neighbors are in
this case we're going to put k equals 5.
we'll talk about K in just a minute a
data point is classified by the majority
of votes from its five nearest neighbors
here the unknown point would be
classified as red since four out of five
neighbors are red so how do we choose K
how do we know k equals five I mean
that's was the value we put in there so
we're going to talk about it how do we
choose the factor K and N algorithm is
based on feature similarity choosing the
right value of K is a process called
parameter tuning and is important for
better accuracy so at k equals three we
can classify we have a question mark in
the middle as either a as a square or
not is it a square or is it in this case
a triangle and so if we set k equals to
3 we're going to look at the three
nearest neighbors we're going to say
this as a square and if we put k equals
to 7 we classify as a triangle depending
on what the other data is around it you
can see as the K changes depending on
where that point is that drastically
changes your answer and we jump here we
go how do we choose the factor of K
you'll find this in all machine learning
choosing these factors that's the face
you get he's like oh my gosh you say
choose the right K did I set it right my
values in whatever machine learning tool
you're looking at so that you don't have
a huge bias in One Direction or the
other and in terms of k n n the number
of K if you choose it too low the bias
is based on it's just too noises it's
it's right next to a couple things and
it's going to pick those things and you
might get a skewed answer and if your K
is too big then it's going to take
forever to process so you're going to
run into processing issues and resource
issues so what we do the most common use
and there's other options for choosing K
is to use the square root of n so N is a
total number of values you have you take
the square root of it in most cases you
also if it's an even number so if you're
using a like in this case squares and
triangles if it's even you want to make
your K value odd that helps it select
better so in other words you're not
going to have a balance between two
different factors that are equal so
usually take the square root of N and if
it's even you add one to it or subtract
one from it and that's where you get the
K value from that is the most common use
and it's pretty solid it works very well
when do we use knnn we can use knnn when
data is labeled so you need a label on
it we know we have a group of pictures
with dogs dogs cats cats data is Noise
free and so you can see here when we
have a class and we have like
underweight 140 23 Hello Kitty normal
that's pretty confusing we have a high
variety of data coming in so it's very
noisy and that would cause an issue data
set is small so we're usually working
with smaller data sets where you might
get into a gig of data if it's really
clean it doesn't have a lot of noise
because K N is a lazy learner I.E it
doesn't learn a discriminative function
from the training set so it's very lazy
so if you have very complicated data and
you have a large amount of it you're not
going to use the KNN but it's really
great to get a place to start even with
large data you can sort out a small
sample and get an idea of what that
looks like using the KNN and also just
using for smaller data sets k n works
really good how does the K N algorithm
work consider a data set having two
variables height in centimeters and
weight in kilograms and each point is
classified as normal or underweight so
we can see right here we have two
variables you know true false are either
normal or they're not they're
underweight on the basis of the given
data we have to classify the below set
as normal or underweight using k n n so
if we have new data coming in this says
57 kilograms and 177 centimeters is that
going to be normal or underweight to
find the nearest neighbors we'll
calculate the euclidean distance
according to the euclidean distance
formula the distance between two points
in the plane with the coordinates x y
and a b is given by distance D equals
the square root of x minus a squared
plus y minus B squared and you can
remember that from the two edges of a
triangle we're Computing the third Edge
since we know the X side and the Y side
let's calculate it to understand clearly
so we have our unknown point and we
placed it there in red and we have our
other points where the data is scattered
around the distance D1 is the square
root of 170 minus 167 squared plus 57
minus 51 squared which is about 6.7 and
distance 2 is about 13 and distance
three is about 13.4 similarly we will
calculate the euclidean distance of
unknown data point from all the points
in the data set and because we're
dealing with small amount of data that's
not that hard to do and it's actually
pretty quick for a computer and it's not
a really complicated Mass you can just
see how close is the data based on the
euclidean distance hence we have
calculated the euclidean distance of
unknown data point from all the points
as shown where X1 and y1 equal 57 and
170 whose class we have to classify so
now we're looking at that we're saying
well here's the euclidean distance who's
going to be their closest neighbors now
let's calculate the nearest neighbor at
k equals three and we can see the three
closest neighbors put some at normal and
that's pretty self-evident when you look
at this graph it's pretty easy to say
okay what you know we're just voting
normal normal three votes for normal
this is going to be a normal weight so
majority of neighbors are pointing
towards normal hence as per k n
algorithm the class of 57 170 should be
normal so a recap of knnn positive
integer K is specified along with a new
sample we select the K entries in our
database which are closest to the new
sample we find the most common
classification of these entries this is
the classification we give to the new
sample so as you can see it's pretty
straightforward we're just looking for
the closest things that match what we
got so let's take a look and see what
that looks like in a used case in Python
so let's dive into the predict diabetes
use case so use case predict diabetes
the objective predict whether a person
will be diagnosed with diabetes or not
we have a data set of 768 people who
were or were not diagnosed with diabetes
and let's go ahead and open that file
and just take a look at that data and
this is in a simple spreadsheet format
the data itself is comma separated very
common set of data and it's also a very
common way to get the data and you can
see here we have columns a through I
that's what one two three four five six
seven eight eight columns with a
particular attribute and then the ninth
column which is the outcome is whether
they have diabetes as a data scientist
the first thing you should be looking at
is insulin well you know if someone has
insulin they have diabetes that's why
they're taking it and that could cause
issue in some of the machine learning
packages but for a very basic setup this
works fine for doing the KNN and the
next thing you notice is it didn't take
very much to open it up I can scroll
down to the bottom of the data there's
768. it's pretty much a small data set
you know at 769 I can easily fit this
into my ram on my computer I can look at
it I can manipulate it and it's not
going to really tax just a regular
desktop computer you don't even need an
Enterprise version to run a lot of this
so let's start with importing all the
tools we need and before that of course
we need to discuss what IDE I'm using
certainly can use any a particular
editor for python but I like to use for
doing very basic visual stuff the
Anaconda which is great for doing demos
with the jupyter notebook and just a
quick view of the Anaconda Navigator
which is the new release out there which
is really nice you can see under home I
can choose my application we're going to
be using python36 I have a couple
different versions on this particular
machine if I go under environments I
create a unique environment for each one
which is nice and there's even a little
button there where you can install all
different packages so if I click on that
button and open the terminal I can then
use a simple pip install to install
different packages I'm working with
let's go ahead and go back under home
and we're going to launch our notebook
and I've already you know kind of like
the old cooking shows I've already
prepared a lot of my stuff so we don't
have to wait for it to launch because it
takes a few minutes for it to open up a
browser window in this case I'm going to
open up Chrome because that's my default
that I use and since the script is
pre-done you'll see I have a number of
windows open up at the top the one we're
working in and since we're working on
the k n predict whether a person will
have diabetes or not let's go and put
that title in there and I'm also going
to go up here and click on Cell actually
we want to go ahead and first insert a
cell below and then I'm going to go back
up to the top cell and I'm going to
change the cell type to markdown that
means this is not going to run this
python it's a markdown language so if I
run this first one it comes up in nice
big letters which is kind of nice minus
what we're working on and by now you
should be familiar with doing all of our
Imports we're going to import the pandas
as PD import numpy is NP pandas is the
pandas data frame and numpy is a number
array very powerful tools to use in here
so we have our Imports so we've brought
in our pandas our numpy our two general
python tools and then you can see over
here we have our train test split by now
you should be familiar with splitting
the data we want to split part of it for
training our thing and then training our
particular model and then we want to go
ahead and test the remaining data to see
how good it is pre-processing a standard
scalar preprocessor so we don't have a
bias of really large numbers remember in
the data we had like number of
pregnancies isn't going to get very
large where the amount of insulin they
take and get up to 256. so 256 versus 6
that will skew results so we want to go
ahead and change that so they're all
uniform between
-1 and 1. and then the actual tool this
is the K neighbors classifier we're
going to use
and finally the last three are three
tools to test all about testing our
model how good is it we just put down
test on there and we have our confusion
Matrix our F1 score and our accuracy so
we have our two general python modules
we're importing and then we have our six
modules specific from the SK learn setup
and then we do need to go ahead and run
this so these are actually imported
there we go and then move on to the next
step and so in this set we're going to
go ahead and load the database we're
going to use pandas remember pandas is
PD and we'll take a look at the data in
Python we looked at it in a simple
spreadsheet but usually I like to also
pull it up so we can see what we're
doing so here's our data set equals
pd.read CSV that's a pandas command and
the diabetes folder I just put in the
same folder where my IPython script is
if you put in a different folder you
need the full length on there we can
also do a quick Links of the data set
that is a simple python on command Len
for length we might even let's go ahead
and print that we'll go print and if you
do it on its own line links that data
set the jupyter notebook it'll
automatically print it but when you're
in most of your different setups you
want to do the print in front of there
and then we want to take a look at the
actual data set and since we're in
pandas we can simply do data set head
and again let's go ahead and add the
print in there if you put a bunch of
these in a row you know the data set one
head data set two head it only prints
out the last one so I usually always
like to keep the print statement in
there but because most projects only use
one data frame pandas data frame doing
it this way it doesn't really matter the
other way works just fine and you can
see when we hit the Run button we have
the 768 lines which we knew and we have
our pregnancies it's automatically given
a label on the left remember the head
only shows the first five lines so we
have zero through four and just a quick
look at the data you can see it matches
what we looked at before we have
pregnancy glucose blood pressure sure
all the way to age and then the outcome
on the end and we're going to do a
couple things in this next step we're
going to create a list of columns where
we can't have zero there's no such thing
as zero skin thickness or zero blood
pressure zero glucose any of those you'd
be dead so not a really good Factor if
they don't if they have a zero in there
because they didn't have the data and
we'll take a look at that because we're
going to start replacing that
information with a couple of different
things and let's see what that looks
like so first we create a nice list as
you can see we have the values talked
about glucose blood pressure skin
thickness and this is a nice way when
you're working with columns is to list
the columns you need to do some kind of
transformation on a very common thing to
do and then for this particular setup we
certainly could use the there's some
Panda tools that will do a lot of this
where we can replace the N A but we're
going to go ahead and do it as a data
set column equals datasetc column dot
replace this is this is still pandas you
can do a direct there's also that's that
you look for your nan a lot of different
options in here but the Nan num pnan is
what that stands for is none it doesn't
exist so the first thing we're doing
here is we're replacing the zero with a
numpy none there's no data there that's
what that says that's what this is
saying right here so put the zero in and
we're going to play zeros with no data
so if it's a zero that means a person's
well hopefully not dead hope they just
didn't get the data the next thing we
want to do is we're going to create the
mean which is the integer from the data
set from the column dot mean where we
skip in A's we can do that and that is a
pandas command there the skip n a so
we're going to figure out the mean of
that data set and then we're going to
take that data set column and we're
going to replace all the npnan with the
means why did we do that and we could
have actually just taken this step and
gone right down here and just replace 0
and Skip anything where except you can
actually there's a way to skip zeros and
then just replace all the zeros but in
this case we want to go ahead and do it
this way so you can see that we're
switching this to a non-existent value
then we're going to create the mean well
this is the average person so if we
don't know what it is if they did not
get the data and the data is missing one
of the tricks is you replace it with the
average what is the most common data for
that this way you can still use the rest
of those values to do your computation
and it kind of just brings that
particular value of those missing values
out of the equation let's go ahead and
take this and we'll go ahead and run it
doesn't actually do anything so we're
still preparing our data if you want to
see what that looks like we don't have
anything in the first few lines just not
going to show up but we certainly could
look at a row let's do that let's go
into our data set with the printed data
set and let's pick in this case let's
just do glucose and if I run this this
is going to print all the different
glucose levels going down and we
thankfully don't see anything in here
that looks like missing data at least on
the ones it shows you can see I skipped
a bunch in the middle because that's
what it does we have too many lines in
Jupiter notebook it'll skip a few and go
on to the next in a data set let me go
and remove this and we'll just zero out
that and of course before we do any
processing before proceeding any further
we need to split the data set into our
train and testing data that way we have
something to train it with and something
to test it on and you're going to notice
we did a little something here with the
pandas database code there we go my
drawing tool we've added in this right
here off the data set and what this says
is that the first one in pandas this is
from the PD pandas it's going to say
within the data set we want to look at
the eye location and it is all rows
that's what that says so we're going to
keep all the rows but we're only looking
at zero column 0 To 8. Remember column
nine here it is right up here we printed
it in here is outcome well that's not
part of the training data that's part of
the answer yes column nine but it's
listed as eight number eight so zero to
eight is nine columns so 8 is the value
you and when you see it in here 0 this
is actually zero to seven it doesn't
include the last one and then we go down
here to Y which is our answer and we
want just the last one just column eight
and you can do it this way with this
particular notation and then if you
remember we imported the train test
split that's part of the SK learn right
there and we simply put in our X and our
y we're going to do random State equals
zero you don't have to necessarily seed
it that's a seed number I think the
default is one when you seated I have to
look that up and then the test size test
size is 0.2 that simply means we're
going to take 20 percent of the data and
put it aside so that we can test it
later that's all that is and again we're
going to run it not very exciting so far
we haven't had any printout other than
to look at the data but that is a lot of
this is prepping this data once you prep
it the actual lines of code are quick
and easy and we're almost there with the
actual running of our k n n we need to
go ahead and do a scale the data if you
remember correctly we're fitting the
data in the standard scalar which means
instead of the data being from you know
5 to 303 in one column and the next
column is one to six we're going to set
that all so that all the data is between
-1 and 1. that's what that standard
scalar does keeps it standardized and we
only want to fit the scalar with the
training set but we want to make sure
the testing set is the X test going in
is also transformed so it's processing
it the same so here we go with our
standard scalar we're going to call it
SC underscore X for the scalar and we're
going to import the standard scalar into
this variable and then our X train
equals SC underscore x dot fit transform
so we're creating the scalar on the X
train variable and then our X test we're
also going to transform it so we've
trained and transformed the X train and
then the X test isn't part of that
training it isn't part of the of
training the Transformer it just gets
transformed that's all it does and again
we're going to run this if you look at
this we've now gone through these steps
all three of them we've taken care of
replacing our zeros for key columns that
shouldn't be zero and we replace that
with the means of those columns that way
that they fit right in with our data
models we've come down here we split the
data so now we have our test data and
our training data and then we've taken
and we've scaled the data so all of our
data going in now no we don't TR we
don't train the Y part the Y train and Y
test that never has to be trained it's
only the data going in that's what we
want to train in there then Define the
model using K neighbors classifier and
fit the train data in the model so we do
all that data prep and you can see down
here we're only going to have a couple
lines we do all that data prep and you
can see down here we're only going to
have a couple lines of code where we're
actually building our model and training
it that's one of the cool things about
Python and how far we've come it's such
an exciting time to be in machine
learning because there's so many
automated tools let's see before we do
this let's do a quick Links of and let's
do y we want yeah let's just do length
of Y and we get 768 and if we import
math we do math dot square root let's do
y train there we go it's actually
supposed to be X train before we do this
let's go ahead and do import math and do
math square root length of Y test and
when I run that we get 12.409 I want to
see show you where this number comes
from we're about to use 12 is an even
number so if you know if you're ever
voting on things remember the neighbors
all vote don't want to have an even
number of neighbors voting so we want to
do something odd and let's just take one
away we'll make it 11. let me delete
this out of here that's one of the
reasons I love Jupiter notebook because
you can flip around and do all kinds of
things on the fly so we'll go ahead and
put in our classifier we're creating our
classifier now and it's going to be the
K neighbors classifier and neighbors
equal 11. remember we did 12 minus 1 for
11. we have an odd number of neighbors P
equals 2 because we're looking for is it
are they diabetic or not and we're using
the euclidean metric there are other
means of measuring the distance you
could do like square square means value
there's all kinds of measure this but
the euclidean is the most common one and
it works quite well it's important to
evaluate the model let's use the
confusion Matrix to do that and we're
going to use the confusion Matrix
wonderful tool and then we'll jump into
the F1 score
and finally accuracy score which is
probably the most commonly used quoted
number when you go into a meeting or
something like that so let's go ahead
and paste that in there and we'll set
the cm equal to confusion Matrix why
test why predict so those are the two
values we're going to put in there and
let me go ahead and run that and print
it out and the way you interpret this is
you have the Y predicted which would be
your title up here we could do let's
just do p r e d
predicted across the top and actual
going down actual
it's always hard to write in here actual
that means that this column here down
the middle that's the important column
and it means that our prediction said 94
and prediction in the actual agreed on
94 and 32. this number here the 13 and
the 15 those are what was wrong so you
could have like three different if
you're looking at this across three
different variables instead of just two
you'd end up with the third row down
here and the column going down the
middle so in the first case we have the
the and I believe the zero has a 94
people who don't have diabetes the
prediction said that 13 of those people
did have diabetes and were at high risk
and the 32 that had diabetes it had
correct but our prediction said another
15 out of that 15 it classified as
incorrect so you can see where that
classification comes in and how that
works on the confusion Matrix then we're
going to go ahead and print the F1 score
let me just run that and you see we get
a 0.69 in our F1 score the F1 takes into
account both sides of the balance of
false positives where if we go ahead and
just do the accuracy account and that's
what most people think of is it looks at
just how many we got right out of how
many we got wrong so a lot of people
when you're a data scientist and you're
talking to other data scientists they're
going to ask you what the F1 score the F
score is if you're talking to the
general public or the decision makers in
the business they're going to ask what
the accuracy is and the accuracy is
always better than the F1 score but the
F1 scores more telling it lets us know
that there's more false positives than
we would like on here but 82 percent not
too bad for a quick flash look at
people's different statistics and
running an sklearn and running the k n n
the K nearest neighbor on it so we have
created a model using KNN which can
predict whether a person will have
diabetes or not or the very least
whether they should go get a checkup and
have their glucose checked regularly or
not the print accuracy score we got the
0.818 was pretty close to what we got
and we can pretty much round that off
and just say we have an accuracy of 80
percent tells us it is a pretty fair fit
in the model what is skin means
clustering k-means clustering is an
unsupervised learning algorithm in this
case you don't have labeled data unlike
in supervised learning so you have a set
of data and you want to group them and
as the name suggests you want to put
them into clusters which means objects
that are similar in nature similar in
characteristics need to be put together
so that's what K means clustering is all
about the term k is basically is a
number so we need to tell the system how
many clusters you need to perform so if
K is equal to 2 there will be two
clusters if K is equal to 3 3 clusters
and so on and so forth that's what the k
stands for and of because there is a way
of finding out what is the best or
Optimum value of K for a given data we
will look at that so that is K means
cluster so let's take an example K means
clustering is used in many many
scenarios but let's take an example of
Cricket the game of cricket let's say
you received data of a lot of players
from maybe all over the country or all
over the world and this data has
information about the runs scored by the
people or by the player and the wickets
taken by the player and based on this
information we need to Cluster this data
into two clusters batsman and Bowlers so
this is an interesting example let's see
how we can perform this so we have the
data which consists of primarily two
characteristics which is the runs and
the wickets so the bowlers basically
take wickets and the batsman score runs
there will be of course a few Bowlers
who can score some runs and similarly
there will be some batsmen who will Who
would have taken a few wickets but with
this information we want to Cluster
those players into batsmen and Ballers
so how does this work let's say this is
how the data is so there are information
there is information on the y-axis about
the runs code and on the x-axis about
the wickets taken by the players so if
we do a quick plot this is how it would
look and when we do the clustering we
need to have the Clusters like shown in
the third diagram out here so we need to
have a cluster which consists of people
who have scored High runs which is
basically the batsman and then we need a
cluster with people who have taken a lot
of wickets which is typically the
bowlers there may be a certain amount of
overlap but we will not talk about it
right now so with cayman's clustering we
will have here that means K is equal to
2 and we will have two clusters which is
batsman and Bowlers so how does this
work the way it works is the first step
in k-means clustering is the allocation
of two centroids randomly so two points
are assigned as so-called centroids so
in this case we want two clusters which
means K is equal to two so two points
have been randomly assigned as centroids
keep in mind these points can be
anywhere there are random points they
are not initially they are not really
the centroids centroid means it's a
central point of a given data set but in
this case when it starts off it's not
really the centroid okay so these points
though in our presentation here we have
shown them one point closer to these
data points and another closer to these
data points they can be assigned
randomly anywhere okay so that's the
first step the next step is to determine
the distance of each of the data points
from each of the randomly assigned
centroids so for example we take this
point and find the distance from this
centroid and the distance from this
center right this point is taken and the
distance is found from this centroid and
the center and so on and so forth so for
every point the distance is measured
from both the centroids and then
whichever distance is less that point is
assigned to that centroid so for example
in this case visually it is very obvious
that all these data points are assigned
to this centroid and all these data
points are assigned to this centroid and
that's what is represented here in blue
color and in this yellow color the next
step is to actually determine the
central point or the actual centroid for
these two clusters so we have this this
one initial cluster this one initial
cluster but as you can see these points
are not really the centroid centroid
means it should be the central position
of this data set Central position of
this data set so that is what needs to
be determined as the next step so the
central point on the actual centroid is
determined and the original randomly
allocated centroid is repositioned to
the actual centroid of this new clusters
and this process is actually repeated
now what might happen is some of these
points may get reallocated in our
example that is not happening probably
but it may so happen that the distance
is found between each of these data
points once again with these centroids
and if there is if it is required some
points may be reallocated we will see
that in a later example but for now we
will keep it simple so this process is
continued till the centroid
repositioning stops and that is our
final cluster so this is our so after
iteration we come to this position this
situation where the centroid doesn't
need any more repositioning and that
means our algorithm has converged
convergence has occurred and we have the
cluster two clusters we have the
Clusters with a centroid so this process
is repeated the process of calculating
the distance and repositioning the
centroid is repeated till the
repositioning stops which means that the
algorithm has converged and we have the
final cluster with the data points and
the centroids so this is what you're
going to learn from this session we will
talk about the types of clustering what
is k-means clustering application of
k-means clustering k-means clustering is
done using distance measure so we will
talk about the common distance measures
and then we will talk about how k-means
clustering works and go into the details
of k-means clustering algorithm and then
we will end with the demo and a use case
for k-means cluster so let's begin first
of all what are the types of clustering
there are primarily two categories of
clustering hierarchical clustering and
then partitional clustering and each of
these categories are further subdivided
into agglomerative and divisive
clustering and k-means and fuzzy c means
clustering let's take a quick look at
what each of these types of clustering
are in hierarchical clustering the
Clusters have a tree-like structure and
hierarchical clustering is further
divided into agglomerative and divisive
agglomerative clustering is the
bottom-up approach we begin with each
element as a separate cluster and merge
them into successively larger clusters
so for example we have a b c d e f which
start by combining BMC form one cluster
DNA form one more then we combine d e
and f one more bigger cluster and then
add BC to that and then finally a to it
compared to that divisive clustering or
divisive clustering is a top-down
approach we begin with the whole set and
proceed to divide it into successively
smaller clusters so we have ABCDEF we
first take that as a single cluster and
then break it down into a b c d e and f
then we have partitional clustering
split into two subtypes k-means
clustering and fuzzy c means in k-min's
clustering the objects are divided into
the number of clusters mentioned by the
number K that's where the K comes from
so if we say k is equal to 2 the objects
are divided into two clusters C1 and C2
and the way it is done is the features
or characteristics are compared and all
objects having similar characteristics
are clubbed together so that's how K
means clustering is done we will see it
in more detail as we move forward and
fuzzy c means is very similar to k-means
in the sense that it clubs objects that
have similar characteristics together
but while in k-means clustering two
objects cannot belong to or any object a
single object cannot belong to two
different clusters in c means objects
can belong to more than one cluster so
that is the primary difference between K
means and fuzzy c means so what are some
of the applications of k-means
clustering k-means clustering is used in
a variety of examples or variety of
business cases in real life starting
from academic performance diagnostic
system search engines and wireless
sensor networks and many more so let us
take a little deeper look at each of
these examples academic performance So
based on the scores of the students
students are categorized into a b c and
so on clustering forms a backbone of
search engines when a search is
performed the search results need to be
grouped together the search engines very
often use clustering to do this and
similarly in case of wireless sensor
networks the clustering algorithm plays
the role of finding the cluster heads
which collects all the data in its
respective cluster so clustering
especially k-means clustering uses
distance measure so let's take a look at
what is distance sure so while these are
the different types of clustering in
this video we will focus on k-means
clustering so distance measure tells how
similar some objects are so the
similarity is measured using what is
known as distance measure and what are
the various types of distance measures
there is euclidean distance there is
Manhattan distance then we have squared
euclidean distance measure and cosine
distance measure these are some of the
distance measures supported by k-means
clustering let's take a look at each of
these what is euclidean distance measure
this is nothing but the distance between
two points so we have learned in high
school how to find the distance between
two points this is a little
sophisticated formula for that but we
know a simpler one is square root of Y2
minus y1 whole square plus x 2 minus X1
whole Square so this is an extension of
this formula so that is the euclidean
distance between two points what is the
squared euclidean distance measure it's
nothing but the square of the euclidean
distance as the name suggests so instead
of taking the square root we leave the
square as it is and then we have
Manhattan distance measure in case of
Manhattan distance it is the sum of the
distances across the x-axis and the
y-axis and note that we are taking the
absolute value so that the negative
values don't come into play so that is
the Manhattan distance measure then we
have cosine distance measure in this
case we take the angle between the two
vectors formed by joining the points
from the origin so that is the cosine
distance measure okay so that was a
quick overview about the various
distance measures that are supported by
k-means now let's go and check how
exactly K means clustering works
okay so this is how k-means clustering
works this is like a flowchart of the
whole process there is a starting point
and then we specify the number of
clusters that we want now there are
couple of ways of doing this we can do
by trial and error so we specify a
certain number maybe K is equal to 3 or
4 or 5 to start with and then as we
progress we keep changing until we get
the best clusters or there is a
technique called elbow technique whereby
we can determine the value of K what
should be the best value of K how many
clusters should be formed so once we
have the value of K we specify that and
then the system will assign that many
centroid so it picks randomly that to
start with randomly that many points
that are considered to be the centroids
of these clusters and then it measures
the distance of each of the data points
from the these centroids and assigns
those points to the corresponding
centroid from which the distance is
minimum so each data point will be
assigned to the centroid Which is
closest to it and thereby we have K
number of initial clusters however this
is not the final clusters The Next Step
it does is for the new groups for the
Clusters that have been formed it
calculates the main position thereby
calculates the new centroid position the
position of the centroid moves compared
to the randomly allocated one so it's an
iterative process once again the
distance of each point is measured from
this new centroid point and if required
the data points are reallocated to the
new centroids and the mean position or
the new centroid is calculated once
again if the centroid moves then the
iteration continues which means the
convergence has not happened the
clustering has not converged so as long
as there is a movement of the centroid
this iteration keeps happening but once
the centroid stops moving which means
that the cluster has converged or the
clustering process has converged that
will be the end result so now we have
the final position of the centroid a and
the data points are allocated
accordingly to the closest centroid I
know it's a little difficult to
understand from this simple flowchart so
let's do a little bit of visualization
and see if we can explain it better
let's take an example if we have a data
set for a grocery shop so let's say we
have a data set for a grocery shop and
now we want to find out how many
clusters this has to be spread across so
how do we find the optimum number of
clusters there is a technique called the
elbow method so when these clusters are
formed there is a parameter called
within sum of squares at the lower this
value is the better the cluster is that
means all these points are very close to
each other so we use this within sum of
squares as a measure to find the optimum
number of class Masters that can be
formed for a given data set so we create
clusters or we let the system create
clusters of a variety of numbers maybe
of 10 10 clusters and for each value of
K the within SS is measured and the
value of K which has the least amount of
within SS or WSS that is taken as the
optimum value of K so this is the
diagrammatic representation so we have
on the y-axis the within sum of squares
or WSS and on the x-axis we have the
number of clusters so as you can imagine
if you have K is equal to 1 which means
all the data points are in a single
cluster the witnesses value will be very
high because they are probably scattered
all over the moment you split it into
two there will be a drastic fall in the
within SS value and that's what is
represented here but then as the the
value of K increases the decrease the
rate of decrease will not be so high it
will continue to decrease but probably
the rate of decrease will not be high so
that gives us an idea so from here we
get an idea for example the optimum
value of K should be either 2 or 3 or at
the most 4 but beyond that increasing
the number of clusters is not
dramatically changing the value in WSS
because that pretty much gets stabilized
okay now that we have got the value of K
and let's assume that these are our
delivery points the next step is
basically to assign two centroids
randomly so let's say C1 and C2 are the
centroids assigned randomly now the
distance of each location from the
centroid is measured and each point is
assigned to the centroid Which is
closest to it so for example these
points are very obvious that these are
closest to C1 whereas this point is far
away from C2 so these points will be
assigned which are close to C1 will be
assigned to C1 and these points or
locations which are close to C2 will be
assigned to C2 and then so this is the
how the initial grouping is done this is
part of C1 and this is part of C2 then
the next step is to calculate the actual
centroid of this data because remember
C1 1 and C2 are not the centroids
they've been randomly assigned points
and only thing that has been done was
the data points which are closest to
them have been assigned to them but now
in this step the actual centroid will be
calculated which may be for each of
these data sets somewhere in the middle
so that's like the main point that will
be calculated and the centroid will
actually be positioned or repositioned
there same with C2
so the new centroid for this group is C2
in this new position and C1 is in this
new position once again the distance of
each of the data points is calculated
from these centroids now remember it's
not necessary that the distance Still
Remains the or each of these data points
still remain in the same group by
recalculating the distance it may be
possible that some points get
reallocated like so you see this so this
point earlier was closer to C2 because
C2 was here but after recalculating
repositioning it is observed that this
is closer to C1 than C2 so this is the
new grouping so some points will be
reassigned and again the centroid will
be calculated and if the centroid
doesn't change so that is the repetitive
process iterative process and if the
centroid doesn't change once the
centroid stops changing that means the
algorithm has converged and this is our
final cluster with this as the centroid
C1 and C2 as the centroids these days
data points as a part of each cluster so
I hope this helps in understanding the
whole process iterative process of K
means clustering so let's take a look at
the K means clustering algorithm let's
say we have X1 X2 X3 n number of points
as our inputs and we want to split this
into K clusters or we want to create K
clusters so the first step is to
randomly pick K points and call them
centroids they are not real centroids
because centroid is supposed to be a
center point but they are just called
centroids and we calculate the distance
of each and every input point from each
of the centroids so the distance of X1
from C1 from C2 C3 each of the distances
we calculate and then find out which
distance is the lowest and assign X1 to
that particular random centroid repeat
that process for X2 calculate its
distance from each of the centroid c 1 C
to C3 up to c k and find which is the
lowest distance and assign X2 to that
particular centroid same with X3 and so
on so that is the first round of
assignment that is done now we have K
groups because there are we have
assigned the value of K so there are K
centroids and so there are K groups all
these inputs have been split into K
groups however remember we picked the
centroids randomly so they are not real
centroids so now what we have to do we
have to calculate the actual centroids
for each of these groups which is like
the mean position which means that the
position of the randomly selected
centroids will now change and they will
be the main positions of this newly
formed K groups and once that is done we
once again repeat this process of
calculating the distance right so this
is what we are doing as a part of Step 4
we repeat step two and three so we again
calculate the distance of X1 from the
centroid C1 C2 C3 and then C which is
the lowest value and assign X1 to that
calculate the distance of X2 from C1 C
to C3 or whatever up to c k and find
whichever is the lowest distance and
assign X2 to that centroid and so on in
this process there may be some
reassignment X1 was probably assigned to
Cluster C2 and after doing this
calculation maybe now X1 is assigned to
C1 so that kind of reallocation may
happen so we repeat the steps 2 and 3
till the position of the centroids don't
change or stop changing and that's when
we have convergence so let's take a
detailed look at it at each of these
steps so we randomly pick K cluster
centers we call them centroids because
they are not initially they are not
really the centroids so we let us name
them C1 C2 up to c k and then Step 2 we
assign each data point to the closest
Center so what we do we calculate the
distance of each x value from each C
value so the distance between X1 C1
distance between X1 C2 X1 C3 and then we
find which is the lowest value right
that's the minimum value we find and
assign X1 to that particular centroid
then we go next to X2 find the distance
of X2 from C1 X2 from C2 X2 from C3 and
so on up to c k and then assign it to
the point or to the centroid which has
the lowest value and so on so that is
Step number two in Step number three We
Now find the actual centroid for each
group so what has happened as a part of
Step number two we now have all the
points all the data points grouped into
K groups because we we wanted to create
K clusters right so we have K groups
each one may be having a certain number
of input values they need not be equally
distributed by the way based on the
distance we will have K groups but
remember the initial values of the C1 C2
were not really the centroids of these
groups right we assign them randomly so
now in step 3 we actually calculate the
centroid of each group which means the
original point which we thought was the
centroid will shift to the new position
which is the actual centroid for each of
these groups okay and we again calculate
the distance so we go back to step 2
which is what we calculate again the
distance of each of these points from
the newly positioned centroids and if
required we reassign these points to the
new centroids so as I said earlier there
may be a reallocation so we now have a
new set or a new group we still have K
groups but the number of items and the
actual assignment may be different from
what was in step two here okay so that
might change then we perform step three
once again to find the new centroid of
this new group so we have again a new
set of clusters new centroids and new
assignments we repeat this step two
again once again we find and then it is
possible that after iterating through
three or four or five times the centroid
will stop moving in the sense that when
you calculate the new value of the
centroid that will be same as the
original value or there will be very
marginal change so that is when we say
convergence has occurred and that is our
final cluster that's the formation of
the final cluster all right so let's see
a couple of demos of k-means clustering
we will actually see some live demos and
python notebook using python notebook
but before that let's find out what's
the problem that we are trying to solve
the problem statement is let's say
Walmart wants to open a chain of stores
across the State of Florida
and it wants to find the optimal store
locations now the issue here is if they
open too many stores close to each other
obviously the they will not make profit
but if they if the stores are too far
apart then they will not have enough
sales so how do they optimize this now
for an organization like Walmart which
is an e-commerce giant they already have
the addresses of their customers in
their database so they can actually use
this information or this data and use
k-means cluster to find the optimal
location now before we go into the
python notebook and show you the Live
code I wanted to take you through very
quickly a summary of the code in the
slides and then we will go into the
python notebook so in this block we are
basically importing all the required
libraries like numpy
matplotlab and so on and we are loading
the data that is available in the form
of let's say the addresses for
simplicity's sake we will just take them
as some data points then the next thing
we do is quickly do a scatter plot to
see how they are related to each other
with respect to each other so in the
scatter plot we see that there are a few
distinct groups already being formed so
you can actually get an idea about how
the cluster would look and how many
clusters what is the optimal number of
clusters and then starts the actual
k-means clustering process so we will
assign each of these points to the
centroids and then check whether they
are the optimal distance which is the
shortest distance and assign each of the
points data points to the centroids and
then go through this iterative process
till the whole process converges and
finally we get an output like this so we
have four distinct clusters and which is
you we can say that this is how the
population is probably distributed
across Florida State and the centroids
are like the location where the store
should be the optimum location where the
store should be so that's the way we
determine the best locations for the
store and that's how we can help Walmart
find the best locations for their stores
in Florida so now let's take this into
python notebook let's see how this looks
when we are learning running the code
live all right so this is the code for
k-means clustering in Jupiter notebook
we have a few examples here which we
will demonstrate how k-means clustering
is used and even there is a small
implementation of k-means clustering as
well okay so let's get started okay so
this block is basically importing the
various libraries that are required like
matplotlib and numpy and so on and so
forth which would be used as a part of
the code then we are going and creating
blobs which are similar to clusters now
this is a very neat feature which is
available in scikit-learn make blobs is
a nice feature which creates clusters of
data sets so that's a wonderful
functionality that is readily available
for us to create some test data kind of
thing okay so that's exactly what we are
doing here we are using make blobs and
we can specify how many clusters we want
so centers we are mentioning here so it
will go ahead and so we just mentioned
four so it will go ahead and create some
test data for us
and this is how it looks as you can see
visually also we can figure out that
there are four distinct classes or
clusters in this data set and that is
what make blobs actually provides now
from here onwards we will basically run
the standard k-means functionality that
is readily available so we really don't
have to implement k-means itself the
k-means functionality or the or the
function is readily available you just
need to feed the data and we'll create
the Clusters so this is the code for
that we import k-means and then we
create an instance of k-means and we
specify the value of K this n underscore
clusters is the value of K remember K
means in K means K is basically the
number of clusters that you want to
create and it is a integer value so this
is where we are specifying that so we
have K is equal to 4. and so that
instance is created we take that
instance and as with any other machine
learning functionality fit is what we
use the function or the method rather
fit is what we use to train the model
here there is no real training kind of
thing but that's the call okay so we are
calling fit and what we are doing here
we are just passing the data so X has
these values the data that has been
created right so that is what we are
passing here and this will go ahead and
create the Clusters and then we are
using
after doing uh fit We Run The predict
which basically assigns for each of
these observations which cluster it
belongs to all right so it will name the
Clusters maybe this is cluster one this
is two three and so on or I will
actually start from 0 cluster 0 1 2 and
3 maybe and then for each of the
observations it will assign based on
which cluster it belongs to it will
assign a value so that is stored in y
underscore K means when we call predict
that is what it does and we can take a
quick look at these y underscore K means
or with the cluster numbers that have
been assigned for each observation so
this is the cluster number assigned for
observation one maybe this is for
observation two observation three and so
on so we have how many about I think 300
samples right so all the 300 samples
there are 300 values here each of them
the cluster number is given and the
class faster number goes from 0 to 3 so
there are four clusters so the numbers
go from 0 1 2 3 so that's what is seen
here okay now so this was a quick
example of generating some dummy data
and then clustering that okay and this
can be applied if you have proper data
you can just load it up into X for
example here and then run the game so
this is the central part of the k-means
clustering program example so you
basically create an instance and and you
mentioned how many clusters you want by
specifying this parameter and underscore
clusters and that is also the value of K
and then pass the data to get the values
now the next section of this code is the
implementation of a k means now this is
kind of a rough implementation of the
k-means algorithm so we will just walk
you through I will walk you through the
code at each step what it is doing and
then we will see a couple of more
examples of how k-means clustering can
be used in maybe some real life examples
real life use cases all right so in this
case here what we are doing is basically
implementing k-means clustering and
there is a function for a library it
calculates for a given two pairs of
points it will calculate the the
distance between them and see which one
is the closest and so on so this is like
this is pretty much like what k-means
does right so it calculates the distance
of each point or each data set from
predefined centroid and then based on
whichever is the lowest this particular
data point is assigned to that percent
right so that is basically available as
a standard function and we will be using
that here so as explained in the slides
the first step that is done in case of
k-means clustering is to randomly assign
some centroids so as a first step we
randomly allocate a couple of centroids
which we call here we are calling as
centers
and then we put this in a loop and we
take it through an iterative process
for each of the data points we first
find out using this function pairwise
distance argument for each of the points
we find out which one which Center or
which randomly selected centroid is the
closest and accordingly we assign the
data
at a point to that particular centroid
or cost staff and once that is done for
all the data points we calculate the new
centroid by finding out the mean
position with the center position right
so we calculate the new centroid and
then we check if the new centroid is the
coordinates or the position is the same
as the previous centroid the positions
we will compare and if it is the same
that means the process has converged so
remember we do this process till the
centroids or that centroid doesn't move
anymore right so the centroid gets
relocated each time this reallocation is
done so the moment it doesn't change
anymore the position of the centroid
doesn't change anymore we know that
convergence has occurred so till then so
you see here this is like an infinite
Loop while true is an infinite Loop it
only breaks when the centers are the
same new center and the old Center
positions are the same and once that is
done we return the centers and the
labels now of course as explained this
is not a very sophisticated and advanced
implementation very basic implementation
because one of the flaws in this is that
sometimes what happens is the centroid
the position will keep moving but in if
the change will be very minor so in that
case also with that is actually
convergence right so for example the
change is 0.0001 we can consider that as
convergence otherwise what will happen
is this will either take forever or it
will be never ending so that's a small
flaw here so that is something
additional checks may have to be added
here but again as mentioned this is not
the most sophisticated implementation
this is like a kind of a rough
implementation of the k-means clustering
okay so if we execute this code this is
what we get as the output so this is the
definition of this particular function
and then we call that find underscore
clusters and we pass our data X and the
number of clusters which is 4 and if we
run that and plot it this is the output
that we get so this is of course each
cluster is represented by a different
color so we have a cluster in green
color yellow color and so on and so
forth and these big points here these
are the centroids this is the final
position of the centroids and as you can
see visually also this appears like a
kind of a center of all these points
here right similarly this is like the
center of all these points here and so
on so this is the example or this is an
example of a implementation of K means
clustering and next we will move on to
see a couple of examples of how k-means
clustering is used in maybe some real
life scenarios or use cases in the next
example or demo we are going to see how
we can use k-means cluster trying to
perform color compression we will take a
couple of images so there will be two
examples and we will try to use k-min's
clustering to compress the colors this
is a common situation in image
processing when you have an image with
millions of colors but then you cannot
render it on some devices which may not
have enough memory so that is the
scenario where where something like this
can be used so before again we go into
the python notebook let's take a look at
quickly the the code as usual we import
the libraries and then we import the
image and then we will flatten it so the
reshaping is basically we have the image
information stored in the form of pixels
and if the images like for example 427
by 640 and it has three colors so that's
the overall dimension of the of the
initial image we just reshape it and
then feed this to our algorithm and this
will then create clusters of only
cluster so this this colors there are
millions of colors and now we need to
bring it down to 16 colors so we use K
is equal to 16 and this is uh when we
visualize this is how it looks there are
these are all about 16 million possible
colors the input color space has 16
million possible colors and we just
subcompress it to 16 colors so this is
how it would look when we compress it to
16 colors and this is how the original
image looks and after compression to 16
colors this is a the new image looks as
you can see there is not a lot of
information that has been lost though
the image quality is definitely reduced
a little bit
so this is an example which we are going
to now see in Python notebook let's go
into the python node and once again as
always we will import some libraries and
load this image called
flower.jpg okay so let me load that and
this is how it looks this is the
original image which has I think 16
million colors and this is the shape of
this image which is basically what is
the shape is nothing but the overall
size right so this is 427 pixel by 640
pixel and then there are three layers
which is this three basically is for RGB
which is red green blue so color image
will have that right so that is the
shape of this now what we need to do is
data let's take a look at how data is
looking so let me just create a new cell
and show you what is in data basically
we have captured this information
so data is what let me just show you
here
all right so let's take a look at China
what are the values in China and if we
see here this is how the data is stored
this is nothing but the pixel values
okay so this is like a matrix and each
one has about for this 427 by 640 pixel
XL all right so this is how it looks now
the issue here is these values are large
the numbers are a large so we need to
normalize them to between 0 and 1 right
so that's why we will basically create
one more variable which is data which
will contain the values between 0 and 1
and the way to do that is divide by 255
so we divide China by 255 and we get the
new values in data so let's just run
this piece of code and this is the shape
so we now have also yeah what we have
done is we changed using reshape we
converted into the three dimensional
into a two-dimensional data set and let
us also take a look at how
and let me just insert
probably a cell here and take a look at
how data is looking all right so this is
how data is looking and now you see this
is the values are between 0 and 1 right
so if you earlier noticed in case of
china the values were large numbers now
everything is between 0 and 1. this is
one of the things we
need all right so after that the next
thing that we need to do is to visualize
this and we can take random set of maybe
10 000 points and plot it and check and
see how this looks so let us just plot
this
there so this is how the original the
color the pixel distribution is these
are two plots one is red against Green
and another is red against Blue and this
is the original distribution of the
color
so then what we will do is we will use
k-means clustering to create just 16
clusters for the various colors and then
apply that to the image now what will
happen is since the data is large
because there are millions of colors
using regular k-means may be a little
time consuming so there is another
version of k-means which is called mini
batch came in so we will use that which
is which processes in the overall
concept Remains the Same but this
basically processes it in smaller
batches that's the only thing okay so
the results will pretty much be the same
so let's go ahead and execute this piece
of code and also visualize this so that
we can see that there are this this is
how the 16 colors uh would look so this
is red against Green and this is red
against Blue there is quite a bit of
similarity between this original color
schema and the new one right so it
doesn't look very very completely
different or anything like
now we apply this the newly created
colors to the image and we can take a
look how this is looking now we can
compare both the images so this is our
original image and this is our new image
so as you can see there is not a lot of
information that has been lost it pretty
much looks like the original image yes
we can see that for example here there
is a little bit it appears a little
dullish compared to this one right
because we kind of took off some of the
finer details of the color but overall
the high level information has been
maintained at the same time the main
advantage is that now this can be this
is an image which can be rendered on a
device which may not be that very
sophisticated now let's take one more
example with a different image in the
second example we will take an image of
the Summer Palace in China and we repeat
the same process this this is a high
definition color image with millions of
colors and also three-dimensional
now we will reduce that to 16 colors
using k-means clustering and we do the
same process like before we reshape it
and then we cluster the colors to 16 and
then we render the image once again and
we will see that the color the quality
of the image slightly deteriorates as
you can see here this has much finer
details in this which are probably
missing here but then that's the
compromise because there are some
devices which may not be able to handle
this kind of high density images so
let's run this chord in Python notebook
all right so let's apply the same
technique for another picture which is
even more intricate and has probably
much complicated color schema so this is
the image now once again we can take a
look at the shape which is 427 by 640 by
and this is the new data would look
somewhat like this compared to the
flower image so we have some new values
here and we will also bring this as you
can see the numbers are much big so we
will much bigger so we will now have to
scale them down to values between 0 and
1 and that is done by dividing by 255 so
let's go ahead and do that
and reshape it okay so we get a
two-dimensional Matrix and we will then
as a next step we will go ahead and
visualize this how it looks those the 16
colors and this is basically how it
would look 16 million colors and now we
can
create the Clusters out of this the 16
k-means clusters we will create so this
is how the distribution of the pixels
would look with 16 colors and then we go
ahead and
apply this
and visualize how it is looking for with
the new just the 16 color so once again
as you can see this looks much richer in
color but at the same time and this
probably doesn't have as we can see it
doesn't look as rich as this one but
nevertheless the information is not lost
the shape and all that stuff and this
can be also rendered on a slightly a
device which is probably not that
sophisticated okay so that's pretty much
it so we have seen two examples of how
color compression can be done using
k-min's clustering and we have also seen
in the previous examples of how to
implement k-means the code to roughly
how to implement k-means clustering and
we use some sample data using blob to
just execute the k-means clustering now
you'll notice here
we've got we're using pandas whoops drew
it through the pandas and we're going to
go ahead and read it as a pandas data
frame and of course pandas sits on numpy
so a lot of stuff you do with pandas can
go right into numpy very easily
uh and the reason I bring this up is
because pandas has a lot of tools in
there for just looking at the data real
quick and easy
and so the first one we want to go ahead
and do is do credit.df or credit
underscore DF our data we read in info
and just see what that looks like
and when we go ahead and print this out
you can see here we have
13 columns remember we were looking at
our data and it had those that row you
couldn't read across the top
um then it has none null count how many
values don't have null what kind of
objects are they they're an object an
integer
um different things like that and we
look at object is it a checking account
this is probably text on here
uh duration how long credit history
amount savings account present employee
employed since so a lot of different
numbers coming in here and these are
just the columns we're looking at
and if you're going to look at the
columns it's kind of nice to actually
look at the data
and so we'll use the pandas to go ahead
and print it out just like you would on
a spreadsheet hard to see them all on
here but you can see we have here's our
row across the top because Panda does
such a good job sorting out columns
and the actual data checking account a11
a12 A14 not sure what that means
duration how long they've had it credit
history I'm not sure what the a33 or a34
means I'm sure it has a special meaning
on there the amount here's our savings
account and all the information on that
and this is actually a very a much more
easy to read view than what we had
before as far as like that text file
when you're just looking at data through
the database sometimes those can be
really hard to read this you can really
see and if I take it down a notch I can
get all the columns in here we'll go and
keep it zoomed in just so we can see
that what's going on a little easier
and then we can also do credit df.i
location the ilocation feature in the
pandas is going to go ahead and do rows
0 through 5 and we're going to look at
columns one through seven and let's go
ahead and just run that and you can see
right here how we just split it up so
it's real easy to manipulate our data
and get a smaller view of different
parts of the data as we're going through
it and just like we can look at the
first seven columns we can also look at
the last seven columns
uh same kind of format we're looking at
row 0 through 5 column seven to the end
if you leave the number out there
and you can see we can easily now look
at this on a smaller screen much better
for displaying those are just tricks to
help you display
your information so that when you
present this in front of a group of
people
it makes it very easy to read or you can
just copy this out and put it into a
document that kind of thing and then we
also like to go ahead and do like credit
status value counts and things like that
again we're just looking at the
different uh sets of information on here
and in our pandas data frame value
counts is we're looking at unique values
so there's a lot of unique values in
here that's um 700 and 300 that's a
significantly diverse set of data
and if we look at the data one of the
things we're looking at is the status 0
1 0 0 1
and I'm going to guess that that means
that it is either default or not default
so that's probably what we're going to
want to look for hopefully you've had
your specialty in domain remember we
talked about the different parts of data
science domain is what field it is in
this would be in Banks and loans and so
if we want to figure out what the status
of a new loan is we're going to separate
the status out and so if we take our X
features equals the list of the columns
that's all this is credit underscore DF
dot columns we remove status
uh and then we go ahead and this will
print our features out and you can see
it's everything but the status on the
end because that's what we want to
predict we want to predict the new data
whether that's status is zero or one or
not and next we want to do a little bit
more data preparation we're going to go
ahead and encode
and we're going to take an encode credit
DF we're going to create that off of our
setup on here
and you're going to ask well what are we
encoding on here well when we go up to
here let me just go back all the way
when we're looking at all this
information up here
you can see there's a object
object object well if I'm doing a
prediction and something's just a random
object it doesn't really mean anything
there's no numbers to process
and so when we come down a little
further we can see down here that we are
looking at
a65 I'm not sure what a65 means we're
looking at a 93 personal status we're
looking at a143 these aren't actual
numbers there's some kind of code that
the bank put in probably and so for our
model they really don't mean anything
unless we convert them to numbers
and you convert them to numbers by
literally creating a bunch of yes no's
so instead of thinking it as as
a173 and a172 as being 0 1 and if you
had an A7 174 maybe 0 1 2 you would
think of this as a label a173 is true or
false and then you'd have another label
a172 is true or false so for every
unique job in here that it becomes
another feature added in and it's on or
off it's true or false that's what this
encoding is doing
and we'll go ahead and list our encoding
as it comes out and if you come up here
you can see it did exactly what I was
describing we've now encoded it so
here's checking account a13 checking
account
a1214
a31 here's all of our uh
checking account numbers so there was
three of them uh here's our credit
history a31 a32 a33 34. again the
computer has no idea of knowing what
those are all it knows is those are each
unique features and the same thing with
the savings account a62 and so on going
down and so once we have our nice list
of there we can go ahead and do
let me pull this in here we go let's
look at our new data set
and if we go ahead and run the new data
set we have our in-cone credit DF
checking and we're just going to look at
these and look at the head this is just
the first few of these so we can see
what it actually looks like in the data
and just like I said it's now uh zero
zero zero zero one one zero zero
this First Column is just the count zero
one two three four that's not part of
the data but you can see here
that it just puts a check mark of one uh
because it's an AC a12 and we have a
checking account aca14 where it's also a
check mark of one going across
so we've done a little data preparation
uh we've come in here and done some
exploratory data analysis
and now we want to start building our
data model and we'll kind of go back and
forth between exploratory data analysis
and data model and then interpreting the
results on this and so when we go ahead
and import our stats models as API
as SM
now a lot of times we use the SK learner
the scikit models in this one we're
going to go ahead and use the SM model
from stats models which is pretty common
for doing a very basic Logistics
regression model and then from the site
kit we're going to have our train test
split
with any data you want to go ahead and
train your model and then you need
something to test it on some unknown
data so you can see how well you did
very common in your in your setting up
your models is to split it up into your
training set and your testing set and
what I want you to notice on here is we
have X train well what is X Train That's
all the columns except for the last one
which was the status was it default or
was it in in good standing and then of
course our X test is part of the data
we're going to split that up by 0.3 so
30 percent of the data is going to be 30
of our rows are going to be put in the X
test and the Y train and Y test is just
the status and then we create our once
we've created our data and split it up
we go ahead and create our model and
it's the logit we're just going to call
it logic but you can a lot of times you
end up seeing logic model
um with logit
equals the sm.logit X train
y train X train and SK learn it's always
x-train y train uh but in the
stats model is reversed on there and
then they go ahead and run the fit so we
load the data up and then we fit it
and then we can go ahead and summarize
that model and see what it looks like
let's go ahead and run that
it takes it just a moment uh and we got
a nice summary of our data again we're
still looking at the data and we have
takes just a moment to to kind of feed
through and you can certainly see where
we have our coefficient which has to do
with the weights in the model standard
error that's very important as we look
at this coefficient and how it affects
the model
p is greater than the absolute value of
Z 0.025 these are all your statistical
notes on here so as you look at these
you might look at like how big is a
standard error that's one of the big
ones that I usually look at as we go up
and we start looking at the different
things the higher the error the less the
more we want to be a little careful of
it the lower the error the better in
more general terms they also have
dealing with the model and it's
iterations you can see some general
status on here how many iterations did
it have to go through through before I
was able to come up with the numbers
because it kind of guesses it's playing
a high low game and it takes its six
iterations to find what it considers the
best fit uh and you can see there's more
information up here as far as when it
converts how it converts and so on now
when we have our summary up there one of
the questions starts coming in remember
I told you we're looking at like our
standard error and you know how these
numbers all are telling us how important
each one of these features is in running
our prediction and if you have a ton of
features and some of them are just kind
of all over the place all they do is
create noise so we really want to get
rid of them they also cause issues in
that if you're running a huge amount of
data and you have to rerun this model
over and over again this can really text
your time and so you're losing both time
money and your results might not be as
good because they might be weighted
based on some of these very fuzzy
numbers
uh so we're going to look at significant
variables and put together a little
routine for that again we're we've come
in if you remember from back here uh
we're still in kind of an exploratory
data analysis and data modeling they
kind of go hand in hand sometimes we
haven't quite got to interpreting the
results in running predictions and so
we'll go ahead and build this thing on
here it looks at the LM values so that's
coming up here where this was generated
I'd have to actually look that up for
the this particular model because I
usually use the sklearn version of this
so as we look at this we're going to
look at the P values of our variables
and basically we're looking to see how
good the p-values are if they're less
than or equal to 0.05 we probably
those are probably solid values and if
they're greater than that then probably
we're not interested in them
and so let's go ahead and run this and
we see that when we pull out all the
values that are less than or equal to
0.05 for the P values and if we go up
here here we go here's our P I knew it
was up here I just wasn't seeing it
correctly so you can probably see
duration that's going to be good amount
0.01 that looks good instance instant
inst rate which I'm guessing is the
percentage rate or the interest it's
trying to say in inst and interest at
the same time so we have our interest
rate and all this if we come down here
we see duration amount our instant rate
age checking account a13 checking
account A14 credit history a34 savings
account a65 these are our primary
features these ones are related when we
look at the data
these are the ones that are going to
predict whether it's a good or bad loan
and so now that we know which ones work
we want to go ahead and create our
recreate our SM model or our final logit
model and you'll see here we now have
the X-ray the Y train and then instead
of the X train it's x-train significant
variables right there so all we're doing
is is running this just on the
significant variables in the setup and
we'll go ahead and fit it and you can
see here you can actually double bracket
and do it all in one line up above we
had to do it in the two lines which is
how the um setup is for this particular
module and then we'll go ahead and do a
final legit summary and just see what
that looks like and we can see here
here's our P scores remember they're all
supposed to be under 0.0 underneath the
0.05 these are all under 0.05 you can
see up here different statuses as far as
how it ran it still took six iterations
to go through the data the date and so
forth and now that we have a solid model
and that's if you remember correctly let
me flip back on over here we've done our
data modeling we've created a solid
model and so now we need to actually run
a prediction so that we can interpret
the results and weigh in on that and see
how good they are and so for that I'm
going to go ahead and let's see find it
over here
uh why predict so we have our model that
we created we want to go ahead and
create our y predict and it's based on
our final object and here's the magic
word predict or dot predict
um and so this is where we're going to
come in and actually get our predictions
on here that our model comes up and
remember we're testing
um X test is going in there's our X test
and it's only the significant variables
so we've created our model now we want
to push in our test version that's never
seen this data before so this is all new
and then we're just going to take a
random sample to see what it looks like
what do those predictions look like
in this random sample we're just looking
at 10 of these and you can see here is
the actual number it says 0.08 gives us
a 1.07
this is our probability number which is
I would have to actually look to see
whether higher or lower is better
I'm guessing the closer to
zero the better it is but I'm not
completely sure on that I have to
actually look up on and see what this
particular framework
but you can see the actual prediction
one zero zero zero so I guess this is a
good loan a bunch of defaults and some
good loans that's what it predicts it's
going to come out as now just looking at
the data you know it's confusing this is
you have different models they have
different setup they have the predicted
probability comes out on this and other
models it doesn't so you really need a
tool to dig deeper into the setup to
understand what this means
and so what we're going to do is we're
going to take our predicted values which
you can see right here has an actual
predicted probability
and then we're going to go ahead and
insert on there
from a sample let me just run this
because it'll make a lot more sense we
have our actual value and our predicted
value so this is what we predicted and
this is the actual setup if we just look
at this right off the bat we can see
that we predicted zero and this was a
one these all came out correct number
332 came out correct 917 was an actual
they were good on their loan and they
predicted it's going to be a default you
start to see that there's some variants
so how do we measure that how do we know
whether our model was any good or not
well for that we're going to go ahead
and load up a nice graft and we'll use
for our graph we'll import matplot
Library Pi plot
in Seaborn Seabourn sits on matplot
Library
in this matplot Library inline is just
because I'm using Jupiter notebook with
the new version I'm in it doesn't even
need it but I tend to leave it in for
older versions and then we will import
from our sklearn metrics this is your
scikit psych kit is the main package and
sklearn is how it looks on here and
we'll go ahead and run that so it's
nicely loaded and then we'll go ahead
and create a little routine
in just a moment here
to print this out so we can see what
that looks like
and this metrics is kind of a fun
metrics because it it tells you uh like
how many you have correct on the correct
one
how many you had wrong on the wrong one
and this top part is just all a draw
routine so it comes in here and has our
actual and our predicted and it's our CM
metrics it breaks it up puts it into the
heat map the SN heat map gives it some
colors
add some labels and then we go ahead and
show it and we're just going to dump
that in there and run that
and you can spend forever building
Graphics is so much fun
we come in here we have bad credit good
credit
uh we have bad credit good credit we
have predicted label
and so when you look at this you can see
here it had
um
on the good credit
it tells you how well it predicted it
and how many false positive it has and
on our bad credit
here we have bad credit bad credit it
said 30 of those
were bad credit it predicted them bad
credit
while 21 were good credit that it
predicted would be bad credit
and then we have here we have 188 that
were good credit
uh but the actual value and then it had
61 there were bad credit that it said
were predicted good credit uh so at this
point you look at this and you'd say
well if I'm predicting
uh these are
this is our good credit here let me flip
this on over here and this is our bad
credit there we go
so we have bad credit good credit you
start looking at and you say okay can we
afford that many defaults after five
years or whatever it is
um and so those are the questions you
start asking is does this model work
good enough to predict whether we should
give these people loans or not you're
always going to have somebody default on
them and again that starts going into
domain uh banking domain something I
don't know very much about clearly I
know whether I default that alone or not
which I don't and I try very hard not to
and then if we're going to draw the
chart which is really nice to have just
a clear visual chart metrics also has
our classification report and you can
see these are just the numbers we are
looking at they let us know the
Precision
uh our F score and recall and all that
stuff on here you can just print the
straight out metrics classification
report now we looked at a regression
model uh let's go ahead and look at a
clustering model to see what that looks
like and we'll go ahead and create a new
Troop
python on there
and this is going to be our
clustering setup let me flip this off
and switch on over to my clustering menu
in this case we're going to be looking
at K means clustering
so let's just put that up here K means
clustering
now the last one was a regression model
so it figured out coefficients for lines
you can go back to your old euclidean
geometry or the algebra expression for
slope on a line Y equals MX plus b or
whatever
and it goes on from there as far as
finding distances and figuring out the
lines on there this is a little bit
different we talk about clustering it
uses similar ideas but it has to do with
edges two points and how do you figure
out a distance between two points and
what does that mean
now you'll see here we have our pandas
PD our numpy is NP our matplot library
Seaborn sits on matplot libraries we
talked about
um they've added some perimeters here as
far as colors and then we did an inline
for the matplot library again that's not
really necessary even in the new version
of the Jupiter notebook in the old
version Jupiter notebook if you didn't
do that it would just kind of hang or
disappear
and then we're going to import some data
it's important to have our data set up
in here
and instead of looking at this and
guessing what the data is
usually open up the CSV file at this
time let's just go ahead and print it
under the DF head
because really those those text files
are so messy and you look at the DF head
and it's easy to look at
whoops had a path issue there so College
data it's a CSV so automatically knows
there's a DOT CSV on there
and we can see here that they downloaded
from a number of colleges
Abilene Christian University Adelphi
University Adrian College
and then it has whether it's private I'm
guessing yes or no
apps I'm not sure what that is
acceptance rate applications and bidding
and then the acceptance rate enrollment
top 10 percent top two five percent
undergrad so on so these are just
statistics based on the college or
college getting into a college
and just like we did before let's
explore the data if you can remember
from the chart we were looking at we're
going through our data Discovery data
preparation and exploratory data
analysis so we're really kind of looking
at the data and what do we have here
what came in at this point the data has
already been prepared we're not doing a
whole lot as far as
getting rid of null values and finding
out whether it's bad data or good data
and that kind of thing and data
Discovery would be figuring out which
data to sit in so that we've already
done
so we're going to go to the exploratory
data jump into Data modeling and
interpret the results just like we did
with the other one
and we'll go ahead and use the panda
tool to get the info DF you'll see DF
very commonly it just stands for data
frame a lot of people use it as a
generic setup when they import from
pandas
and so we have our info and you can see
right here uh
non-null numbers here's our count so
each one of these has 777 non-null
values
and again here's our type of data we're
dealing with
and if you remember from last time
here's an object
uh
this was our yes or no everything else
looks like it's integer we do have a
float value here integer integer floats
and integers usually either when you're
running them on a prediction they're
pretty interchangeable in a lot of cases
but whether it's private true or false
that's pretty important on here
the fact that they could probably be
switched to a zero or one is pretty
helpful also and if we're going to look
at all that data we can go ahead and
describe it so there's our data frame
describe
and you have the same thing here's our
count all these should be 777.
we have the mean value so you can
actually look at what our average is
standard deviation
minimum different quartiles 25 50 the
third quartile and so on and of course
our max value on there Min and Max and
as we explore the data we can do a lot
of fun things on here we're going to use
our Seaborn
and we're going to look at a room and
board versus graduation date we're going
to add this is going to be a heat map so
we're going to add whether it's a
private college or not
how it fits the size the aspect ratio
and all that that's what this line is
here Seaborn you can almost do your own
class on matplot library in Seabourn
because there's so many features in
there but when you look at the very
Basics you can throw up some data
and have a nice colorful map set up
and here we have our graduation rate
compared to room and board costs and in
private or public
so you can see that the graduation rate
compared to room and board play
interesting thought how much did I spend
on room and board uh am I going to
graduate the more I spend on room and
board and you can see it numbers go up
there in graduation rate and you can see
that the graduation rate tends to go way
up for your private schools and the room
and board also goes
continues to grow on private schools
kind of thing it's kind of just a fun
heat map
and we can explore other things in our
doing our heat Maps we can look at our
state whether it's out of state
undergrad private again is one of our
setups on here and you can see here that
um
for undergrad there certainly is a lot
more public schools and whether it's out
of state
interestingly enough the out-of-state
number goes way up how many people
coming from out of state into the school
for the private schools just kind of fun
things if you're trying to figure out
where you're going to go maybe you'd
want to do this for picking a bachelor's
degree or a master's degree or something
or certainly you could also plot this
with fun locations and download
information on
uh tourism sites if you're traveling
that kind of thing you do the same kind
of thing with and we'll go ahead and
throw another map on here
um let me go and run this this is a
slightly different setup on here with
the out of state
and so we're running let's see pull this
up
uh Ben's 20
the bins is each how many uh bins are
you going to split it into and this is
kind of a fun one where you can see
private versus public we have how many
out of state and
I'd have to look this up to see what
they picked on here
oh there we go okay so you can see we
have another chart that has to do with
the out of state and the number of
students coming in and private and
public
uh so a lot of different setups on here
as we dig into the different graphing
so at this point we've just been kind of
looking at uh the graphs on here let's
go ahead and import our cluster our
k-means cluster
and you can see here we have we're going
to call it km I guess for k-means or
maybe it's K means model I always label
mine with model
equals K means in clusters equals two
random State equals 90.
uh and so where when we cluster it we're
only going to Cluster into two groups
that's what this this is meaning here
across the different settings on there
and then we're going to go ahead and fit
and we're going to drop private
uh so we don't we're not going to be
looking at whether it's a private or
public school we're just going to go
ahead and
run the cluster on there
and then once we run the cluster on
there we can actually look at cluster
centers let's go ahead and do that on
this
when we talk about K means let me run
this boom there we go so we have
all these different columns and each of
those columns has a center and we start
looking how the data comes together on
those centers that's what all these
numbers this is the hidden stuff behind
the Clusters on here
and so we can now do maybe we'll create
a little converter here if private
equals yes return one now let's return
zero we're going to run our cluster
private and apply the converter
and then we'll go ahead and print that
out let me just show you what that looks
like so you can see what we're doing
here
go ahead and do uh DF cluster we'll
create a new column on here private
apply converter
and we can see here it creates some
private apps except we've just added on
to our data frame on here
and we did that so that we can run the
confusion Matrix
make sure we import our confusion Matrix
we're going to do a classification
report confusion Matrix and we'll go
ahead and run this on our clustering
and as you can see here as we're
predictions here's our confusion Matrix
up here just like we had on the other
setup where it has how many
false true false false true false and
false false as your accuracy and our
setup on there this is really if you're
looking at which where you want to go
maybe you're looking at where you want
to go in a I think more of a tourism
thing but for colleges this is a great
way for looking for a bachelor's or a
masters coming in here and you can start
finding out which one you want to go to
based on this accuracy whether it's
private or public or how many
graduations are on there
so we looked at a couple examples went
through some of the parts of the cycle
whether using a k-means or a linear
regression model
and certainly this cycle and these
models you start to see that there are
some similarities we're doing the same
thing and each model has a better setup
depending on what you're trying to
accomplish on there the need for feature
selection to train a model we collect
huge quantities of data to help the
machine learn better consider a table
which contains information on old cars
the model decides which cars must be
crushed for spare parts and when we talk
about huge quantities of data there they
save everything from people's favorite
cat pictures to and you can imagine
there's so much data out there even in
company they'll save all these little
pieces of information about people and
companies and corporations you need some
way to sort through because if you try
to run your models on all of it
you'll end up with these very clunky
models and they might have issues which
we'll talk about later but in this case
we're talking about cars and crushing
but not all this data will be useful to
us some classes are part of the data may
not contribute much to our model and can
be dropped and you can see right here we
have who was the owner of the car
in our data a car will not be crushed
based on its previous owner
so yeah that's kind of a clear cut you
can see that why would I care who owned
the car before once it's in the junkyard
and we're crushing the cars we're not
going to really care about that so here
we have dropped the owner column as it
does not contribute to the model having
too much unnecessary data can cause the
model to be slow the model may also
learn from this irrelevant data and be
inaccurate so feature selection is a
process of reducing the input variable
to your model by using only relevant
data and getting rid of the noise in the
data consider the database given below a
library wants to donate some old books
to make place in their shells for new
books we want to train a model to
automate this task
in this case the color of the book does
not matter and keeping it can cause a
model to learn to donate books based on
color we can remove this as a feature
using feature selection we can optimize
our model in several ways
and so the number one is to prevent
learning from noise and overfitting
that's actually the huge one because we
we don't want it to give us a wrong
prediction and that means also improved
accuracy so instead of giving us a ROM
prediction we also want it to be as
close to the right answer as we can get
and we want to reduce the training time
it's an exponential growth in some of
these models so that each feature you
add in increases that much
more training time we talk about feature
selection methods we put together a nice
little flowchart that shows the various
methods used for feature selection
and you have your basic feature
selection and then there is supervised
and unsupervised under supervised
there's intrinsic wrapper method filter
method
so we talk about unsupervised feature
selection refers to the method which
does not need the output label class for
feature selection and that was you can
see here under super unsupervised we
don't have I mean that's really a
growing market right now
unsupervised learning and so feature
selection is the same thing supervised
feature selection refers to the method
which uses the output label class for
the feature selection and if you
remember we looked at three different we
have intrinsic wrapper and filter method
so we're going to start with the filter
method on this now remember we know what
the output is so we're going to be
looking at that output to see how well
it's doing versus the features in this
method features are dropped based on
their relation to the output or how they
are correlating to the output
and you can see here we have a set of
features selecting best feature learning
algorithm and then performance and so we
want to find out which feature
correlates to the performance on the
output consider the example of book
classifier here we drop the color column
based on simple deduction and that kind
of sums it up in the in a nutshell is we
want to filter out things that clearly
do not go with what we're looking for if
we look at the wrapper method in the
wrapper method we split our data into
subsets and train a model using this
based on the output of the model we add
and subtract features and train the
model again and you can see here in the
wrapper method we have a set of features
we generate a subset we run it through
the algorithm and we see how each one of
those subset of features performs
consider the book data set by using the
wrapper method we would use a subset of
different features to train the machine
and adjust the subset according to the
output and so you can see here let's say
we take a name and number of times red
and we run just those and we look at the
output and if we looked at them with all
four inputs and look at the output we'd
see quite a different variation in there
and we might say you know what condition
of the book and color really doesn't
affect what we're looking for and you
can see here we've run it on a condition
of the book and color
depending on the output of the model we
will choose our final set of features
these features will give us the best
result for our model
and it might come up that the name
number of times red is probably pretty
important the intrinsic method this
method combines the qualities of both
filter and wrapper method to create the
best subset the model will train and
check the accuracy of different subsets
and select the best among them we kind
of looked at a little overview of some
of the stuff some of the common feature
selection algorithms based on which
method they belong to are given below
and you'll see it's primarily under
supervised there's not like I said a lot
of unsupervised methods and the ones
that are usually used these methods and
finds a way to create a supervised
connection between the data
and we talk about supervised methods we
have our filter method which we talked
about and it uses like the Pearson's
coefficient Chi Squared Anova
coefficient those are all under the
filter method and in the wrapper method
recursive feature elimination so
remember we're choosing a subset and we
want to go through there and look at
each one so you're just doing a lot of
Loops or recursive calculations to see
which one works best and which ones
don't have an impact on the output and
there's a lot of genetic algorithms to
go with this too on the wrapper method
and how they evaluate it and with the
intrinsic method there's the two main
ones we're looking at is the lasso
regularization the last algorithms are
basically your standard regression model
so it's finding out how these different
methods fit together and which ones have
the best add together to have the least
amount of error
the other one used in the intrinsic
method is a decision tree it says hey if
this one is this one produces this
result this one produces this result yes
no which way do we go based on the input
and the output variables we can choose
our feature selection model so you have
your numeric input coming in you have
your numeric output if you use the
Pearson's correlation coefficient or
spearman's rank coefficient you can then
select what features you're going to
feed into that specific model and you
maybe have a numerical input and a
categorical input so we're going to be
looking more at Anova correlation
coefficient or Kindles rank coefficient
and if you have a core categorical input
and a numerical output we might be
looking at an over correlation
coefficient in Kindle's rank coefficient
So based on the input and the output
variables we can choose our feature
selection model and you can see we have
categorical to categorical we might be
looking at the chi-squared test
contingency tables and mutual
information let's go and take a look and
see in the python code what we're
talking about here
and I'm going to go ahead and use for my
IDE the Jupiter notebook in the and they
always launch it out of anaconda on here
and we'll go ahead and go up here and
create a new Python 3 module
and we'll call it uh
feature
select
since we're in Python we're going to be
working mainly with your numpy your
pandas your matplot library so we have
our number array our data frame setup
which goes with the number array the
numpy the pandas data frame and then we
want to go ahead and graph everything so
we're going to import these three
modules
and then we put together some data we're
going to read this in it's Kobe Bryant I
guess he's a basketball player our guys
in the back we have a number of them
guys it's both we have a lot of men and
women so it's probably a misnomer our
team in the back they have some of them
have a liking for basketball and they
know who Kobe Bryant is and they want to
learn a little bit more about Kobe
Bryant what's going in for what whatever
is going on with his game
in basketball so we're going to take a
look at him
and once we import the data we can see
what columns are available original
features count so we can see how many
features there are
um the length of it and we'll actually
have a list of them and then print just
the data head the top five rows
and so when we do this
we can see from the CSV file we have 25
original features
original features are your action type
combined shot type game event ID and so
forth there's a lot of features in here
that they're recorded on all of his
shots this is we talk about like a
massive amount of data I mean imagine
people are sitting there and they record
all this stuff and they import this
stuff for different reasons but
depending on what we want to look at do
we really want all those features
maybe the question we're going to ask is
what's the chance of him making any one
specific shot
um in right from the beginning we can
look at the some of these things and say
team name team name probably I don't
know maybe it does matter because the
other team might be really good at
defense uh game date maybe we don't
really want to look at the game date
team ID definitely not of importance in
any of this so we look at this we have
25 features and some of these features
just really don't matter to us we also
have location X location y latitude and
longitude I'm guessing that's the same
data we've actually imported the the
very similar data maybe they're slightly
zoned differently but as far as our
program we don't want to repeat data
some of the models when you repeat data
into them and this is true for most
models create a huge bias they weigh
that data over other data
so just at a glance these are the things
we're looking at we want to find out
well how do we get this these features
down and get rid of this bias and all
these extraneous features that we don't
really want to spend time running our
models on and programming on
as I pointed out there's a location x a
location y latitude and longitude let's
take a look at that and see what we're
looking at here we'll go ahead and
create a plot of these
and we'll just plot we'll do a scatter
plot of location X and location Y and
then we'll do a scatter plot of data
lawn data lat which is probably
longitude and latitude and the scatter
plot I'm just going to actually put a
little Title Here location and Scatter
on there and we'll just go ahead and
plot these and when you look at this
coming in
these two graphs are pretty identical
except they're flipped and so when we
look at the location from which they're
shooting from they're probably the same
and at this point we can say okay we can
get rid of one of these sets of datas we
don't need both X and Y and latitude and
longitude because the same data coming
in and as we look at this particular
data the latitude longitude we might
also ask does it really make a
difference which side of the Court
you're on whether you're on the left
side or the right side
and so we might go ahead and explore
instead of looking at this as
X Y we might look at it as a distance
and an angle and we can easily compute
that and you can see we can create our
data distance equals location X Plus
location y squared standard euclidean
geometry or triangular geometry
hypotenuse squared equals the each side
squared
and then once we've done that
uh we can also compute the angle so the
data angle is based on the arc tangent
and so forth on here so this is all this
is we're just going to compute the angle
here and then set that up pi over 2 to
get our angle
and we'll go ahead and run that
and you'll see some errors Run come up
and that's because when we took slices
over here we took a slice of a slice
there's ways to fix that but it's really
not important for this example so if you
do see that you want to start looking up
here for
instead of data location X of
not location x0 this would be like um I
believe the term is ilo.i location if
this was yeah this is in pandas uh so
there's different things in there but
for this it doesn't really matter these
are just warnings that's all they are
and then let's combine our remaining
minutes and seconds column into one uh
there's another one so if you remember
up here we're trying to get rid of these
columns
do we really need let me see if I can
find it on here there we go there's our
minutes remaining
um and then they had
what was it it was uh minutes remaining
and seconds column so there's also a
seconds column on here
and find that one this is where it
really gets kind of crazy because here's
our seconds remaining so you can see
that here's our minutes remaining this
gets crazy when you're looking at
hundreds of these features and you can
see that if if I'm gonna say um
write a model that's going to predict a
lot of this and I want it to run in this
case it's a basketball and how good his
shots are as the data comes in them
let's say I want to have it run on your
phone if I'm running it across hundreds
of features it's going to just hang up
on your phone where if I can get it down
to just a handful
um we'll actually be able to come in
here and run it on a smaller device and
not use up as much memory
or processing power so we'll go ahead
and take data remaining time here
and data minus remaining times 60 plus
data seconds remaining so we're just
going to combine those and we'll go
ahead and reprint our data so we can see
what we got
um
coming across we have our action type
combined and this is we do this a lot we
want to take a look at oops I got so so
zoomed in let me see if I can zoom out
just a little bit
there we go
boom
all right so we come up here you can see
that we now have our distance our angle
remaining time which is now just a
number uh that computes both the minutes
and seconds together
and we still have we've been adding
columns I thought you said we're
supposed to subtract columns right
um we're going to delete the obsolete
columns when we get to them so we're
just filtering out and then this is the
filter method we're just filtering
through the things that we really
don't need and next let's go ahead and
explore team ID and team name let me
just go ahead and run that and if you
look at this we have Los Angeles Lakers
and then they have the team ID here and
they're unique it's not that's not
really anything that's going to come up
because that's this particular athletes
works for that team so it's the same on
every line so there's another thing we
can filter out on there team ID and
tname is just useless the whole column
contains only one value each and it's
pretty much useless
let's go ahead and take a look at
matchup and opponent that's an
interesting one and we see here that we
have the Lal versus por and the opponent
is POR and IND
again here's a lot of duplicate
information
so
this basically contains the same
information on here again we're
filtering all this stuff out and this is
because we're only looking at one
athlete this might change if you're
looking at multiple athletes that kind
of thing now these are easy to see but
we might have something that looks more
like this we might have something where
we're looking at the distance which we
computed and the shot distance are they
the same thing
and what we can do is we can plot that
and plot them against each other on here
and we see it just draws a nice straight
line and so again we're looking at the
same information so again we're
repeating stuff and we really don't want
to be running our model on repeat
information on here so again it contains
the same information so now let's look
at the shot Zone area shot Zone basic
shot Zone range
so now we're looking at the zones and
what does that mean and we'll go ahead
and do this also in a scatter plot in
this case we're going to just create
three of these side by side so we're
going to create our plot figure side 20
by 10 and then we're going to Define our
scatter plot by category feature and
we're going to do each one setup button
here give it a slightly different color
and so our shot Zone area is going to be
plot subplot 131 scattered 131 is how
that's read by the way
meaning that it's number one
um we have three across
and this is the first one down so one
one one our scatter plot by category is
going to be the shot Zone area we're
going to plot that
and then we're going to do the shot Zone
basic and then the shot Zone range and
each just push them through our
definition so each of those areas go
through and you'll see one three one one
three two one three three again it's a 1
by 3 setup and then it's just a place on
each one and so we look at this we can
see that these shots they map out the
same so it's very again redundant
information that should be intuitive
um when we're looking at this in this
color graphs
it kind of helps you start looking at
something you it's very intuitive like
this is and you start to realize that
some of this stuff you'll be looking for
in data you might not understand and
you'll see these circular patterns where
they match or they mostly match and you
start to realize when you're looking at
these that their repetitive data then
you want to explore them more closely
depending on what domain you're working
in so we we look at these and we look at
them and they look just like the regions
of the court but we already have stored
this information in angle and distance
columns so we've seen this image before
we go back up here and here's our the
similar image
and repeating that image is down here
and so let's go ahead and drop some of
this in this stuff uh so now let's drop
all the useless columns and we can drop
the shot ID team ID team name shot Zone
area shot Zone range shot Zone basic uh
the match up the longitude and latitudes
are putting that into distance seconds
remaining minutes remaining because we
combine that into one column
shot distance because we have just
distance on there location X location y
the game event ID game ID all this stuff
is just being dropped on here and we'll
just go ahead and loop through our drops
and this is a nice way of doing this
because as you're playing with this
um this kind of data
putting your list into one setup helps
uh because then you're just running it
through an iteration
and you can come back and change it you
might be playing with different models
and do this with models you might be
looking at all kinds of different things
that you can drop and add in as you test
these out and again we're working in the
filter method so this is a lot of human
interaction with the data and it takes a
lot of critical thinking to look at this
stuff and say what matches and what
doesn't and so we look at the remaining
features let me go ahead and just run
this
uh the original to the new count we had
25 features now we have 11 features you
can see that right there let me just
circle that there's our 25 and there's
uh old new now we're down to 11. so
we've cut it down to less than half
uh and you can just see
the actual different information on here
and the remaining time at this point we
filtered it through and then we'd move
into the next process which would be to
run our model on this
and maybe we would drop some of the
features and see if it runs better or
worse and what happens
uh that's kind of would be the next step
on there versus this is the filter setup
and that would be one of the other
setups depending on which algorithm you
use so that wraps up our demo on uh
filter the feature selection and going
through and seeing how these different
features are being repeated in this
particular in a basketball setup the
need for cost function comes in a number
of points one of them is that after
training our model we need to see how
badly our model is performing while
accuracy function tells us how well our
model is performing they do not provide
us with the Insight on how to improve
them better and when we're talking about
the training process I'm not talking
about you you train a model and then you
run this on there we're talking about
each time you train the model the model
itself is continually going through
iterations and finding a better solution
and hence we need a correctional
function which can help us compute when
our model is the most accurate
a cost function is used to measure just
how wrong the model is in finding a
relation between the input and the
output it tells us how badly our model
is behaving predicting consider a robot
which is used to stack boxes in a
factory
the robot might have to consider certain
changeable parameters called variables
which influence how it performs let's
say our robot comes across an obstacle
like a rock
the robot might bump into the Rock and
realize that's not the correct action it
will learn from this and next time it
will learn to avoid rocks hence our
machine uses variable to better fit to
the data the outcome of all these
obstacles will further optimize our
robot and help it perform color the
outcome acts as a cost function which
helps us optimize our variable to get
the best variables in fit our model the
outcome of all these obstacles will
further optimize a robot and help it
perform better the outcome acts as a
cost function which helps us optimize
our variable to get the best variables
and fit our models so to kind of
understand this we're going to look at a
linear regression model
and the cost function for linear
regression it uses a straight line to
fit the model this is done using the
equation for a straight line as shown
this should look familiar as your
euclidean geometry you have y equals ax
plus b where A and B A is a slope and B
is The Intercept in this case we'll call
it output equals a times input plus b
for the intercept
in the equation we can see there are two
entities which can have changeable
variables or variables we have a which
is the slope of the line and B which is
The Intercept on the y-axis
if at first the variables are not
properly optimized we get a line which
might not properly fit our model
and you can see this line as you draw it
through the data might give us a very
skewed setup it might predict one point
of data have a small error on a couple
of them and then a huge error on the
other four pieces of data going in
and this is when we start talking about
error we're looking more at numbers than
a single on off obstacle so it's more
regression you'll think regression
numbers if you've seen some of our other
videos
so we're looking at the numbers how can
we minimize the error and as we optimize
the values of our model for some
variables we will get the perfect fit
for our linear regression model the cost
function will be the minimum of the root
mean squared error of our model obtained
by subtracting the predicted values from
our actual values our cost function will
be the minimum of these error values and
you can see we have our output y equals
a input you could say a input X plus b
and so in this case they just went ahead
and left it as output well let's look at
the cost function the cost function J
equals 1 over n so we're summoning up
all of our
inputs
and it's based on what we predicted is
going to be so that was the output of
our formula minus the actual value that
we're looking for and we square that
for our linear regression model the cost
function will be the minimum of the root
mean squared error for a model obtained
by subtracting the predicted values from
the actual values our cost function will
be the minimum of these error values
when you think of this and you're
Computing this in on a computer like you
know my mind's trying to look at this
long formula it's not really that long
really you're you're adding them up one
at a time so that makes it a lot easier
your data comes in and you say hey this
is what the answer is and then it goes
back and says oh these are what the
answer was supposed to be
and then you can compute each line one
at a time and easily add them up to get
your cost function on there and we talk
about cost functions we certainly look
at that in the linear regression model
and there's a couple other ways to do a
linear regression model but certainly we
want to minimize the error and we look
at a cost function for our neural
networks neural networks are interesting
because they have multiple layers on
there
and a neural network is a machine
learning algorithm which takes in
multiple inputs runs them through an
algorithm and essentially sums the
output of the different algorithms to
get a final output
the cost function of a neural network
will be the sum of the errors in each
layer this is done by finding the error
at each layer first and then summing the
individual errors up to get a total
error the cost function of a neural
network will be the sum of errors in
each layer this is done by finding the
erities layer first the error function
will depend on the model used
at each layer and that's important to
note if you're working with neural
network it's based on the model used on
each layer so there's a whole other
level in here that we're not going to
address on neural networks maybe I'll
mention a little bit when we look at the
code down here in just a minute the
below function is for linear regression
model
so we have a cost function which equals
the sum of the actual minus the
predicted there's our error squared 1
over the number of observations
so if you have if you're if you have 100
points of data going in and you
calculate your actual values minus the
predicted values you have to divide it
by a hundred that way when you look at
the cost function over the next setup
they're very uniform and you don't end
up getting a bias on there
and so we can see here the cost function
equals one over n times I equals zero to
n of Y of I minus MX of I plus b squared
now when we're solving this uh we have a
gradient descent gradient descent is an
algorithm which is used to optimize the
cost function or the error of the model
it is used to find the minimum value of
error possible in our model when you're
writing code this comes up there isn't a
maximize function if you go into most of
like site kit learn a lot of the other
packages in Python they have a minimize
function not a maximize function because
we are expecting this that the error
will never be unlimited you're always
your error can go to zero it can't go to
negative Infinity
and so you are looking for the minimum
because you know it's not going to be an
open-ended formula when you look for
that minimum and so the gradient descent
can be visualized as a ball rolling down
a hill in this case the Bobble row to
the lowest point in the hill this point
can be taken as a point where the error
is leased for any model the error will
be minimum at one point and will
increase again after that the graph
shows the error in a model and again
this comes off of the fact that we're
squaring the error the error that the
best error you can have is zero but even
if you have like a negative error it
gets squared and so you have it's plus
or minus one it's not looked at as a
negative error and a plus error it's
just how far off are we from the the
least amount of error in gradient
descent we find the error in our model
for different values of input variables
you can see here we have our Error 1
listed there
this is repeated and soon we see that
the error values keep getting smaller
and smaller
this is repeated and soon we see that
the error values keep getting smaller
and smaller and it just keeps going down
until you find the bottom of our little
downward loop on our errors and so we
can take that and the air graph for
linear regressions is given this graphs
of attained using the cost function J
and you see the cost function J this
would look familiar now we have our
predict minus our actual squared and
we're summing it up over the total
number that we're Computing that under
we must reach the lowest point in the
graph this can be done by traversing the
graph from any point and moving to the
point where the error is lower now I
know this is a little repetitive but
this is going to make a sense why why
we're repeating here in just a minute uh
so as we keep going down the hill the co
the small difference between each errors
can be attained by differentiating the
cost function and subtracting it from
the previous gradient descent to move
down the slope
so here's our cost function of J and
then we go ahead and try new numbers and
the gradient descent is going to be our
difference in those and that's how we're
going to look at finding that new value
in there and if this is you know they
put it in the uh the differential of J
and the differential of theta so you
have Theta J minus Alpha times the
differential we're just looking at the
differences uh just a fancy way of
saying hey what's the difference of our
last last cost function minus the
difference of our new cost function and
so you get a gradient descent the
gradient descent uh full formula looks
like this with the the original
difference minus the new difference
summation and and as we continue to go
down we can continue to compute the
differences on there to find our new
values in the above equation Alpha is
known as learning rate it decides how
fast we move down the slope if Alpha is
large we take big steps now remember I
said we're doing a lot of repeating that
we're going down the slope and you're
going to see why we keep repeating that
and where the complications come in and
it's important to note that we have this
value in there of alpha hey how far are
we going to try on the next number are
we going to jump way ahead are we going
to take Little Steps you can see that
this happens we might completely miss
the least error point and our results
will not be accurate so that's one of
the dangers of High having a very high
alpha
and as you go down if Alpha is small we
take small steps and we may take a very
long time to reach the error point and
waste computational power to do it when
we're playing with this Alpha we might
be talking the difference between a
hundred iterations and 2 000 iterations
when you're talking a large neural
network and suddenly instead of solving
this in the course of an hour you're
looking at days processing time on your
computer so it's very this is a big deal
to start understanding how that Alpha
comes in and understanding your data and
how it all fits together
hence we need to optimize value for
Alpha to attain the correct minimum
error value so we want it to go down as
quickly as we can without missing where
we want to go
for neural networks each layer will have
a cost function and each cost function
will have its own least minimal error
value the error graph for neural
networks is showing and this gets
interesting because you'll see that we
have multiple minimal error areas that
come out from the neural network
and this is also true even on some of
our regular models are more complex that
when you look at a polynomial regression
model as opposed to linear where we're
fitting a curve versus a straight line
through the data you start having
multiple minimals and depending on where
we start we can arrive at different
value for the minimum error
we need to find the minimum value out of
all local Minima and you can see here we
have a global Minima and then the two
local Minima and depending on where we
start we can arrive at different values
for the minimum error we need to find
the global minimum value out of all
local Minima
and this can be a real challenge because
if you're looking at just one of those
Loops you run into the issue that you
don't know whether there's other
minimals Minima out there minimal values
and if one of those is the global
minimal value and so this can be quite a
challenge when we're programming and
writing these putting together these
different models is finding these
different points especially in a neural
network again it's not just a neural
network that has that come up that comes
up in a lot of regular Solutions in our
different regression models the gradient
is sent for a neural network is just a
differentiation of this cost function it
can be written as gradient descent
equals
the Theta J and then the differential of
J over the differential of theta cost
function J equals one over the total
number we're going to do and then you
sum up the total number of the
differences of the Y of I minus MX of I
plus b where m and b is your slope in
your intercept of your linear regression
model
the difference is is we're doing that
linear regression model across all the
different neural nodes and the different
layers and that's where you're summing
them all up on there and it still looks
very similar but it is done in a larger
scale the gradient descent for a neural
network is just the differentiation of
its cost function in the equation m is
the weight of the layer and B is a
constant called the bias
and you'll you'll see that a lot because
like in a neural network you might have
each node will have all the nodes from
above going into it so if you have 10
nodes going into it you have to add all
those nodes and they have a weight the M
value
and then the summation of all those
nodes going in all the values going in
from the above layer then has a bias in
there the bias weight that's in added in
and then you get the full you can see
down here we have the gradient Descent
of the differential of J and the
differential of theta equals the total
number
um
and I'm not going to go too detailed on
the actual formulas we'll show that in
the code a lot of times these formulas
are always being updated so when you're
writing code for this it's important to
know these formulas a little bit if it
comes up you can understand why it's
doing what it is but there's more than
one formula to compute this and so as
you start understanding these different
formulas you can start seeing how they
fit and how one works better than
another
these are the most basic formulas that
are currently used today and you can see
here we form a nice little Matrix with
the one over n of n of I of zero minus
two x of i y of I minus MX of I plus b
there's our linear regression kind of
set up right in the middle of the
formula
and then you have that with the 1 over 1
n of n of I equals zero minus two y i m
x i plus b so you're forming a matrix
out of it so as we continue looking at
gradient descent for neural networks in
the following picture we are Computing
the errors for each layer separately and
to this gradient descent will be applied
we also know that each layer has a
weight which is assigned to it
since we have our total error at the end
and here's those nodes I was talking
about you have your input layer goes
into a layer of algorithms you use the
error from those algorithms to program
each one of those nodes
and one of the things they're not
showing here is each input goes to each
one of the nodes to sum it so I guess in
this particular image the sum would be a
single node
and then you have your layers each layer
goes into lower layer and so forth until
you sum them up and you get a total
error on the end the weight will be
different for each node in each layer
consider a node in layer three the node
will have an output which may differ
from the desired output
uh so layer three has our predicted
versus our actual wanted output on there
and then we create a weight equals a new
weight as a value of the predicted
output depends on the way it applied to
the layer we can tweak it to get the
desired output we can similarly tweak
the weight of each node in the layer we
use gradient descent on the cost
function to get the best value of the
weights which is a variable in the cost
function using the corrected values of
the outermost layer we can tweak the
weight of the layer before that this
will help us minimize the error in the
second last layer too we keep using the
corrected weight of layer to further
tweak the weight of the layer before
that and get the desired output from the
network this is called back propagation
as we move backwards
so to kind of put that more in
perspective you have your output you
have your all of your inputs you know
maybe it's a picture with a million
pixels on it and you have a million
inputs and it comes out and says it's a
cat picture or dog picture so you might
have just one output
or maybe you have all your inputs and
you're trying to figure out what the
next predicted value for the stock
market is you have a number coming out
we look at that error at the very end
and we push it back to the layer right
before it and we kind of split it up
between all the nodes in that layer
and each one of those nodes computes an
error
then all of those nodes push back their
error to the layer before and so forth
that's what back propagation is as it
starts at the end and goes in reverse so
we've actually looked a lot of stuff
here as far as cost functions and neural
networks are probably the most labor
intensive as cost functions because
you're solving that cost function for
each layer and for each node in the
layer they're all working together so it
gets very complicated
but this cost function is the same we're
still looking at the same thing even in
a simple linear regression model so
let's go ahead and take a look at a demo
on a cost function
and I'm going to do this in Python
through I'm using the add account and
navigator to open up a jupyter notebook
in Chrome
I will go up here on our Chrome setup
and do a new Python 3 give it a moment
there
and so we're going to be looking at Cost
function
I'm going to rename that
and let's go ahead and start by just
importing our numpy
in our matplot library so we have a
little view of what's going on here
and then I have a data set that has a
just a bunch of random points on it kind
of
um we'll go ahead and just bring that in
this is a simple numpy load text because
we put it as a text file probably could
have put it as a comma separated file or
whatever and you can see it's just a
bunch of pairs of numbers we have
6 11 17 592 whatever on there and we can
take that list of numbers on there that
was pretty much randomly
uh set up on this
we'll go ahead and plot it so you can
see what we're looking at run
and I would probably spend a little bit
more time on here
um
playing with this to see what the
numbers are these are just random
numbers so you know don't write too much
into them there's nothing fancy going on
here they do kind of group along a nice
line that's what we're going to look up
at this graph and let me switch this
this is
sometimes we'll do graphs where we put
the x's in to make it very clear that
these are points on the thing but let's
just do a scatter plot on here
that's all this is if you looked at the
last one we had
we did a plot x y r x marker size 10.
this plot would normally do lines but we
change it to RX and we put a marker size
that's what gives it the nice little X's
but I like the scatter plot better so
we'll just do a scatter plot and you can
see the values kind of go from 5 to 22.5
0 to 25 on the y-axis and if we drew a
line through here
which is what we're going to be working
with this line would have a y-intercept
our B number and our slope M and we'd
want to just fit this with the least
amount of error between all this data
and so uh we're going to go ahead and
create
and bear with me on this just for a
minute this part gives just a little
confusing here oops I left a t off Theta
uh we're going to take our theta equals
our numpy zeros we're just going to
create a zero array and it's um two by
one so it's just one row that's too wide
and our new X numpy delete points not BS
one to one
insert new x01 axis equals one learning
rate equals zero initial initially b
equals zero and iterates fifteen hundred
times
what this means is that we're going to
start with a flat line that equals the
x-axis this is y equals 0 times X plus
zero there's our M there's our B there's
our slope there's our intercept
and the learning rate is going to be
looking at going 0.01 and its steps to
find the minimal error now we're not
talking this is the distance between
this line what it predicts which is
going to be very small here on this
point let me just
there we go you'll see this point here
here's the distance because right now we
have a flat line our Flat Line we just
draw that in there for you goes here and
we look at this the the squared value of
this difference here
versus the squared value of this
distance here the squared value of this
distance this distance
and we're going to look at all these
errors and so we look at all the sum of
these errors that is the error we're
looking at is the predicted which is all
going to be zero so we can just put 0
squared and the actual and actually did
this backwards so the action would be
here would be y Square y minus 0
squared
so why is our actual output and then
zero is our predicted output the first
time through because we set everything
equal to zero
usually you guess a little bit more in
the first one I would take when I write
a script on here it pulls the first two
data points in
so maybe pull these two data in and it
says okay here's our line with our first
two data points and then it starts
looking for then it goes through and
looks for the error on there
but this is fine we start with 0 1 here
and so let's go ahead and load this up
so we have our Theta which is going to
track the differences
it starts off with pretty much just a
simple
two points our first beta and our first
our first slope and our first intercept
and so we need to start putting together
a cost function
and again a lot of this stuff is in your
scikit learning packages to find
minimums and stuff like that
and so our cost function goes in here
and it says m equals the length of the
points we look at all our points y
equals delete points no BS so we're
going to kind of skip through on looking
at the why and how they compare and we
end up with a
let's see here we go if we look at next
one over two times n times numpy dot sum
this is just summing all of these values
up for us
and we have our numpy.power numpy
subtract numpy dot X Theta number be
such a powerful array it's just so fun
to play with it's a little hard to go
backwards and dissect this but this is
just our cost function on here it's what
we expected and what we're actually
going to get
and so when we come out we print this we
come out we look at this we go okay so
this has an error of 32 that's what that
number is that's just the first time
through the error is the summation of
all those lines to the x-axis on there
and we're going to go ahead and do theta
second equals numpy array
and it's going to be the same thing but
we're going to let me just run this
guessing at a second number based on the
first number and it gets an error of 54.
uh really this is telling us because
we're not doing we're not actually going
through the implementation of 0.01
remember up here we're going to iterate
learning rate of 0.01 we just went in
and said hey what happens if I take this
error up here and I adjust for it based
on this error what do I get well my new
error is 54. it actually got worse
that's why you need a gradient descent
when we play high low you might look at
it and just pick some random huge number
you end up with that kind of return on
there
and there's a lot of ways there's
actually a lot of math that can go into
this you might do something where okay
this is this error maybe we would try a
value on each side of that error that is
a quarter of it so there's some math in
here that they do when they do the
optimization inside kit which which
really does a good job zeroing in on
this but to understand it it's better to
go ahead and do an actual gradient
descent
and so we're going to go ahead here and
do cost history this is just kind of fun
uh equals the numpy zeros iteration and
then we have our Theta history
Theta second and so it's going to have
our first Theta oops
uh
yeah that's right Theta history which we
start out by just putting in the number
of iterations it's going to go down and
we're going to have our
Theta second
which is we're going to start stacking
on them and tracking them and that's
really not what we're interested we're
interested in the cost history
uh but it's kind of fun to generate
these values down here the cost history
is what we're looking at
and we start with iterating through the
total number of iterations that's what
we set up above which was what 1500 yeah
there it is 1500 so we're going to go
through 1500 uh iterations
we're going to do our production our
prediction which equals numpy dot
product X Theta second
so right here we're just creating what
we guess the new number is based on in
this case our Theta second
is our
is our slope on there that's why we're
doing the dot product
slope and intercept Theta second so we
create our new Theta Theta second minus
one half times the learning rate there's
our 0.005
times our x dot T dot product which is a
prediction minus y
now this code looks a little confusing
it's when you're digging through it and
you go back you'll see how the numbers
match up playing with numpy arrays in
itself is a lot of fun and once you
start playing with them looking at
somebody else's code is really hard to
do the guys in the back put this
together for me building your own code
just becomes like a very creative fun
challenge to see how it all fits and how
you flip the numbers around the dot t
means I'm transposing it in a numpy
array so I'm turning it from columns to
rows
and we're just going to take our Theta
history and our iteration
and create a Theta history and then
here's our temp cost this is the one
that's really important
it's going to be
1 over 2 times n number sum and we have
our numpy power numpy subtract numpy Dot
X Theta second of Y 2. so we're looking
at the cost of each
iteration on there and this form comes
from here where we're summing the all
the different values and finding our
error
and then we're adding it on to Theta
history and so here is our slope here's
our intercept and it just keeps guessing
for each one of these and we could look
at pieces of the history and you can see
it slowly changes on here a lot of times
I'll do something like this and just
look at the end of the data the last
oh let's look at the last 20.
run that in the last 20 you can see that
6210-3261 602 this becomes a five a zero
is kind of bouncing back and forth on
the slope and it kind of zeros in to the
630 down here six two nine six three oh
it gets closer and closer to this one
answer on there
uh but that's not the part we want to
look at the part we want to look at
is the there we go is the cost history
we want to take a look remember we're
dumping on here
um our temp cost and we're just going to
keep adding it on to the cost history so
let's go ahead and run that
there we go and you can see we have a
nice curve here and what you want to
notice on this curve what's really
important uh one of the things a lot of
programs look for would be the elbow
not as important on this particular
graph
and somewhere right around here
we jump from 800 to 1400 with almost no
improvement look how small this
Improvement is a lot of times this
Improvement as you get down to here is
less than the actual error that we have
coming off of it and so when you're
looking at statistics if my error
is something like this here's my error
um that means that these values right
here
supposedly are getting better but they
might not be
um so when you have when you start
looking at
um the uh
craziness of data coming in and how it
varies at some point you cut it off and
you say okay right here we got to cut it
off and you might actually find an
intercept here usually though on the
curve like this I would look around 800
to a thousand around a thousand you
really are just bouncing back and forth
between the bottom
and in this size of data that is Way
Beyond what this size of data would
actually be able to predict and that's
why that's why you look at these things
you want to know where where your points
are and there's a lot of algorithms to
guess where this best spot is
but as far as understanding
how we minimize the error you can see we
use a basic
setup to do our gradient descent to find
the minimal error finding that bottom of
our whoops that's a horrible yeah
finding that bottom of this graph right
here how close can we get to zero there
might be our zero line
so we've gone through a lot we have our
we went through a quick demo to show you
what that looks like and what's going on
and that minimized routine
using the most commonly used gradient
descent with a linear model
and we talked a little bit about how
that fits in with neural networks
pointed out that there's a global and
local minimals all important things to
understand when you start looking at
minimizing the error on the most common
used tools to train our models in our
machine learning tool in our machine
learning kits
we talk about the principal component
analysis we're going to cover
dimensionality reduction principal
component analysis what is it important
PCA terminologies and you'll see it
abbreviated normally as PCA principal
component analysis PCA properties PCA
example and then we'll pull up some
python code in our Jupiter notebook and
have some Hands-On demo on the PCA and
how it's used dimensionality reduction
dimensionality reduction refers to the
technique that reduces the number of
input variables in a data set
and so you can see on the table on the
right shows the orders made at an
automobile parts retailer the retailer
sells different automobile parts from
different companies and you can see we
have company bpacs isomax and they have
the item the tire the axle an order ID a
price number and a quantity in order to
predict the future cells we find out
that using correlation analysis that we
just need three attributes therefore we
have reduced the number of attributes
from five to three
and clearly we don't really care about
the part number I don't think the part
number would have an effect on how many
tires are bought
and even the store who's buying them
probably does not have an effect on that
in this case that's what they've
actually done is remove those and we
just have the item the tire the price
and the quantity one of the things you
should be taking away from this is in
the scheme of things
we are in the descriptive phase we're
describing the data and we're
pre-processing the data what can we do
to clean it up why dimensionality
reduction
well number one less dimensions for a
given data set means less computation or
training time that can be really
important if you're trying a number of
different models and you're rewriting
them over and over again and even if you
have seven gigabytes of data that can
start taking days to go through all
those different models
so this is huge this is probably the
hugest part as far as reducing our data
set
redundancy is removed after removing
similar entries from the data set
again pre-processing some of our models
like a neural network if you put in two
of the same data it might give them a
higher weight than they would if it was
just one so when you get rid of that
redundancy
it also increases the processing time if
you have multiple data coming in
space required to store the data is
reduced
so if we're committing this into a big
data pool we might not send the company
that bought it why would we want to
store two whole extra columns when we
add it into that pool of data
makes the data easy for plotting in 2D
and 3D plots this is my favorite part
very important you're in your
shareholder meeting you want to be able
to give them a really good clear and
simplified version you want to reduce it
down to something people can take in
it helps to find out the most
significant features and skip the rest
which also comes in in postcribing leads
to better human interpretation that kind
of goes with number four what makes data
easy for plotting you have a better
interpretation we're looking at it
principal component analysis so what is
it uh principal component analysis is a
technique for reducing the
dimensionality of data sets increasing
interpretability but at the same time
minimizing information loss so we take
some very complex data set with lots of
variables we run it through the PCA we
reduce the variables we know what the
reduced variable setup
this is very confusing to look at
because if you look at the end result we
have the different colors all lined up
so what we're going to take a look at is
let's say we have a picture here let's
say you are asked to take a picture of
some Toddlers and you are deciding which
angle would be the best to take the
picture from so if we come up here we
look at this we say okay this is you
know one angle we get the back of a lot
of heads not many faces so we'll do it
from here we might get the one person up
front smiling a lot of the people in the
class are missing so we have a huge
amount off to the right a blank space
Maybe from up here again we have the
back of someone's head
and it turns out that the best angle to
click the picture from might be this
bottom left angle you look at it and you
say hey that makes sense it's a good
configuration of all the people in the
picture now when we're talking about
data it's not you really can't do it by
what you think is going to be the best
we need to have some kind of
mathematical formula so it's consistent
and so it makes sense in the back end
one of the projects I worked on many
years ago
has something similar to the iris and if
you've ever done the iris data set it's
probably one of the most common ones out
there where they have the flower
and they're measuring the stamina in the
petals and they have width and they have
length of the petal
instead of putting through the width and
the length of the petal we could just as
easily do the width to length ratio we
can divide the width by the length and
you get a single number where you had
two
that's the kind of idea that's going on
into this in pre-processing and looking
at what we can do to bring the data down
the very simplified example on my Iris
petal example
when we look at the similarity in PCA we
find the best picture or projection of
the data points
and so we look down at from one angle
we've drawn a line down there we can see
these data points based on in this case
just two variables now keep in mind
we're usually talking about 36 40
variables almost all of your business
models usually have about 26 to 27
different variables they're looking at
same thing with like a bank loan model
we're talking 26 to 36 different
variables they're looking at that are
going in
so we want to do is we want to find the
best view in this case we're just
looking at the X Y
we look down at it and we have our
second idea PC2 and again we're looking
at the x i this X Y this time from a
different direction here for our E's we
can consider that we get two principal
components namely pc1 and PC2
comparing both the principal components
we find the data points are sufficiently
spaced in pc1
so if we look at what we got here we
have pc1 you can see along the line how
the data points are spaced versus the
spacing in PC2 and that's what they're
coming up with what is going to give us
the best look for these data points when
we combine them and we're looking at
them from just a single angle
whereas in PC2 they are less spaced
which makes the observation and further
calculations much more difficult
therefore we accept the pc1 and not the
PC2 as the data points are more spaced
now obviously the back end calculations
are a little bit more complicated when
we get into the math of how they decide
what is more valuable
this gives you an idea though that when
we're talking about this we're talking
about the perspective which would help
in understanding how PCA analysis works
we want to go ahead and do is dive into
the important terminologies under a PCA
and important terminology is our views
the perspective through which data
points are observed
and so you'll hear that if someone's
talking about a PCA presentation and
they're not taking the time to reduce it
to something that the average person
shareholders can understand you might
hear them refer to it as the different
views what view are we taking
Dimension number of columns in a data
set are called the dimensions of that
data set and we talked about you'll hear
features Dimensions
um and I was talking about features
there's usually when you're running a
business you're talking 25 26 27
different features minimal and then you
have the principal component new
variables that are constructed as linear
combinations or mixtures of the initial
variables
principle component is very important
it's a combination if you remember my
flower example it would be the width
over the length of the petal as opposed
to putting both width and length in you
just put in the ratio instead which is a
single number versus two separate
numbers projections
the perpendicular distance between the
principal component and the data points
and that goes to that line we had
earlier it's that right angle line of
where those Point how those points fall
onto the line important properties
important properties number of principal
components is always less than or equal
to the number of attributes
that just makes common sense you're not
going to do
10 principal properties with only three
features are you trying to reduce them
so it's just kind of goofy but it is
important to remember that people will
throw weird code out there and just
randomly do stuff with instead of really
thinking it through principle components
are orthogonal
and this is what we're talking about
that right angle from the line when we
when we do pc1 we're looking at how
those points fall on to that line same
thing with PC2 and we want to make sure
that pc1 does not equal PC2 we don't
want to have the same two principal
points when we do two points
the priority of principal components
decreases as their numbers increase
this is important to understand if
you're going to create
uh one principle
component everything is summarized into
that one component as we go to two
components the priority how much it
holds value decreases as we go down so
if you have five different points each
one of those points is going to have
less value than just the one point which
has everything summarized in it how PCA
works
I said there was more in the back end we
talk about the math this is what we're
talking about is how does it actually
work
so now we have understanding that you're
looking at a perspective
now we want to see how that math side
Works PCA performs the following
operations in order to evaluate the
principal components for a given data
set
first we start with the standardization
then we have a covariance matrix
computation
and we use that to generate our I Gene
vectors and I Gene values
which is the feature vector and if you
remember the I Gene Vector is like a
translation for moving the data from x
equals one to x equals two or whatever
we're altering it and the IGN value is
the final value that we generate
when we talk about standardization the
main aim of this step is to standardize
the range of the attributes so that each
one of them lie within similar
boundaries
this process involves removal of the
mean from the variable values and
scaling the data with respect to the
standard deviation
and you can see here we have Z equals
the variable values minus the mean over
the standard deviation
The covariance Matrix computation
covariance Matrix is used to express the
correlation between any two or more
attributes in multi-dimensional data set
The covariance Matrix has the entries as
the variance and the covariance of the
attribute values the variance is denoted
by VAR and the covariance is denoted by
Cove
on the right we can see the covariance
Matrix for two attributes and their
values
when we do a Hands-On look at the code
we'll do a display of this so you can
see what we're talking about and what
that looks like
for now you can just notice that this is
a matrix that we're generating with the
variance and then the covariance of x to
y
on the right side we can see the
covariance table for more than two
attributes in a multi-dimensional data
set
this is what I was talking about we
usually are looking at not just one
feature two features we're usually
looking at 25 30 features going on
and so if we do a setup like this we
should see all those different features
as the different variables
covariance Matrix tells us how the two
or more variables are related positive
covariance indicate that the value of
one variable is directly proportional to
the other variable negative covariance
indicate that the value of one variable
is inversely proportional to the other
variable that is always important to
note whenever we're doing any of these
matrixes that we're going to be looking
at that positive and negative whether
it's inverted or not
and then we have the Aging values and
the Aging vectors
iodine values and hygiene vectors are
the mathematical value that are
extracted from the covariance table
they are responsible for the generation
of a new set of variables from the old
set of variables which further lead to
the construction of the principal
components
I Gene vectors do not change directions
after linear transformation I Gene
values are the scalars or the magnitude
of the I Gene vectors
and again this is just chain
transforming that data so we're going to
change the vector B to the B Prime as
denoted on the chart and so we have like
multiple variables how do we calculate
that new variable and then we have
feature vectors feature vectors is
simply a matrix that has igne vectors of
the components that we decide to keep as
the columns
here we decide whether we must keep or
discard the less significant principal
components that we have generated in the
above steps this becomes really
important as we start looking at the
back end of this and we'll do this in
the demo but one of the more important
steps to understand
and so we have the PCA example consider
Matrix X within rows or observations and
K columns or variables now for this
Matrix we would construct a variable
space with as many dimensions as the
variable
before our Simplicity let's consider
this three dimensions for now
now each observation row of the Matrix X
is placed in the K dimensional variable
space such that the rows in the data
table form a swarm of points in this
space
now we find the mean of all the
observations and then place it along the
data points on the plot
the first principle component is a line
that best accounts for the shape of the
point swarm it represents the maximum
variance Direction in the data
each observation may be projected onto
this line in order to get a coordinate
value along the pc1 this value is known
as a score
usually only one principal component is
insufficient to model the systematic
variation for a data set thus a second
principal axis is created
the second principle component is
oriented such that it reflects the
second largest source of variation in
the data while being orthogonal to pc1
PC2 also passes through the average
point
let's go ahead and pull this up and just
see what that means inside our python
scripting
I'm going to use the Anaconda Navigator
and I will be in Python 3.6 for this
example I believe there's even like a
3.9 out
I tend to stay in 3.6 because a lot of
the models I use especially with the
neural networks are stable in 3 6.
and then we open up our Jupiter I'm in
Chrome and we go ahead and create a new
python 3.
and for ease of use uh our team in the
back was nice enough to put this
together for me
and we'll go and start with the
libraries the first thing I like to do
whenever I'm looking at any new setup uh
well you know what Let's do let's do the
libraries first we're going to do our
basic libraries which is matplot Library
the PLT from the matplot library pandas
our data frame PD numpy our numbers
array NP Seaborn for graphing SNS that
goes with the plot that actually sits on
matplot Library so the Seaborn sits on
there
and then we have our Amber sign because
we're in Jupiter notebook matplot
library in line the newer version
actually doesn't require that but I put
it in there either anyway just because
I'm so used to it
and then we want to go ahead and take a
look at the data
and in this case we're going to pull in
certainly you can have lots of fun with
different data but we're going to use
the cancer data set and one of the
reasons the cancer data set is it has
like 36 35 different features
so it's kind of fun to use that as our
base for this
then we'll go ahead and run this and
look at our keys
and the first thing we notice in our
keys for the cancer data set is we have
our data we have our Target our frame
Target names description feature names
and file name
so what we're looking for in all this
is let's take a look at the description
let's go in here and pull up the
description on here
I'm not going to spend a huge amount of
time on the description
because this is we don't want to get
into a medical domain we want to focus
on our PCA setup what's important is you
start looking at what the different
attributes are what they mean if you
were in the medical field you'd want to
note all these different things whether
what they're measuring where it's coming
from
you can actually see the actual
different uh measurements are taking
no missing attributes
let me page all the way to the bottom
and you're going to have your data in
this case our Target
and if you dig deep enough to the Target
let's actually do this let's go ahead
and print Target names
real quick here I always like to to just
take a look and see what's on the other
end of this
uh Target
names
run that
and so the target name is is it
malignant or is it B9 so in other words
is this uh dangerous growth or is it
something we don't have to worry about
that's the bottom line with the cancer
in this case
and then we can go ahead and load our
data and you know what let me go up a
just a notch here for easy of reading
sorry to get that just right I guess
I'll have to do uh so let's go ahead and
look at our data uh our we're going to
use our pandas
and we're going to go ahead and do our
data frame it's going to equal cancer
data columns equals cancer feature
equals feature names so remember up here
we already loaded the the names up of
our of the features in there what is
going to come out of this let me just
see if we can get to that
it's at the top of Target names
um that's just this list of names here
in the setup
and we can go ahead and run this code
and it'll print the head and you can see
here we have the mean radius the mean
texture mean perimeter
I don't know about you this is a
wonderful data set if you're playing
with it because like many of the data
that most of the data that comes in half
the time we don't even know we're
looking at we're just handed a bunch of
stuff as a data scientist going what the
heck is this and so this is a good place
to start because this has a number of
different features in there we have no
idea what these feature means or where
they come from we want to just look at
the data and figure that out
and now we actually are getting into the
PCA side of it as we've noticed before
it's difficult to visualize High
dimensional data we can use PCA to find
the first two principal components and
visualize the data this new
two-dimensional space with a single
scatter plot before we do this we need
to go ahead and scale our data
now
I haven't run this to see if you really
have to scale the data on this
but as just a general
run time I almost do that as the first
step of any modeling even if it's
pre-modeling as we're doing here in
neural networks that is so important
with PCA visualization it's already
going to scale it when we do the means
and deviation inside the PCA but just in
case it's always good to scale it
and then we're going to take our PCA
with the scikit learn uses very similar
process to other pre-processing
functions that come with scikit-learn we
instantiate a PCA object find the
principal components using the fit
method then apply the rotation and
dimensionality reduction by calling
transform we can also specify how many
components we want to keep when creating
the PCA object
and so the code for this
oops getting a little bit ahead let me
go ahead and run this code
uh so the code for this
is
from SK learn decomposition import PCA
PCA equals PCA and components equals two
and that's really important to note that
because we're only going to want to look
at two components
I would never go over four components
especially if you're going to demo this
with somebody else if you're showing
this to the shareholders
the whole idea is to reduce it to
something people can see
uh and then the PCA fit we're going to
is going to take the scaled data that we
generated up here and then you can see
we've created our PCA model with in
components equals two
now whenever I use a new tool
I like to go in there and actually see
what I'm using so let's go to the scikit
webpage for the PCA
and you can see in here here's our call
statement it describes what all the
different setups you have on there
probably the biggest one to look at
would be well the biggest one is your
components how many components do you
want which you have to put in there
pretty much and then you also might look
at the SVD solver it's on auto right now
but you can override that and do
different things with it it does a
pretty good job as it is
and if we go down all the way down to
um
there we go to our methods
if you notice we have fit we have fit
transform
nowhere in here is predict because this
is not used for prediction it's used to
look at the data again we're in the
describe setup we're fitting the data
we're taking a look at it we've already
looked at our minimum maximum we've
already looked at what's in each quarter
we've done a full description of the
data this is part of describing the data
that's the biggest thing I take away
when I come zooming in here and of
course I have examples of it down here
if you forget
um and the biggest one of course is the
number of components and then uh I mean
the rest you can play with
the actual solver whether you're doing a
full randomize there's different things
it does pretty good on the auto
and now we can transform this data to
its first two principal components
and so we have our xpca
we're going to set that equal to PCA
transform scaled data
uh so there we go there's our first
transformation
and let's just go ahead and print the
scaled data shape and the xpca data
shape
and the reason we want to do this is
just to show us uh what's going on here
we've taken 30 features I think I said
36 or something like that but it's 30.
and we've compressed it down to two
features and we decided we wanted two
features and that's where this comes
from we still have 569 data sets I mean
data rows not data sets we still have
569 rows of data but instead of
computing 30 features we're now only
doing our model on two features
so let's go ahead and plot these and
take a look and see what's going on
and uh
we're just going to use our PLT figure
we'll set the figure size on here here's
our scatter plot xpca X underscore PCA
of uh of one these are two different
perceptions we're using uh and then
you'll see right here C for color cancer
equals Target and so remember we have
zero we have one
and if I remember correctly zero was
malignant one was B9 so everything in
the zero column is going to be one color
and the other color is going to be one
and then we're going to use the plasma
map just kind of telling you what color
it is add some labels first principle
component second principle component
we'll go ahead and run this
and you can see here instead of having a
chart one of those heat maps with 30
different columns in it we can look at
this and say hey this one actually did a
pretty good job
of separating the data
and a couple things when I'm looking at
this that I notice is first
we have a very clear area or it's
clumped together
where it's going to be benign and we
have a huge area it's still clumped
together more spread out where it's
going to be malignant or I think I have
that backwards
and then in the middle
because we're dealing with something in
this particular case cancer we would try
to separate I would be exploring how to
separate this middle group out
in other words there's an area where
everything overlaps and we're not going
to have a clear result on it just
because those are the people you want to
go in there and have extra tests or
treat it differently versus going in and
saying just cutting into the can into
the cancers that the body absorbs it and
it dissipates versus uh actively going
in there removing it testing it going
through chemo and all the different
things that's a big difference you know
as far as what's going to happen here in
that middle line where the overlap is
going to be huge that's domain specific
uh going back to the data we can see
here uh clearly by using these two
components we can easily separate these
two classes so the next step is what
does that mean interpreting the
components
unfortunately with this great power of
dimensionality reduction comes a cost of
not being able to easily understand what
these components represent
I don't know a principle component one
looks represents or second principle the
components correspond to combinations of
original features the components
themselves are stored as an attribute of
the filtered PCA object and so we talk
look at that we can go ahead and do look
at the PCA components this is in our
model we built we've trained it we can
run that and you can see here's the
actual components it's the two
components have each have their own
array
and within the array you can see the
what the scores are using and these
actually give weight to what features
are doing what
so in this numpy Matrix array each row
represents a principal component and
each column relates back to the original
features
what's really neat about this is we can
now go in reverse
and drop this onto a heat map
and start seeing what this means and so
let me go ahead and just put this down
up here to get it down here
uh we'll go ahead and put this in here
we're going to use our DF comp data
frame and we do our PCA components
and I want you to notice how easy this
is uh we're going to set our columns
equal to cancer feature names
that just makes it really easy
and we're dumping it into a data frame
what's needed about a data frame is when
we get to Seabourn it will pull that
data frame apart in and set it up for us
when we want and so we're just going to
do the CIA the Seabourn heat map of our
data frame composition and we'll use a
plasma coloring
and it creates a nice little color graph
here you can see we have the mean radius
and all the different features along the
bottom on the right we have a scale so
we can see we have the dark colors all
the way to the really light colors which
are what's really shining there this is
like the primary stuff we want to look
at
so this heat map in the color bar
basically represent the correlation
between the various features and the
principal component itself
so you know very powerful map to look at
and then you can go in here and we might
notice that the mean radius look how how
on the bottom of the map it is
um on some of this uh so you have some
interesting correlations here that
change the variations on that and what
means what this is more when you get to
uh postscribe you can also use this to
try to guess as what these things mean
what you want to change to get a better
result hi everyone welcome to this
exciting session by simply loan today we
have a really interesting topic for you
in this video we'll be analyzing the
upcoming United States presidential
election using Twitter sentiment
analysis in Python
in the course of this session we will
understand in brief about the upcoming
election the candidates fighting the
2020 U.S election and throw light on the
result of the 2016 U.S election
we look at the election forecast by some
of the popular news agencies as well as
poll analysis websites such as 538
before we begin I want to make it clear
that this video is solely for learning
purposes
we at simply learned do not lean towards
any party in the United States or are
biased towards any candidate
the analysis is based on what people
have tweeted and we will understand the
modern sentiment of the public
the main objective of this video is to
help you understand how to extract
tweets from Twitter handles using python
libraries
store it in a CSV file and perform
textile analysis the results obtained
are purely based on the data that we
have collected
let's begin
the battle for the 2020 U.S presidential
election has begun with the 59th United
States presidential election scheduled
to be held on the 3rd of November 2020.
this will decide who will be in the
white house for the next four years
all 435 seats in the United States House
of Representatives 35 of the hundred
seats in the United States Senate and
Office of the President of the United
States will be contested
both the Republican party and the
Democratic party have nominated their
respective president and vice
presidential candidates
the incumbent president Donald Trump is
the Republican nominee
while the 47th Vice President of the
United States Joe Biden is the
Democratic party's nominee
the current vice president Mike Pence is
the Republican party's Vice Presidential
nominee and is running for a second term
in office
sanator Kamala Harris of California was
chosen by Joe Biden as his running mate
on 11th of August 2020. now
let's see the results of the last U.S
presidential election in 2016. the
Republican ticket of businessman Donald
Trump and Indiana Governor Mike Pence
had defeated the Democratic ticket of
former Secretary of State Hillary
Clinton and U.S senator from Virginia
Tim Kaine
Donald Trump received a total of 304
electoral votes while Hillary Clinton
got 227 electoral votes a significant
number of central states in the United
States were swept by the Republican
Party
it was surprising to see that Donald
Trump getting nearly 46.4 percent
popular vote as compared to Hillary
Clinton who got 48.5 percent votes
Donald Trump's Victory came after
crucial wins in the Battleground streets
of Florida Ohio North Carolina and
Pennsylvania
will Donald Trump be re-elected to the
White House or are we going to see a new
president and a vice president of the
United States is the big question
let's see what our pollsters have to say
and what has been their forecast for the
upcoming election according to 538
Donald Trump has not gained ground since
the final debate on 22nd of October
at this moment Joe Biden is favored to
win the election and he leads in both
National and State pools The Economist
is analyzing polling economic and
demographic data to predict the U.S
elections their model thinks Joe Biden
is very likely to beat Donald Trump in
the Electoral College as per their
forecast Joe Biden has 96 percent chance
of winning the Electoral College and
this 99 percent chance of Biden winning
the most votes the Democrats have 75
percent chance of controlling the Senate
while the Republicans have around 25
percent
the Democrats are highly likely to keep
their majority in the House of
Representatives now according to the
guardian Joe Biden is leading Donald
Trump in the National polls for the
presidential election
but to keep in mind this does not
guarantee the Democratic candidate Joe
Biden's victory
Hillary Clinton also had a clear lead
over Donald Trump in the polls for
almost the entire 2016 campaign she
ended up losing the electoral college
now the BBC forecast tells that Biden is
leading National presidential polls with
51 percent
he has hovered around 50 percent in
recent months and has had a 10 point
lead on occasions
so clearly Joe Biden is set to be the
next U.S president let's wait and watch
what happens on the 3rd of November the
voters of America will decide on 3rd of
November whether Donald Trump remains in
the white house for another four years
let's perform a tutor sentiment analysis
to understand the sentiments of people
tweeting about Donald Trump and Joe
Biden by tagging them in their tweets
we have our code implemented already
I'll run through each line of code and
explain our analysis in detail
the objective is to check the polarity
of each tweet to figure out if it's
positive negative or neutral we'll
compare the tweets of Donald Trump and
Joe Biden to see who people are favoring
the most
finally we learn to create a word cloud
I have already extracted the tweets and
stored them in two separate CSV files
it takes some time to fetch 10 000
tweets hence it won't be possible for me
to show it to you live
if you want to know how we extracted the
tweets for Donald Trump and Joe Biden
then please put your email IDs in the
comment section of the video we'll share
the code file and the source file with
you now you would need to install the 3p
Library fetch the Twitter keys and
access tokens and then authenticate the
Twitter API
I've extracted 5000 tweets each for
Donald Trump and Joe Biden converted
into a data frame and stored it in a CSV
file so let me open and show you both
the files
so here is my data set for Donald Trump
on the top you can see Trump underscore
data 5000 which means there are 5000
tweets here
the first column
has the number of tweets it starts from
zero and goes all the way to 499 the
next column is the text column which has
the content of the tweet
you can see
they have tagged at the rate real Donald
Trump
there are links as well there are
special characters like emoticons
and the third column is the user
which means
it's the username who had put that tweet
similarly I have another data for Biden
you can see these are
for Joe Biden
and here you can see the content they
have tagged Kamala Harris also
similarly we have the username now let
me take you straight to my jupyter
notebook where I have implemented the
code
okay so first and foremost let's import
all the required libraries so we have
the numpy library for numerical
computation then we have the pandas
library for data manipulation next we
are importing two libraries matplotlib
and c bond for data visualization
then we have text blob and word cloud
to get the sentiment and to build the
word cloud
and finally we are importing the plotly
library for creating graphs
let me run this cell
in the current cell we'll import the
data sets using read underscore CSV
function present in the pandash library
so I have passed in my location where
the data file is so I have placed it on
my desktop
and
the index underscore col parameter or
column parameter refers to the columns
to be used as the row labels of the data
frame here 0 indicates that the First
Column will be used as row labels
let me run it
okay now we have imported both the data
files
let me go ahead and
print the shape of one of the data
frames so I'll write print
let's say we'll check the shape of Biden
data frame so I'll write print Biden Dot
shape
I let shift enter
you can see there are 5000 rows and
there are two columns one is the text
column and the next column is the user
column
now let me
go ahead and print the head of the data
sets so the head function will return
the first five rows
I'll write
Trump
dot head
you can see these are the first five
rows from the Trump data frame and
similarly if you want to check for Biden
I can write Biden dot head
you can see it here
now you can also use the info method so
let me
show you that you can write drum dot
info
and this is the result so it tells there
are 5000 entries from 0 to 499 there are
two columns these are the number of
rows
and similarly you have the data types
okay moving ahead in the next cell I am
displaying the 200th tweet present in
the Trump data frame so I have my data
frame name mentioned then I have my text
column
and inside one more square bracket I
have put 200 which means I want to see
what's there in the 200th row if I hit
enter
so you can see this was the Tweet fake
fake president
next
let me show you
the Tweet number 1000 for Biden so I'll
write Biden
and inside square brackets I'll give the
text column and
the number is one thousand
for hit shift enter
so this is the tweet
now the text block function
is used in natural language processing
the sentiment property returns a named
Tuple in the form of sentiment
in Brackets polarity and subjectivity
let's check the sentiment of the 200th
to it made for Donald Trump
if I hit shift enter
you can see this was the polarity
now minus 0.399 means the polarity was
negative and you can see the
subjectivity is around
0.933
similarly
let's check for Biden's tweet number
so I'll write
text
blob which is my function name
and inside brackets I'll give Biden
then
pass in my column name that is text
and I'll give the row number which is
1000 and then I'll give the
parameter or the attribute sentiment
for hit shift enter you can see the
polarity and the subjectivity
now moving ahead
here
I have defined a function that will add
another column called polarity to our
two data frames Trump and Biden
let me run this
okay
in the next cell I have used the apply
function that will return the polarity
based on the tweets you can see we have
the apply function
this might take some time to run it okay
we are done now
Let Me Now display the top 5 rows of the
data frame so what I'll do is I'll click
on this cell go to insert and
I'll hit insert cell below
let's do one more
okay now here
I'll display the head of the data frame
once again so that you can see the
polarity column added
you can see it here so for Donald Trump
we have the polarity you can see the
tweet and the polarity now 0.0 which
means these are neutral minus is
negative and anything
that's in positive value
indicates it's a
positive tweet or it has positive
polarity
similarly let's see for Biden
I'll write biden.head
okay so here you can see the
polarity for Biden now this 0.5 means
it's a positive tweet
okay
now
I want to create another column called
expression where we will classify the
tweets as positive negative or neutral
based on the polarity value
so I have used the NP dot where function
and the condition we have here is if
polarity is greater than 0 it's a
positive tweet else if it is less than 0
it's a negative tweet and if the
polarity is equal to 0 it means it's a
neutral tweet
let me run this
okay so here you can see we have the
column called expression and it has
classified the polarity based on
negative neutral as well as positive
foreign ly let's do the same for Biden
data frame as well
okay
before moving ahead if you want to get
access to the source code and the data
sets we have used in this demo then
please put your email address in the
chat section we'll send it to you via
mail
also please subscribe to Simply learn
Channel and hit the Bell icon to never
miss an update from Simply alone
in the next cell of code we have another
function that will basically help us
creating a bar plot based on the
expression column from both the data
frames
so this is my user defined function name
and it has two parameters reviews and
title
you can see we have
grouped the expression column and found
out the count using the count function
then we have created or converted it
into a list
similarly
below you can see here
we have defined the color for the bars
using RGB values
now let me run it
okay
so we have successfully created our user
defined function
now let me go ahead and call the
function and pass in my two parameters
reviews and title so here we have the
function name and under reviews we have
the data frame name Trump and the title
we have given is analysis for Trump let
me run this
okay so you can see we have a horizontal
bar plot on the top you can see the
title of the plot which is analysis for
Trump
and
as per the tweets it has classified as
positive neutral or negative
if I hover over you can see there were
2831 neutral tweets
1211 positive tweets and similarly there
were
958 negative tweets for Donald Trump
now
let me call that function once again so
I'll write exp underscore graph
which is my function name
then I'll pass in my
parameters this time I'll take Biden and
the title I'll put is analysis
for Biden
if I run it
okay you can see the plot for Biden now
if I hover over there were 1290 positive
tweets for Biden and 747 negative tweets
okay
let's scroll down
now let me check the number of rows that
have polarity equal to zero
the number of rows that have polarity
less than 0 and greater than zero for
both the data frames using the dot shape
attribute so first we have
for Trump equal to equal to 0 means we
are checking the total number of neutral
tweets
you can see the result
now let's check for Biden we have the
result below
let me run it
okay
now
we'll drop those columns that have a
polarity equal to zero from both the
data frames and display the shape you
can see
we have the condition mentioned and we
have also used the draft function
so all the neutral treats will be
deleted
and I am printing the shape of the data
frame
there you go so out of the 5000 tweet it
has deleted all the neutral tweets or
dropped all the neutral treats and this
is the final result
in the current cell we have defined
another function called balanced
underscore data now this will help us
get an equal number of rows and columns
and delete a specified number of rows
let me run it all right
now I'll call that function to delete
169 rows from the trumps data frame and
37 rows from Biden's data frame this
will help us subset the data frames
you can see
we have now 2000 tweets from each of the
data frames
up next we'll create some visualizations
to analyze the textual data
so first I'm using the C bone library
and creating a distribution plot for
Donald Trump
if I hit shift enter
you can see this is the distribution
plot thus there are bars at the back and
there's a trend line
okay
similarly let me now create a box plot
so this is a box plot here you can see
there are some outliers
now let me add
a few cells below so that I can show
that plot for Biden
so I'll write SNS
Dot
I'll use the function dist plot
and under this plot I'll give
Biden underscore
subset
and
I'll pass in my column that is polarity
let me run it
so this is the distribution plot for Joe
Biden
and now
let me also create the box plot so I'll
use the c bond library and the box plot
function
I'll pass in my data frame which is
Biden underscore subset
and I'll give my column name that is
polarity
I'll run it
so here you can see the box plot for Joe
Biden
let me tell you how you can create a
cross table using the group by function
so before coming to this cell of code
let me insert cell above okay
Now using Group by function you can
create a cross table
so I'll use
the Trump underscore subset data frame
and then I'll give my group by function
and inside Group by function I'll give
my expression column
and I'll count the number of Expressions
if I run this
you can see this is a cross table
similarly you can do it for Joe Biden as
well
I'll just replace the names I'll write
Biden
and the rest is the same
you can see this is the cross table for
Biden underscore subset
now moving ahead
let's find the polarity percentage for
negative and positive tweets to do this
I have defined a function called
pole underscore percent and we have two
parameters declared subset and total
let me run this
okay
now here
I am calling the above defined function
and printing the polarity percentage for
Biden and Trump
and I have mentioned my two parameters
subset
and the total number
so these are the values moving ahead
now let's create a bar graph that will
show the negative and positive polarity
percentage for Donald Trump and Joe
Biden
let me hit shift enter
you can see we have a
really good bar graph now if I hover the
mouse cursor you can see Donald Trump
had
27.825 percent of positive tweets and
22.17 negative similarly Joe Biden had
31.6 positive tweets and
18.4 negative tweets
now we want to find the public sentiment
based on Trump and Biden tweets let me
run this two cells first
okay
now for Donald Trump the total positive
polarity is a combination of Trump's
total positive percentage and Biden's
negative percentage
similarly
for Joe Biden the total positive
polarity is a combination of Biden's
total positive percentage and Trump's
negative percentage
let me run this
you can see the result here
next
let's plot a horizontal bar graph to
visualize the public sentiment
we have our accent y labels defined we
also have set our bar colors with the
help of RGB values and we have the title
as well
now if I go up you can see this is the
public sentiment so 26.88
is the percentage that is in favor of
Joe Biden and for Donald Trump you have
23.11
coming down
now in the next cell of code
we have a user defined function that
will basically plot a table which has
the most positive tweets for Donald
Trump and Joe Biden the condition we are
checking is that the polarity should be
equal to 1 so if it's close to 1 or
equal to 1 which means
the Tweet has positive polarity
let me run it
okay
now let me go ahead and call the
function now
let me scroll over to the top
you can see
these are the top five positive tweets
for Donald Trump and
here you can see the top five positive
tweets for Joe Biden
likewise
let's check the polarity for most
negative tweets here the condition will
be the polarity should be equal to -1
which means it's highly negative
let me run it
okay
now let's go ahead and call the function
negative tweets so I'll write neg
underscore tweets
and then inside bracket I will give my
parameters
which is Trump underscore subset
and then
I'll give my title as
negative
tweets
for
Donald Trump
okay now I'll just copy this
will also check for Joe Biden so I'll
just replace this with
Biden and let's say
negative tweet for Joe Biden
let's run it
okay if I go on top here you can see
the top
negative tweets for Donald Trump and
similarly we have the
top five negative tweets for Joe Biden
all right
finally
let's see how to create a word cloud
now word cloud is a method to show which
words are most frequently occurring
among the given text I have defined a
function called word cloud you can see
here and it has two parameters data and
title
inside
the built-in function or the word cloud
function we have mentioned the max font
size
the maximum words scale value there's
also background color which is white
okay
let's run it
now this will create
a word cloud
so let me go ahead and
call the word cloud function and pass in
the arguments
so I'll write word cloud which is my
user defined function
and I'll give my parameters
Trump underscore subset
comma I'll give my title as
word
cloud
for
Donald Trump
let's see Donald Trump tweet
replies
okay
similarly
let's
do it for Joe Biden
write word cloud
Biden underscore subset
and then I'll give the title as
word
cloud
for
Joe Biden
to it replies
okay
let me run it
there you go
you can see we have a nice word cloud
so on the top you can see the title
which says word cloud for Donald Trump
tweet replies
so here you can see
some of the words like real Donald Trump
then there's president
love right
all these
similarly if I scroll down you can see
the word cloud for Joe Biden tweet
replies you can see this is the handle
Joe Biden Falls there are some other
words like due taxes believe even will
it's fact
and you can see Kamala had his name here
okay now that brings us to the end of
this demo on Twitter sentiment analysis
using Text data you learned how to
classify tweets and find the polarity
we also looked at how to create
interesting visualizations
with this data and understood the mood
of the public
finally you saw how to create a word
cloud that had the most frequently
occurring words in the tweets data
science is completely transformed all
major business sectors including it
banking
Healthcare Entertainment Sports and much
more in order to improve customer
service and their financial results
businesses all over the world have long
gathered and analyzed data about their
customers the global data science
platform Market was worth 3.93 billion
US dollars in 2019 and 4.89 billion US
dollars in 2020. from 2020 to 2027 the
market will be expected to increase at a
compound annual growth rate of 26.9
percent due to this huge usage and
demand of data science more and more
folks are trying to get into data
science as a career today in this video
we will assist you on how to switch
career to data science so stick with us
till the end of this video to understand
each and every step required to get into
data science but before moving on let me
ask you a quick question which of the
following is the most appropriate skill
set for a data science
probability and statistics machine
learning or deep learning data wrangling
or all of the above
please leave your answer in the comments
section below and stay tuned to get the
answer so first let's understand what
exactly data science is
given the enormous volumes of data being
generated today data science is one of
the most hotly contested topics in the
it Community data science methodologies
are being used by businesses to expand
their operations and it is used in a
wide variety of Industries including
marketing Healthcare finance and banking
data science is a field of study that
deals with massive amounts of data
utilizing contemporary Technologies to
uncover hidden patterns obtain valuable
information and make business decisions
building predictive models with data
science requires sophisticated machine
learning techniques like statistical
skills data visualization skills
analytical skills Etc one thing we've
observed about the jobs is the
similarity in how the job roles are
described you might be unable to
distinguish between the numerous data
science job profiles even though most
recruiters use the appropriate
description because of this you might
apply for the wrong jobs and miss the
good opportunities due to the confusion
between the work role and the job
description so let's understand each job
role in detail first up we have business
analyst business analysis is the process
of identifying a company's needs by
executing tasks and using specialized
approaches to require Insight from the
data
these experts analyze business processes
identify business requirements and give
data-driven reports and suggestions to
leaders and stakeholders in The Firm
next up there are data analysts the data
analyst is a specialist whose analysis
and problem-solving focus on data data
types and connections between data
elements in a business system
data analysts serve as a bridge between
data scientists and business analysts
they take the technical analyzes and
turn them into qualitative action items
coming to database oriented roles we
have database administrator
data like Financial records and customer
shipment history are stored and
organized using software by a database
administrator
a database administrator ensures that a
company's database and any related
applications run effectively and
functionally
next up we have data architect
data Architects are it Specialists who
utilize their knowledge of computer
science and database architecture to
assess and analyze an organization's
data infrastructure create future
database plans and put into practice
ways to store and manage data for both
businesses and their users
moving on to data engineer the
development deployment management and
optimization of the company's data
infrastructure and data pipelines is the
main emphasis of data Engineers by
assisting with data transport and
transformation for queries Engineers
assist data scientists and last but not
the least we have data scientists a data
scientist is someone who does
statistical analysis Data Mining and
data retrieval operations on large
amounts of data in order to find Trends
and information useful to an Enterprise
data scientists typically evaluate the
data in order to make the best business
decisions so which data science role do
you fancy let us know in the comments
each job role offers a unique chance to
develop a particular set of data skills
for example in business analytics you
will learn some technical skills such as
SQL Perl power bi and tableau some
interpersonal skills such as
presentation and negotiation skills and
some analytical skills such as Gap
analysis financial planning
documentation data reviewing and so on
then as a data analyst you learn how to
get insights convey important findings
and develop data-driven Solutions you
will learn python SQL and statistics
as a data scientist you'll be tasked
with real-world data science projects in
the field you'll learn how to run data
pipelines plan experiments and create
recommendation systems while developing
efficient machine learning models
as a data engineer you will work with
big data design data models construct
data lakes and warehouses and automate
data Pipelines
before we discuss how to switch from
another job profile to a data science
one consider subscribing to our Channel
we create informative videos like these
on a regular basis so hit the Bell icon
to not miss out on any new videos now
let's talk about switching from another
job profile to data science
to switch from some other job profile to
a data scientist profile you must
possess some good database skills in any
classical rdbms including at least SQL
programming for example MySQL postgre
SQL Oracle and SQL Server you need to
understand how to use your mathematical
background to address actual business
difficulties in addition to all of this
you'll need a solid grasp of simulation
statistical inference and appropriate
data visualization
you can also study these topics
algorithms for machine learning linear
algebra and intermediate statistics and
probability
let's now look at the skills required to
become a data scientist
skills needed to become a data scientist
statistics and Mathematics deep learning
big data or data engineering data
visualization programming machine
learning
besides these you will require some tool
expertise SQL python Tableau XL so the
answer to the question at the beginning
of the video regarding the most
appropriate skill for a data scientist
is option D all of the above so these
were some of the skills that you need or
can learn to become a data scientist
now let's understand some ways to level
up your skills in data science
how to level up your skills
Master relevant skills the two most
important programming languages for data
science are Python and R give these two
languages your whole attention first the
next is mathematics
mathematics executing algorithms also
requires an understanding of probability
Theory and statistics moving on to
practice real world case studies
the case studies in data science center
on actual technical problems that
businesses are now experiencing having
experience resolving such case studies
will undoubtedly Aid you in developing
your career in the real world
next up we have maintain contact with
data science leaders it is always
thought to be a wise idea to seek
counsel from an expert who has
previously attained Mastery in the field
of data science you may do it by
connecting with data science experts via
websites and services like LinkedIn
another fantastic strategy for achieving
your organization's objective is to
enroll in a data science program to
reinvent tomorrow's Enterprises now
let's understand about the networking
you need to create which will help you
in switching your career to data science
so first we have Meetup and conferences
meetups and conferences are excellent
locations to network with other aspiring
data scientists you may meet established
data scientists at some of these events
network with them and even learn about
unannounced job openings
next up we have knowledge Discovery in
data science a major data science
conference is called knowledge Discovery
in data science it is also a group that
works to promote the study and teaching
of the science behind data science and
at last but not least we have LinkedIn
you can find some profiles of
established data scientists who work at
organizations that are presently hiring
and who appear to share your technical
interests more than just the fact that
you both work in data science you can
uncover things that you have in common
with them so these were some ways to
help you switch your career to data
science a variety of job opportunities
will become open to you once you have
mastered these skills so which profile
are you targeting now that you have
every detail let us know in the comments
below who is a data science engineer are
you a data science engineer or are you
going to be looking for a different
field what exactly is a data science
engineer well a data science engineer is
someone who has programming experience
and Python and our expert level
knowledge ability to rate proficient
codes and the we have Python and R I'm
going to say python or R once you become
really proficient at one language
transferring those skills into another
one is usually fairly easy now R is a
little different because it is an
analytics platform so going from python
to R if you already know the data
analytics in Python moving to R is
pretty easy now R doesn't have all the
other code that you can access with
python there's so many things you can do
with python that that are not data
analytics so that's important to keep in
mind that you should probably be pretty
well-rounded in Python and really have a
solid foundation in r or have a solid
foundation R and be well-rounded in
another programming language where you
really get the programming side of it
strong SQL and Big Data experience so
you have to have a strong coding skill
with Hands-On Big Data experience and of
course we're showing SQL here most
commonly used whether you're using a
Microsoft SQL server or MySQL server you
can also start thinking Hadoop and Spark
in Big Data access Hadoop file system is
not a huge jump if you've already
learned your SQL and you've already
learned your basics in coding Hadoop
sits on top of all that and does a
wonderful job creating huge clusters of
data but you really need to know your
SQL because that is so common in most of
the large companies now accessing their
data and an ability to visualize models
and troubleshoot code of the models this
is a kind of an interesting one because
these models are can get very
complicated so you got to be able to
break them down into something that you
can put the pieces together and digest
each of the pieces so being able to
visualize these models is very important
and then being able to drill down and
troubleshoot the different models or the
pieces in those models they need to be a
versatile Problem Solver equipped with
strong analytical and quantitative
skills a self-starter with a strong
sense of personal responsibility and
Technical orientation this is an
interesting one because when you talk
about data science engineer it's such a
new field that most companies don't have
it well defined they don't know what
they're looking for you might not even
know what you're looking for you might
have an idea and you're looking for
patterns but where do those patterns
lead you so you really need that
self-starter side to jump in there and
figure out where to go and be able to
communicate that back to the team and
there we go we have a strong product
intuition data analysis skills and
business presentation skills and this
was talking about is you got to bring
that back to the team so if you don't
have a strong product intuition if you
don't know what's going on with the
company what they need and where you're
going with your analysis it's going to
be a dead end and you got to be able to
present that to the shareholders to your
co-workers which leads us to Great
teammate with excellent interpersonal
skills and this is kind of a strange one
because you spend so much time behind
your desk so you have to be able to kind
of float between you're studying all the
data and being able to explain this to
people in simple terms that they can
understand no one wants somebody to come
up and say yeah the Peace Corps and the
F score is this that and the other thing
and you might have two people in the
room understand you you have to be able
to sit down and explain what that means
and why so let's take a look at the data
science skill set we talk about data
science engineer skill set we're talking
about database knowledge statistics
programming tools data wrangling
probably the least favorite and most
used machine learning data visualization
and then the touch on big data and so
we'll start with database now knowledge
the most common databases of course your
SQL structured query language think rows
and columns it's an essential language
for extracting a large amount of data
from data sets so knowledge of the SQL
is mandatory for data science engineers
and you can see there's tools required
there's the Oracle database I mentioned
MySQL server Microsoft SQL Server
teradata there are so many different
forms of SQL and it'll just keep coming
back and coming back so if you don't
have a solid basic understanding of SQL
go get it very important because it will
come up you know it's if you don't know
it it's going to bite you in statistics
of course we are you know that's what
this is all about is figuring out and
predicting things so you need to know
your statistics statistics is a subset
of mathematics that deals with
collecting analyzing and interpreting
data therefore data scientists needs to
know statistics so you need to
understand your probabilities and what
that means and what the p-score means in
the F score and means and mode and
median all that information standard
deviation all of those you need to be
aware of and then we get into the
programming tools and I mentioned this
earlier a little bit but you need to
master any one of these specific
programming languages programming tools
such as R python SAS are essential to
perform analytics in data and again you
know you can move in there and you can
be an expert in just R you can be an
expert in just SAS in a little bit you
can be an expert in Python because most
of these when we're talking about data
science and data wrangling you really
kind of get down to the point where you
really need to have a full programming
language at least a Basics and if you're
going to be working in data science
python right now is the main one but you
know there's also Java C plus plus so
you need to know a solid language at
least the basics of it so you can
understand how to do basic iterations
and things like that I always found that
interesting that my sister who runs a
university data analytics Center that's
the first question she asks for people
candidate to come and work for is how
how do you iterate through data you'd be
amazed at how many people don't
understand that very basic concept in
programming so when we look at r r is a
free software environment for
statistical Computing and graphs
supports most machine learning
algorithms for data analytics like
regression Association clustering and
Etc python python is an open source
general purpose programming language and
there's our general purpose I was just
talking about you need to know a little
bit about python libraries like numpy
and scipy are used in data science site
Pi yeah numpy inside Pi are very Central
to Python and I'd throw pandas in there
also that module those are very Central
to working with python and data
analytics and then SAS SAS can mine
Ultra manage and retrieve data from a
variety of sources it can perform
statistical analysis on the data so
where R is the open source platform SAS
is more like the paid for platform and
so it has some things more automated
because people are paying for it
developing it but it's also if you
really start using it as a company
you're gonna have to pay for it where R
is resource is a free software Python's
also open source and free to use so
we're going to talk a little bit about
data wrangling and I mentioned earlier
that is uh both the probably people's
least favorite aspects of data science
and also probably one of the places you
spend the most time so when we talk
about data wrangling it is a process of
transforming raw data into an
appropriate format to make it useful for
analytics and it involves cleaning raw
data structuring raw data and enriching
raw data and this gets interesting
because you'll get stuck on something
like in Python you might get stuck on
something that is a date time based on
an integer 64 numpy set you might not
know what all those terms mean because
you work in r or something like that but
you get the point that it's all one
particular format and then you have to
figure out how to switch it so that the
computer can see it correctly in
whatever format you're using or whatever
analytics platform you're using
knowledge of machine learning techniques
such as supervised machine learning
decision trees linear regression K and N
Etc is useful for few job roles so this
is kind of interesting because sometimes
that's the center of the job role of a
data scientist and sometimes you just
have to be able to apply the programming
skills to it so you can get the answer
and let somebody else fine-tune your
machine learning techniques so it really
depends on what it is you're working
with and you can see here we have our
nearest neighbor setup where it groups
things together that look alike linear
regression you're drawing a line through
the data or curve so you can predict
what the next value is going to be and
then our nice decision tree would start
splitting things up and says you know
it's sunny out yes let's go swimming no
it's raining we're not going to go
swimming yes it's sunny out we might go
swim it's raining uh we'll stay indoors
yes we'll walk the dog no so you have a
decision tree that helps figure out how
you get to the end result so decision
trees can be pretty powerful and data
visualization data visualization is the
study and creation of visual
representation of data data
visualization uses algorithms
statistical graphs plots information
graphics and other tools to communicate
information clearly and effectively this
one you really have to master as a data
science this one you really have to
master as a data scientist and there
certainly are so many different tools to
use to visualize it but when you're
communicating a picture is worth a
thousand words when you can put a
picture up in and people can look at and
go oh I see what's going on that's worth
a lot more than saying yeah yeah this is
good people hear that and they just kind
of go okay it's good but why and you
might say you know okay these numbers
make it look good no people want
something they can see and there
certainly is uh Tableau is probably one
of the most popular ones out there calic
view power bi Google data studio in
Python there's the pi kit and Seaborn
there's all kinds of different options
for visualization you need to master
probably at least one or two of them so
you understand how they work and how
they're different and then Big Data big
data is a massive amount of data which
cannot be stored and processed using
traditional methods big data has various
benefits like access to social data can
enable organizations to tune their
business strategies Big Data can improve
customer experience uh and so we're
usually when you say big data we're
almost always talking about Hadoop and
Apache spark it used to be Hadoop as
your file system so that's how you store
all your data going across the nodes and
there certainly are other ways to store
it when we talk about Hadoop we're
usually talking about at least 10
terabytes of data when you're dealing
with a Hadoop file structure and then
you can use spark where Hadoop processes
on and off the hard drive so it's
continually reading and writing to the
hard drive spark is running in your RAM
and so when you're doing a very
intensive data process you'll run a
spark setup which will spread those
process processes over multiple
computers and of course now the two
combine and Spark sits on top of Hadoop
and you get your big data there's also
Talent tablu has its own server set up
there's Splunk Cassandra you'll hear the
Cassandra database pentahoe I'm not even
sure how to pronounce that one it's not
one I've worked with certainly there's a
lot of options for Big Data the two big
players are of course Hadoop and Spark
and even your SQL servers and MySQL
servers will spread across five
different servers and you can be talking
about Big Data across five servers with
those pulling them into say Apache spark
to do your high-end processing and then
there's non-technical skills probably
the most important one in data science
in any of our data analytics is
intellectual curiosity updating
knowledge by reading contents and
relevant books on Trends in data science
this is such there's so much going on in
this field and it's exploding now that
it's hard to keep track of it all so you
really need to have that Curiosity in
the data science probably even more so
than a lot of other fields but I would
say in just today's world you need
intellectual curiosity because things
are changing so rapidly in today's world
the way that's going with our technology
understanding how the problem solved can
impact the business business Acumen this
is the one where a lot of people kind of
skip over you have to have a little
business sense if you don't know how
it's going to impact the business you're
going to be in trouble why do they want
to even pay you to be there unless they
know what's going on and they're getting
something in return so this is your
bottom line for your paycheck is what's
going on with the business how is this
going to impact the business what are
you doing for them and communication
skills companies look for someone who
can clearly and fluently translate
technical findings to a non-technical
team and I've talked about this a bunch
and I I can't even iterate this enough
if you are struggling with your
communication skills work on building
them they don't have to be you know this
isn't rocket science where you have to
know all these complicated terms what
you need to do is take the complicated
terms you know from data science and
reduce that down to something that
anybody can understand so when you come
up and you have you know knnn no one
knows that k n is you know unless
they're in data science nearest neighbor
looking for things that match together
you got to explain that to people who do
not have the technical skill in the data
science Arena and a data science
engineer needs to work with everyone in
the organization including customers so
it's teamwork and that's always one that
throws people for a loop But ultimately
you are analyzing your customers
information and so sometimes getting in
there and rolling up your sleeves if
you're let's say you're doing data
analysis for the sales team and you're
backing a sales team you might have to
get in there and go start making some
cells and making some phone calls and
see what it's like what is that team
doing when they call 15 people in cold
calls and then they do a follow-up two
weeks later or three weeks later which
one works better two or three does it
work better to call and send a fax call
and send an email you know when you
should you show up in person if it's
that kind of business so working with
everybody including the customers very
important with the data with this kind
of setup and non-technical skills for a
data scientist so let's take a look at
some of the roles a data science plays
in the job market let's drill in there
just a little bit here so when you have
a data scientist they're going to
perform predictive analysis and identify
Trend and patterns that can help in
better decision making companies hiring
data scientists include Apple Adobe
Google Microsoft I would say that's even
expanding down to smaller companies you
know where you're talking about only 100
employees or something like that they're
starting to look at data scientists
because they need them to come in and be
a part of that team and the rule is
understanding challenges of a system and
offer best Solutions this should always
be the goal of a data scientist is to be
looking at the whole system and then
trying to find those patterns that are
going to best enhance the the company or
the business or the whatever group maybe
you're working with the sales team or
the marketing team and you can see
languages pretty important to have a
these are a number of different
languages and again it depends on your
own specialty there's all kinds of
different variations but we have our SAS
python Matlab SQL Hive Pig spark you
should have at least a knowledge of all
of these maybe a python programmer never
used our download it go through the
basics so at least you know what's going
on in R versus python because R is
pretty powerful for doing a very quick
display and then of course a lot of
things you can do in Python you have to
be able to do queries on database from
time to time create and modify
algorithms which can be used to reduce
information from large databases and
usually this is one of those things you
do at the beginning you set it up and
then you kind of Let It Go Until It
Breaks and you have to go back and fix
it because your query isn't working that
certainly is a very common thing to to
have happen especially if you're pulling
data off the web and the internet and
then we have some more companies that
are hiring analysis like IBM DHL HP and
so we're talking about data analysis the
role is responsible for a variety of
tasks such as visualization optimization
and processing large amount of data and
so we're talking about a data analyst
we're also we're still talking a lot of
the same stuff which you'll see we now
thrown in JavaScript and HTML in here
because that's pretty common with the
data analyst versus a data scientist and
you can see that SQL is still pretty
solid and also CC plus plus is pretty
big so some companies also use Java so
I'd put Java in the languages also on
that for a data analyst and then you
have a data architect ensuring that data
Engineers have best tools and systems to
work with and so companies hiring a data
architect are like Visa Logitech
Coca-Cola they create blueprints for
data management with the best security
measures I cannot highlight that a data
architecture really spends a lot of time
with security measures that's big how
many hacks have we seen in the last year
on large companies have lost data for
millions of their customers and how
badly that affects them and we're
looking at languages as you see that SQL
is pretty solid across all of these
under a data architect XML that's one
that a lot of the data science jobs
don't really you don't see as much but
you're going to see more XML with a data
architect because there's a lot of XML
files that are that have your security
measures embedded in them and of course
your hive Pig those are Hadoop systems
for doing some basic queries so instead
of doing the high-end queries you know
how these simplified query systems built
into Hadoop and Spark so if you're using
big data you're going to want to know
your spark also and then we have our
data engineer the data engineer updates
the existing systems with better version
of the current Technologies to improve
the efficiency of the databases think
admin here a lot of work tracking down
what version you're in of the different
programs what version of python are you
using what version of R are using what
version of C plus plus so companies
hiring data Engineers or like Amazon on
Spotify Facebook and they develop
construct test and maintain
architectures such as databases and long
scale processing systems and here we
have our languages our SQL our Matlab
SAS SPSS python Java Ruby C plus Pearl
Hive Pig you pretty much as a data
engineer at this level when you talk
about admin and updating all these
databases need to know all the different
stuff that's being used in the company
and you're testing out these structures
to make sure they work and so you really
are talking admin level kind of setups
if you like spinning up an admin onto a
Google cloud service or Amazon cloud
service now you start to get an idea
what we're talking about because then
you can test it out up there and then
you can bring it back and update it to
the company statistician creates new
methodologies for engineers to apply and
so when we look at this this is where
we're digging into the math of Which
models to use what setup is going to
work what kind of activation do we have
on our neural network these little
tweaks are going to make a big
difference and we look for methodologies
at a large level what kind of data are
we going to be looking at how we're
going to pull it together companies
hiring a data engineer or talking about
statisticians we're talking about
LinkedIn PepsiCo Johnson and Johnson and
of course these companies probably hire
a little bit of everything but they have
a lot of statisticians working for them
and so we look at the role extract and
offer valuable reports from the data
clusters through statistical theories
and data organization and the languages
across the board we're still seeing SQL
our Matlab SAS SPSS data that's a new
one that we haven't seen in some of the
other roles python Pearl an older
version and that shouldn't be a surprise
because a lot of these companies
probably built a lot of the original
packages on Pearl if you go look at
Johnson and Johnson and of course your
big data Hive Pig and Spark and then our
database administrator I mentioned the
other one is an admin they're more on
admin level for the software itself so
administrator is another level some of
the tasks involved are monitoring Opera
trading and maintaining databases
installation configuration defining
schemas training users Etc and this is
interesting training users because when
you build a database and you define all
the different tables that are embedded
in that database and how they're all
connected the end user's got to have
that information otherwise you're in
trouble when we have companies hiring
data Engineers of course Tableau Twitter
Reddit the role ensures that all the
databases are available to all relevant
users getting a little security in there
what role do they have is allowed in a
not and is performing correctly and is
being kept safe and you better be ready
to spend some time in security because
again that's a very big thing nowadays
with the number of people who hack into
these databases and the languages are
going to be covered you have your
c-sharp your Java SQL Ruby on Rails XML
again there's that XML because a lot of
your security is embedded in XML files
python all the main players depending on
what the company's using data and
analytics man manager so when you see
manager that means that somebody's going
to sit on top and organize the people
underneath so they're going to improve
the business process as an intermediary
between business and I.T oh you better
have some really good communication
skills for this one some of the
companies hiring a data Engineers or a
Coursera Motorola slack of course these
companies are hiring data scientists in
almost all of these fields so the role
oversees the data science operations and
assigns the duties to the team according
to skills and expertise so that's a big
one you better be able to communicate
what's going on help your team members
come out and be able to communicate with
other people so sometimes your job is
just being able to get people to talk to
each other the big thing on that is is
the whole communication line going from
one end to the other because you can't
communicate all the information that
everybody's working on you have to
pretty much come in there and help
people communicate with theirs going on
and also know what they're up to without
being micromanagement because that will
crash a company if you micromanage
everybody but if you just let them do
whatever they want and they never talk
to each other that will also destroy the
company you got to find that nice middle
ground and you really have to have an
overview of everything as a data and
analytics manager one of the things I
mean you know it's good to have at least
one or two solid bases of programming
under your belt for a data analytics
manager but you do need to have a very
general understanding of all the
different tools being used so that you
know what's going on with your different
team members of course sqlr SAS Java
python Matlab all of those are big
business analytics so this is when
you're talking about your bi or your
business intelligence and your business
analytics very important to know this is
kind of a subdivision of a lot of the
other stuff we've talked about a lot of
the other rules we've looked at so you
possess specialized knowledge of their
business domain and apply that knowledge
and Analysis specifically to the
operation of the business so you might
be a specialist in banking you may be a
genetics engineer so you know about
genetics you might just be General
business helping the marketing so a lot
of companies hiring data engineer Oracle
Uber Dell and the role acts as a link
between the data engineers and the
management Executives so it's very
similar to when you go back up here we
look at data analytics manager a
business and analytics is going to also
kind of fill that role in between but
they're more specialized in business and
you better know SQL because we're
talking about a business specifically
most of the large companies are storing
their data that's up and running right
now that people are accessing to
purchase something on the Home Depot
website or the Uber they're logging in
you better know your SQL it's very
Central to business analytics so let's
go ahead and take a look at the data
science engineer salary Trends and
you'll see that our source is Glassdoor
as we're pulling a lot of our data from
average base pays around 117
000 in the US the average salary and
when we look at India we're talking
about at 950 000 a year and those are
based on some of them you need to go
ahead and dig deeper to find out what
education level versus entry level but
those are pretty solid base once you're
in the industry and once you created
your career in there and we look at the
job titles the most common job title is
data scientist business intelligence
manager is the second greatest one
that's kind of good to note that's why
they put that up there as being its own
little subcategory of data science
managers a business intelligence manager
because it's such a high level of jobs
and then we looked at some of the other
ones data architect business
intelligence architect again your bi
your business intelligence gets its own
ranking because it's such a high level
you know it's a business people want
their businesses to make money so that's
who's hiring of course data engineer
business intelligence developer business
intelligence consultant business
intelligence analyst business analyst
and data analyst so you can look at the
data analysis being the Gen General one
that doesn't go specific to business so
if you're looking just for your career
as far as getting a job probably should
have some kind of business understanding
in the background and again you know
your companies want to make money so
they're going to hire someone who knows
business if banking business if you
specialize in banking or retail if you
specialize in retail marketing and you
can see here on the data science salary
Trends and the growth in data science
job listings it's continually going up
it's um since 2014 to 2012 we've gone
from 400 to 600 that's a pretty big
increase so you know huge growth in this
market it's one of the biggest growing
markets right now for jobs and careers
so let's go ahead and take a look at
building a resume always exciting
putting ourselves out selling ourselves
and if you looked at some of our other
videos dealing with some resumes you'll
see a trend here the top part is so
different than what resumes were in the
90s in the 2000 to 2010 they've evolved
they've really evolved it used to be
2000 2010 maybe LinkedIn maybe one other
reference now you're gonna see that we
want those references this is a sales
tactic which now has come into resumes
used to be that if you're a real estate
agent every real estate agent I knew I
used to deal with real estate software
for the real estate industry back in the
90s every real estate agent won their
picture on their business card they
wanted them their picture if they could
put on their contracts they want people
to see the face so that's really a big
change is to make sure that it stands
out you stand out here's a picture of
somebody so you're more than just a
couple letters and a name but of course
you need your contact information should
always be at the top uh you have your
summary what are you focusing on be a
little careful with your summary because
if you have everything in your summary
and then they scroll down to experience
and education and skills they're going
to stop the second you repeat yourself
in your resume that usually means to the
reader hey this person doesn't have
anything more to offer me I'm done so be
a little careful how you word your
summary most companies appreciate when
you come in here and you've adjusted
this summary to be both about you and
how you're going to serve that company
so it's worth researching that company
to find out how those connect and put
that in the summary take some time to do
that that's actually a pretty big deal
and the references are huge also
especially in data science when you're
talking about any of the programming or
data science data analytics having a
place to go where they can look it up
and scroll down and see different things
you're doing whether it's LinkedIn in
this case which is a business profile
most commonly used in GitHub where you
have stuff published Facebook I'm always
hesitant because that tends to push more
towards a social media type jobs and
other jobs but certainly there's people
who have Facebook who do marketing and
stuff like that but these links having
these basic links here is important
people are starting to look for the that
for some other setup maybe you have a
personal website this is a good place to
put that so that they now have a
multitude of links that go back to you
and highlight who you are and then the
next part or next four parts so for the
next four parts we have a combination of
experience education skills
certifications and you can see they're
organized if you have you know a lot of
people like to see what kind of degree
you have they want to know where it came
from and if you just got out of college
you're going to put education at the top
and then maybe you'll put skills after
that and then your experience at the
bottom if you've been in the field for
years you know my degree just to give
you my age goes back to the night early
90s so I usually put education at the
very bottom and then because a lot of
the stuff I'm trying to sell myself on
right now is my skills I actually put
that at the top and I'll put my
education my certifications at the
bottom my skills and then my experience
is since it's a huge part of my resume
goes next you can organize these in
whatever order you want that's going to
work best for you and sell you so
remember you're selling yourself this is
your image probably don't wear an old
tie-dye T-shirt with holes in it you
know something nice because it is
professional and of course your summary
your and then what do you have to offer
the company and again when I put out
resumes I haven't done a resume in a
while you go in there and you can take
this and reorganize this so if the
company is looking for something
specific you might put the experiences
specific to that company you might even
take experience if you have like a long
job history like I do I've gone into a
lot of different things you might leave
out those companies or those experiences
that had nothing to do with data science
because it just becomes overwhelming
resumes should only take about 30
seconds to glance over maybe a minute
tops because after that point you've
lost the person's interest and if they
want to dig deeper they now have links
they have your website they have
LinkedIn and they can now take this this
and they come back to it and they go
okay let's look at this person a little
closer so quick overview this is your
sales sheet selling you to the company
so always tie it to the company so that
you have that what am I going to give
this company what are they going to get
from me we've covered a lot on data
science engineer in general and we've
gone over a basic resume remember keep
it simple short and direct that is so
important with that resume today's
how to become a data scientist in 2021
so here are the topics we'll be
discussing today a brief introduction to
data science laying the groundwork for a
data science career
short note on who is a data scientist
later we'll discuss the in-demand
technical skills for data scientists and
then the salary of data scientists after
which we'll discuss the future of data
science and data scientists
so now let's have a brief introduction
to the field of data science
there is no specific definition to
describe data science if you ask 500
people to describe what data science is
you'll probably end up getting 500
different responses because data science
is a continually evolving field well
under Wikipedia data science is an
interdisciplinary discipline using
computational methods processes
algorithms and systems to derive
information and insights from both
structural and unstructured data
in simple terms data science is the
domain of study that deals with vast
volumes of data using modern tools and
techniques
these tools and techniques are used to
find the Unseen patterns derive
meaningful information and make business
decisions the data used for analysis can
be from multiple sources and present in
various formats
there is a saying a jack of all trades
and a master of none when it comes to
being a data scientist you need to be a
bit like this but perhaps a better
saying would be a jack of all trades and
a master of some let now discuss about
laying the groundwork for a data science
career
let's now look at some of the
prerequisites for getting a data science
job
have a relevant degree a solid
educational background is required to be
a data scientist pursue an undergraduate
degree in data science or any closely
related fields like statistics computer
science or mathematics after the
undergraduate course a master's degree
in one of the relevant areas is an added
advantage
creativity and critical thinking
creativity in data science is very much
needed in this field you will need it
for creating a storyline for Innovative
modeling for developing new tools
different ways to collect your data and
lots more
parallely critical thinking is very
useful in data science a data scientist
should be able to develop questions and
at the same time question the data as
well
required Technical and non-technical
skills we'll be discussing in depth the
required technical skills later on in
this video talking about the other
necessary skills in this field you will
need problem solving skills risk
analysis and many more good
communication skills having a strong
command over your communication skills
is very much needed in this field the
outcomes that are delivered through data
science are quite complicated and hard
to explain you will have to translate
your technical findings clearly and
fluently to the other teams you will
need good presentation skills
storytelling skills writing skills and
listening skills
short make sure you focus on building
lasting relationships through your
communication
here are some of the roles in the field
of data science data scientist machine
learning engineer machine learning
scientist data engineer data analyst
statistician business intelligence
developer
infrastructure architect Enterprise
architect applications architect data
scientist is most likely one of the most
sizzling job titles among the lot and
now let's talk about who is a data
scientist
in simple terms a data scientist is the
one who practices the art of data
science a data scientist analyzes
business data to extract meaningful
insights in other words a data scientist
solves business problems through various
methods
DJ patil and Jeff hamerbacher coined the
term data scientist a data scientist's
work typically revolves around data and
his role will be a combination of three
main subjects computer science
statistics and Mathematics
it's time we discuss the in-demand
technical skills for data scientists
to become a data scientist you need
various skills as mentioned earlier some
significant technical skills you will
need to master include programming
there are several programming languages
for data scientists learning and
mastering at least one of them is
essential to realize various functions
of data science but at the same time
just a single language can't solve
problems in all areas
python is the most widely used
programming language in the world today
when it comes to data science
the next widely used language is r there
are still some data scientists who use r
instead of python but if you are doing
applied data science these days then
you've got to Learn Python because
that's the most valuable programming
language for data scientists
some other languages include JavaScript
scalar SQL
Etc
talking about Python programming
language it is open source and easy to
use language you will need to understand
the basic syntax of this language
initially you will need to know how to
write functions loops and modules you
should be familiar with both object
oriented and functional programming in
Python
is a general purpose and dynamic
programming language that supports
multiple paratims
one of the factors that make python
stand out from the rest is its
flexibility you can use Python for
almost all the steps involved in data
science
the next skill we'll be talking about is
machine learning the concept of machine
learning has been around for a while now
however the ability to automatically and
quickly apply mathematical calculations
to Big Data is now gaining a bit of
momentum
you will need to learn techniques such
as supervised machine learning decision
trees logistic regression and natural
language processing one of the crucial
reasons why you need machine learning in
data science is because of the high
value predictions that can guide better
decisions and smart actions in real time
without human intervention
there are in fact a lot of advantages of
machine learning in data science it
helps analyze large chunks of data and
it changes the way data extraction and
interpretation Works to sum it up
machine learning and data science can
work hand in hand
with machine learning being such a craze
data scientists need to learn it this is
why simply learn has introduced a
revolutionary machine learning
certification program that provides
advanced level training on the
applications and algorithms it uses we
have provided the link in the
description box for the same do not
forget to check that out here's to yet
another essential skill in data science
math
mathematics is the Bedrock of any
contemporary discipline in science a
it's one of the major requirements for
data science
some of the major math topics you will
need to know are calculus linear algebra
probability and statistics some other
math topics that will help you solve
data science problems are discrete math
graph Theory information Theory and many
more
up next we have analytical tools they
help you extract useful meaningful
insights from data and provide you with
valuable Frameworks for processing Big
Data
data analysis is a core practice of
modern day businesses and choosing the
right analytical tools is very
challenging as no tool fits every need
anyway some of the most used analytical
tools and data science are SQL spark
Hadoop Hive and many more
coming to data visualization it is an
interdisciplinary field that deals with
the graphic representations of data data
visualization plays two prominent roles
communicating results clearly to a
general audience and organizing a view
of data that suggests a new hypothesis
of the next step in a project
of the data visualization tools are
matplotlib GT plot and d3.js
data visualization encompasses
techniques that are used to communicate
data or information by encoding it as
visual objects that are contained in
graphics
well as Big Data keeps growing data
visualization becomes an increasingly
crucial tool
up next we have data of wrangling this
is the process of gathering selecting
and transforming data to answer and
analytical question it will help the
data scientists fast in decision making
and hence get better insights in less
time
data wrangling is also known as data
cleaning or munching
at last we have business acumen when you
are a data scientist you must have more
business sense in analyzing the data in
other words you need to know whether the
insights gained from the data is of
value to the business or not
hence business Acumen plays a very vital
role in structuring business data
analytics
when we are talking about business
knowledge three things come into the
picture General business knowledge
industry specific knowledge and Company
specific knowledge knowing these are
very much important when you are a data
scientist
so guys this sums up the in demand
technical skills for data scientists
well let's now discuss the salary of
data scientists
before we go into the topic we would
like to introduce our new platform skill
up where you can find some of our best
courses for free we are offering more
than one thousand hearts of content for
free which can help you acquire more
than 300 skills across a number of
different categories
take the next step to grow in your
career by joining skill up by checking
out the link in the description
when we are talking about the salary of
data scientists many factors come into
the picture the salary would depend on
the experience he or she holds the
industry the company size educational
background and finally the region
according to Glassdoor the average
salary of a data scientist in India is
close to 10 lakh Rupees and that in the
United States is close to 1 lakh 13
309 dollars in the it field
the driving Factor behind High data
science salaries is that the companies
and organizations are realizing the
power of big data and they want to use
it to drive smart business decisions
coming to our last topic of the day
future of data science and data
scientists
with every passing your data science is
improving and expanding at a
significantly faster Pace data science
has found its applications in almost
every industry
healthcare companies are using data
science to build sophisticated medical
instruments to detect and cure diseases
video and computer games are now being
created with data science and that has
taken the gaming experience to the next
level
similarly data science has taken various
other fields to a whole new level
the top three most common Search terms
in July 2020 are data science machine
learning and artificial intelligence
according to the 2020 emerging jobs
report LinkedIn listed data scientist as
the top third job with an annual growth
rate of 37 percent
for four years in a row data scientist
has been named the number one job in the
U.S by Glassdoor
playing a career in data Sciences a
smart move not just because it pays well
and is trendy it is because data is the
Pivot Point on which the entire economy
turns
however you can also go through our
video on the topic tips for becoming a
data scientist for more information
thank you all for watching this video
tutorial on python for data science full
course I hope you liked it if you have
any questions then please put them in
the comment section below thanks for
watching stay tuned for more from Simply
learn
[Music]
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn YouTube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos turn it up and get certified
click here